JOINT HEARING BETWEEN ASSEMBLY
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE NUMBER ONE
ON HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AN
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
NUMBER FOUR ON STATE
ADMINISTRATION. COVERING
PROPOSALS AND ISSUES RELATED TO
THE HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE BEFORE
WE BEGIN I HAVE BEEN ASKED TO
READ SOME DIRECTIONS REGARDING
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION IN TODAY'S
HEARING TO HELP ENSURE THE
SAFETY OF EVERYONE WHO IS HERE
TODAY WHILE ALSO ALLOWING FOR
FULL PUBLIC ACCESS TO THE
DISCUSSION. TODAY'S HEARING IS
AT THE STATE CAPITOL IN HEARING
ROOM ONE TWENTY SEVEN HOWEVER
ALL OF THE PANELISTS ON THE
AGENDA ARE APPEARING REMOTELY.
WE ARE ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENT
AT THE END OF THE HEARING BOTH
IN THE HEARING ROOM AND ON THE
PHONE. THE PHONE NUMBER TO
CONNECT IS ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND SHOULD BE ON THE
SCREEN IF YOU ARE WATCHING OVER
THE INTERNET. THE NUMBER IS TOLL
FREE. 877-692-8957 AND THE
PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE
ONE FIVE ONE TWO SEVEN. IF YOU
ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE
CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT. 916-319-2090 NINE
AND A STAFF MEMBER WILL ASSIST
YOU. WE WILL BEGIN PUBLIC
COMMENT AFTER ALL MEMBERS HAVE
CONCLUDED THEIR QUESTIONS FOR
ALL OF THE PANEL. THERE WILL BE
NO VOTES TAKEN IN TODAY'S
HEARING. FINALLY WE WILL ALSO
ACCEPT WRITTEN PUBLIC COMMENT
AND FEEDBACK THROUGH THE SUB ONE
EMAIL ACCOUNT AND THE ADDRESS IS
BUDGET SUB ONE AT ASM DOT CA DOT
GOV. A FEW COMMENTS BEFORE WE
GET STARTED. AS A PHYSICIAN THE
ISSUES WITH HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE SHORTAGE IN CALIFORNIA
ARE NEAR AND DEAR TO MY HEART.
SPECIFICALLY AS A LATINO
PHYSICIAN FROM THE CENTRAL
VALLEY ETHNIC DIVERSITY AND
GEOGRAPHICAL DISPARITIES IN THE
HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE SHOULD BE
FRONT AND CENTER OF ALL OF OUR
ATTENTION AS WE EMBARK ON THE
NEXT MAJOR EXPANSION TO THE
MEDICAL PROGRAM THROUGH THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET. WE ALL KNOW IT IT
BEARS REPEATING THAT HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE IS NOT THE SAME THING
AS HEALTHCARE ACCESS. THAT
HAVING MEDIC CAL OR COVERED
CALIFORNIA COVERAGE CARD IN YOUR
WALLET IS MEANINGLESS IF THERE
IS NO AVAILABLE DOCTOR OR OTHER
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONAL TO SEE.
AS A RESULT OF THE HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE SHORTAGE IN CALIFORNIA
ARGUABLY NO ONE IN THE STATE HAS
SUFFICIENT ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
. NEVER THE LESS ACCESS IS
LIMITED MOST SEVERELY FOR LOW
INCOME AND RURAL CALIFORNIANS
AND PEOPLE OF COLOR. THIS IS
WHERE WE MUST FOCUS OUR
ATTENTION AND RESOURCES IN ORDER
TO GUARANTEE THIS BASIC HUMAN
RIGHT AND ENSURE THE GREATEST
OVERALL PUBLIC HEALTH FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I WILL NOW
ASK MY COLLEAGUE AND CHAIR OF
SOME FOR ANY INTRODUCTORY
COMMENTS AND TO INTRODUCE THE
FIRST. THANK YOU DR ARAMBULA-
AND THANK YOU FOR HELPING
FACILITATE THIS JOINT
INFORMATIONAL HEARING BETWEEN
OUR TWO BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEES I
KNOW THAT INTO FOUR WE HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT IT FOR QUITE SOME
TIME AND PROBABLY AND SOMEONE
YOU'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT IT FOR
SOME TIME AND IT'S NOW AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO JOIN
TOGETHER AND NOT HAVE THE
CONVERSATIONS AND SILO. AS NOTED
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES A
SIGNIFICANT- INVESTMENT OF ONE
POINT SEVEN BILLION OVER THREE
YEARS TO EXPAND THE CARE-
ECONOMY WORKFORCE WHILE
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR HAS EXAMINED
SOME ELEMENTS OF THIS PROPOSAL
DURING ITS LABOR HEARING ON
FEBRUARY TWENTY SECOND THIS WILL
BE THE FIRST TIME BOTH
COMMITTEES WILL HAVE A CHANCE TO
HEAR ALL THE COMPONENTS OF THIS
PROPOSAL IN ITS ENTIRE CONTEXT
WHICH IS IMPORTANT. THE COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HIGHLIGHTED
THE NEED TO CREATE A CULTURALLY
COMPETENT HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES WORKFORCE WHOSE
TRAINING IS ROOTED IN THE
PRINCIPLES OF DIVERSITY EQUITY
AND INCLUSION TODAY'S HEARING
WILL BE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION TO OUTLINE ITS
SPECIFIC PLAN TO EXPAND SUCH A
WORK FORCE BUT THIS BUT THIS
HEARING IS ALSO ABOUT MAKING
SURE CALIFORNIA HAS A LONG TERM
PLAN TO SIMULTANEOUSLY INCREASE
FRONTLINE WORKER WAGES ADDRESS
HEALTH DISPARITIES AND IMPROVE.
POPULATION HEALTH OUTCOMES THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL SPREADS THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF IMPLEMENTATION
ACROSS SEVERAL STATE AGENCIES
AND DEPARTMENTS INCLUDING THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT THE EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING PANEL THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE ACCESS AND
INFORMATION AS WE HEAR THESE
VARIOUS PROPOSALS I HOPE THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL HIGHLIGHT
HOW THE OVERALL EFFORT FITS
TOGETHER AND HOW THIS INITIATIVE
WILL REMAIN COORDINATED TO MEET
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES NEEDS ULTIMATELY WE
WANT A SYSTEM THAT IS. SEAMLESS
COOPERATIVE AND TALKS TO EACH
OTHER WHICH IS IMPORTANT SO
LET'S BEGIN WITH THE ISSUE ONE
OUR FIRST PANEL THE GOVERNOR'S
HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE BUDGET
PROPOSAL OVERVIEW- LET'S GET
STARTED INTERNS WILL INCLUDE
DOLLS- DARCY THEN GADO ASSISTANT
SECRETARY. FOR THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY- AND ABBY'S NAY DEPUTY
SECTOR FUTURE WORK CALIFORNIA
LABOR AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY LET'S BEGIN MISSILE GOT
ALL YOU ON THE LINE. I THANK YOU
SO MUCH MANAGER ARE YOU ABLE TO
HEAR ME OKAY YES POLICE BEGAN.
UNDERFLOW THANK YOU SO MUCH. I'M
SUPER HAPPY TO BE HERE TODAY MY
NAME IS DARCY DELGADO IN THE
ASSISTANT SECRETARY FOR
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES I WANT TO START JUST BY
THINKING. BOTH OF THESE
SUBCOMMITTEES AND IN PARTICULAR
THINKING THE SUBCOMMITTEE STAFF
THE AGENDA THAT THEY'VE PROPOSED
AFTER TODAY'S DISCUSSION. IS
VERY THOROUGH AND WE'RE EXCITED
ABOUT THAT TO BE ABLE TO TALK
ABOUT ALL THE DIFFERENT ASPECTS
OF THIS INITIATIVE IN REALLY THE
THOROUGHNESS OF THE AGENDA
SPEAKS TO THE URGENCY AND
IMPORTANCE OF THIS ISSUE THANK
YOU SO MUCH. AND OF COURSE I
THINK YOU TOO MUCH TO THE DOCTOR
ARAMBULA AND MOUNTAINS YOUR
CARDIO FOR YOUR EFFORTS AND WORK
IN THIS AREA AND CAN'T GROW
ENOUGH YOUR OPENING STATEMENTS I
HOPE THAT BY THE END OF THE DAY
YOU'LL SEE HOW THE LINES THIS
INITIATIVE IS. WITH THE THEMES
AND VALUES THAT BOTH COULD BE
ARTICULATED. IN YOUR
INTRODUCTORY COMMENTS. SO MY
ROLE TODAY- I HAVE THREE. IN
WITH YOU ALL TODAY THE FIRST TO
OVER THE WAY FORCE ALL
INITIATIVE. THE SECOND PIECE
ALTHOUGH SOMETIMES DOESN'T HAVE
BEINGS THAT IS WHY THIS ISSUE IS
SO URGENT RIGHT NOW. AND THEN I
WILL SPEAK TO THE COLLABORATIVE
EFFORTS THAT. CALIFORNIA HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES HAS TAKEN
WITH A BUNCH OF DIFFERENT
STAKEHOLDERS. AFTER I FINISH
THOSE THREE ITEMS I'LL HAND IT
OVER TO LABOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY IS DEPUTY
DIRECTOR ABBY ST. WHO WILL BE
GIVING A LITTLE BIT MORE
BACKGROUND FROM LABOR
PERSPECTIVE. SUCH AS- I
WORKFORCE FRAWLEY. IS A LARGE
PACKAGE AT ELEVEN LINE ITEMS
TOTALING ONE POINT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS OVER THREE YEARS I AM
JUST GOING TO PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF THIS INITIATIVE. AND
DON'T WANT TO STEAL THE THUNDER
ASK FOR HER ARE EACH TIED
DIRECTOR LIZ THAT LANDSBERG.
DEPUTY DIRECTOR HOBBIES NAY WHO
WILL BE DEEP DIVING INTO A LOT
OF THOSE ELEVEN DIFFERENT LINE
ITEMS BUT I CAN'T SAY. THAT THE
PACKAGE IN TOTAL RELEASED I
STRIDES TO ADDRESS THE URGENT
NEEDS THAT WE'RE SEEING IN BOTH
THE HEALTH WORK HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE IN HUMAN SERVICES
WORKFORCE. I KNOW THAT- BUT MANY
FOLKS HAVE SENIOR THROUGHOUT THE
KOBE PANDEMIC. THAT WE HEAR A
LOT ABOUT SHORTAGES IN NURSING
AND SHORTAGES AND HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS AND YES COMPLETELY
AGREE THAT THAT SHORTAGE EXISTS
BUT WE'RE ALSO SEEING IT. QUITE
STRONGLY IN HUMAN. SERVICES
WORKFORCE SO. EXCITED TO TALK
ABOUT. THE DIFFERENT LINE ITEM
IN THE- TODAY INCLUDING-
INITIATIVES THAT ARE TARGETING
SOCIAL WORKERS. NURSING OR
NURSING AS A WHOLE INCLUDING
CERTIFIED NURSING ASSISTANT
RN'S- PSYCHIATRY AND REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT THE COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKER. THANK YOU WE HAVE
MANY ANALYSTS ON THE CALL TODAY
AND OTHERS WHO ARE GOING TO BE
pGOAL OF THIS WORKFORCE
INITIATIVE WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
THE WORK FORCE FOR ALL
INITIATIVE AND I'M SPEAKING TO
BE BROUGHT INTO. A LEVIN LINE
ITEMS TOTAL. THE PRIME GOAL IS
TO RECRUIT. TRAIN HIGHER AND
ADVANCED AN ETHNICALLYAND
CULTURALLY INCLUSIVE WORKFORCE
WE NEED TO IMPROVE DIVERSITY WE
NEED TO IMPROVE COMPENSATION.
AND WITH THE HOPES THAT BY
IMPROVING THIS WORKFORCE WILL
ALSO SEE SOME SECONDARY HEALTH
EQUITY OUTCOMES. SO MY BOSS- AT
DR MARK GALLI WHO IS THE
SECRETARY OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES. HAS TOLD ME
SPECIFICALLY WORKING ON THIS-
INITIATIVE THAT NOT A DAY GOES
BY WHERE SOMEONE ISN'T COMING TO
HIM ABOUT WORKFORCE ISSUES
WHETHER HE'S ADDED A CLINIC.
ADDED ASSISTED LIVING FACILITY
OR NURSING FACILITY HOMELESS
SHELTER TALKING TO COUNTY MENTAL
HEALTH MAY BE VISITING- ONE OF
OUR STATE HOSPITALS OR WITHIN
THE CORRECTIONAL SETTING NOT A
DAY GOES BY THAT SOMEONE IS NOT
COMING TO HIM AND PLEADING. FOR
ASSISTANCE WITHIN THE WORK FORCE
FIELD AND WE KNOW THAT THERE WAS
THERE WERE PROBLEMS WITH OUR
WORKFORCE BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
STARTED BUT THE PANDEMIC HAS
REALLY ONLY EXACERBATED THE
ISSUES THAT WE'RE SEEING- BUT
BEING AT. PIECE THAT I REALLY
WANT TO FOCUS ON TODAY AND AGAIN
HOPEFULLY YOU WILL GET A SENSE
OF AS WE TALK TO ALL OF THE LINE
ITEM. IS THE IMPORTANCE OF
DIVERSITY. REPRESENTATION
MATTERS AND A WORKFORCE NEEDS TO
LOOK LIKE THEY'RE CALIFORNIANS
BUT IT SERVES IN NEEDS TO SPEAK
THE SAME LANGUAGE AS THE
CALIFORNIANS THAT SEARCH IN
OFTENTIMES NEEDS TO HAVE THE
SAME LIFE EXPERIENCE AND SO WHEN
WE SPEAK TODAY- IN PARTICULAR
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKERS. VERY EXCITED TO
TALK ABOUT THE INITIATIVES THAT
REALLY FOCUSED ON- BROWN AND
BLACK COMMUNITIES TO HELP LIFT
UP THE WORK FORCE IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE AGAIN
REPRESENTATION. MATTERS AND- AB
HELPED WORKERS BIRDS THERE ARE A
BILL TO REACH PARTS- THE LACK
COMMUNITY YOU KNOW THE I'M WHAT
USED- REPRESENT MATTER. IN AT
TWENTY HELP OR RIGHT THAT OR PRO
WE THAT TYPE X. IS GOING TO BE
ABLE TO CONNECT WITH THE
COMMUNITY IN A WAY THAT OTHER
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS HAVEN'T
BEEN ABLE TO REACH. AND SO THAT
REALLY IS ONE OF THE CORE VALUES
OF THE WORK FORCE FOR ALL
INITIATIVE DIVERSITY AND
REPRESENTATION. AND AS WE TALKED
TODAY AND AS I GO THROUGH THE
OVERVIEW HOPEFULLY YOU WILL SEE
THAT THE MAGNITUDE OF NEED.
JUSTIFIES THE MAGNITUDE OF
FUNDING THE URGENCY. YEAH I
CAN'T STATE ENOUGH HOW URGENT
THIS ISSUE IS. AND SO THAT'S
KIND OF A BRIEF OVERVIEW BUT I.
REALLY WANT TO FOCUS ON THE
JOINT EFFORT AND COLLABORATION
THAT'S BEEN HAPPENING I LOVE
WHEN CHAIR CARDIO SAID EARLY ON
THAT. I IN HER OPENING
STATEMENTS ABOUT THE YOU KNOW
BRINGING TOGETHER THESE TWO SUB
COMMITTEES AND IN SOME WAYS
THAT'S ACTUALLY WHAT WE'VE BEEN
DOING FOR THE PAST THREE OR FOUR
MONTHS ON THIS INITIATIVE. IS
THAT IN THAT IT IS VERY UNIQUE
IN THAT WE HAVE BEEN WORKING WE
AT CAL HHS HAVE BEEN WORKING
SIDE BY SIDE HAND IN HAND WITH
THE LABOR AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY. IN FACT I
DOUBT THAT DEPUTY DIRECTOR HEARD
ABBY'S NAY HAS TAKEN A PHONE
CALLER IS DOING CALL THAT I
HAVEN'T BEEN ON IN THE LAST
THREE MONTHS BECAUSE WE JUST
HAVE BEEN. ATTACHED AT THE HIP-
IN SO WHAT THAT MEANS IS THAT
THE- THE SUM IS GREATER THAN ITS
PARTS THE WORK THAT WE'RE DOING
IT CAL HHS THE EXPERTISE THAT WE
BRING IN HUMAN SERVICES FIELD.
IS ONLY BOLSTERED BY THEIR
AMAZING EXPERIENCE FROM OUR L.
WGA PARTNERS AND SO JUST REALLY
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE- JOINT
EFFORTS THAT WE HAVE BEEN
ENGAGING IN BETWEEN HHS LWT ANY
AND. ARE DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE
WORKING TOGETHER. THANKS TO SOME
OF THE BUS. AND THAT YOU'RE MAN
GETTING- MENTIONED EARLIER. IN A
WE BEEN. FRANKLY STEP OF THE
WAY- WE HAVE HAD MANY MEETING
WITH LABOR GROUPS THAT COMMUNITY
OR- I'M TO. GROUP AT AND
ADVISORY. PEOPLE WHO ARE IN THE-
OF THIS WORKING WHO ARE LIVING
THIS URGENT PROBLEM EVERY SINGLE
DAY. AND THOSE ARE THE FOLKS
THAT WE NEED TO LEARN FROM AND
THOSE ARE THE FOLKS THAT
HOPEFULLY WHEN YOU HEAR ABOUT
THE PACKAGE TODAY. YOU'LL I
RECOGNIZE THAT WE ARE TAKING
THOSE VOICES INTO CONSIDERATION
EVERY STEP OF THE WAY AS WE'RE
DEVELOPING THIS INITIATIVE. AND
SO WE ARE REALLY EXCITED I HAD
TO TALK ABOUT THE STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENTS AND- YOU KNOW WHILE
SOME RIGHTFULLY SO WILL COMMENT
ON. MAYBE AN ABSENCE OF DETAILS
AND SOME OF THE PROPOSALS THAT
WILL THAT WE TALK ABOUT TODAY.
AB WE MIGHT NOT KNOW EVERY
SPECIFIC OUTCOME THAT YOUR SENT
COMMITTEES ARE INTERESTED IN. I
WILL SAY THAT THAT'S ACTUALLY A
BENEFIT TO US WE ARE LOOKING FOR
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT WE'RE
LOOKING TO. ENGAGE WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ENGAGE WITH YOUR SUB
COMMITTEES ON A LOT OF THESE
ISSUES AND SO. JUST REALLY
EXCITED TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
THAT STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT. I'M
ALSO BREAKING NEWS. LAST WEEK
OUR WORKFORCE ROLLIN ISSUED IT
WAS CHOSEN BY THE NATIONAL
GOVERNORS ASSOCIATION FOR
PARTICIPATION IN THE LEARNING
COLLABORATIVE. AND SO WHAT THAT
MEANS IS THAT OUR TEAM BOTH
TECHNOLOGY JUST TEAM L. W. D.
EIGHTEEN. WE OUR WORK FORCE FOR
ALL INITIATIVE WE'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO ENGAGE WITH NATIONAL
EXPERTS THE NATIONAL SUBJECT AND
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTISE FOLKS.
TO BE ABLE TO IMPROVE THE
PACKAGING TO BE ABLE TO IMPROVE
OUR WHAT WE'RE OFFERING IN THE
WORK FORCE FOR ALL INITIATIVE SO
REALLY EXCITED ABOUT ALL THE
COLLABORATIONS SO JUST WANTED TO
MAKE SURE COMMUNICATED THAT WITH
YOU ALL TODAY. I'M GOING TO DO
NOW IS HANDED OVER. TO DEPUTY
DIRECTOR I AT LEAST NAY IN
EXCUSE ME THAT MEANS THAT. WHO
ABBY'S NAY IS GOING TO TALKING A
LITTLE MORE THIS. I FROM THAT L.
G. AND- ABBY. THANK YOU TO. AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH CHAIR CO. AND
SHARE AROUND FOR THE- TO BE HERE
SO. WITH YOU TODAY AND I
CERTAINLY SHE HER THERE'S YEAH-
ABOUT THIS REALLY EXCITED AND-
AS WE THINK ABOUT. IN A- I
INITIATIVE AND I WILL TALK
BRIEFLY- TO CONTINUE DARCY'S
OVERVIEW ON WHY THESE HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE ISSUES ARE PROBLEMATIC
FOR CALIFORNIA A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT THE
SHORTAGES OF HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE AND WHY THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT IS IMPORTANT FROM THE
WORKFORCE PERSPECTIVE. AS WELL
AS OUR HEALTH CARE PERSPECTIVE.
AS WE KNOW WHO THE CULPRIT
NINETEEN ENDEMIC REALLY SERVE AS
THE GREAT I'M MASTER OF
INEQUITIES ACROSS THE STATE
INCLUDING THOSE FOUND IN THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
WORKFORCE WELL WE HAD IDENTIFIED
LABOR SHORTAGES OVER THE LAST
FIVE YEARS THE CRISIS WAS
EXACERBATED AND ACCELERATED. BY
THE CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC
REALLY CREATING A NEW URGENCY
HOSPITALS ARE SHORT STAFFED AND
DESPERATE AND PAYING VERY HIGH
REGISTRY RATES FOR A TEMPORARY
WORKFORCE SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES AN ADULT IN SENIOR
CARE PROGRAMS PROVIDING HOME AND
COMMUNITY CARE ARE ALSO SHORT
STAFFED AND CONTINUE TO
STRUGGLE. TO MEET- STAFFING
RATIOS REALLY AND PREVENTING
FACILITIES FROM ACCEPTING
PATIENTS READY FOR LOWER LEVELS
OF CARE. ARE HOMELESS SERVICE
PROVIDERS ARE DESPERATE FOR EACH
CASE MANAGERS AND TEAM MEMBERS
CHILD WELFARE SERVICE PROVIDERS
DO NOT HAVE ENOUGH PEOPLE TO
PERFORM THE ASSESSMENTS
REFERRALS AND ENGAGEMENT WORK
NEEDED TO PLACE CHILDREN INTO
OPTIMAL SETTINGS. AN OVER
ARCHING PROBLEM MISTER SEA
MANSION IS EVEN WHEN STAFFING
CHALLENGES MAY BE LESS
SIGNIFICANT IS THE LACK OF
REPRESENTATION DIVERSITY. WORST
LGBT PLUS STAFF AS WELL AS- WITH
LIVE EXPERIENCES. AND OCCUR
TRAINING. THROUGH OUR TRAINING
SYSTEM OUR EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM
ARE ALREADY IMPACTING AND
HITTING ROADBLOCKS AND COULD NOT
PRODUCE THE BODY MUST HEALTHCARE
WORKERS NEEDED TO REPLACE
CURRENT HEALTHCARE WORKERS
PROJECTED TO RETIRE. CURRENT
HEALTHCARE WORKERS LEAVING THE
WORK FORCE BECAUSE OF COLD
INDUCED STRESS. OR TO MEET THE
HEALTHCARE NEEDS OF A RAPIDLY
AGING POPULATION. I SURE DARTH
GARCIA IT DOESN'T FOR THE WAYS
IN WHICH THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY AND THE LABOR
AGENCY ARE WORKING CLOSELY
TOGETHER TO PLAN THE SPECIFIC
PROGRAM COMPONENTS IN THE
INITIATIVE WHICH WILL BE
ADDRESSED LATER THIS. IN THIS
HEARING AND THE WAYS IN WHICH WE
ARE LEVERAGING OUR COMPLEMENTARY
EXPERTISE IS IN HEALTHCARE
DELIVERY AND WORKFORCE PLANNING
AND DEVELOPMENT IN CONSULTATION
WITH ACADEMIC RESEARCHERS LABOR
PARTNERS. AND COMMUNITY
STAKEHOLDERS. EDT LABOR MARK
INFORMATION DIVISION JUST THIS
MORNING RELEASED ITS TWO YEAR
PROJECTIONS UPDATED BECAUSE SO
MUCH HAS CHANGED IN THE LAST TWO
YEARS OF COURSE. TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TO TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND
PROJECTS A MILLION FIVE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY EIGHT THOUSAND AND
FORTY TOTAL OPENINGS ACROSS A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE HEALTH
RELATED OCCUPATIONS REQUIRING A
BE A OR BELOW. AT THE END OF
OCTOBER ALONE THERE WERE OVER
FIFTY SEVEN THOUSAND WANT ADS
FOR HEALTHCARE JOBS. WE ALSO
JUST RECEIVED A REGIONAL
ANALYSIS THAT ALAM ID PUT
TOGETHER OF HEALTH CARE
PREFERRED JACKSON'S AND WHILE WE
WILL DIG INTO THIS MORE DEEPLY
THOSE ARE CONFIRMING THE MORE
URGENT SHORTAGES IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND INLAND EMPIRE IN ALL.
AREAS OF THE STATE. YOU MAY BE
FAMILIAR WITH THE FUTURE OF
HEALTH WORKFORCE COMMISSION
WHICH FINISHED ITS WORK IN PRE
CODED TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. AND
EVEN AT THAT TIME SEVEN MILLION
CALIFORNIANS LIVED IN THE HOUSE
HEALTH PROFESSION SHORTAGE AREAS
WITH SHORTAGES WORSE AGAIN IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE IN LOS ANGELES
IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AND
MOST RURAL AREAS. THE COMMISSION
FOCUSED ON THE NEED TO INCREASE
THE DIVERSITY OF THE STATE'S
HEALTH WORKFORCE AND ABLE
BECAUSE WORKFORCE TO BETTER
ADDRESSING HEALTH DISPARITIES.
AND INCORPORATE NEW AND EMERGING
TECHNOLOGIES THE COMMISSION'S
RECOMMENDATIONS CALLED FOR
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF HEALTH
WORKERS BY OVER FORTY SEVEN
THOUSAND. IMPROVING DIVERSITY IN
THE HEALTH PROFESSIONS PRODUCING
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY THOUSAND
WORKERS FROM UNDERREPRESENTED
COMMUNITIES AND INCREASING THE
SUPPLY OF HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
WHO COME FROM AND TRAIN AND
RURAL AND OTHER UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. WE'RE PLEASED THAT
THE HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE FOR ALL
INITIATIVE WILL BE TALKING ABOUT
TODAY ALIGNS WELL WITH THESE
COMMISSION RECOMMENDATIONS AND
SPECIFICALLY AND I'M EXCITED FOR
YOU TO HEAR MORE ABOUT THE
PROPERTY. TO TAKE TO SCALE WORK
TRAINING COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS I'M FROM A TARDIS. WE
ALSO THE DOING CONSERVE AND
RESEARCH ON SPECIFIC OCCUPATIONS
AS AN EXAMPLE JUST LAST MONDAY
WE HEARD FROM RESEARCHERS AT U.
C. S. F. SIR YOU SEE S. S. HELP
FOR CENTER. WHICH HIGHLIGHTED
PAIN POINTS IN EXPANDING NURSING
EDUCATION INCLUDING THE SHORTAGE
OF CLINICAL FACULTY AND CLINICAL
TRAINING SITES. DIFFICULTIES OF
NEW ARE IN GRADUATES GETTING
HIRED WITHOUT EXPERIENCE AND
WE'RE NOW CONSULTING WITH
LEADERSHIP OF THE STATE'S FIFTY
FIVE TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
FACILITIES TO EXPAND THEIR ROLE
IN TRAINING THE WORKFORCE AND
HEALTH CARE IN NURSING OF THE
FUTURE. IN HOSTING CLINICAL
ROTATIONS DEPUTY SECRETARIES NAY
IT APPEARS YOU HAVE PAPER OVER
YOUR CAMERA. OH DEAR THAT'S NOT
GOOD. I'M SO SORRY- I HOPE YOU
CAN HEAR WHAT I SAY EVEN IF YOU
COULDN'T HEAR. EVEN IF YOU
COULDN'T SEE MY MAPS WITH- SO.
WHY THIS INITIATIVE IS IMPORTANT
FROM WORKFORCE PERSPECTIVE. IN
ADDITION TO CREATING INNOVATIVE
AND ACCESSIBLE OPPORTUNITIES TO
RECRUIT TRAIN HIRE AND ADVANCE
AND ETHNICALLY AND CULTURALLY
INCLUSIVE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES WORKFORCE WITH IMPROVE
DIVERSITY AND HIGHER WAGES THIS
INVESTMENT WILL BUILD LADDERS OF
OPPORTUNITY AND ECONOMIC
MOBILITY ACROSS THE HEALTH OF
HUMANS THE SECTORS FOR
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES
ESPECIALLY YOUNG PEOPLE OF COLOR
IN CALIFORNIA. MOVING THEM FROM
UNEMPLOYMENT OR LOW WAGE
EMPLOYMENT INTO FAMILY
SUSTAINING JOBS AND HEALTH CARE
. TWENTY THREE OCCUPATIONS AND
OCCUPATIONAL CLUSTERS IN THE L.
M. I. G. TEN YEAR PROJECTIONS
WHICH WILL BE UPDATED IN JUNE.
DO NOT REQUIRE FOUR YEAR DEGREES
AND OFFER ACCESSIBLE PATHWAYS
INTO FAMILY SUSTAINING JOBS
AVERAGING ABOUT TWENTY FIVE
DOLLARS AN HOUR. IN HOSPITAL
PRIMARY CARE AND COMMUNITY
SETTINGS THESE INCLUDE
HEALTHTECH MISSION ROLES SUCH AS
EKG EKG ULTRASOUND TECHS
RESPIRATORY THERAPISTS WILL
BOTTOM MISSED AND COMMUNITIES
HELP HEALTH WORKERS WHO SERVICES
WILL SOON BE COVERED BY
MEDICARE. REIMBURSEMENTS MY
COLLEAGUES AT THE LABOR AGENCY
IN OUR DEPARTMENTS WILL ADDRESS
THE SPECIFIC PROGRAMS PROPOSED
FOR L. W. D. A.'S LATER IN THIS
HEARING BUT JUST A FEW BRIGHT
POINTS. THE EMPLOYMENT TRAINING
PANEL BECAUSE OF THE
RESTRICTIONS ON THE ETP FIND
MOST LARGE NONPROFIT AND PUBLIC
HEALTH CARE EMPLOYERS MOST OF
THESE HIGH ROAD EMPLOYERS HAVE
BEEN EXCLUDED FROM TAPPING. ETP
FUNDING FOR TRAINING AND
UPSKILLING THEIR CURRENT WORKERS
WE HAVE LAST WEEK WITH THE EACH
YEAR SHIFT AT UCSF WHOSE
REACTION WHEN WE MENTION THIS
COMPONENT OF THE INITIATIVE SAID
WHEN CAN WE SIGN UP. OUR
COLLEAGUES AT ET ADMINISTER SIX
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE MILLION OF
FEDERAL FUNDS FOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT EACH YEAR AND SERVE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF WORKERS
ACROSS THE STATE YOUR TRAINING
AND SUPPORT SERVICES. YOU NEED
TO WORK FOR SERVICES BRANCH
TARGET SPECIAL POPULATIONS
THROUGH DISCRETIONARY GRANT
DOLLARS VETERANS PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS FORMALLY INCARCERATED
HOMELESS USED AND IS UNIQUELY
POSITIONED TO IMPLEMENT THE- EMT
PROGRAM FOCUSED ON AT RISK YOUTH
YOU WILL BE HEARING ABOUT AND I
ASSURE YOU WILL BE VERY EXCITED
ABOUT LATER ON. OUR COLLEAGUES
AT THE STATE WORKFORCE BOARD
WILL BUILD NEW HIGH ROAD TRADING
PARTNERSHIPS IN HEALTH CARE
BUILDING ON ITS SUCCESSFUL TRACK
RECORD OF. INDUSTRY PARTNERSHIP
CENTERED ON JOB QUALITY EQUITY
AND WORKFORCE. AND THE PROPOSED
INVESTMENT OF A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY MILLION IN ADULT
EDUCATION ALTHOUGH L. W. G. A.
WILL NOT ADMINISTER THIS
DIRECTLY WE'VE BEGUN PLANNING
BUT OUR COLLEAGUES AT THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. AND THE
STATE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION ON
STRATEGIES THAT WILL A GREAT
LEARNING. TRAINING AND
EMPLOYMENT FOR IMMIGRANTS AND
REFUGEES FLEEING THEIR MUCH
NEEDED LINGUISTIC AND CULTURAL
COMPETENCY INTO THE HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE AND ALSO INCREASING
MOMENTS IN THESE HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEMS- THANK YOU AND
LOOK FORWARD TO ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. THE REST THE
PRESENT SINCE. THANK YOU MUCH
FOR. LET'S START HERE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IF THERE
ARE ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS. I
BETTER TOP AND DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
IN THIS TIME. LOL CORIACEA WITH
THE L. A- WE HAVE NO COMMENT AT
THIS TIME. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. AS CHAIR THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR UP FOR MY OPENING
COMMENTS I WAS HOPING TO GET THE
ADMINISTRATION'S TAKE ON WHETHER
OR NOT YOU FEEL THAT THE PACKAGE
OF PROPOSALS WHICH IS PRESENTED
SUFFICIENTLY PRIORITIZES ISSUES
OF ETHNIC DIVERSITY IN OUR
WORKFORCE AS WELL AS ADDRESSES
THE GEOGRAPHICAL DISPARITIES
THAT SHOW UP FROM OUR WORK FORCE
SHORTAGES HOPING YOU CAN COMMENT
ON THAT. I MEAN I CAN CERTAINLY
BE HANDED OVER TO YOU THAT'S
OKAY SURE. SO YES WE ARE
CONFIDENT THAT THE MEDIA EACH OF
THE LINE ITEM PROPOSALS I DOES
IN FACT. TACKLE APMEX OF
DIVERSITY AND WILL LEAD TO A
FOCUS TO ENSURE THAT THE DOLLARS
ARE. TO ENSURE THE DOLLARS
THEMSELVES ARE FOCUSED ON
INITIATIVES PROGRAMS AND
TRAINING FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE-
OUR REPRESENTATIVES- FOR
EXAMPLE- ETHNIC MINORITIES
LINGUISTIC MINORITIES PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES SUBJECT YOU TO
CLASS STATUS. IN OTHER TYPES OF
LIVED EXPERIENCE- AS WE GO
THROUGH EACH OF THE PROPOSALS
FOR EXAMPLE NURSING INITIATIVE
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS FROM I
THOUGHT I AM MY HOPE IS THAT YOU
WILL SEE THAT ARE FOCUSED ON IN
THAT DIVERSITY IS THE WAVES AS A
CORE VALUE IN EACH OF THOSE
ITEMS. I MEAN I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU WANT TO SPEAK TO ANY OFTHE
REGIONAL QUESTIONS THE DOCTOR AN
ENVELOPE BROUGHT UP OR ANYTHING
THAT YOU WANT TO ADD. WELL I
WILL JUST ECHO WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING. AND WE IT UP THE SECOND
BEFORE YOU CAN CAN YOU SPEAK A
LITTLE CLOSER TO YOUR MICROPHONE
YOU SOUND A LITTLE BIT FAR AWAY.
I'M HAVING ALL KINDS OF PROBLEMS
TODAY BUT LET ME- CONTINUE IS
THAT BETTER. OKAY THANK YOU TO
ECHO WHAT GARCIA SAYING AS WE
HAVE BEEN PLANNING FOR THE
SPECIFIC PROGRAM COMPONENTS OF
THESE INITIATIVES THERE ARE FEW
THROUGH LINES THAT CUT ACROSS
EVERY SINGLE PROGRAM COMPONENT
ONE OF THOSE AND THEN THE TWO
ONES THAT ARE MOST HIGHLIGHTED
IN SIGNIFICANT AND CONSISTENT
OUR DIVERSITY ACROSS THE
SPECIFIC COMMUNITIES OF OUR
STATE THAT- ARE NOT ADEQUATELY
REPRESENTED IN THE HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE- AND HAVE BEEN REALLY
HAVE NOT HAD ACCESS TO THE GOOD
JOBS THAT THAT. HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM CAN OFFER- AND ANOTHER
THROUGH LINE IS THE GEOGRAPHIC
DIVERSITY AND THIS IS THE
EMPHASIS OF BOTH OF THESE
DIMENSIONS O DIVERSITY ARE NOT
ONLY GOOD FOR THE HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM AND THE HEALTH OF
CALIFORNIANS BUT THEY'RE GOOD
FOR INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR
FAMILIES IN THE STATE TO GET
THEM TO THE KINDS OF JOBS THAT
WILL SUPPORT THEMSELVES AND
THEIR FAMILIES. THANK YOU FOR
THAT RESPONSE AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO BRINGING UP THIS AND ISSUES
TWO SEVEN AND ELEVEN LATER
TODAY. BUT SPECIFICALLY WITHIN
THIS ISSUE ITEM- WHAT WE HEAR
THAT THE LOWEST PROVIDER TO
POPULATION RATIOS ARE OFTEN
TIMES IN THE INLAND PARTS OF OUR
STATE LIKE THE INLAND EMPIRE AND
THE SAN JOAQUIN. VALLEY AND IT
SPECIFICALLY TALKS ABOUT
PSYCHIATRIST TO POPULATION US
HAVING A THIRD OF THE PROVIDERS
PER POPULATION THAT ARE
OCCURRING IN THE BAY AREA. THAT
I'D REALLY LIKE TO MAKE SURE WE
ARE APPROPRIATELY FOLLOWING UP.
THAT AND UNDERSTANDING. WHAT WHY
WE DON'T HAVE ANY DOCTORAL
PROGRAMS AT ALL FOR PSYCHOLOGY
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY IT'S
AWFULLY HARD FOR US TO CATCH UP
BEFORE NOT TRAINING THEM IN OUR
BACKYARD. AND AS QUOTED IN THE
AGENDA OF THE HELPS FORCE
RESEARCHERS PREDICT THAT BY
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT WE WILL HAVE
AS A STATE. 50% FEWER
PSYCHIATRIST THEN WILL BE NEEDED
TO MEET THE STATE'S MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS. I'D LIKE TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT PERCENTAGE ARE
WE SHORT TODAY- AND THEN HOW
EXACERBATED IS IT WITH THOSE
GEOGRAPHICAL DISPARITIES. THANK
YOU SO MUCH DR ONLINE AND- I
PROBABLY WILL FORGET. PARTS OF
THE QUESTION THAT YOU JUST ASKED
BUT I WILL SAY THAT I'M A
CLINICAL PSYCHOLOGIST BY TRADE
AND SO TO HEAR YOU SPEAK ABOUT
THE ABSENCE OF PSYCHOLOGY
PROGRAMS IS NEAR AND DEAR TO MY
HEART BECAUSE I KNOW THAT
THAT'S- ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT A
LOT OF MY COLLEAGUES SPACE. I'M
SO I WILL HIT Q. Q. ADDED TOPICS
ON NINE I DON'T HAVE THE VACANCY
RATES OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD BUT
HAPPY TO BE BACK AROUND WITH
YOUR TEAM TO PROVIDE THOSE
NUMBERS. I'M FOR. SOME OF THE
SITE VACANCY RATES ARE THE
HIGHEST THAT WE SEE ACROSS ANY
DISCIPLINE- FOLLOWED BY
PSYCHOLOGY BUT DECK BUT
PSYCHIATRY VACANCIES ARE
DEFINITELY MORE OF AN URGENT
ISSUE. AND SO TO OF THEIR PIECES
BUT I'D LIKE TO TALK ABOUT I
KNOW THEY HAD A PIECE FOR THE
PSYCHIATRY PIECE WE'RE GOING TO
BE HEARING A LITTLE BIT. LATER
FROM DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITALS WHO HAS A PSYCHIATRY
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS WHICH I THINK
YOU WILL ANSWER SOME OF THE
DETAILS OF WHAT YOU'RE SPEAKING
TO BUY. TWO OF THE INTERVENTIONS
BEING ONE. RESIDENCY PROGRAMS
TRAINING SITES WE KNOW. THAT
WHEN YOU HAVE TRAINEES IN
CERTAIN GEOGRAPHIC AREAS THAT'S
WHERE THEY END UP NOT WORKING
AND THAT'S WHERE THEY END UP-SETTLING DOWN. AND PUTTING THEIR
ROOTS INTO COMMUNITIES
THEMSELVES. TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF CLINICAL SITES. AS A
DANCE FOR PSYCHOLOGY A PRE
DOCTORAL AND POST DOCTORAL
INTERNS- IS A BIG ASSET IT.
THERE'S A LOT OF LOW HANGING
FRUIT THERE THAT I THINK THAT WE
CAN THAT WE CAN TACKLE IS THE
STATE'S. SOMETHING THAT AND
DEPUTY SECRETARY'S NAME
MENTIONED EARLIER SPECIFICALLY
HAS TO DO WITH HOW CAN WE
LEVERAGE THE STATE. STATE
FACILITIES STATE HOSPITALS ARE
PRISON NETWORK WHICH IS ALL
ACROSS THE STATE- AS CLINICAL
TRAINING SITES FOR PSYCHIATRY
AND PSYCHOLOGY- RESIDENTS AND
FELLOWS JUST JUST AN IDEA THAT
WOULD LOVE TO ELABORATE ON- BUT
IT IS THAT THROUGH CLINICAL
TRAINING PROGRAMS AN
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS HOW CAN
WE TRAIN. HOW CAN WE EMBED THOSE
TYPES OF PROGRAMS.
GEOGRAPHICALLY IN A SMART WAY
GEOGRAPHICALLY BECAUSE WE DO
KNOW THAT THERE ARE CERTAIN
REGIONS THAT ARE A DESERT FOR
LACK OF A BETTER TERM WHEN IT
COMES TO CLINICAL TRAINING
SITES. AND THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT WE NEED TO DO BETTER ON.
FOREVER BECAUSE ABBY DO YOU HAVE
ANYTHING YOU WANT TO ADD TO
THAT. YEAH I REALLY THINK YOU
COVERED IT WELL DARCY. WHAT I
CAN DO CHAIR AROUND A LOT JUST
FOLLOW UP WITH YOU I'D MENTIONED
THAT WE'VE GOTTEN REGIONAL
BREAKDOWNS. OF THE LABOR MARKET
INFORMATION DIVISION-
PROJECTIONS AND CAN FOLLOW UP
WITH YOU ON SOME OF THE
SPECIFICS AND- PSYCHIATRY AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR PRACTICAL THANK YOU
I A I HAVE A QUESTION JUST WITH
REGARDS TO PROCESS OF EQUITY AND
DIVERSITY WE OFTEN- SPEAK ABOUT
AND MAKE PLANS WITH REGARDS TO
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND WHAT
THAT LOOKS LIKE BUT SOMETHING
THAT WE'VE COME ACROSS AND STUFF
FOR. HAS BEEN- HELP PROP TWO OH
NINE OFTEN GETS IN THE WAY OF
REACHING THOSE EQUITY AND
DIVERSITY GOALS IS THERE A WORK
AROUND THAT OR WHAT ARE THE BEST
PRACTICES TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE. YOU KNOW LANGUAGE-
OPPORTUNITIES AND CAPABILITIES
AS WELL AS CULTURAL COMPETENCY
AND THAT DOES REQUIRE EQUITY AND
DIVERSITY SO WHAT DOES THAT LOOK
LIKE. UP THANK YOU- CHECK IDEA
AND ABSOLUTELY AND I THINK AS AS
CAME UP IN OUR- EARLIER. BUDGET
HEARING THE KEY ONE OF THE KEYS
TO- INCREASING DIVERSITY IN OUR
TRAINING PROGRAMS WHICH LEADS TO
GREATER DIVERSITY IN THE- IN IN
THE WORK FORCE ITSELF. IS
WORKING IN CLOSE PARTNERSHIP
WITH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS THAT HAVE CLOSED
LINKAGES TO THE COMMUNITIES WE
WANT TO SEARCH WHO CAN BE
TRUSTED MESSENGERS AND PARTNERS
IN. RECRUITING TRAINEES FOR THE
PROGRAMS AND CAN ALSO OFFER THE
KINDS OF- SUPPORTIVE SERVICES-
THAT. ENABLE PEOPLE TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN THOSE PROGRAMS IN
TO FINISH THEM THAT CAN BE
SUPPORT FOR CHILD CARE THAT CAN
BE I'M- SUPPORT FOR
TRANSPORTATION THAT CAN- IN
IDEAL SENSES B. TRAINING STIPEND
SO PEOPLE DON'T HAVE TO GIVE UP
JOBS TO PURSUE TRAINING. ON THE
SET UP TO ADDRESS YOUR QUESTION
. SOMEONE BUT I THINK IT'S
PROBABLY A LARGER CONVERSATION
ON ON RECRUITMENT OUTSIDE OF. A
CBO ON THE GROUND WITCHES ARE
OFTEN ALREADY INUNDATED
OVERWORKED UNDERSTAFFED AND
UNDER RESOURCED. SO IT'S JUST A
MATTER OF HOW DO WE MAKEIT A
REALITY. YES AND I THINK PART OF
DOING THAT IS MAKING SURE THAT
THERE'S FUNDING TO SUPPORT THE
WORK OF THOSE PARTNERS ON THE
GROUND. THANK YOU. I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK OUR FIRST PANELIST IN
THE TO AGENCIES FOR BEING HERE
TODAY WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
PANEL TO ON GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION FOR THOSE PANELISTS
WHO ARE PRESENTERS PLEASE
PRESENT IN THE ORDER THAT YOUR
NAME APPEARS ON THE AGENDA WE
WILL HAVE THREE PRESENTERS ON
THIS PANEL INCLUDING KAREN RIZZO
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF H. CAI DR
CATHERINE NATION VICE PRESIDENT
OF HEALTH SERVICES AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
BRENT HOUSE THE CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF OPERATIONS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS.
LET US BEGIN WITH KAREN RESULT.
GOOD AFTERNOON- THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO
EVERYONE TODAY. I AM SO I'M
GOING TO GIVE AN OVERVIEW OF THE
GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION
PROGRAMS THAT H. CRIED
MINISTERS- I'M THEIR GOVERNORS
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET FOR THIS BROWN PROGRAM-
INCLUDED- THREE PIECES ONE TIME
FIFTY MILLION SUPPORT. FOR NEW
PRIMARY CARE RESIDENCY PROGRAMS
ONGOING THIRTY THREE MILLION TO
SUPPORT NEW EXISTING EXPANSION
AND TEACHING HEALTH CENTER
PROGRAMS AND TEN MILLION TO
SUPPORT NURSING PROGRAMS. FOR
THE PRIMARY CARE RESIDENCY
PROGRAM- H. CHI IS PREPARING FOR
ITS ANNUAL PRIMARY CARE
RESIDENCY SPRING APPLICATION
CYCLE- THIS APPLICATION CYCLE
INCLUDE MODIFICATIONS TO THE
PROGRAM TO SUPPORT THE ONE TIME
FUNDING. FOR THESE NEW PROGRAMS
. WE ALSO RECENTLY COMPLETED OUR
NURSING- APPLICATION PROGRAM AND
WE AWARDED TWENTY THREE PROGRAMS
OVER NINE MILLION AWARDS- AND
ANY UNSPENT JERRY OVER INTO OUR
NEXT APPLICATION CYCLE STARTING
IN THE FALL. I'M I ALSO WANTED
TO TALK ABOUT OUR PSYCHIATRY
EDUCATION CAPACITY EXPANSION
PROGRAM. THAT EVEN THOUGH ARE
THE TOPIC OF THIS PANEL WAS
FOCUSED ON SOME BROWN I WANTED
TO PROVIDE A BRIEF UPDATE ABOUT
THAT SPECIFIC PROGRAM. WITH
APPROPRIATIONS IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY NINETEEN FROM THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT AND THE
GENERAL FUND WE BEGAN OUR
PSYCHIATRY EXPANSION CAPACITY
PROGRAM TO SUPPORT THE
ESTABLISHMENT AND EXPANSION OF
PSYCHIATRY RESIDENCY PROGRAMS.
AND PSYCHIATRISTS PSYCHIATRIC
MENTAL HEALTH NURSE PRACTITIONER
PROGRAMS. WITH THIS FUNDING WE
HAVE ALREADY AWARDED ELEVEN
POINT SIX MILLION TO FIND TWO
NEW PSYCHIATRY RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS. AND THE EXPANSION OF
ONE PSYCHIATRY PROGRAM. WE'VE
ALSO AWARDED FOUR POINT FIVE
MILLION TO SUPPORT TO NEW
PSYCHIATRY- MENTAL HEALTH NURSE
PRACTITIONER PROGRAMS. AND THE
EXPANSION OF THE PROGRAM. WAIT
TO OPEN OUR NEXT APPLICATION
CYCLE IN SPRING OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. I ALSO WANT TO TALK ABOUT
WITH THE PASSAGE OF AB ONE
THIRTY THREE THIS YEAR H. CRIED
STANDING UP THE NEW HEALTH
WORKFORCE EDUCATION AND TRAINING
COUNCIL. THIS COUNCIL IS
RESPONSIBLE. FOR HELPING
COORDINATE CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH
WORKFORCE EDUCATION AND
TRAINING. THE DEVELOPER HEALTH
WORKFORCE THAT MEETS
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH CARE NEEDS.
TAKING A BROAD STATEWIDE
APPROACH TO GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION BE ONE AREA OF FOCUS
FOR THIS COUNCIL. AMONG OTHER
THINGS IS COUNSELED ABOUT
GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION
WORKFORCE TRAINING AND
DEVELOPMENT PRIORITIES FOR THE
STATE. PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND SUPPORT FOR
ESTABLISHING NEW GRADUATE
MEDICAL EDUCATION. AND EXPLORE
OPTIONS FOR DEVELOPING A BROAD
GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION AND
HEALTH PROFESSIONS EDUCATION AND
TRAINING FUNDING STRATEGY. THE
FIRST MEETING OF THIS COUNCIL WE
MARCH THIRTIETH. TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. NOW I WOULD DRESS THE
QUESTIONS POSED IN THE AGENDA
I'M ONE QUESTION ASKED COMING OR
RESIDENCY SLOTS ARE THERE IN
CALIFORNIA AS A RESULT OF THE
SONG BROWN PROGRAM OR AS A
RESULT OF INCREASED FUNDING. IN
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY SEVENTEEN H.
CHI RECEIVED A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN FUNDING FOR THE SONG
BROWN PROGRAM. BEFORE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THE ANNUAL BUDGET FOR
THE SONG BROWN PROGRAM WAS SIX
POINT SIX MILLION I'M GOING FOR
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH AID IN
PLANNING FUND. IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE BEGAN
RECEIVING AN ADDITIONAL THIRTY
THREE MILLION ANNUALLY FROM THE
GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT THE SONG
BROWN PROGRAM. WITH THIS NEW
FUNDING WE BEGAN TRACKING HER
PROGRESS TO DETERMINE THE- EXACT
MYSTERY THE IMPACT. OF THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING OUR PRIMARY
CARE RESIDENCY TRAINING SLOTS.
SINCE TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE SONG
BROWN PRIMARY CARE RESIDENCY
PROGRAM HAS SUPPORTED THE
LAUNCHING OF THIRTY TWO NEW
PROGRAMS. AND THE EXPANSION OF
THIRTY SEVEN EXISTING PROGRAMS.
WHICH RESULT IN AN ADDITIONAL
TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN
ADDITIONAL PRIMARY CARE
RESIDENCY SLOTS IN CALIFORNIA.
IN THAT SAME TIME PERIOD THE
OVERALL NUMBER OF SLOTS GREW BY
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT SO THE
SONG BROWN PROGRAM SUPPORTED TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTEEN OF THESE. IN
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY THIS ALSO
FUNDING SUPPORT. FOR PRIMARY
CARE RESIDENCY PROGRAM. IF YOU
WOULD LIKE WE CAN GATHER DATA
BACK TO TWENTY FOURTEEN BUT WE
WANTED TO POINT OUT THAT THE
IMPACT OF THE SIGNIFICANT
GENERAL FUND INVESTMENT IN THE
SONG BROWN PROGRAMS THAT'S
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. I ALSO WANT TO
ADDRESS THE SECOND QUESTION
AROUND- WHETHER WE MONITOR SONG
BROWN GRANTS TO ENSURE THE
HOSPITAL DO NOT USE GRANT FUNDS
TO BACK FILL. OTHER FUNDING- AND
IN ORDER TO SHARE FUNDS TO OTHER
HOSPITAL NEEDS. WHEN PROGRAMS
ARE FOR ARE. BASE CERTIFY THAT
THE INFORMATION THEY'RE
PROVIDING IS TRUE AND ACCURATE.
THE SONG BROWN PROGRAM HAS IS.
MINE WOULD YOU HAS GRANT
GUIDANCE AND GRANT AGREEMENTS
THAT PROHIBIT SUPPLANTING OF
EXISTING STATE OR LOCAL FUNDS.
THERE IS ALSO GRANT AGREEMENT
LANGUAGE REQUIRING THE GRANT YOU
KEEP CLEAR RECORDS FOR AT LEAST
THREE YEARS TO ACCOUNT FOR THE
SONG BROWN FUNDS. SB FOR EVERY
APPLICATION CYCLE WE PROVIDED
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE WEBINAR. I
THINK POTENTIAL APPLICANTS. AND
REINFORCE THE REQUIREMENTS ABOUT
THE GRANT FUNDS. MY PROGRAMS
INVOICE FOR PAYMENT THEY CERTIFY
THAT THE FUNDING WENT TO THE
EDUCATION TRAINING AND THE
SUPPORT RESIDENTS. FINALLY WE
HAVE A CLAUSE IN THE GRANT
AGREEMENT ABOUT THE CHANGE ON
OUR- OVER THERE OTHER THAN THESE
PROGRAM REQUIREMENTS H. H. CARD
HAS NOT CONDUCTED A FULL FISCAL
AUDIT OF ITS GRANTEES. THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM DR
CATHERINE NATION WITH UNIVERSIT
OF CALIFORNIA. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
CHARMELOT CHAIR CARILLO MEMBERS
OF THAT COMMITTEE- I SO
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
JOIN YOU THIS AFTERNOON- AND
HAVE SPENT ACTUALLY MUCH OF MY
PROFESSIONAL CAREER- ON TOPICS
THAT ARE- PART OF YOUR PLANS FOR
DISCUSSION THROUGHOUT THESE
PANELS. ON AS WAS MENTIONED MY
NAME IS KATHERINE NATION I AM
THE VICE PRESIDENT FOR HEALTH
SCIENCES IN THE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM WIDE- OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT. I WAS ASKED TO SPEAK-
TODAY JUST BRIEFLY AND MINDFUL
OF TIME ABOUT THE CRITICAL
RELEVANCE AND IMPORTANCE OF
GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION- AS A
STRATEGY AN AREA OF INVESTMENT
FOR MEETING OUR FUTURE- WORK
FORCE NEEDS TO AND DR RONNY LIKE
PARTICULARLY. APPRECIATED YOUR
OPENING REMARKS. ON TO BE TO BE
BRIEF- GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION OR RESIDENCY TRAINING
IS BUT SECOND MAJOR PHASE OF
MEDICAL EDUCATION FOR PRACTICING
DOCTORS- THIS IS THE TRAINING
THAT PROVIDES OUR MEDICAL SCHOOL
GRADUATES. WITH SPECIALTY
SPECIFIC TRAINING THIS IS
REQUIRED FOR LICENSURE AND FOR
INDEPENDENT PRACTICE. OUR
RESIDENT POSITIONS TYPICALLY
SPEND SOMEWHERE BETWEEN THREE
AND SEVEN YEARS IN RESIDENCY
TRAINING DEPENDING. UPON THE
SPECIALTY THEY SELECT. I WOULD
CONTEXT- THERE ARE MORE THAN
ELEVEN THOUSAND MEDICAL
RESIDENTS ENROLLED IN CALIFORNIA
TRAINING PROGRAMS. NEARLY HALF
OF THESE PARTICIPATE IN OUR OWN
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SPONSORED AND CLOSELY AFFILIATED
PROGRAMS. ACCORDING TO NATIONAL
DATA FROM THE ASSOCIATION OF
AMERICAN MEDICAL COLLEGES AND I
THINK OF POINT OF SPECIAL
RELEVANCE FOR THE DISCUSSION
THIS AFTERNOON. CALIFORNIA LEADS
THE NATION. IN THE RETENTION OF
MEDICAL STUDENTS AND RESIDENTS
FOR COMPLETE THEIR TRAINING IN
THE STATE. NOW ALL COME BACK TO
THIS IS PART OF MY CLOSING
REMARKS. NOT NOT NOT
WITHSTANDING THESE VERY HIGH
RATES OF RETENTION. THE
CALIFORNIA FUTURE HEALTH
WORKFORCE COMMISSION FOUND IN
ITS TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN FINAL
REPORT THAT THE STATE WILL FACE
SIGNIFICANT PHYSICIAN SHORTAGES.
AND SHORTAGES OF OTHER HEALTH
CARE PERSONAL AS WELL BY THE
YEAR TWENTY THIRD. THIS IS
EXPECTED AS A RESULT OF A
GROWING AND AGING POPULATION IN
CALIFORNIA. AS WELL AS AN AGING
PHYSICIAN WORKFORCE WITH A TRULY
A GENERATION EXPECTED TO RETIRE
IN THE NOT TOO DISTANT FUTURE.
OUR COLLEAGUES IN SPEAKERS
BEFORE ME HAVE ALSO HIGHLIGHTED
THE CRITICAL IMPORTANCE OF
DIVERSITY EQUITY AND INCLUSION-
WE KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA
PHYSICIANS DO NOT CURRENTLY
REFLECT THE RICH DIVERSITY. OF
OUR POPULATION AND THAT TOO FEW
ARE TRAINED IN SOME OF THE
SPECIALTIES THAT ARE MOST
NEEDED- WE WE'VE TALKED A LOT IN
PAST YEARS ABOUT PRIMARY CARE
WERE SPEAKING TODAY. ABOUT
PSYCHIATRY AND MENTAL HEALTH-
CRITICAL AREAS. OF NEED I THINK
IN OUR SHARED VIEWS. FOR OUR OWN
WORK FORCED REALLY TO BETTER
REFLECT OUT OF THE CALIFORNIA
POPULATION. IT WILL BE CRITICAL
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL SCHOOLS
AND RESIDENCY PROGRAMS CONTINUE
TO PRIORITIZE OUR EFFORTS TO
INCREASE DIVERSITY. AND ALL OF
PONSON OFFER DEPENDING UPON THE
TIME ALLOWED TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT OUR ARE YOU SEE-
CRIME INITIATIVES WITH THE
TWENTY YEAR HISTORY- AND-%
CURRENTLY THREE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY SIX STUDENTS ENROLLED
SIXTY EIGHT OF PERCENT OF HOME
OUR OUR STUDENTS
UNDERREPRESENTED IN MEDICINE I
THINK THIS BODES WELL FOR THE
FUTURE. FOR GMT AMONG THE RECENT
STATEWIDE INITIATIVES THAT ARE
INTENDED TO HELP ON HOW TO DRESS
CALIFORNIA NEEDS AND
PARTICULARLY THOSE OF
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES OUR OUR
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY- OR INLAND
EMPIRE THE WORLD NORTH.
CALIFORNIA VOTERS APPROVED
PROPOSITION- FIFTY SIX IN
NOVEMBER OF TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN. THIS MEASURE PROVIDES
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR
TOBACCO TAX REVENUE TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. FOR
THE PURPOSE AND GOAL OF
SUSTAINING. RETAINING AND
EXPANDING GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION PROGRAMS IN ORDER TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF PRIMARY
CARE AND EMERGENCY MEDICINE
PHYSICIANS WHO PRACTICE IN THIS
STATE. CREDIT PROGRAMS IN FIVE
SPECIALTIES ARE ELIGIBLE TO
APPLY. THESE PROGRAMS INCLUDE
EMERGENCY MEDICINE. FAMILY
MEDICINE INTERNAL MEDICINE
OBSTETRICS AND GYNECOLOGY AND
PEDIATRICS. FIFTY SIX FURTHER
STATES THAT FUNDING SHOULD BE
PRIORITIZED FOR DIRECT MEDICAL
EDUCATION BOB COSTAS AND FOR
PROGRAMS SERVING MEDICALLY
UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS ON AN
AREA OF FOCUS THAT WE'VE LEARNED
TO OUR PRIME PROGRAMS- HAUSER
RECORD OF SUCCESS WITH CAREFUL
INVESTMENT. TO ADMINISTER- THIS
PROGRAM WHICH IS REFERRED TO AS
CHALAMET FORCED THE UNIVERSITY
HAS RETAINED AN INDEPENDENT
THIRD PARTY. POSITIONS FOR
HELPING CALIFORNIA OR PH C. IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH US AND WITH THE
STATEWIDE ADVISORY COUNCIL PHC
HAS ESTABLISHED A STRUCTURE AND
A PROGRAM THAT IS ALIGNED WITH
THE AIMS OF PROPOSITION FIFTY
SIX AND THAT IS COMPLIANT WITH
APPLICABLE STATUTE AND
REGULATIONS. I'M PROUD TO SAY
THAT SINCE THE PASSAGE OF
PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX PC HAS
MANAGED FOR COMPETITIVE GRANT
CYCLES AND AWARDED A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY TWO MILLION IN SUPPORT OF.
A TOTAL OF SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY EIGHT RESIDENCY PROGRAMS
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
DURING OUR MOST RECENT CYCLE
ALONE NEARLY A HUNDRED MILLION
WAS REQUESTED AND THIRTY NINE
MILLION WAS AWARDED ON TO
SUPPORT TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN
POSITIONS. 83% OF THE HE'S
SERVING UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES-
AND THIS IS A FAST USING A PAYER
MIX OF PROGRAMS MEDIC CAL DUAL
ELIGIBLE INDIGENT AND UNINSURED.
76% OF OUR PROGRAMS ALSO SERVE
DESIGNATED HEALTH FOR SENATE
HEALTH PROFESSION SHORTAGE AREAS
OR HIPS THE COMMUNITIES.
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT- ALTHOUGH
OUR STATEWIDE FUNDING REQUEST
CONTINUE TO FAR EXCEED CURRENT
FUNDING LEVELS TO IT AGAIN FORTY
MILLION ANNUALLY. THESE FUNDS
HAVE ENABLED EXISTING PROGRAMS
TO GROW AND THAT HELPED- PROVIDE
CRITICALLY NEEDED RESOURCES TO
SUPPORT THE LAUNCH OF NEW
PROGRAMS. THIS FUNDING AND I
PERHAPS SHOULD HAVE SAID WITH MY
INTRODUCTION THAT I HAD THE LONG
PRIVILEGE OF SERVICE ON THE SONG
BROWN COMMISSION REPRESENTING
YOU SEEK MEDICAL SCHOOLS
ANALYSTS SAY THAT. THE STATE
SUPPORT FOR SONG BROWN AND OUR
TOBACCO TAX FUNDED PROP FIFTY
SIX PROGRAMS OFFER ONE OF THE
SINGLE MOST EFFECTIVE STRATEGIES
FOR MEETING STATEWIDE POSITION
NEEDS. ON THIS IS BECAUSE I
THINK IT WAS STATED EARLIER- IN
REMARKS BY OTHERS THAT THE
LOCATION OF RESIDENCY TRAINING
IS AMONG THE STRONGEST
PREDICTORS OF FUTURE PRACTICE
LOCATION- ALL WRAPPED UP HERE
WITH A FEW LAST COMMENT SAY I'D
LIKE TO SPEAK TO THE VALUE. OF
THIS INVESTMENT TURNOUT SONG
BROWN PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX- IT
IS ESPECIALLY NOTEWORTHY THAT
77% OF CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
RESIDENTS. ARE EXPECTED TO
REMAIN IN THE STATE FOLLOWING
THE COMPLETION OF THEIR
TRAINING. BOB THIS IS BY
CONTRAST TO ABOUT 55% ON A
NATIONAL LEVEL. AND AS I
MENTIONED BRIEFLY AT THE START-
CALIFORNIA PROUDLY LEADS THE
NATION IN THE RETENTION OF
MEDICAL STUDENTS AND RESIDENTS
WERE TRAINED HERE. AND I THINK
THIS REFLECTS A VERY HIGH RATE
OF RETURN ON THE INVESTMENT-
DOCTOR ON THIS PART OF YOUR
OPENING REMARKS YOU YOU YOU YOU
MENTIONED THE IMPORTANCE OF
DIVERSITY- AND DEPUTY AND
INCLUSION IN STRATEGIES FOR
IMPROVING ACCESS AND ACCESS AND
HEALTH CARE OUTCOMES. ON TOPICS
OF PRIORITIES I THINK FOR US ALL
I'D LIKE TO MENTION THAT YOU SEE
MEDICAL SCHOOLS IN PARTICULAR
HAVE ALSO RECEIVED SOME NATIONAL
RECOGNITION- IN THE LATEST US
NEWS AND WORLD REPORT RANKINGS
FOR DIVERSITY WITHOUT FOUR OF
OUR SIX UC MEDICAL SCHOOLS
RANKING IN THE TOP TEN IN THE
COUNTRY. WITH DAVIS AT NUMBER
FOUR UC RIVERSIDE ARE OUR NEWEST
AND YOUNGEST MEDICAL SCHOOL AT
NUMBER SIX YOU SEE LOS ANGELES
AND SAN FRANCISCO- TIED AT NINE
AND AGAIN OUR PRIME PROGRAMS ARE
ROOTED IN D. I. D. E. I. AND-
AND TO HAVE CONTRIBUTED
SUBSTANTIALLY TO THE SUCCESSFUL.
JUST CLOSE BY SAYING THAT- ON
BEHALF OF OUR PARTNERS AT PH C.
AND CALIFORNIA'S GMB COMMUNITY I
WOULD ALSO REALLY LIKE TO THANK
GOD THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR. FOR THE ADDITIONAL
STATE GENERAL FUND SUPPORT TO
THE PROP FIFTY SIX PROGRAM WHEN
TOBACCO TAX REVENUES HAVE FALLEN
SHORT J. J. INSURE THAT OUR
ANNUAL PROGRAM REMAINS BUDGET
REMAIN STABLE AT FORTY MILLION.
NINE APPRECIATE. THE TIME TO BE
HERE WITH EVERYONE THIS
AFTERNOON. THE YOU NEXT WE WILL
HEAR FROM BRENT HOUSE IS THE-
DEPUTY DOOR OF OPERATIONS FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITALS PLEASE BE IN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRS AND COMMITTEE
MEMBER SPRINT HEALTH SEARCHING
DEPUTY RECTOR OF OPERATIONS OF
THE DEPARTMENT STATE HOSPITALS.
BEFORE SPEAKING DIRECTLY TO THE
D. S. H. MAP A RESIDENCY PROGRAM
AS NOTED IN THE AGENDA I DID
WANT TO TAKE A BRIEF OPPORTUNITY
PER TO PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF
THE DEPARTMENT STAY HOSPITALS.
DEPARTMENTS THEY HOSPITAL'S
MANAGES CALIFORNIA STATE
HOSPITAL SYSTEM IN OUR MISSION
IS TO PROVIDE EVALUATION AND
TREATMENT AS SAFE AND
RESPONSIBLE MANNER. BY THE END
OF PATIENT EXCELLENCE ACROSS THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE AND SETTINGS.
DEPARTMENTS THEY HOSPITALS ALSO
KNOWN AS THE S. H. OVERSEAS BY
STATE HOSPITALS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND EMPLOYS NEARLY
THIRTEEN THOUSAND STAFF. IN
ADDITION TO STAY HOSPITAL
TREATMENT YES H. PROVIDE
SERVICES AND CONTRACTED JAIL
BASED COMPETENCY TREATMENT
COMMUNITY BASED RESTORATION AND
PRE TRIAL FELONY MENTAL HEALTH
DIVERSION PROGRAMS. IN ADDITION
TO THE CONDITIONAL RELEASE
PROGRAM. YES AGES WORKFORCE
PROVIDING SUPPORT PATIENT CARE
THAT SERVES OVER FIVE THOUSAND
PATIENTS AND DALY AND A TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN HOSPITAL SETTING. THE
INDIVIDUAL SURVIVOR SYSTEM OF
CARE AMANDA FOR MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT BY EITHER CRIMINAL OR
CIVIL COURT JUDGE. WE SERVE
DIFFERENT TYPES OF PATIENTS SUCH
AS BUT NOT LIMITED TO
INDIVIDUALS DETERMINED TO BE
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL. NOT
GUILTY BY REASON OF INSANITY AND
INDIVIDUALS FROM CDC ARE WITH
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS WHO
REQUIRE INPATIENT HOSPITAL
TREATMENT. DUE TO MULTIPLE
FACTORS INCLUDING THE NATURE OF
THE INDIVIDUALS WE SERVE
INDIVIDUALS ON SOME OF THE MOST
DIFFICULT TO TREAT BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS. THE
GEOGRAPHIC LOCATION OF SOME OF
OUR STATE HOSPITALS RECRUITMENT
AND RETENTION HAS BEEN
HISTORICALLY CHALLENGING. AS A
DEPARTMENT WE LOOK FOR
OPPORTUNITIES TO EXPAND
WORKFORCE PIPELINE INTO OUR
SYSTEM. AND ONE OF TH MOST
CHALLENGING POSITIONS TO FILL A
PSYCHIATRIST AND TO THAT END WE
SOUGHT TO ESTABLISH A RESIDENCY
PROGRAM. SPECIFIC TORTILLA SAGE
NAPA RESIDENCY PROGRAM THE
TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET ACT
INCLUDED RESOURCES TO SUPPORT
THE DEVELOPMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF A PSYCHIATRIC
RESIDENCY PROGRAM. I ONE OF OUR
STATE HOSPITALS PSH NAPA. THE
PURPOSE OF THIS WAS TO ESTABLISH
A MEANS OF ATTRACTING OR
RETAINING A SUFFICIENT WORKFORCE
TO PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. TO PATIENTS. YES IT
RECEIVED SIX HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY ONE POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND ABOUT ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING TO
OPERATE THIS PROGRAM. PRESENTS
THE PROGRAM IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
SAINT JOSEPH MEDICAL CENTER AND
YES H. NAPPER RECEIVED
ACCREDITATION FROM THE
ACCREDITATION COUNCIL FOR
GRADUATE MATCHETT MEDICAL
EDUCATION IN FEBRUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. WHICH ENABLED
RECRUITMENT FOR RESIDENTS. THE%
PSYCHIATRIC RESIDENCY PROGRAM
BEGAN ITS FIRST COHORT OF SEVEN
RESIDENTS AND JULY OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. ORIGINAL PROPOSAL
ONLY CALL FOR RESIDENTS PER
PROGRAM YEAR WHICH WAS AN
ESTIMATE AT THE TIME BUT WITHIN
THE EXISTING PROGRAM BUDGET YES
H. WAS ABLE TO FIND SEVEN
RESIDENTS PER PROGRAM YEAR
THROUGH FISCAL YEAR TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE. ADDITIONALLY WE
RECENTLY MATCHED ALL SEVEN OF
OUR RESIDENCY SLOTS FOR NEXT
YEAR AS WELL. THE RESIDENTS
DEPENDING ON WHICH YEAR SPEND
TIME IDEA STAGE NAPA UNDER THE
SUPERVISION OF A LICENSED
PSYCHIATRIST PROVIDING DIRECT
PATIENT CARE THEREBY EXTENDING
OUR WORKFORCE. WITH THE CURRENT
CONTRACT IN PLACE TWENTY EIGHT
RESIDENTS WILL BEGIN THE PROGRAM
BY POSTGRADUATE YEAR FOUR. OF
THOSE NO MORE THAN EIGHT WILL BE
ON SITE AT ANY GIVEN TIME. GIVEN
THE SUCCESS OF RECRUITING THE
FIRST COHORT AND SECOND COHORTES
DE S. H. IS CURRENTLY EXPLORING.
I WITH ST JOSEPH MEDICAL CENTER
ON POTENTIALLY INCREASING THE
NUMBER OF RESIDENTS
PARTICIPATING AND A RESIDENCY
PROGRAM GIVEN THE DUAL BENEFIT
OF SUPPLEMENTING OUR WORKFORCE
IN THE SHORT TERM AND
POTENTIALLY GROWING OUR OWN
WORKFORCE NOT LONG TERM. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY PERCENT
TODAY AND AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WILL BRING
IT UP TO THE DÍAS TO SEE IF ANY
MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS. I WILL
KEEP IT HERE FOR A SECOND AND
FOLLOW UP- WE JUST HEARD- THIS
QUESTION WILL GO TO KAREN RESELL
IT I'M- GONNA ASK ABOUT THE TWO
NEW PSYCHIATRY PROGRAMS THAT WE
JUST HEARD ABOUT AS WELL AS THE
NEW AND PEACE. PROGRAMS AND
OVERLAY ARE COMMENTS FROM ISSUE
ONE AGAIN. AND ASK IF THERE'S-
PLANS FOR US TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
ADDRESSING THE GEOGRAPHICAL
DISPARITIES THAT WE HAVE. THANK
YOU- SO. WITH THE- PSYCHIATRY
RESIDENCYPROGRAMS- THAT WE- I
TALKED ABOUT EARLIER- THE MOST
THOSE ARE- INTENDED TO SUPPORT
PROGRAMS THAT ARE SERVING- AND
TRAINING IN THESE PARTICULAR IN
TRAINING IN THE PUBLIC MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM AND SO IT'S REALLY
NICE. REALLY FOCUS ON TRAINING
PEOPLE TO SERVE IN UNDERSERVED
AREAS- I ALSO LOOKED AT THE
EXPANSION THROUGHOUT THE STATE
SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS INCLUDE A
NEW PSYCHIATRIC RESIDENCY
PROGRAM IN BUTTE COUNTY AN AREA
THAT IS THE TIME TO SORT
SHORTAGE I'M LOOKING AT CHARLES
DREW- HAS A STRONG COMMITMENT.
TO SERVING IN UNDERSERVED AREAS
SO THESE ARE EXAMPLES OF HOW
THESE PROGRAMS ARE REALLY
COMMITTED TO YOU ON THAT
DIVERSITY WE'RE TRYING TO EXPAND
GEOGRAPHICALLY BUT ALSO EXPAND
THE DIVERSITY OF THOSE SERVING
IN WHERE THERE'S- WILL- MENTION
IT AGAIN WE DO HAVE A STATE WE
HAVE. MANY STATE HOSPITALS AND
THE CENTRAL VALLEY THERE MAY BE
OPPORTUNITIES AS WE'RE LOOKING
TO EXPAND AND GROW TO CONSIDER
THE GEOGRAPHICAL DISPARITIES
THAT HAVE BEEN HIGHLIGHTED HERE
TODAY. LIKE TO STAY WITH YOU
MISS RESULT IF I CANNOT. EARLY
BOTH PROUD AND APPRECIATIVE OF
THE SONG BROWN FUNDING WE HELPED
TO SECURE IN TWENTY SIXTEEN. AND
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO FOLLOW
UP ON. YOUR STATEMENTS WHICH
WERE MUCH STRONGER THAN- I AM
VERY APPRECIATIVE FOR IT THAT.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
NOT PROHIBITING SUPPLANTING OF
THESE FUNDS BUT I'D LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO FOLLOW UP AND ASK WHY WE
DON'T DO MORE OVERSIGHT OVER
THIS PROGRAM YOU WOULD MENTION
THAT WE HAVE NOT DONE A FISCAL
AUDIT THUS FAR. AND WOULD LIKE
TO ASK. WHY SHOULD WE HAVE THAT
MUCH TRUST. HOW ARE WE ENSURING
THAT THESE DOLLARS ARE GOING
TOWARDS THEIR INTENDED PURPOSES-
WHAT HOPING YOU CAN COMMENT ON
IT AS I BELIEVE THERE'S
CONFUSION REGARDING THE NEW AND
EXISTING PROGRAMS ON WHETHER OR
NOT AND HOW THOSE FUNDS ARE TO
BE SPENT AND- HOPING YOU CAN
PROVIDE SOME INSIGHTS. THANK YOU
FOR THAT QUESTION AND IF THERE
ARE IS SOME CONFUSION THAT'S
HELPFUL TO KNOW WHEN WE COULD
CERTAINLY FOLLOW UP ON THAT IN
TERMS OF. OF CLARIFYING THAT FOR
THE PROGRAM AND THE PROGRAM
APPLICANTS. I'M AS I MENTIONED
BEFORE- WHAT WE DO AT. BILL YOU
KNOW WE- PUT SOME LANGUAGE
INTERNET REIMAGINE OUR GRANT
GUIDES IN TERMS OF REALLY-
PROVIDING THE PARAMETERS IN
TERMS OF HOW OF SPENDING THAT.
THE FUNDING I'M ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE HAVE LEARNED IS
THAT YOU DO HAVE TO IF WE WANTED
TO DO FULL FISCAL AUDITS- BUT
THAT THAT WOULD NECESSITATE-
SIGNIFICANT ADDITIONAL- STAFFING
AND RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO DO
THAT. I'M WE HAVE NOT BEEN AWARE
OF ANY ISSUES AND- IN THAT IN
THE USING OF THE PROGRAMS
ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY ARE.
INDICATING THAT THEY ARE-
INVOICING PERIODICALLY AND
INDICATING HOW THEY ARE. USING
THAT THE FUNDS. I LOOK FORWARD
TO THOSE- FOLLOW KIND. AND WILL
IDENTIFY SPECIFIC SITES- WE HAVE
A LEVEL ONE TRAUMA CENTER IN
DOWNTOWN FRESNO COMMUNITY
REGIONAL MEDICAL CENTER THAT
WHEN I SOKE WITH THEIR CEO
CRAIG CASTRO WAS NOT ABLE TO GET
A STREET RESPONSE. REGARDING HOW
THESE FUNDS HAVE BEEN SPENT OR
WHETHER OR NOT THEY'VE BEEN
SUPPLANTED I'VE FOLLOWED UP
THOSE QUESTIONS WITH A
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
AND WOULD NOW LIKE TO ASK THE
ADMINISTRATION. TO ENSURE THAT
THESE FUNDS ARE GOING TOWARDS
MORE RESIDENTS IN COMMUNITIES
LIKE OURS AND BELIEVE THAT THEN
ASSESS IT TAKES GREATER
OVERSIGHT IF WE ARE NOT.
PROVIDING THAT THROUGH OUR
CURRENT- PROCESS AND- WOULD
APPRECIATE A FOLLOW UP ON THAT
SPECIFIC EXAMPLE AND- HAPPY TO
GIVE YOU MORE DETAILS AS WE GO
FORWARD. I WOULD NOT- MAYBE THEN
I'LL I WILL STICK WITH THIS-
REGARDING THE NEW AND EXISTING
PROGRAMS THAT WE SAW IN THE
AGENDA ON PAGE TWENTY. IS THERE
A IS THAT IS IT MORE BENEFICIAL
TO SUPPORT THE NEW OR EXISTING
PROGRAMS IS THERE A- HOW SHOULD
WE BE BEST UTILIZING THESE FUNDS
TO GET THE BEST RETURN ON
INVESTMENT. WELL I MEAN AS WE
KNOW- THE COST TO ESTABLISH A
NEW RESIDENCY PROGRAM IS YOU
KNOW SIGNIFICANT RIGHT IRAN IS
LESS COSTLY TO EXPAND AN
EXISTING PROGRAM AND OF COURSE
AS LEAST COSTLY TO HAVE FIND
EXISTING SLOTS- BUT WENT AT THE
SAME TIME- YOU KNOW WE FEELS
VERY STRONGLY THAT ONE OF THAT.
SONG RAP JENKINS- NOT ONLY TO
INCREASE THAT- I DIVERSITY OF-
THE- PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS
SERVING AND WHERE THEY'RE
SERVING BUT IT'S REALLY TO
EXPAND THE CAPACITY TRAIN MORE
PRIMARY CARE RESIDENTS WE MEAN I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S A HUGE
SHORTAGE AND SO WE THINK THAT
THAT FUNDING PROGRAMS TO BE ABLE
TO EXPAND- AND PUT DOLLARS
TOWARDS NEW AND EXPANSION-
REALLY HELPS ALLEVIATE SOME OF
THE SHORTAGE THAT WE'RE SEEING.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE TO PROVIDE
THAT CLARITY BECAUSE THERE ARE
CONFUSION AMONG SOME OF THE
SITES ABOUT THIS THE FEELING IS
THAT IF IT'S AN EXISTING SLOT
THE QUESTION WHETHER OR NOT THEY
CAN USE THE DOLLARS TO FUND
THOSE EXISTING SLOTS AND NOT AS
YOU STATED TO EXPAND THOSE
EXISTING PROGRAMS I WANT TO MAKE
SURE FOR GIVEN DOLLARS WE'RE
GETTING MORE DOCTORS. AND
BELIEVES THAT THE CLARITY YOU
PROVIDED JUST GAVE US THAT THAT
I WOULD LIKE TO ENSURE THAT ALL
OF THE SITES HAVE THAT SAME
INFORMATION AS WELL. WITH THAT I
WILL PASS IT TO MADAM CHAIR TO
SEE IF YOU HAVE ANY. QUESTIONS
THE MY ONLY FOLLOW UP TO THIS-
ARAMBULA WOULD BE TO GET. SOME
KIND OF- TIMELINE AND DATE AS TO
A COMMITMENT TO A DATE AS TO
WHEN YOU WILL SEE. THE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
EFFORT THAT YOU JUST RAISED IN
YOUR COMMUNITY. BECAUSE
OFTENTIMES IN THESE HEARINGS WE
HEAR FROM THE ADMINISTRATION LET
ME GET BACK TO YOU. AND THEN
THEY LET ME GET BACK TO YOU
DOESN'T ACTUALLY QUITE HAPPEN.
AND THEN WE ARE AND THEN CHARGED
WITH ACTUALLY PASSING BUDGETS-
AND ALSO TALKING TO OUR
COLLEAGUES TO SUPPORT BUDGET
REQUESTS WHEN WE DON'T HAVE THE
INFORMATION NECESSARY TO MAKE.
THE APPROPRIATE DECISIONS AND
RESPONSES TO HOW WE BEST UTILIZE
PUBLIC DOLLARS SO CAN WE GET A
COMMITMENT AS TO WHEN MR
ARAMBULA WILL BE RECEIVING. THE
DATA THAT HE HAS BEEN REQUESTING
- WELL I WOULD LIKE TO SAY IS
THAT WE WILL FOLLOW UP
IMMEDIATELY THIS WEEK- AND
WHAT'S YOUR OFFICE AND THAT. YOU
HAVE MORE INFORMATION AS TO WHAT
WE CAN PROVIDE FOR YOU
ABSOLUTELY. THANK YOU MUCH
APPRECIATED WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER THREE WHICH
IS A REQUEST FOR COORDINATION
RESOURCES FOR THE LABOR AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY-
THE PRESENTER FOR THIS PANEL IS
GOING TO BE DEPUTY SECRETARY-
ABBY'S NAME. MISS NAY YOUR BACK
GARDEN HOPEFULLY WE- ARE ABLE TO
HEAR YOU A LITTLE BIT BETTER IF
YOU CAN PROJECT INTO YOUR
MICROPHONE THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
YES THANK YOU SO MUCH AS WE'VE
BEEN DISCUSSING THE WORK FORCE
FOR ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA.
ENVISIONS A NEW AND
COMPREHENSIVE PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN C. HHS AND L. WGA THAT
ENCOMPASSES ENTRY LEVEL AND
ADVANCED TRAINING PATHWAYS GROUP
CAREER ADVANCEMENT. AND CHANGES
IN REIMBURSEMENT AND
CERTIFICATION TO APPROVE THE
QUALITY OF JOBS. PLANNING FOR
THIS INITIATIVE IS BEING
CONDUCTED ALREADY IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH C. H. H. S. WITH H. CRIED
AND FOCUSED ON PROJECTED LABOR
MARKET DEMAND WORKFORCE
SHORTAGES. WITH NEW TRAINING
PROGRAMS TO BE DEVELOPED THAT
WERE BUILT ON BEST PRACTICE
RESEARCH AND UTILIZE MULTIPLE
TRAINING MODALITIES AND
TECHNOLOGY PLATFORMS ALONG WITH
A FOCUS ON PRACTICAL EXPERIENCE
AND THE GOLD STANDARD
APPRENTICESHIP. IN ORDER TO
FULLY IMPLEMENT THIS EXCITING
THE PROPOSAL AND PARTNERSHIP THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY IS REQUESTING
TWO POSITIONS AND A FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLAR GENERAL FUND FOR
OVER THREE YEARS FOR STAFF TO
DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT. THE WORK
FORCE FOR A HEALTHY CALIFORNIA
INITIATIVE. AND FOR THIS NEW
LEVEL OF COORDINATION WE SEE
THAT WE REQUIRE AND ARE
REQUESTING ASSISTANCE SECRETARY
A RESEARCH DATA SPECIALIST TWO
AND SIXTY SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY AND TEMPORARY STAFFING
IN CONSULTATION TO PLAN AND
EXECUTE THIS INITIATIVE AND
BUILD A SUCCESSFUL AND
SUSTAINABLE PARTNERSHIP WOULD
SEE HHS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU DO
WE HAVE ANY COMMENTS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. BY
PATRICK TOPPING DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THAT THE FOR THE AD
RIGHT NOW WOULD HAVE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU L. L.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR COREY WITH
THE L. A. L- WE DON'T WE DON'T
HAVE ANY. COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
TO RAISE SPECIFIC TO THIS TO
THIS B. C. P. THANK YOU MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. OKAY I JUST A
QUESTION FOR ME AS A FOLLOW UP.
AS YOU'VE NOTED BEFORE THIS
PROPOSAL SPANS MULTIPLE AGENCIES
AND DEPARTMENTS. IS THE LABOR
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY
THE DESIGNATED AGENCY THAT- TO
PROVIDE LEADERSHIP AND
COORDINATE. COORDINATE THIS
ENTIRE INITIATIVE AND- WHAT WILL
BE THE ROLE OF THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY
. WELL AS WE MENTIONED PART OF
WHAT'S SO EXCITING ABOUT THIS IS
THAT IS A COLLABORATION THAT IS
LEVERAGING THE CAPABILITIES AND
COMPETENCIES. OF EACH OF THE
AGENCIES AND THE LABOR AGENCY
BRINGS OUR EXTENSIVE EXPERIENCE
IN DEVELOPING AND IMPLEMENTING
WORKFORCE. PROGRAMS FOR MULTIPLE
KINDS OF A SECTOR INDUSTRY
SECTORS EMPLOYER PARTNERS AND-
COMMUNITY GROUPS AND CJ JUST
BRINGS IT'S- REALLY AMAZING
EXPERTISE IN ALL ASPECTS OF.
HEALTH CARE AND HEALTH HEALTH
CARE PLANNING HEALTHCARE
DELIVERY AND SO WORKING TOGETHER
IN CREATING THIS NEW TRUE-
COLLABORATION WE FEEL VERY
CONFIDENT OPTIMISTIC AND EXCITED
ABOUT BEING ABLE TO- REALLY
TAKE. THE KINDS OF TRAINING THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT I'M IN
INNOVATIVE WAYS TO BUILD A NEW
HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE FOR THE
STATE. AND AS YOU KNOWN AS WE
WILL HEAR- INCOMING. ISSUE AREAS
FOR THIS. HEARING IT IS THE
DEPARTMENTS WITHIN THE- LABOR
AGENCY AND ALSO ON A PARALLEL
BASIS WITHIN HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES THAT WILL ACTUALLY BE.
DOING THE- DIRECT PROGRAM
ADMINISTER AND FUNDING. BUT THE
LEADERSHIP AND INITIATIVE WILL
BE TAKEN BY WHICH AGENCY
SPECIFICALLY IT WOULD IT BE A
COMBINED PARTNERSHIP AND
RESPONSIBILITY OLD OR WILL IT.
LANDYN ONE AGENCY SPECIFICALLY
AND I ASK ONLY IN TERMS OF WHEN
WE DO FOLLOW UP TESTS TO
MEASUREMENTS OF SUCCESS WHO
WOULD BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
OUTCOMES. THERE WILL BE THAT
YOU'RE GETTING TO THE REALLY
GREAT QUESTION ON EVALUATION AS
WELL- GOOD TO AGENCIES WILL BE
JOINTLY RESPONSIBLE FOR.
ADMINISTERING THE ADMINISTRATIVE
THE OVERALL INITIATIVES AS YOU
HAVE SEEN IN THE PROPOSAL THERE
ARE SPECIFIC PROGRAM COMPONENTS
THAT WILL BE ADMINISTERED BY THE
DEPARTMENTS UNDER THE LABOR
AGENCY AND SPECIFIC PROGRAM
COMPONENTS- THAT WILL BE
ADMINISTERED BY THE DEPARTMENT
UNDER C. H. H. S. WHAT WE'RE
ENVISIONING WOULD BE AN OVERALL
AN ISSUE THAT THE EVALUATION.
BUT BUT ALSO VERY SPECIFIC
PERFORMANCE EVALUATIONS FOR EACH
ONE OF THOSE OF PROGRAM
COMPONENTS. I'M SORRY I'M NOT ON
THE AGENDA ITEM BUT TO ANSWERED
JEOPARDY HAS QUESTIONED ITS-JOINTS WHEN YOU WANT RESULTS AND
WHEN YOU WANT TO HEAR ABOUT THE
OUTCOMES OF BOTH KELLY JACKSON
L. W. D. I. THANK YOU A JUSTICE
AS A FOLLOW UP TO THIS. EDT
ALREADY PROVIDES THE DATA
ANALYSIS INCLUDING LABOR MARKET
PROJECTIONS WHAT WILL BE THE
ROLE OF THIS NEW RESEARCH DATA
SPECIALIST. THE ROLE OF HIS
RESEARCH NATIONALIST WILL BE TO
TAKE. THOSE PROJECTIONS AND
REALLY CONDUCT FURTHER ANALYSIS
I MENTIONED EARLIER THAT WE GOT
THEM ON A REGIONAL BASIS- THAT
WILL REQUIRE EXTENSIVE ANALYSIS
AND WE ARE EAGER TO GET THIS
POSITION FILLED TO REALLY LOOK
BY REGION BY OCCUPATION TO
PINPOINT SOME OF THAT
DISPARITIES WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT TO PINPOINT OPPORTUNITIES
FOR TRAINING AND TRAINING
PARTNERSHIPS THAT IS ONE EXAMPLE
THERE IS ALSO EXTENSIVE RESEARCH
TO BE DONE. TO- LOOK AT BEST
PROGRAMS- DELIVERED ELSEWHERE
AROUND THE COUNTRY GARCIA
MENTIONED ARE EXCITING
ACCEPTANCE INTO THE NATIONAL
GOVERNORS ASSOCIATION
COLLABORATIVE BUT EVERY STATE IN
EVERY MUNICIPALITY IN THE
COUNTRY IS DEALING WITH- HEALTH
CARE WORKFORCE SHORTAGES AND WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE.
AWARE OF AND BORROWING FROM IN
REPLICATING SOME OF THE BEST
PRACTICES AROUND THE COUNTRY- I
CAN ASSURE YOU THIS PERSON WILL
BE VERY VERY BUSY THIS PERSONAL
ALSO BE WORKING ON A PROGRAM
DEVALUATION AND SUPPORTING THE
DEPARTMENTS WITHIN L. W. D. A.
ON AND- DEVELOPING THOSE
EVALUATIONS AND MEASURING
PERFORMANCE. EVERY STEP OF THE
WAY. DOES THE EDT ANALYSIS
CURRENTLY NOT TO A LARGE
PERCENTAGE OF THAT OR ANY
REGIONAL APPROACHES TO WHAT THIS
NEW RESEARCH AT A SPECIALIST
WOULD DO. THEY DO THE REGIONAL
BREAKDOWN AS I MENTIONED WE DID
RECEIVE THE OCCUPATIONAL.
PROJECTIONS BRKEN DOWN BY
FOURTEEN REGIONS AROUND THE
STATE- HOWEVER THERE IS
ADDITIONAL ANALYSIS NEEDED- TO
REALLY CONNECT THE SPECIFIC
OCCUPATIONS- THE SPECIFIC SETS
OF- JOB ADS- BY REGION. SO
THERE'S A AN ADDITIONAL LEVEL OF
ANALYSIS THAT WE ANTICIPATE THIS
PERSON TO DO. AND WILL THERE BE
COORDINATION BETWEEN WHAT EDT
ALREADY DOES AND WHAT THE REPORT
AND DATA ANALYSIS THAT THEY
ALREADY PROVIDE OUR LABOR MARKET
PROJECTIONS WITH THIS NEW
POSITION THAT SEEMS TO OVERLAP
IN RESPONSIBILITY. ABSOLUTELY WE
ENVISION THEM WORKING CLOSELY
TOGETHER AND- THIS POSITION WILL
FOCUS SOLELY ON THE HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE AND ENJOYMENT SERVICES
WORKFORCE. ENABLE I THINK
WORKING HAND IN HAND WITH L. L.
MY D. TO DO SOME OF THE DEEPER
DIVES AND LEVELS OF ANALYSIS
THAT WILL ENABLE US TO IMPLEMENT
THIS PROGRAM SUCCESSFULLY ALL
THESE PROGRAMS SUCCESSFULLY.
THANK YOU IF THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU TO OUR
ISSUE NUMBER THREE PANEL WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
FOUR. WITH REPRESENTATIVES OF
THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD TO PRESENT ON
THEIR HIGH ROAD TRAINING
PARTNERSHIP FOR HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES. WE WILL ALSO HAVE THE
REPRESENTATIVE OF THIS YEAH YOU
FOR THIS PANEL OUR PRESENTERS
ARE- THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR MISTER TIM RAINY. AT
MATT LYNCH WITH- GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS WITH US YEAH YOU
MISTER RANEY ARE YOU ON IF SO
YOU MAY BEGIN. I AM A TEACHER
CARILLO THANK YOU CHAIR ARAMBULA
ON TO BE HERE. AS PART OF THIS
BROADER INITIATIVE- THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD IS REQUESTING THREE
HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS OVER THREE YEARS FOR
HIGH ROAD. TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS
FOR HEALTH CARE. THIS IS
INDUSTRY SECTOR WORK- I WROTE IS
A UNIQUE APPROACH TO WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT IT'S VERY INDUSTRY
DRIVEN. WE START WITH EMPLOYERS
A LOT OF- OF COORDINATION AND
DEVELOPMENT WITH EMPLOYERS IN
ORGANIZED LABOR- OFTEN- WITH A
COMMITMENT TO EQUITY JOB QUALITY
CLIMATE RESILIENCY IS THAT AS
THE END GAME- THE UNDERPAINTING-
NOTION IS YOU CAN'T ACHIEVE
EQUITY WITHOUT. PAYING A LOT OF
JOB QUALITY- THE PROJECTS THAT
WE THAT WE INVEST IN AND DEVELOP
. IMPLEMENT ARE- THEY CREATE THE
CONDITIONS THROUGH THESE KINDS
OF SECTOR BASED PARTNERSHIPS
EMPLOYER PARTNERSHIPS FOR MOVING
WORKERS. FROM DISADVANTAGED
GROUPS AND POPULATIONS INTO GOOD
QUALITY JOB TO ME TO FIND. OUT
WHAT IT GOOD QUALITY JOB MEANS
HIRING PLAYER- MEANS- OFTEN THIS
WORK INCLUDES UPSKILLING CURRENT
WORKERS. A LOT OF DEVELOPMENT
COORDINATION AMONG LABOR
MANAGEMENT TO GET THAT DONE AND
WORKERS AT THE TABLE OR HER
VOICE IS VERY IMPORTANT TO THIS-
AND THEN ALIGNING WITH SCHOOLS
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WORKFORCE
BOARDS. COMMITTEE BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TO CREATE PATHWAYS
INTO THOSE GOOD JOBS- OFTEN AT
THE ENTRY LEVEL- SOMETHING WE
CALL UPSKILLING BACKFILL VERY
WONKY- CONCEPT- THESE ARE NOT
ONE AND DONE INVESTMENTS THE
INTENTION IS TO ESTABLISH LONG
TERM INDUSTRY PARTNERSHIPS THAT
ARE SUSTAINED- WITH THE
INTENTION. OF CHANGING THE WAY
WHOLE INDUSTRIES ARE RECRUIT
TRAIN PROMOTE AND RETAIN TALENT
AND DEVELOP REGIONAL TALENT- SO
IT'S REALLY AND AN EFFORT TO
CHANGE SYSTEMS AND TO IMPACT
LABOR MARKETS FOR THE ENDGAME OF
INCREASING EQUITY ECONOMIC
EQUITY ACROSS THE STATE IN
REGIONS ACROSS THE STATE- THE
PARTNERSHIPS INCLUDE. EMPLOYERS
OF COURSE HEALTHCARE EMPLOYERS
IN THIS CASE ORGANIZED LABOR
WORKFORCE BOARDS. SCHOOLS
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS.
ESPECIALLY THE CBO'S AS DEPUTY
SECRETARY SNAPE POINTED OUT THAT
WORK CLOSELY WITH THE COMMUNITY
THAT WORK THAT WE AIM TO IMPACT.
THE HEALTH CARE HIGH ROAD BUT
INITIATIVE WILL TARGET
OCCUPATIONS THAT DON'T REQUIRE
FOUR YEAR DEGREES OUT LARGELY
ALLIED HEALTH- EVERYTHING EXCEPT
DOCTORS NURSES MEDICAL
ASSISTANTS RESPIRATORY
TECHNICIANS SURGICAL TECHNICIANS
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS MEDICAL
RECORDS. TECHNICIAN SIX IT'S
ADDRESS WE PLAN TO TRAIN WITH
THIS INVESTMENT OVER THREE YEARS
UP AROUND TWENTY TWO THOUSAND
WORKERS- IT THROUGH JUST THIS
HIGH ROAD PIECE YOU'LL HEAR
ABOUT OTHER- ESTIMATES OF TRAINS
WERE TRYING TO GET SCALE-
THROUGH THIS COLLABORATION. WITH
HEALTH HUMAN SERVICES BUT ALSO
ACROSS THE WORKFORCE AND TO
TEACH. SO FOR OUR PART THAT
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE BOARD IS-
ESTIMATING THAT WILL TRAIN
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND WORKERS ITH
THESE INVESTMENTS. AND I THINK
AT AS THE DEPUTY SECRETARY ALSO
POINTED OUT THE TEN YEAR
PROJECTIONS ON GROWTH IN THE
SECTOR AND I KNOW THE-
IMPLEMENTED. OPEN DEPARTMENT IS
UPDATING THIS DATA BUT THE
CURRENT PROJECTIONS WE HAVE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN IT'S TWENTY A-
CHAU TO MILLION. HEALTH
OCCUPATIONS OPEN OR JOBS OPEN-
SO WE'RE JUST. I HATE SAYS GIVEN
THE SERVICE THERE'S A LOT MORE
TO BE DONE- WITH THESE-
INVESTMENTS ARE VERY IMPORTANT
TO GET AT SOME OF THE GAPS AND
SHORTAGES AND HEALTH CARE ACROSS
THE STATE- I'LL LEAVE IT THERE.
AND I'M SURE. THANK YOU- MR
LET'S SHARE LEAD JUMPS I'M SO
SORRY IF I'M MISPRONOUNCING YOUR
LAST NAME. NO TOTALLY FINE- MATT
WAS A WITH S. YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIA- THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR HAVING TODAY REALLY HAPPY TO
BE SPEAKING ABOUT- THIS PROPOSAL
ON THE HIGH ROAD TRAINING
PARTNERSHIPS- AND WOULD LIKE TO.
THINK THAT CHAIRS THAT COMMITTEE
AND STAFF. FOR HOLDING THIS
HEARING ON THE CARE ECONOMY
WORKFORCE WHICH IS SUCH AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE AS WE- ARE
CONTINUING TO BATTLE WITH THE
PANDEMIC BUT THEN OF COURSE-
PLANNING OUR WAY OUT OF IT AS
WELL. TO ADDRESS THE CARE NEEDS
OF CALIFORNIA- EYES- MY CO
PANELISTS JUST MENTIONED- THE
COVE IN NINETEEN PANDEMIC IS
REALLY- SORT OF HIGHLIGHTED SOME
OF THE GAPS THAT WE'VE HAD EVEN
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC. IN TERMS OF
A SEVERE GALA PARTICULARLY WITH
ALLIED HEALTH PROFESSIONALS- OF
YOUR CLOSE TO FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND WORKERS. ON
CALIFORNIA'S FACING THAT
SHORTAGE BY TWENTY TWENTY FOUR-
THE SHORTAGES IS ALLIED HEALTH
WORKERS NURSES PROVIDERS IN THE
IMPACT THE MORE THAN SEVEN
MILLION CALIFORNIANS MANY
LATINOS AFRICAN AMERICANS AND
NATIVE AMERICANS. WERE LIVING IN
AN AREA EXPERIENCING HEALTH
PROVIDER SHORTAGE. THESE ARE
GAPS ARE PARTICULARLY FELT
GEOGRAPHICALLY WITHIN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND INLAND EMPIRE
WHERE THERE'S A SHORTAGE OF
EXPERIENCED NURSES AND OTHER
PROFESSIONALS. AND WE'RE
RECEIVED HUNDREDS OF VACANCIES
RIGHT NOW- OUT OUR EMPLOYERS FOR
POSITIONS LIKE MEDICAL
ASSISTANCE AND LICENSE
OCCASIONAL NURSES. REALLY ACROSS
THE CARE SPECTRUM- MANY
POSITIONS ARE OPEN. THE
HEALTHCARE SHORTAGES ARE HEAT TO
COMMUNITIES BOTH IN TERMS OF
THAT- JOB QUALITY AVAILABLE
BECAUSE HEALTHCARE JOBS ARE
OFTEN GOOD PAYING JOBS ALTHOUGH
YOU KNOW THERE IS SOME
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN PROVIDER
TYPES. AND ALSO ON THE
COMMUNITIES ABILITY TO ACCESS
CARE. WALL WE ARE IN A SHORTAGE
LONG BEFORE THE PANDEMIC WE
HAVEN'T HAD A PANDEMIC OF THIS
MAGNITUDE BEFORE IN IS REALLY
UNCLEAR- THE IMPACT THAT THIS
WILL HAVE ON THE WORK FORCE AND
HOW IT WILL COVER- IT LIKELY
WILL NOT BE THE SAME WAY AS IT
IS- WE'RE COVERED IN THE PAST-
THE WHOLE TRAINING PRE MODEL I
THINK IS ONE THAT'S GOING TO BE
REALLY PUT TO THE TEST AS WE-
ARE CLIMB OURSELVES OUT OF THE
PANDEMIC. EVEN IF THE GROWTH THE
STATE WIDE EYED THE GROWTH OF-
JOB TRAINING POSITIONS ARE. GROW
STATEWIDE TO MEET THE PROJECTED-
SHORTAGES THERE'S STILL AMOUNT
DISTRIBUTION OF HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE- WHICH IS STUBBORNLY
PERSISTENT IN COMMUNITIES THAT
WERE UNDER SERVED AD UNDER
INVESTED. THIS UNDER INVESTMENT
PARTICULARLY IN THE MEDICAL
PROGRAM FOR PROVIDERS THAT
PRIMARILY SERVE THESE
POPULATIONS HAVE LED TO IN IT
ANY INEQUITIES IN GAPS IN THE
WORKFORCE- BY PROVIDING.
PROVIDER TYPE SUCH AS AFTER WE
SEE CLINICS. LEADING TO HIGH
TURNOVER IN AREAS WHERE THERE IS
SUFFICIENT IN SUFFICIENT SUPPLY
BECAUSE OF. THAT WELL RESOURCE
PROVIDERS THEY'RE STILL ABLE TO
SORT OF PULL FROM THOSE WITHOUT
THE SAME RESOURCES. UNDER
INVESTMENT COUPLED WITH STRESS
AND TOLD A PANDEMIC IS TAKE IN A
WELL DOCUMENTED IMPACT ON
HEALTHCARE WORKERS WITH THE
ESTIMATED ONE IN FIVE HEALTHCARE
WORKERS. CONSIDERING LEAVING THE
INDUSTRY. YOU MUST DO MORE TO
RETAIN OUR CURRENT WORKERS BY
RAISING THEIR WAGES AND PROVIDE
CAREER LADDER OPPORTUNITIES. H.
R. T. P. IN PARTICULAR IS A
PROVEN MODEL FOR ADDRESSING THE
HEALTH CARE INDUSTRY WORKFORCE-
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN R. EIGHT
IN TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE- 70%
OF SEIU PARTICIPANTS IN H. R. P.
P. PROGRAMS ARE WOMEN. 70% ARE
UP PEOPLE OF COLOR AND ROUGHLY
25% OR INTERESTS. GRADUATES MOVE
THROUGH THESE PROGRAMS AND INTO
NEW JOBS- SEE AN AVERAGE OF- WE
NEED TO INCREASE OF 45% IN
HEALTH CARE IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT ONLY ABOUT 10% OF ENTRY
LEVEL CLINICAL ROLES. HAVE ANY
KIND OF- JOBURG THREE LADDER AND
OCCUPATION SEGREGATION IS
COMMON. H. R. T. T. R. LEXUS
WORK DIRECTLY IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH EMPLOYERS AND FRONTLINE
WORKERS REMOVE BARRIERS TO
IMPACT INVESTING IN VANCE MET
AND DESIGN PROGRAMS OF WORKERS
AT THE CENTER. LEADING TO HIGH
DEMAND FOR HIGHER WAGE POSITIONS
IN THE INDUSTRY WE NEED AN
INDUSTRY DEMAND A WIN FOR
WORKERS IN A WIN FOR EMPLOYERS.
THIS ISVITAL BECAUSE MANY OF
THESE HEALTH CARE WORKERS
ESPECIALLY WOMEN PEOPLE OF COLOR
IMMIGRANTS ENTER THE FIELD IN
ANY WAY THEY CAN. THEY'RE OFTEN
OVER REPRESENTED IN ENTRY LEVEL
NONCLINICAL ROLES. THESE ARE
SOME OF THOSE THE SAME GROUPS
ARE OVER REPRESENTED IN PRIVATE
FOR PROFIT TRAINING INSTITUTIONS
THAT MAKE UP SIXTY EIGHTY
PERCENT. OF TRAINING FOR OUR
HEALTH CARE ROLES IN 50% OF
NURSING SCHOOL POSITIONS. BUT
OFTEN THESE FAIL ARE NOT ALWAYS
BUT OFTEN FAIL TO PROVIDE
AFFORDABLE HIGH QUALITY
EDUCATION THAT LEADS TO A- HIGH
QUALITY JOB- THESE PROGRAMS SUCH
AS- THE ETP PROGRAM WHICH WILL
BE HEARD LATER TODAY AND ALSO
THE H. R. T. PEOPLE ROOM ARE SO
IMPORTANT TO BOTH THE UPWARD
MOBILITY OF WORKERS BUT ALSO
ADDRESS THE DIVERSITY OF THE
WORKFORCE BECAUSE THEY DO CREEK
DECKER LADDER. THROUGH FUNDING
FOR THESE PROGRAMS WE HAVE
DEVELOPED PROGRAM INNOVATIONS
THAT SERVE OUR MEMBERS AND
INCLUDES- INCLUDING COMPETENCY
BASED REGISTERED APPRENTICESHIPS
THAT ADDRESS THE CRITICAL NOR
NEED FOR EARNING LEARN DURING
CLINICAL AND X. IN EXTENDED ON
THE JOB TRAINING EXPERIENCES. WE
PARTNER WITH EDUCATIONAL
PROVIDERS THAT PROVIDE
FLEXIBILITY AND JUST THE
TRAINING CONTENT TO MEET THE
NEEDS AND THE SCHEDULE OF
WORKING ADULTS THAT THEY CAN
SUPPORT THE FAMILY WHILE
PURSUING GRANDPARENTS SPENT.
PROGRAMS LIKE ET P. AND H. R. T.
P. LAY THE FOUNDATION FOR
INDUSTRY PARTNERSHIP TO CREATE
BETTER PARKWAY- IN OUR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT SYSTEM ONE JUST VERY
QUICK EXAMPLE IS THAT THROUGH H.
R. T. P. P. FINDING WE HAVE
CREATED A PRE APPRENTICESHIP
MODEL. TO CREATE A PIPELINE FROM
NON INCUMBENT COMMUNITY MEMBERS
TO ON CALL NONCLINICAL WORKERS
TO FULLY BENEFIT NONCLINICAL
WORKERS THE CERTIFIED NURSE
ASSISTANT APPRENTICES. AND WE
ARE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
TO DEVELOP BETTER FRIENDSHIP
PROGRAM AND CONTINUE TO DEVELOP
MORE CAREER LADDERS. THROUGH I
THOUGHT THIS ADDITIONAL FUNDING
IF APPROVED. I THANK YOU FOR THE
TIME AND HAPPY ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS BUT JUST REALLY WANT
TO STRESS THE IMPORTANCE OF
CREATING A CAREER LADDER WITHIN
THE HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE DOUBLE
DIVERSIFY. AND LIFT UP OUR
HEALTH CARE WORKERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THAT- ARE THERE
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. FIVE HUNDRED UP IN
THE PUBLIC FINANCE NO-NOTHING
FURTHER TO ADD AT THIS TIME I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THE L. A. L. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR HI COREY HISTORY- WITH THE
L. A. L. WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
COMMENTS TO RAISE ON THIS THIS
ISSUE AT THIS TIME. Q. I DO WANT
TO OPEN IT UP TO THE MEMBERS OF
THE DÍAS SIDE I DO HAVE ONE.
QUESTION TO KICK US OFF- THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD IS CURRENTLY IMPLEMENTING
VERY SIMILAR STRATEGIES AS- AS
WE'VE- HEARD TODAY SUCH AS THE
HIGH ROAD TRAINING PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE HIGH ROAD CONSTRUCTION
CAREERS. DOES THE C. W. D. B.
EXPECT THE ROLLOUT OF THIS
INITIATIVE TO BE SIMILAR. AND
CAN THE C. W. D. B. EXPLAIN HOW
CURRENT HIGHROAD INITIATIVES ARE
BEING IMPLEMENTED NOW. I THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- YES IT WILL BE
ROLLED OUT IN A VERY SIMILAR
FASHION WE HAVE A AN APPROACH TO
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT WE CALL
HIRING TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS
THAT HAS. ALL THE SAME ELEMENTS
REGARDLESS OF THE SECTOR THAT WE
THAT WE- WE FOCUS ON- AS YOU
KNOW WE HAVE HIGHER TRAINING
PARTNERSHIPS IN A VARIETY OF
SECTORS. SUCH AS HEALTHCARE-
INCLUDING CONSTRUCTION.
CONSTRUCTION TRADES IS A
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT- SO THE
APPROACH IS THE SAME. ENGAGING
EMPLOYERS IMPINGING INDUSTRY ARE
DOING A LOT OF DEVELOPMENT WORK
UP FOR THAT WITH WITH INDUSTRY
EMPLOYERS WORKING AS FAST AS WE
CAN BECAUSE WE WANT TO GET TO
PROGRAM IMPLEMENTATION AS FAST
AS WE CAN. GET OUR END GAME IS
TO TRAIN. OUR TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND PEOPLE ARE IN QUALITY
TRAINING AND TO GET QUALITY
JOBS- SO I THINK THAT THE
DIFFERENCE HERE. IS THE URGENCY
AROUND HEALTHCARE AND FEELING IN
ADDRESSING SOME OF THE GAPS
AROUND CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY IN
THE IN THE PARTS OF THE STATE-
SO THE DEVELOPMENT. SIDE I THINK
IT'S GONNA MOVE FASTER THAN WE
HAVE IN THE PAST IN OTHER
SECTORS- THE GOOD NEWS ABOUT
HEALTHCARE THERE ARE ALREADY
REALLY STRONG- PARTNERSHIPS WHEN
AND- AMONG EMPLOYERS. AS MATT
WAS LAYING OUT ESPECIALLY WITH
THE EMPLOYERS THAT ARE
SIGNATORIES TO. BUDGET YOU H. W.
S. U. S. W. BOB SO WE CAN BUILD
ON THOSE PARTNERSHIPS SCALE
THOSE UP AND TAKE THE MODEL WHEN
APPLIED TO A LOT OF OTHER HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS AROUND THE STATE.
SO IT WE'RE VERY EXCITED ABOUT
THIS. THANK YOU FOR THAT AND
WHAT WILL BE THE METRICS OF THAT
WILL BE USED TO DETERMINE THE
SUCCESS OF THE PROPOSED
INVESTMENTS FOR EXAMPLE WILL.
TIME TO HIGHER WAGES CAREER
ADVANCEMENT BE CONSIDERED. YEAH
ALL THE ABOVE WE HAVE A- ARE YOU
WISHING THAT WE ESTABLISHED A
FRAMEWORK WITH UCLA WITH THE
LABOR CENTER THERE- THAT WERE
APPLYING TO ALL OF OUR HIRING
TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS
INVESTMENTS- IT'S A MIXED
METHODOLOGY SO IT INCLUDES BOTH
QUANTITATIVE AND QUALITATIVE
ELEMENTS SO WE WE'RE GONNA BE
LOOKING AT. EMPLOYMENT POST
SECONDARY EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT
OF THE PARTICIPANTS SKILLS GAINS
WAGE GAME- THE DEMOGRAPHIC DATA
WORK WE'RE LOOKING AT WE'VE GOT
TARGETS UP FOR OUR POPULATIONS
THAT HAVE SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS
TO EMPLOYMENT SO WE WANT TO
UNDERSTAND THE DEMOGRAPHIC THAT
MAKE PEOPLE'S AS MATT ACTUALLY
POINTED OUT- THAT SUV STRUCK IN
THE VERY CLOSELY. RACES
ETHNICITY GENDER AGE LOW INCOME
STATUS- A FORMERLY INCARCERATED
TO IS A BIG FOCUS OF OURS
JUSTICE INVOLVED STATUS VETERANS
BY ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS-
AND I'M JUST ONE MORE THING THE
QUALITATIVE. THERE IS- A
RECRUIT- HIGHER UP SKILL- RETAIN
TALENT REGIONALLY SO WE HAVE IN
OUR FRAMEWORK ELEMENTS THAT
INCLUDE- ARE WE IMPACTING
ECONOMIC EQUITY AND MOBILITY ARE
WE BUILDINGS- WORKER VOICE AND
POWER- WHAT IS THE IMPACT ON
QUALITY JOBS- IMPROVING JOB
QUALITY- ARE WE BUILDING
SUSTAINED INDUSTRY PARTNERSHIPS
IMPROVING LABOR MANAGEMENT CORP
OPERATION IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
OUR PROJECTS- ARE WE GETTING CO
INVESTMENT- FOR SCALE AND
SUSTAINABILITY FROM THE EMPLOYER
SO IT'S ACTIVE TO THE- THE
GOVERNMENT'S MONEY COMING IN.
AND INVESTING THROUGH GRANTS AND
THEN WHEN THE GRANT THAT FUNDS
ARE GONE THE PROGRAM WORK GOES
WAY ARE INTENTION IS THAT
SUSTAINABILITY THAT MEANS
EMPLOYERS INVESTING FOR THE LONG
TERM SO WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
THESE BOTH A QUANTITATIVE AND
QUALITATIVE MEASURES. WITH UCLA
. THANK YOU MISTER AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I'M GONNA STICK WITH
TIM RAINY IF I CAN ON PAGE
TWENTY FOUR WITHIN THE AGENDA IT
IT STATES THAT SIMILAR TO OTHER
C. W. D. B. EFFORTS FUNDING
WOULD BE AWARDED THROUGH
REGIONAL GRANTS I WAS HOPING YOU
COULD EXTRAPOLATE ON WHERE IS
THIS HAPPENING CURRENTLY WITHIN-
THE LOCAL THE C. W. D. B. AS
WELL AS IS THIS TYPICALLY AN
EQUITABLE GEOGRAPHIC
DISTRIBUTION OF FUNDING AS WE
HEARD FROM MATT ABOUT HOW WE
CURRENTLY HAVE A MAIL
DISTRIBUTION OF HEALTHCARE
RESOURCES. HOPING YOU CAN
COMMENT ON THAT. YES WE ARE
GOING TO INVEST IN INDUSTRY
BASED PARTNERSHIPS- BUT WE DO
PAY A LOT OF ATTENTION TO- TO
GEOGRAPHY- AND WE'RE REALLY
INTENTIONAL ABOUT ENSURING. THAT
WE GET GRANTFUNDING TO THE
INLAND PARTS OF THE STATE AND
THAT'S BEEN HISTORICALLY WHAT
WE'VE DONE NOT JUST WITH HIGHER
TRAINING PARTNERSHIP WORKING
HIRING CONSTRUCTION WORKERS IN
FACT HIGHER CONSTRUCTION
INCREASES AT EVERY CORNER OF
CALIFORNIA- SO IT'S A- IT'S A
PRIORITY OF OURS AND IT'LL BE A
PRIORITY. IN THIS FUNDING IF
WE'RE ABLE TO DO IT IF
EVERYTHING WORKS OUT- WILL BE
SURE THAT WE HAVE ADEQUATE
PROGRAM FUNDING IN THE IN THAT
PART OF THE STATE. THANK YOU FOR
THAT- I WANT TO UPLIFT- MAPS
COMMENTS ABOUT 25% OF IMMIGRANTS
IN OUR CARE. KANEMI RIGHT NOW
AS- I BELIEVE IT'S IMPORTANT TO
CALL OUT THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
ESSENTIAL IN OF CARED FOR US
DURING THIS PANDEMIC. AND I'M
GRATEFUL FOR WHERE THE
GOVERNOR'S LEADERSHIP IS GOING.
BUT I'D LIKE TO THEN BE ABLE TO
TURN AND ASK WHETHER OR NOT- WE
HAVE A PREFERENCE FOR LINGUISTIC
SKILLS. IS THERE ARE OUTREACH
STRATEGIES WERE USING TO ENSURE
A BROAD DIVERSITY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. HOW DO WE ENSURE
THAT THE HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE OF
TOMORROW IS ABLE TO. COMMUNICATE
AND ESTABLISH THAT TRUST. YEAH
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION AND I'M
GOING TO. REPEAT A LITTLE BIT OF
WHAT- DEPUTY SECRETARY STATE
POINTED OUT A LOT OF. THE WORK
ALL OF THE TRAINING PARTNERSHIP
THAT WE'RE DEVELOPING WITH
INDUSTRY AND ORGANIZED LABOR
INCLUDING THE BASE
ORGANIZATIONS. THAT HAVE THE
ABILITY TO REACHING THE
COMMISSION PULL PEOPLE INTO
THESE GREAT TRAINING PROGRAMS SO
IT'S A VERY ESSENTIAL PIECE OF
HOW WE DESIGN OF THE PROJECT HOW
WE DIVIDE THE DESIGN THE
INITIATIVE AND WHAT WE ACTUALLY
FIND. SO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO POINT OUT THAT. WE'RE NOT
JUST ASKING COMMUNITIES
ORGANIZATIONS TO USE THEIR
CURRENT CAPACITY TO HELP US. IN
THESE INVESTMENTS IN THESE
PARTNERSHIPS WE ARE REQUIRED
THAT EACH OF THE PARTNERS IN THE
PARTNERSHIP- BUILT INTO THE-
BUDGET HOW MUCH FUNDING THEY'RE
GONNA GET AS PART OF INITIATIVE
AND IT'S TIED TO THE ACTIVITIES
THAT THAT PARTNER WILL WILL
PROVIDE SO THAT WE'RE SURE. THAT
COMMUNITIES ORGANIZATIONS ARE
BUILT IN WITH CAPACITY FUNDING
TO DO THE WORK THAT WE HOPE
THEY'LL DO WHICH IS REACHING OUT
TO HOSE COMMUNITIES THAT THAT
MOST NEED. THAT MOST NEED
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BACK TO YOU MADAM CHAIR. THANK
YOU IF THERE ARE NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
FIVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO THE
PANELISTS. OF ISSUE NUMBER FOUR
. WE ARE TRANSITIONING TO
REPRESENTATIVES FOR THE
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL OUR
PRESENTERS WILL BE CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF. A AND A HIGH ME
WITH THE ADDRESS AS WELL AS- THE
L. A. O. AND B. YES WELL LET'S
BEGIN MISTER WITH THE ADDRESS
ARE YOU ONE. YES I AM THANK YOU-
CHAIR CARDIO AND- CHAIR. I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY- A YEAR AS PART OF
OUR CORE FUNDING BE EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING PANEL OR- DEVELOPS AND
FUNDS APPROXIMATELY THREE
THOUSAND BUSINESSES AND OVER
EIGHTY THOUSAND INCUMBENT AND
NEWLY HIRED WORKERS PRIMARILY
AND- CERTAIN AREAS OF
MANUFACTURING. A GOVERNMENT
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
CONSTRUCTION TRADES AND OTHER
CRITICAL INDUSTRIES HOWEVER ONE
OF THE INDUSTRIES THAT I WE
DON'T CURRENTLY FOCUS ON IS THE
HEALTHCARE INDUSTRY- SO AS YOU
KNOW ETP DIFFERS FROM OTHER
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT TRAININGS
AS WE PLACE EMPHASIS ON EMPLOYER
DRIVEN JOB WORKFORCE TRAINING-
BY THE END OF THIS MONTH- THE
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL WILL
HAVE DISTRIBUTED. APPROXIMATELY
EIGHTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN
GENERAL FUND MONEY FROM THIS
YEAR THAT WILL HAVE GONE OUT AND
WE'VE SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENTED
OUT SO THAT IS ON TOP OF OUR
CORE FUNDING SO TO THE POINT OF
OUR INITIATIVE- EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING PANEL IS REQUESTING.
YOUR SUPPORT IN DEVELOPING AND
JOB CREATING IN AREAS A BACK OR
ADVANCEMENT IN ENTRY LEVEL FOR
WORKERS IN HEALTH CARE. HUMAN
SERVICES STANDINGS AND SOCIAL
WORK SETTINGS. THE FUNDING WILL
GO DIRECTLY TO EMPLOYERS TO
PROVIDE THEIR OWN TRAINING AS
WELL AS TO ORGANIZED LABOR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
TRADE ASSOCIATIONS THAT PROVIDE
TRAINING TO WORKERS. IN MULTIPLE
EMPLOYER SETTINGS. THE ALL.
PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
DEMONSTRATE WAGE INCREASES AS
WELL AS A COMPLETION AND IN
ORDER TO RECEIVE THE FUNDS I'M
AS PART OF THAT EFFORT- AS
PREVIOUSLY STATED- V. CORE
INDUSTRY HERE SUCH AS
MANUFACTURING CONSTRUCTION IS
THE AREA THAT YOU CAN NORMALLY
HIGHLIGHTS THE HEALTH CARE AND
HUMAN SERVICES INDUSTRY
PROVIDERS ARE UNFORTUNATELY NOT
THE AREA THAT WE NORMALLY
PROVIDE FUNDING TO. BARBER
THROUGH THIS INITIATIVE I WE
WILL BE ABLE TO APPLY I DON'
THINK WE'LL BE ABLE TO APPLY FOR
THE FUNDS TO BUILD THE SKILLS OF
THEIR WORKFORCE SUPPORT CAREER
ADVANCEMENT INTO MORE HIGHLY
SKILLED AND COMPENSATED ROLES-
TO THAT END ONE OTHER COMPONENT
THAT I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT IS
THAT ACT AS PART OF OUR- ETP'S
NORMAL PROCESSES AND I HAVE THE
ABILITY FOR US TO QUICKLY GET
FUNDS OUT AND WE HAVE IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD. HAVE DEVELOPED INTO A
GRANT APPLICATION PROCESS THAT
IS AUTOMATED AND STREAMLINED IN
ORDER TO EXPEDITE THE ABILITY OF
GETTING THE FUNDS OUT SO WITH
THAT HI MADAM CHAIR I THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
THIS BRIEF PRIVACY PRESENTATION-
AND I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
INTRODUCE MY COLLEAGUE PETER
COOPER. WHO IS HERE. TO HELP
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MAY HAVE. THANK YOU- MISTER
MACHINERY ON THE LINE. YES THANK
YOU THANK YOU MANAGER- COURT
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- JUST WANT TO MENTION
THAT- LAST WEEK WE DID PUBLISH
OUR ANALYSIS OF THE GOVERNORS
CARE ECONOMY WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PACKAGE- WE PLAN TO
RAISE FURTHER COMMENTS ON THE
PROPOSED ASHY PACKAGE IN ISSUE
SEVEN WHEN WE DISCUSS THE- THE
MAJOR H. CHI BCTV- BUT WE DO
HAVE JUST A FEW COMMENTSON THE
PACKAGES SPECIFIC PROPOSAL FOR
ETP TO RAISE- YOU KNOW AS
MENTIONED EARLIER LIKE ETP
PROVIDES GRANTS TO. BUSINESSES
TO TRAIN EXISTING WORKERS- BUT
DOES NOT- TYPICALLY FOCUS ON
HEALTH CARE JOBS OR DIRECTLY
ENCOURAGE BUSINESSES TO HIRE NEW
WORKERS OR DO SO IN A WAY THAT
DIVERSIFIES THEIR WORK FORCE
WHICH ARE TWO OF THE OVER
ARCHING GOALS OF THAT. PROPOSED
CARE CONNIE PACK PACKAGE- YOU
KNOW THIS PROPOSAL WOULD ALSO-
ALMOST DOUBLE THE GRANT FUNDING
MADE BY ETP IN RECENT YEARS. AND
THE PROGRAM ALSO ALREADY
RECEIVED A ONE TIME INCREASE OF
SIXTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN TO
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
BUDGET- WE FIND THAT WE HAVE
SUCH A LARGE INCREASE- COULD%
PROVE CHALLENGING FOR THE ATP TO
ADMINISTER- GIVEN THESE
CONSIDERATIONS YOU SHOULD THE
LEGISLATURE WISH TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH THE GOVERNORS- WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PACKAGE WE WOULD
RECOMMEND IT CONSIDER WHETHER A
SMALLER GRANT INCREASE AT ATP
IS. WARRANTED AND IF SO WHETHER
THOSE FREED UP FUNDS SHOULD GO
TOWARDS OTHER WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PURPOSES- THOSE ARE
ALL OUR COMMENTS AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU. A ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. YOU CARE BETTER TOP AND
APARTMENT OF FINANCE- THE MOVE
FOR THE ADD ON THAT WE WOULD
JUST KNOW THAT WHILE THAT
DOESN'T INCREASE IT DOES PROVIDE
IT DOES TRAINING PROVIDE UPWARD
MOBILITY AND ALLOW NEW EMPLOYEES
TO GAIN EMPLOYMENT AS PART OF
THIS LARGER. HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES PACKAGE SO ON THE FOR
YOU TO MY COLLEAGUES FOR AN
ADDITIONAL POINTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT'S THE BEGINNING
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS FROM
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE DICE ALL
BEGIN WITH JUST A COUPLE. HOW
WITH THE E. T. T. P. PROGRAM
DIFFERENT FROM THE C. W. D. B.
PROGRAM. SO I DON'T START BY
ANSWERING THAT THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION. CORREO SO AS AS
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED- WE REALLY
FOCUS ON THE INCUMBENT WORKERS
MEANING THAT WE FOCUS ON THE
FOLKS THAT ARE ALREADY ON THE
GROUND WORKING WITH THESE
EMPLOYERS. AND OUR GOAL AND
OBJECTIVE IS TO UPSKILL THOSE
INDIVIDUALS. AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE
I THINK THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
OUR PROGRAM AND I'LL LET-
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR. I RAINY
ALSO. CHIME IN IF YOU'D LIKE TO
DO SO BUT THE DIFFERENCE IS ON
OUR END WE'RE WALKING GAUGING
DIRECTLY WITH A LOT OF THE
INCUMBENT WORKERS ON THEIR AND
THEIR- HIRING YOU. AND
INDIVIDUALS INTO- INTO THEIR
PROGRAMS. TO CHECK. OUT I'M
GONNA- START MADAM CHAIR IF I
CAN CONTINUING TO BEAT THE DRUM
I'VE BEEN BEATING MOST OF TODAY.
WHICH IS HOW WILL THIS PROGRAM
SPECIFICALLY IDENTIFY AND
SUPPORT REGIONS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY EXPERIENCING
HEALTHCARE SHORTAGES HOPING YOU
CAN COMMENT ON THAT. YES YEAH
THANK YOU AND IT CHAIR ARAMBULA-
WE ACTUALLY HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO OUR PANEL TO DIVERSE APPLYING
THE AREAS IN WHICH WE PROVIDE
FUNDING- THANKFULLY BECAUSE OF-
THE STRUCTURE THAT WE HAVE IN
PLACE AND THE WAY OUR PANEL
PROVIDES. THE FUNDING THROUGH
THE APPLICATION PROCESS WERE
ABLE TO TAKE GEOGRAPHIC AREAS
INTO CONSIDERATION AND WE HAVE
DONE THAT IN THE PAST WE WILL
CONTINUE TO DO THAT TO MAKE SURE
THAT. THOSE PARTICULAR AREAS ARE
READY I'M PROVIDED WITH A FOCUS. AS WELL WHICH IS PART OF THE
INTENT HERE. HOPING YOU COULD-
FOLLOW UP ON WHAT THE L. A. O.
HAD COMMENTED ON. AND WHEN I'M
GOING THROUGH I'M NOTICING
SIGNIFICANT WORKFORCE AREAS IN
SKILLED NURSING AND SOCIAL WORK
AND- COMMUNITY OUTREACH SCHOOL
BASED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH EARLY
LEARNING AND CARE AND
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES. THAT I'D
LIKE TO UNDERSTAND WHETHER OR
NOT YOU. THINK THIS NEEDS TO BE
EXPANDED WHETHER THIS IS
SUFFICIENT TO WORK COMMENTS ON
THE L. A- REGARDING. IT NEEDING
TO BE SMALLER HOPING THE
DEPARTMENT CAN PROVIDE SOME
INSIGHT. SO FROM A AND B.
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL
PERSPECTIVE. WE BELIEVE THE
REQUEST OF NINETY NINE THIS IS
ADEQUATE ON OUR END- AS
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED WE DON'T
HAVE A LOT OF EMPHASIS IN THE
HEALTHCARE INDUSTRY RIGHT NOW
THERE'S A LITTLE BIT ON OUR END
BUT NOT A LOT. THE INTENT OF
THIS PARTICULAR INITIATIVE AND
THIS FIND WOULD BE TO REALLY
FOCUS IN THAT AREA AND IN ALL
ASPECTS. OF THE HEALTH CARE
INDUSTRY AS A SAID THE AG IT IT
VARIES DEPENDING ON ANYWHERE
FROM. WELLNESS EDUCATION AND-
MERGING SEE SERVICE AS-
OUTPATIENT SERVICES ALL OF THOSE
PARTICULAR AREAS SO THOSE ARE A
LOT OF THE AREAS THAT WE DON'T
TO ATP DOES NOT AFFORD
UNFORTUNATELY DOES NOT PROVIDE A
LOT OF SERVICES AND RIGHT NOW.
BUT WE WOULD LIKE TO MAKE SURE-THAT WE DO EMPHASIZE THAT AREA
CONSIDERING THE NEED. BUT LET ME
CHECK ON THAT NEED AS THE CHAIR
SUB ONE WHO OFTEN. WILL HEAR
FROM MANY OF THESE INDUSTRIES
ABOUT THE NEEDS FOR US TO MAKE
INVESTMENTS AND WORKFORCE AND
THEN TURN THE QUESTION AROUND
AND IF. IF THIS IS A SUFFICIENT
AMOUNT OF FUNDING HOW DID WE
COME TO THE- ESTIMATION THAT
THIS WAS THE BEST NUMBER FOR US
TO CHOOSE HOW DID WE- PICK
NINETY MILLION DOLLARS. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION I AM SO
ESSENTIALLY WHAT WE LOOKED AT IN
ORDER TO COME UP WITH THE FUNDS.
WELL AS WE LOOK AT SOME OF THE
AREAS THAT WE'VE ALREADY
PROVIDED MINIMAL SERVICES IN
THEIR HEALTHCARE AREA. AND WE
IDENTIFIED HOW MANY INDIVIDUALS
WE COULD SERVE WITH WHAT THAT
AMOUNT OF MONEY. WE'RE LOOKING
AT POTENTIALLY RIGHT NOW IF THIS
GOES TO HAVE THE FULL NINETY
MILLION. WE'RE PROJECTING TO
SERVE MORE THAN TWENTY FIVE.
THOUSAND PARTICIPANTS AS PART OF
THIS EFFORT BUT WE TOOK THE
BASIS OF- THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
HOURS THAT GO INTO THE TRAINING
WHAT TYPE OF TRAINING IS THAT
THEY WOULD BE INVOLVED IN
OBVIOUSLY IT'S GOING TO VARY
SIGNIFICANTLY- BUT BASED ON THAT
WE- DID WE TOOK A GENERAL.
OVERVIEW OF THAT AN AVERAGE OF
IT AD THEN IDENTIFIED THE
FUNDING AMOUNT. OF HEAT YOUR
STATEMENT AS THERE WAS YOU
FOCUSED ON THE NUMBER THAT YOU
WOULD TRAIN. BUT DO YOU HAVE AN
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT. THE NEED
IS FOR US IS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAVE WE COMPLETED A
NEEDS ASSESSMENT. AND HOW FAR
WILL THIS NUMBER OF PROVIDERS.
TAKE US IN ADDRESSING THAT NEED
. THANK YOU FOR A FOLLOW UP
QUESTION AND SO WE DID. I LOOK
AT LABOR MARKET INFORMATION FROM
EDT IS LET MARKET INFORMATION
DIVISION. THE NEED IS OBVIOUSLY
SIGNIFICANTLY GREATER. THAN
NINETY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
THAT WE'RE ASKING FOR ACTIONS
PARTY THINK PART OF THE REASON
WHY YOU'RE SEEING MULTIPLE
REQUESTS HERE. FROM ALL THE
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS BECAUSE
THE NEED IS SIGNIFICANTLY
GREATER. THE NEED FROM OUR END
IS FROM THE EMPLOYMENT TRAINING
PANEL AND THE NINETY MILLION
DOLLARS IS BASED PRIMARILY ON
THE FACT THAT- WE'RE WE KNOW
WE'RE ABLE TO MANAGE THAT AMOUNT
OF MONEY WITHIN OUR CURRENT
PROCESSES RIGHT NOW. IF WE WERE
TO ASK FOR A SIGNIFICANTLY
LARGER BUCKET OF MONEY THEN WE
WOULD- HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY HAVE
TO INCREASE OUR WORKFORCE WE'RE
ALREADY LOOKING AT INCREASING.
OUR STAFFING LEVELS BY ANOTHER
TWENTY P. WISE IN ORDER TO MEET
SOME OF THESE OTHER DEMANDS BUT-
IF WE WERE TO INCREASE ANYTHING
MORE THAN THAT WE HAVE TO GET
SIGNIFICANTLY LARGER WE'RE NOT
LOOKING TO DO THAT WE'RE JUST
LUCKY TO. BE ABLE TO HELP AS.
MUCH AS POSSIBLE WITH WHAT WE
CAN. THANK YOU MAY CHAIR. THANK
YOU JUST A COUPLE OF FOLLOW UP
QUESTIONS WHO WILL CONDUCT WITH
THE THIRD PARTY ASSESSMENT
ASSESSMENTS OF THESE PROGRAMS
AND HOW WILL THAT THIRD PARTY BE
SELECTED WHAT OUTREACH
STRATEGIES WILL BE USED TO
ENSURE A BROAD SERVER CITY OF
COMMUNITIES CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF RECRUITMENT TRAINING AND JOBS
OFFERED THROUGH THESE- THIS
PROPOSAL. THANK YOU FOR THE
CHAIR AT THE QUESTIONING CARE.
SO YES WE ARE PLANNING TO DO AT
AN INDEPENDENT EVALUATION AND WE
ARE GOING TO FOLLOW THE OPEN
PROCUREMENT PROCESS MEANING WE
WILL PUT OUR REQUEST FOR
PROPOSAL THAT WILL BE AVAILABLE-
PUBLICLY TO ANYONE AND EVERYBODY
THAT'S INTERESTED- AND THROUGH
THAT PROCESS WILL IDENTIFY AN
INDEPENDENT EVALUATOR THAT WILL.
THEN DO AN EVALUATION AND OUR
INTENTIONS ARE TO HAVE AN
EVALUATOR THAT WILL- END INCLUDE
NOT ONLY THIS PROGRAM BUT SOME
OF OUR OTHER PROGRAMS AS WELL.
SO WHAT. MY FOLLOW UP TO THAT
SAME QUESTION WAS WHAT ARE THE
OUT WE TRIED STRATEGIES THAT
WOULD BE USED TO ENSURE THAT
THROUGH THE PROCUREMENT PROCESS
AND YOUR EVALUATION. OF THOSE
THAT SUBMIT- THERE IS A BROAD
DIVERSITY OF COMMUNITIES THAT
CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THAT. AND
MAN IF I MAY ASK A FOLLOW UP
QUESTION TO THAT ARE USED
TALKING SPECIFICALLY TO BE
EVALUATOR THAT WOULD BRING ON
BOARD. CORRECT OKAY THANK YOU
OKAY- SO WE DO HAVE OBVIOUSLY WE
WOULD FOLLOW THE PROCUREMENT
PROCESSES WHICH AT WITH THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT IN SUPPORT OF WHAT WE
DO THERE- THEY THEN ALSO PROVIDE
THE R. F. P. TWO DG ASKED THE
POST ON THEIR SITES WE POSTED
PUBLICLY ON OUR SITE- SO GETS
POSTED EVERYWHERE WE ALSO AND-
THE EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL
ALSO DOES HAVE. AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT UNIT THAT DOES
OUTREACH WITH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AS WELL AS OTHER-
EMPLOYMENT IN IN AREAS AND HOW
AND THEY WOULD ALSO THEN BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT THIS EFFORT TO GET
THE WORD OUT THAT WE HAVE THIS.
EVALUATION IN PLACE AND WE'RE
LOOKING FOR AN EVALUATOR AND
THAT WOULD BE ABLE TO HOPEFULLY.
ALLOW US TO BRING IN A BROAD
ARRAY OF APPLICATIONS AND ALL.
CAN YOU PROVIDE US WITH A LIST
OF THE CURRENT STATE WIDE CBO'S
THAT YOU HAVE ON FILE THAT WOULD
BE USED IN WHAT IS THE
MEASUREMENT OF SUCCESS THAT THEY
HAVE HAD IN THE PAST. BECAUSE I
KEEP HEARING CBO'S ARE A LARGE
PART OF THE ANSWER. BUT WHAT WE
HAVE SEEN IN THE LAST TWO YEARS
AS THE CBO'S ARE ALSO.
INCREDIBLY UNDERFUNDED AND
OVERWORKED AND I'M JUST CURIOUS%
AS TO. WHAT THAT CURRENT LIST OF
CEOS ACROSS THE STATE LOOKS LIKE
REGIONALLY. TO ENSURE THERE'S A
BROAD A BROAD STRATEGY OF. AS WE
THINK ABOUT MEASUREMENTS OF
SUCCESS AS WE MOVE FORWARD. YEAH
ABSOLUTELY I CAN FROM THE- PLAN
TRAINING PANEL WE CAN PROVIDE
YOU A COMPLETE LIST OF THE CBO
THAT WE UTILIZE I'M I'M HAPPY TO
COORDINATE SOME INFORMATION WITH
OUR PARTNERS AT THE COMPACT
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD- AS WELL AS THE- WORK FOR
SERVICES BRANCH YET EDT. TO BE
ABLE TO INCORPORATE ALL OF THAT
CBO SAID DAVE- WORK WITH THAT AS
WELL. RIGHT THAT. THANK YOU I
THINK THAT WOULD BE VERY
BENEFICIAL TO MEMBERS ACROSS THE
STATE AS WE HAVE DISCUSSED TODAY
THAT CURRENTLY- DON'T SEE
RESOURCES IN THEIR COMMUNITIES I
THINK THAT WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL
OTHER VARIOUS ASPECTS TO
UPSKILLING THE HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE ONE OBTAINING
LICENSING OR ASSERTIVE-
CERTIFICATIONS TO SKILLBASED
TRAINING WHAT ARE SPECIFIC
EXAMPLES OF HOW ETP WILL UP
SKILL HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICE
WORKERS. THANK YU FOR THE
QUESTION NOW I'M SURE AND I
WOULD LIKE TO ALLOW MY COLLEAGUE
AT PETER COOPER TO JUMP IN AND
PROVIDE SOME INFORMATION ON
THAT. THAT'S OKAY. YEAH PETER
COOPER A PLYMOUTH TRAINING PANEL
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION- SO
WE DO WORK WITH A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS AND ASSOCIATIONS
ACROSS THE STATE- AS WELL AS
CEOS AND- WHEN WE ENTER INTO
CONTRACTS DIRECTLY WITH
EMPLOYERS NEED TRAINING IS
REALLY DRIVEN BY THEIR THEIR
NEEDS- WHAT KIND OF SKILLS THEY
NEED AND SO FOR THIS FUNDING
THIS WOULD LOOK SIMILAR AND WHEN
WE GET WILL BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
UPSCALING FOR. JOBS LIKE
PHLEBOTOMIST OR MEDICAL
TECHNICIANS AND I'LL IN A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT- JOB
CLASSIFICATIONS THAT. THAT OR
MENTIONED EARLIER AT THE
BEGINNING OF THIS- CAL. OKAY
THANK YOU FOR THAT THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
. WE ARE GONNA THANK YOU THANK
YOU TO THE PANEL ON THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER SIX- OUR
LAST LABOR RELATED ISSUE FOR
THIS ISSUE WE WILL HEAR FROM THE
REPRESENTATIVES. FOR FROM THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT SENSE EDT PROPOSES TO
IMPLEMENT AN EMT TRAINING
PROGRAM THAT WAS BASED ON A
PILOT PROGRAM IN ALAMEDA WE WILL
HEAR FROM THE ADMINISTRATOR OF
THE PILOT PROGRAM AS WELL.
PRESENTERS ON THIS PANEL WILL BE
HEAVIER ETAL DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
WORK FORCE SERVICES BRANCH OF
EDT. AND ALEX BRISCOE WITH THE
DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC WORK ALLIANCE
MISTER AMERICA YOU WANT. IF SO
YOU MAY BEGIN. GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHARAMBA ENSURE
CUTTING UP AND MEMBERS- THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT IS REQUESTING A TOTAL
OF SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS I IN
GENERAL GENERAL FUND DOLLARS
OVER THREE YEARS TO LAUNCH THE
TARGETED EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES CORPS INITIATIVE LAST
MOM THIS BILL- INITIATIVE WHAT
IS INTENDED TO EXPAND EMERGENCY
MEDICAL TECHNICIANS IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH LOCAL. HEALTH
SYSTEMS. ARM I WOULD SAY LITTLE
ABOUT MY BRANCH- MY BRANCH WE
MINISTER WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS WE OVERSEE SIXTY SIX
HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS.
AND ARE WILL FEDERAL DOLLARS ARE
WITH INTACT MINISTRY CAPACITY WE
ALSO OVERSEE- ARMS THE
SOLICITATION OF GRANT
APPLICATIONS AND THOSE PROCESSES
WOULD BE UTILIZED FOR THIS
INITIATIVE AS WELL- WE HAVE
UNITS DEDICATED TO. DEVELOPING
THE SOLICITATIONS AND WE HAVE A
UNIT DEDICATED TO MANAGING THESE
CRACKS SO WE WOULD HAVE WE HAVE
THE INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE
PROCESSES TO CONDUCT THIS
INITIATIVE AND ALSO I WOULD- WE
HAVE A PORTION OF WHAT WE CALL
IN THE WORK FORCE DURING. THE
GOVERNOR'S DISCRETION DOLLARS
FOR WE OUGHT AND WE ARE PORTION
OF IT IS FOCUS TO WHAT WE CALL
SPECIAL POPULATIONS THESE ARE
UNDER REPRESENTED ON MEMBERS OF
OUR COMMUNITY THAT ARE UNDER
REPRESENTED SECTORS AND
REPRESENTATIVES SERVICE LEVELS
ON OUR PROGRAMS- WE SEE THIS IS.
THIS EMT PROGRAM IS ALSO FOCUSED
ON- TARGETING YOUTH YOUTH WITH
DISADVANTAGES. ADMINISTRATED BY
THE MODEL ALAMEDA WHICH WE'LL
GET TO HEAR MORE DETAIL FROM MR
BRISCOE- MCUS THESE BE- TARGET
YOUTH WITH BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT- BIT WAR WE SEE
SOMETHING THE NEW INFORMATION
THAT WILL COME ABOUT FOR THE
WORK FORCE WORLD IS THAT IT
WOULD SEE THE FORMATION OF
PARTNERSHIPS WITH LOCAL PUBLIX
HEALTH SYSTEMS ARM AND THEIR
CONTRACTORS MERCY MEDICAL
PROVIDERS WE SEE THAT MOVING
FORWARD I HAVE SOMETHING THAT
WOULD BE ON A SYSTEMS CHANGE
PIECE. PIECE FOR US- THE OUTCOME
DATA- WE WILL BE FOCUSED ON IS
OF COURSE ACHAEMENID EMPLOYMENT
AFTER COMPLETION OF THE PROGRAM.
THE QUARTERLY ON WAGES
THEREAFTER DEVELOPING FACTORS
DON'T POINT AND ALSO THE
CREDENTIALING EIGHT WILL HAVE WI
FI ARM WILL BE. ON WE'RE
PROJECTING TO HAVE ON THIS
PROGRAM- EXPANDED TO FIFTEEN
OTHER STATE OTHER SITES WITHIN
OUR STATE- ARMCHAIR ARROBA WE
HEAR YOU AND WE SHARE YOUR
OBJECTIVE AND SEEN SOME
GEOGRAPHY DIVERSITY IN THIS
PROGRAM- TO DO THAT TO OUR
HAPLESS FIFTEEN SITES SO WE GET
THOSE PROJECTED TARGET NUMBER OF
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED PARTICIPANTS
WE'RE GOING TO GO ABOUT THIS BY
THE FIRST YEAR BEING A PAIN
YEARS SO REALLY GIVE THESE RULE
AREAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY
PUT TOGETHER PARTNERSHIPS AND SO
ON NECESSARY- TO MAKE THIS
HAPPEN TO MAKE IT REAL- THIS
PROGRAM. IS IT'S BEEN THE A- WE
WILL MORE ABOUT THIS PROGRAM IN
ITS HOLISTIC APPROACH BUT- WHY
WE'RE SO EXCITED ABOUT THIS
PROGRAM AND WHAT WE THINK IT'S
PROVEN SUCCESS WHICH WILL HEAR
MORE ABOUT THE COMPONENTS. IS
THEY REALLY HAVE A HOLISTIC
APPROACH WE ARE FEEL STRONGLY
THAT IF WE'RE GOING TO DO THIS
EQUITY WORKING FOR GOING TO GIVE
PEOPLE THE OPPORTUNITY TO ENTER
INTO. OCCUPATIONS THAT ARE IN
DEMAND OUT WITH THOSE THAT
ACTUALLY HAVE SUFFERED TRAUMAS
OR HAVE BEEN INCARCERATED THINGS
LIKE THAT HE NEED THIS. HOLISTIC
APPROACH IN WHICH ALAMEDA HAS
PILOTED AND I WILL HEAR MORE
ABOUT IT- AND ALSO A COMMON
THEME YOU HEARD ABOUT OUR
INVESTMENTS WE ALSO WILL BE
FUNDING A COMPREHENSIVE
EVALUATION ON THIS EVALUATION
WILL BE SELECTED THROUGH A
COMPETITIVE PROCESS ON THIS
EVALUATIONS IT IS SOMETHING THAT
WE UTILIZE CURRENTLY AND OTHER
FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES AND WHAT'S
IMPORTANT EVALUATIONS NOT ONLY
THAT WE MEASURE OF SUCCESS THERE
AFTER- WE USE- A DEVELOPMENTAL
EVALUATION APPROACH WHICH ALLOWS
FOR ENGAGEMENT OF OUR GRANTEES
THROUGHOUT THE TERM OF THE
GRANT. TO HELP THEM WITH REAL
TIME INFORMATION TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THE BARRIERS TO THEM BEING
SUCCESSFUL AND WE BELIEVE THIS
IS ESSENTIAL IF WE'RE GOING TO
MAKE THIS A SUSTAIN PROGRAM
BEYOND THE TERM OF THE GRANT AND
HAVE THAT SYSTEMS TEAM THEY WERE. AIMING FOR- WITH THAT I WILL-
INCLUDE MY BE STATEMENTS
REGARDING THIS PROGRAM. AND LOOK
FOR YOUR QUESTIONS. THANK YOU MR
BRISCOE. GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYBODY- IT'S MY PLEASURE TO
PRESENT TO YOU TODAY- I'M GOING
TO QUICKLY TAKE YOU THROUGH THE
HISTORY AND THE DESIGN OF THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY EMS CORE- AND
WHILE IT MAY SEEM ALTERNATING
CLEAN AND TIDY- I THINK ANYBODY
KNOWS ANYTHING ABOUT THIS WORK
WILL SEE- LOTS OF REALLY TOUGH
LESSONS LEARNED. FROM TO CLARIFY
FOR THE RECORD I AM THE PREVIOUS
DIRECTOR OF THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
HEALTH CARE SERVICES AGENCY
THAT'S THE HEALTH AUTHORITY IN
THE EAST BAY OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA. AND AS YOU
MAY OR MAY NOT KNOW ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT LOCAL HEALTH
AUTHORITIES DO IS PROVIDE ALL
HEALTH CARE FOR YOUNG PEOPLE IN
DETENTION. AND HISTORY OF THE
ARMENIAN ON IBM ESCORT BEGINS
THAT. WHEN ONE OF OUR STAFF MIKE
GIPSON- AFTER RECOMMEND THE
MIDDLE THAT PICTURE. COMING UP
MONDAY BECAUSE HE HAD BINGED
DOING SOME TRAINING FOR MSME
AGENCY AFTER CAMP A CAMPER LAST
. AND THOSE OAKLAND. AND HE SAID
THE ALEX WE GOT SOMETHING HERE
YOU GOTTA COME CHECK IT OUT. AND
HE WAS DOING A PRE COURSE FOR
EMS FOR YOUNG PEOPLE IN
DETENTION. AND I HE SAID ALL OF
THEM WERE SUPERINTENDENT
SUPERSIZED. SO WE OPEN THE
BUILDING ARE ARE YOU DEVOTE ARE
SHE'S ME ARE AUTHORITY BUILDING
AT NIGHT YOUNG PEOPLE STARTED
SHOWING UP. AND FAST FORWARD
OVER TEN YEARS. WE HAVE NOW
GRADUATED NINETEEN COHORTS A NEW
COHORT WILL BEGIN NEXT WEEK.
THERE ARE TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
GRADUATES SINCE 2017100% OF THE
YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE PASSED THE
NATIONAL REGISTRY THAT IS
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER THAN THE
STATE AVERAGE SO DON'T BELIEVE
THE HYPE. SYSTEM INVOLVED ISN'T
PROPERLY SUPPORTED ARE AWESOME.
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY OF MY WORKING
IN THE FIELD. 30% HIGHER ADD
SEVENTEEN OUR FIREFIGHTERS. I
COULD GO ON- YEAH I HAVE RUN
HOSPITALS ONE OF THE BUSIEST
NINE ONE SYSTEMS IN THE STATE.
MENTAL HEALTH PLANS AND NUMEROUS
OTHER SERVICES AND SUPPORTS AND
SAFETY NETS THIS IS PART OF
WHERE THE MOST TRANSFORMATIVE
PROGRAM I HAVE EVER BEEN A PART
OF. AND I'M DEEPLY COMMITTED
PERSONALLY PROFESSIONALLY
SYSTEMS EXPRESSION. SO WHAT DO
WE LEARN. WE LEARNED THAT IN
ORDER TO MAKE FROM THIS WORK FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE. WE HAVE TO PREPARE
THEM TO SUCCEED. SO WE ACTUALLY
DOUBLED THE LENGTH OF THE
TRAINING FOR EMS. MEETING
INSTEAD OF THE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
HOURS INTO TRAINING THAT IS THE
NORMAL COURSE WE DON'T WANT TO
THREE THIRTY HOURS. WE DID A
QUICK COURSE IN MEDICAL
TERMINOLOGY SO THAT WHEN THE
YOUNG PEOPLE FIRST ENCOUNTER THE
STANDARDIZED INTO CURRICULUM
THEY HAVE SEEN ALL THE WORKS
BEFORE. WE ALSO TRIPLE THE
NUMBER OF RIDE ALONGS. AND
RETAILERS THE EDUCATION
INDIVIDUALLY TO EVERY YOUNG
PERSON'S PERSONAL EXPERIENCE.
AND THEN WE DEVELOP A
COMPREHENSIVE. PROGRAMS CASE
MANAGEMENT MENTORSHIP WITH A
PERSON OF COLOR FIRE SERVICE FOR
PARAMEDIC SERVICE. YOU LIKE
CIRCLES WHICH IS REALLY COOL FOR
MENTAL HEALTH. LIKE COACHING
AND- A NUMBER OF OTHER OUR
WORKPLACE SUPPORTS INCLUDING JOB
READINESS SUBSTANCE TRAINING.
AND THEN FINALLY WE PROVIDE A
ONE THOUSAND DOLLAR A MONTH
MONTHLY STIPEND FOR ALL YOUNG
PEOPLE SUCCEED. AND ONE MORE
TIME WE DIDN'T THIS WASN'T THE
PROGRAMMER WE STARTED. WE WE GOT
IT ALL WRONG NUMBER OF TIMES AND
REALIZE THAT WE HAVE TO PAY ON
PEOPLE THAT WE HAVE TO PROVIDE A
SUPPORT WE HAVE TO TRAIN THEM
CAREFULLY. I BUT IF WE DID WHAT
WE GOT WAS EXTRAORDINARY AND
SHE'S. WE ALSO PROVIDE FREE
SERVICE WHERE EMTS TRAIN MIDDLE
SCHOOLERS AND HIGH SCHOOLERS ON
CPR. AND LAST YEAR WE ARE GOING
TO REPLICATE THE PROGRAM IN NEW
MEXICO AND WE HAD OUR FIRST
COWORKER GRADUATED LAST YEAR
JUST TO GIVE YOU A BRIEF LITTLE
TASTE OF IT. THIS IS DANTE.
DANTE WAS UNEMPLOYED. LIVING IN
A SOVEREIGN LANDS ARE HIS
NOMINEE AND T. AS IN THE FIRE
DEPARTMENT. THIS IS DALLAS. SHE
IS NOW ALSO WORKING AT HIM SHE
AS AN EMT AND I'M A COOKING FIRE
THAT'S ON MY VERY FIRST CALL
WORK. IN OAKLAND COMPANIES
WORKING IN THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT ALAMEDA HEALTH
SYSTEMS. AND NICHOLAS I COULDN'T
HELP BUT PUT NICOLAS UP HERE HE
IS ACTUALLY A GRADUATE OF THE
HARVARD UNIVERSITY. OF MEDICINE
CLASS. OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN IS NOT
A PRACTICING PHYSICIAN. SO HOW
WE GONNA DO. WELL WE HAVE FROM
WORKING WITH ABBY AND HOW THEIR
END CAME IN THEIR TEAM WE
CREATED THE FOLLOWING CONCEPT
LAUNCHED TEN TO FIFTEEN SITES
OVER THE NEXT FIVE YEARS EACH
SIDE CUSTODY FORTY CORPS MEMBERS
THAT'S ABOUT FIVE TO SIX HUNDRED
EMTS ANNUALLY. I'M SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN FOUR AND SIX THOUSAND
TOTAL OUR TRAINEES. YES HE IS
TRAINED AND CERTIFIED OVER THE
COURSE OF THE PROGRAM. FOR THOSE
OF YOU WHO DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
NINE ONE ONE SYSTEM IT'S AN
UNHOLY MARRIAGE BETWEEN THE
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT WHO
OVERSEES THE SYSTEM. FIRE
DEPARTMENTS YOU FOR SPONSORED AN
AMBULANCE SYSTEMS WHO TRANSPORT
AND BILL THAT ACCOUNTS FOR ABOUT
80% OF ALL NINE ONE ONE SYSTEMS
IN THE STATE WHAT WE'RE REALLY
DOING HERE IS PARTNERS
LEVERAGING THE PURCHASING POWER.
OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT
. THE LANSA WHISKEY IN THE
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT. RIGHT
ALL THE STANDING ORDERS.
OVERSEES AND MANAGES ALL
TRAINING AND DELIVERY OF THE
NINE ONE SYSTEM IN EVERY
JURISDICTION IN CALIFORNIA.
THOSE SYSTEMS HAVE NEVER TRAINED
THEM ONLY CERTIFIED TRAINING
PROGRAMS THE REAL INNOVATION OF
THE MS SCORE IS WHEN THE PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENT CREATES ITS
OWN TRAINING PROGRAM AND
PRIVILEGES THOSE YOUNG PEOPLE
FOR EMPLOYMENT IN THE NINE ONE
SIX. ONE SYSTEM THAT THEY
OVERSEE. HERE'S A BRIEF TIMELINE
OVER FIVE YEARS NOW WE WILL
LAUNCH WELL THE THIRTEEN SITES.
I'M INTERESTED RIGHT ON TIME TO
TAKE AS MANY QUESTIONS AS YOU'VE
GOT A TALK ABOUT THIS PROGRAM.
FOREVER THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER RISK APOLOGIES FOR THE
DELAY I LOST TRACK OF MY ALL OF
MY PAPERS THAT I. HAVE IN FRONT
OF ME. HELLO WHICH PAPER I'M
LOOKING AT- JUST A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS FOR YOU BEFORE I TURN
IT OVER TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AS WELL. HOW MANY
INDIVIDUALS PARTICIPATED IN THE
PILOT PROGRAM. I BELIEVE YOU HAD
IT IN IN YOUR SLIDE BUT I MAY
HAVE MISSED IT. TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY NINE SO FAR OVER
NINETEEN COHORTS. THERE ARE TWO
COURTS A YEAR THE TRAINING
PROGRAM IS ABOUT SIX MONTHS LONG
. AND WHAT WAS THE ORIGINAL
INVESTMENT IN THE PILOT PROGRAM
IN ALAMEDA. YEAH THE ORIGINAL
RESTAURANT WAS WELL THE FIRST
THREE YEARS THERE WAS NO
INVESTMENT WE ALL DID IT ON
EVERY TIME SO ONE IS FOR ALL THE
TALK ABOUT EVALUATION LIKE WE
KNEW THIS WAS RIGHT WE ALL
BELIEVE THAT YOUNG PEOPLE COULD
BE INCREDIBLE WE JUST DIDN'T
KNOW HOW. BUT THE FIRST TWO
YEARS OF THE FORMAL PROGRAM WERE
FUNDED BY THE ROBERT WOOD
JOHNSON FOUNDATION AT SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR. SO SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND. DOLLARS TWICE. TOLD
HIM ONCE THAT THAT'S THAT'S TWO
COHORTS OF FIFTEEN TO TWENTY.
WHERE MEMBERS OF PEACE AND WHAT
IS THE WEIGHT OF ONCETHE
INDIVIDUALS- PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROGRAM AND THEY GRADUATE FROM
IT WHAT IS THE- I GUESS THE
RATIO OF HIGHER OF THE MEMBERS
THAT HAVE GONE THROUGH THE-
PILOT PROGRAM. TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY NINE HAVE GONE THROUGH
THE NINETEEN COURTS TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY ARE WORKING. IT'S
GREAT AND DO YOU KNOW WHAT THE
AVERAGE SALARY IS OF. YES YES
ALSO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT YEAH
HE AND HE STARTS AT AROUND
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY FIVE AN HOUR.
BUT WHAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
UNDERSTAND ABOUT HIM SHE IS IT'S
THE FIRST STEP. ON THE PATHWAY
TO MEDIC. OR NURSE OR THE REST
OF THE ALLIED HEALTH
PROFESSIONS. I'M NOT BEING AN
ISSUE FOR YOUR WHOLE ENTIRE
CAREER ALMOST NEVER HAPPENS. A
LOT OF EMTS ARE TRYING TO GET
HIRED BY FIRE. SO WHAT THAT DOES
IS FIRE HIRES OUT OF THE IMPACT
AND IT CREATES A NATURAL CHARM.
THAT ALLOWS FOR ON CONSISTENT
OPPORTUNITY FOR HIRING. THE
OTHER BIG PLACE THAT EMTS ARE
GETTING HIRED INCREASINGLY IS IN
MODEL MODE RECEIVING CENTERS.
AND IN SOBRE DETOX FACILITIES AS
FRONT DOOR STAFF BASICALLY THINK
OF LIKE A INTAKE. OR CHARGES
WILL. I THANK YOU FOR THAT I
BRING UP THESE QUESTIONS JUST TO
THINK ABOUT. INCOME INEQUALITY-
AND THE INVESTMENT THAT IS
CLEARLY NEEDED BUT ALSO. LIVING
WAGES MAKING EIGHTEEN DOLLARS AN
HOUR IN LOS ANGELES AT FORTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR OR EVEN
IN SOME A LOT ACTUALLY SEVERAL
PARTS OF CALIFORNIA. JUST MAKES
IT ALMOST NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE TO
HAVE THAT LEVEL OF STRESS THE
LEVEL OF JOB THE LEVEL OF
RESPONSIBILITY. AT EIGHTEEN
DOLLARS AN HOUR DOESN'T SEEM
FAIR- AND IT CERTAINLY DOES
SOMETHING FOR US TO THINK ABOUT
IN TERMS OF WHAT THAT ACTUALLY
LOOKS LIKE. FOR A WORK FORCE
THAT SO DESPERATELY NEEDED
MISTER AMBULANCE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- I'M GONNA CONTINUE
WITH MR BRISCOE IF I CANNOT I
FIRST HAVE TO SAY HOW PLEASED I
AM WITH THIS PROPOSAL KNOWING
THE CRITICAL ROLE THAT EMTS PLAY
OVERALL IN OUR HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM AND- AGREE WITH YOU ON
THE TURN AND NATURAL TRANSITION
THAT OCCURS. AS THIS IS THE
FIRST STEP IN THE LATTER BUT I
WANTED TO FOLLOW UP ON THE TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY NINE
GRADUATES THAT YOU MENTIONED AS
I COULDN'T HELP BUT NOTICE
SAYING THAT THE PICTURE
PRESENTED ONLY HAD. MALES IN IT.
I'D LIKE TO UNDERSTAND HOW MANY
OF THOSE GRADUATES ARE FEMALES
AND HOW ARE WE MAKING SURE TO
ENCOURAGE THEIR PARTICIPATION IN
THIS PROGRAM AS WELL. THANK YOU
AND- SO THE PROGRAM IS NOW CO ED
BUT WHEN WE STARTED WE STARTED
DURING THE MY BROTHER'S KEEPER
TIME AND WE ALSO FRANKLY MADE NO
APOLOGIES AND WE'RE TRYING TO
FIND A WAY TO BRING YOUNG MEN OF
COLOR INTO HEALTH CAREERS. SO
THE FIRST WELL ACTUALLY THE
FIRST CAR WAS CONRAD AND I DON'T
MEAN TO BE FLIPPANT BUT WE WERE
READY- THANK WE DIDN'T HAVE THE
STAFFING APPROPRIATE WE DIDN'T
HAVE THE GENDER AND THE TRAUMA
SENSITIVITY WE NEEDED AND IT
WAS. A TOTAL DISASTER CERVANTES
RESTRICTED TO- JUST MEN AND IS
NOW COED AGAIN AND THE PROGRAM
WE STARTED IN NEW MEXICO IS
GOING TO FROM JOHN I DON'T HAVE
THAT IN FRONT OF ME I'M SORRY
I'M ACTUALLY CAN GET IT FOR YOU
ABOUT THE TOTAL NUMBER TRAIN BUT
I WOULD VERY APPROXIMATELY THINK
THAT I'M TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
OF THE TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY I
HAVE BEEN BOYS. OR YOUNG MEN TO
ME.WHAT WOULD YOU ANTICIPATE
WITH THE GROWTH AND SCALING OF
THIS PROGRAM FOR THAT CONTINUED
RATIO OR THEIR INTENTIONS. TO
HELP TO ADDRESS THAT DISPARITY.
NO WE WILL BE OUT WE WILL BE CO
ED AND SEEK- THE APPROPRIATE MIX
OF MEN AND WOMEN IN THE PROGRAM
. I'LL FOLLOW UP WITH SEVERE
ROMERO DEPUTY DIRECTOR IF I CAN
ON ON THE BOTTOM OF PAGE TWENTY
NINE OF THE AGENDA THE PROPOSAL
STATES THAT THE PROGRAM WILL
IDENTIFY PROGRAM SITES BASED ON
VARIOUS FACTORS INCLUDING THE
REGIONAL CAPACITY TO ADMINISTER
THE PROGRAM. SHOULDN'T NEED.
DRIVE SELECTION OF PROGRAM SITES
RATHER THAN EXISTING CAPACITY.
OFTEN LOCATIONS WITH THE LEAST
CAPACITY HAVE THE GREATEST NEED-
WOULD LOVE TO FOLLOW UP ON THE
FIFTEEN SITES THAT YOU MENTIONED
AND HOW WE ARE ENSURING THAT IT
IS GOING. TOWARDS THE- YES LIKE
I STATED THAT WE DO INTEND ON
WORK THEY WERE SHOOTING FOR THE
FIFTEEN- SITES WE WANT TO SEE
SOMEONE WILL AREAS AND THAT'S
WHAT'S SO IMPORTANT AT FIRST
YEAR THAT PLANNING PER YEAR THAT
WILL GIVE US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REALLY SOME STAND UP. SOME OF
THESE- AREAS THAT NEED
ADDITIONAL TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO PUT BRING ABOUT THE
PARTNERSHIPS AND SO ON SO THAT
IS PART OF OUR STRATEGY THAT WE
COALESCE AROUND NEED. WILL FINAL
COMMENT ON THIS SIDE ONE OF THE
STATE THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
WRAPAROUND SERVICES THAT ARE
BEING DISCUSSED WORKING WITH
POPULATIONS THAT- HAVE HISTORY
OFTENTIMES MEANS WE NEED TO WRAP
OUR ARMS AROUND THEM AND TO
ENSURE THAT THEY PARTICIPATE AND
ARE WORKING WITH US IN THESE
PROGRAMS. I'M VERY GRATEFUL FOR
THE- INITIAL- COHORTS THAT CAME
OUT OF ALAMEDA AS IT WILL ALLOW
US TO THINK ABOUT HOW WE SCALE
THIS AND GROW THIS GOING
FORWARD. I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
VERY MUCH PANEL SIX WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO PANEL SEVEN WHICH IS
ON THE H. KAIT WORK FORCE FOR A
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA FOR ALL
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL. WE WILL
HOLD ALL MEMBERS QUESTIONS UNTIL
AFTER THE PRESENTERS HAVE
CONCLUDED AND WE WILL HAVE A
TOTAL OF FOUR PRESENTERS WHO ARE
ON THIS PANEL BEGINNING WITH
DIRECTOR ELIZABETH LANDSBERG OF
H. CHI. MAHDIA LYNN MORRIS WHO
IS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
VISION AND COME FROM ME SOUL
COREY HOW SHE DEALT WITH THE
OLEO AND MICHELLE GIVENS WHO IS
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF. GEAC
LET US BEGIN WITH DIRECTOR LANCE
BURKE. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS ELIZABETH LANDSBERG
THE DIRECTOR OF H. CAI
PRESENTING OUR PORTION OF THE
WORKFORCE FOR A HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL AND SHE LIVED
WHICH INCLUDES A BILLION DOLLARS
OVER THREE YEARS FROM THE
GENERAL FUND AS WELL AS A
PORTION OF THE OPIATE OPIOID
SETTLEMENT FUNDS. AS WITH ALL OF
THESE GUYS WORKFORCE INITIATIVES
THESE PROPOSAL SEEK TO INVEST IN
TRAINING A DIVERSE HEALTH
WORKFORCE. IMPORTANCE OF THAT
HAS BEEN DISCUSSED-
APPROPRIATELY AT LENGTH THIS
AFTERNOON- WERE ALSO WORKING TO
ADDRESS WORKFORCE SHORTAGES IN
UNDERSERVED AREAS AND INCREASE
ACCESS TO CALIFORNIANS
PARTICULARLY- WITH MEDIC HOW
MEMBERS. BECAUSE DOCTOR ARAMBULA
IS RIGHTLY PUSHING US TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF EVERY PART OF THE
STATE I DO WANT TO MAKE CLEAR
THAT IT IS A KEY PRIORITY OF ALL
OF H. GUYS WORKFORCE PROGRAMS TO
SERVE. THOSE TO IDENTIFY THOSE
PARTS OF THE STATE OF THE THAT
THAT ARE MEDICALLY UNDERSERVED
AND TO FOCUS OUR RESOURCES THERE
H. CHRIST SERVES AS THE STATE'S
PRIMARY CARE OFFICE AS WELL AS
THE STATE OFFICE OF RURAL
HEALTH. AND IN THAT CAPACITY WE
IDENTIFY THE MEDICALLY
UNDERSERVED AREAS BOTH IN TERMS
OF PRIMARY CARE AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. OUR LOAN REPAYMENT AND
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAMS REQUIRE A
SERVICE OBLIGATION SPECIFICALLY
IN A MEDICALLY UNDERSERVED AREA
ON A RESIDENCY IN TRAINING
PROGRAMS ALSO FOCUS ON
SUPPORTING THOSE AREAS THAT WE
LOOK FORWARD TO THIS VERY
IMPORTANT CONTINUE DISCUSSION
ABOUT HOW TO. DIVERSIFY THE
WORKFORCE AND AGAIN MAKE SURE
THAT EVERY AREA OF THE STATE
UNSERVED. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSES THE FOLLOWING
INVESTMENT THAT WOULD BE AND
ADMINISTERED BY H. CHI. FIRST IS
THE 20% FOR NURSING INITIATIVE
WHICH PROPOSES TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY MILLION TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF REGISTERED NURSES
LICENSED VOCATIONAL NURSES
CERTIFIED NURSING ASSISTANT
CERTIFIED NURSE MIDWIVES.
CERTIFIED MEDICAL ASSISTANT
FAMILY NURSE PRACTITIONERS AND
OTHER HEALTH PROFESSIONS- I
THINK WE'RE ALL WELL AWARE OF
THE SIGNIFICANT NURSING
SHORTAGES FACING CALIFORNIA A
DEPUTY SECRETARIES NAY TALK
ABOUT OME OF THE SPECIFIC DATA
THAT WE'VE BEEN GETTING. FROM
HEALTH FORCE- AND OTHERS ABOUT
THE THOSE NURSING SHORTAGES AND
WELL H. I. ALREADY HAS PROGRAMS
SUPPORTING A VARIETY OF NURSE
NURSING PROFESSIONS WE BELIEVE
SIGNIFICANT ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT IS NEEDED TO MEET THE
CURRENT NEEDS. UP NEXT ALL TURN
TO THE CALIFORNIA SOCIAL WORK
TWENTY THIRTY INITIATIVE WHICH
PROPOSES TWO HUNDRED AND TEN
MILLION TO SUPPORT SOCIAL WORK
TRAINING PROGRAMS AS WELL AS
PROVIDING STIPENDS AND
SCHOLARSHIPS FOR PEOPLE WORKING
TO CREATE A NEW PIPELINE. FOR
DIVERSE SOCIAL WORKERS WHO CAN'T
OTHERWISE AFFORD THE FINANCIAL
OR TIME INVESTMENT REQUIRED TO
COMPLETE FULL TIME PROGRAMS SO
AT AGE I WE'VE WE'VE
TRADITIONALLY RELIED A LOT ON
LOAN REPAYMENT PROGRAMS LOAN
REPAYMENT PROGRAMS ONLY WORK IF
YOU HAVE THE CREDIT TO. TO TAKE
OUT THOSE LOANS AND I'M AT THE
OUTSET SO WE'RE LOOKING A LOT
MORE- THAT EXPANDING A
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAMS AS WELL AS
DEVELOPING MORE STATEMENT. THE
PROGRAMS WE'RE PLEASED OF THAT
SOCIAL WORK PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE ASSESSING OPTIONS
TO FOR EXAMPLE ACCELERATE A
MASTERS IN SOCIAL WORK DEGREE-
WE'VE WE'VE HAD SOME PRELIMINARY
DISCUSSIONS I'M WITH. THOSE
PROGRAMS AND ARE CONTINUING TO
DO SO FOR EXAMPLE TODAY MANY
PEOPLE AS SPEND FOUR YEARS
GETTING THEIR UNDERGRADUATE
DEGREE- MAKE IT MAY GET THROUGH
CLINICAL EXPERIENCE AFTER THAT
THEN HAVE A TWO YEARS. OF
PROGRAM TO GET THEIR MASTERS AND
THEN ADDITIONAL LICENSING
REQUIREMENTS SO MANY PEOPLE IT'S
TAKING THEM EIGHT YEARS TO
BECOME AN LCSW UNTIL WE'RE
LOOKING AT WAYS OF ACCELERATING
THAT- THERE ARE THERE ARE
DEVELOPMENT FOUR PLUS ONE.
PROGRAM FOR A MASTERS IN SOCIAL
WORK DEGREE THAT THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT. WE ARE ALSO
PROPOSING- AS NOTED IN THE IN
THE AGENDA IN THAT SOME OF THE
DISCUSSION TODAY WE STILL HAVE
VERY SIGNIFICANT- A LACK OF
PSYCHIATRISTS PSYCHIATRIC. OF
PROFESSIONALS IN CALIFORNIA O
WE ARE PROPOSING INVESTMENT OF A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY MILLION. TO
CREATE TRAINING POSITIONS FOR
PSYCHIATRIC RESIDENTS.
PSYCHIATRIC MENTAL HEALTH NURSE
PRACTITIONERS PSYCHOLOGY INTERNS
AND FELLOWS AND PSYCHIATRIC
NURSES. INCREASING ON SITE
TRAINING PROGRAMS WILL HELP
BUILD THE WORKFORCE WHILE ALSO
SERVING AS AN ACTIVE RECRUITMENT
TOOL FOR ADVANCEMENT WITHIN THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
WORKFORCE. WITH LEADING WE HOPE
TO PROMOTIONAL PATHWAYS AND
INCREASED SALARIES SO A DEPUTY
DIRECTOR RISE L. TALKED EARLIER
ABOUT THE FACT THAT WE HAVE.
BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN EXPANDING
SOME OF THE PSYCHIATRIC
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS INCLUDING- IN
PLACES LIKE BUTTE COUNTY AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO HOPEFULLY HAVING
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT- SO
THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT- LACK OF
PSYCHIATRISTS IN IN CALIFORNIA
BUT ALSO THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO. DEVELOP THE OTHER
PROFESSIONS LIKE THE PSYCHIATRIC
MENTAL HEALTH NURSE
PRACTITIONERS. I'M AND THEN WE
HAVE A PROPOSAL TO HAVE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT OF THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR A COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKER AN
ISSUE OF IN CALIFORNIA. THESE
FUNDS WOULD BE USED TO RECREATE
RECRUIT TRAIN AND CERTIFY
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS AND I
DO WANT TO GO INTO THIS
PROPOSAL- AND A LITTLE BIT MORE
DETAIL AS THIS IS A NEW
PROFESSION THAT H. I WOULD BE
SUPPORTING. THERE IS A LONG
HISTORY OF COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS AND PROMOTE TORRES
PROVIDING CULTURALLY CONGRESS
PERSON CENTERED SERVICES AND
IMPROVING HEALTH OUTCOMES AS
IT'S BEEN NOTED A COVERT
NINETEEN HAS SHOWN AN EVEN
THE SERVICES. AND ON HEALTH
DISPARITIES IN CALIFORNIA- JUST
CRITICAL THAT WE HAVE TRUSTED-
AMBASSADORS TOOK TO OUR
COMMUNITY IS TO HELP WITH THESE
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES IS SEEKING FEDERAL
APPROVAL TO USE MEDICAID FUNDS
TO SUPPORT SERVICES PROVIDED BY
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS AND
FROM A TORTOISE. AND H. CHI'S
BUILDING ON DHS'S CONSIDERABLE
WORK SO WE APPRECIATE ALL THE-
WONDERFUL WORK THEY'VE DONE THEM
BOTH WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
LOOKING AT OTHER STATES-
ENGAGING WITH STAKEHOLDERS. SO
H. HIGHS RELATIVELY NEW AGAIN TO
THIS AREA BUT WE HAVE ENGAGED-
OVER THE LAST FEW MONTHS AND
WILL CONTINUE TO ENGAGE WITH
STAKEHOLDERS. TO DETERMINE THE
OPTIMAL ROLE THE STATE CAN PLAY
IN SUPPORTING THE DEVELOPMENT OF
STANDARDIZED CURRICULA AND
TRAINING COMPONENTS AND
SPECIALIZED TRAINING FOR
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS ACROSS
THE STATE. SO IN THIS ENGAGEMENT
WE ARE VERY COMMITTED TO
ACKNOWLEDGING THE VALUE OF
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS
TRAINING AND EXPERIENCE. I
ESTABLISHING A FRAMEWORK THAT
WILL PROVIDE COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS A PATHWAY TO OBTAIN A
CERTIFICATE THROUGH A STATE
APPROVED PROGRAM. WE ARE ALSO
COMMITTED TO EMPOWERING AND
SUPPORTING EXISTING TRAINING
PROGRAMS BY AUTHORIZING THOSE
PROGRAMS TO GRANT CERTIFICATES
THAT VERIFY A COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKER HAS UNDERGONE TRAINING
THAT MEETS. THE FORTHCOMING
STANDARDS- THAT WILL BE
ESTABLISHED BY THE STATE AND
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKER
STAKEHOLDERS. WE WANT TO WITH.
THE TRAINING AND CURRICULA
STANDARDS THAT WILL PROVIDE
EMPLOYERS OF COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS A CLEAR UNDERSTOOD ANY
OF THEIR ABILITY THE FIELD AND
VALUE. AND CREATE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR HORIZONTAL AN UPWARD CAREER
MBILITY. HEALTH WORKERS. WE'RE
PLEASED TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND VALUE
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS WITH
DIVERSE LIVED EXPERIENCE AND
THOSE WITH THE VERSE CULTURAL
AND LINGUISTIC BACKGROUNDS. WE
ARE IN THE PROCESS OF- TRYING TO
FINALIZE OUR TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO CREATE A CERTIFICATE
FOR COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS AND
ARE COMMITTED TO CONTINUING
GAUGE MEANT OF COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKER STAKEHOLDERS. INCLUDING
TRAINING ENTITIES EMPLOYERS AND
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
UNDER THE FORTHCOMING TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE WE WOULD CONVENE
STAKEHOLDERS TO ESTABLISH CORE
COMPETENCIES FOR COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKERS AND SPECIALIZED
TRAINING STANDARDS. WE EXPECT
THAT HAVEN'T A NUMBER OF
SPECIALIZATIONS INCLUDING
CLIMATE HEALTH HOMELESSNESS
DEMENTIA. AND OTHER SPECIALIZED
AREAS OF NEED. WE WILL ALSO
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE WITH OUR
SISTER DEPARTMENTS INCLUDING DH
CS THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
ALL OF WHOM HAVE DONE VERY
IMPORTANT WORK IN THINKING ABOUT
THIS TO ENSURE A COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKER TRAINING STANDARDS
MEET THEIR PROGRAMMATIC NEEDS.
SO WE'RE VERY PLEASED TO BE
WORKING ON THIS COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKER INITIATIVE AND BELIEVE IT
IS FOUNDATIONAL TO THE STATE'S
EFFORTS TO ADDRESS HEALTH
DISPARITIES. I'M OKAY SO MOVING
ON AND ALSO A FOUNDATIONAL TO
ADDRESS HEALTH DISPARITIES AS IS
INCREASING OUR LINGUISTIC
CAPACITY- WITH THE HEALTH
WORKFORCE SO WE ARE PROPOSING
SIXTY MILLION GENERAL FUND- IN A
MULTI LINGUAL HEALTH INITIATIVE
TO EXPAND SPECIFICALLY
SCHOLARSHIPS AND LOAN REPAYMENT
PROGRAMS IN HEALTH CARE AND
SOCIAL WORK- SPECIFICALLY FOR
MULTI LINGUAL APPLICANTS. WITH
THE GOAL OF INCREASING LANGUAGE
AND CULTURAL COMPETENCIES
THROUGHOUT THE CARE WORK FORCE.
I DO WANT TO NOTE THAT ALL OF H.
GUYS WORKFORCE PROGRAM SEEK TO
INCREASE RACIAL AND LINGUISTIC
DIVERSITY BUT THESE FUNDS WOULD
BE FOCUS SPECIFICALLY ON
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF MULTI
LINGUAL PROVIDERS ARE WE THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO HAVE. FOLKS
THIS FUNDS TO DO THAT. I AM THE
PROPOSAL TO USE TWENTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS OF THE OPIOID
SETTLEMENT FUNDS- FOR OPIOID
PROVIDER TRAINING IN SUPPORT OF
EMPLOYMENT. OF THAT AMOUNT A
TWENTY TWO MILLION WOULD BE USED
FOR OPIOID PROVIDER TRAINING TO
PROVIDE GRANT FUNDING FOR
COMMUNITY BASED SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER PROVIDERS. TO INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF LICENSED
CLINICIANS AS WELL AS NON
LICENSE SIDE WORKFORCE WITH A
FOCUS ON OPIOID TREATMENTS. AND
THEN THAT OF THE LAST FOUR
MILLION WITH SUPPORT A PILOT
PROJECT TO PROVIDE SUPPORT OF
EMPLOYMENT FOR THOSE IN RECOVERY
FROM SIDE. TO TRANSITION THEM-
INTO ONGOING EMPLOYMENT. SO AS
NOTED BY ASSISTANT SECRETARY
DELGADO AND DEPUTY SECRETARIES
NAY SOME OF THE SPECIFIC SEVENTH
PROPOSALS ARE STILL UNDER
DEVELOPMENT BASED ON OUR
CONTINUED ENGAGEMENT WITH THE
DATA. AND WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS
IT'S REALLY BEEN A WONDERFUL TO
BE PART OF THIS ENGAGEMENT. OF
BRINGING HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AND L. W. D. A.
TOGETHER TO WHICH IT TO PUT OUR
HEADS TOGETHER TO TRY TO DO THE-%
THAT TO HAVE THESE IMPORTANT
WORKFORCE. DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS
MOVE FORWARD AND. I AM PLEASED
TO BE HERE TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM
MONEY ALLOW MOST WHO'S THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR WITH THE PC
ON ECONOMY SO PLEASE BEGIN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I DON'T
ALTURAS ASSEMBLYMEMBER DOCTOR
JOAQUIN ARAMBULA AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WENDY CARILLO MEMBERS OF
SUBCOMMITTEES ONE AND FOUR. AND
I FIRST- TO START MY TESTIMONY
BY THINKING YOUR STAFF FOR
MAKING IT POSSIBLE FOR ME TO BE
HERE TODAY. I LIVE IN TWO
THOUSAND THE SENATE COMPROMISSO
IS A NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION DEDICATED
TO IMPROVING COMMUNITY HEALTH
AND WELLBEING BY SUPPORTING FROM
THE BONUS WE ARE A PIONEER AND
INNOVATOR IN THE MOVEMENT FOR AN
UPDATE OF A THOUGHT AS- WE
CURRENTLY EMPLOY OVER TWO
HUNDRED AND WITH ORDERS AND OUR
NETWORK OF BUT WITH THE RECENT
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTS OVER FOUR
THOUSAND FROM THE VOTING
SCREENING HEALTH WORKERS. AND
OTHER COMMUNITY LEADERS. WELL WE
ARE IN STRONG OF THE BUDGET.
ALLOCATE FROM HER AND FIFTY
MILLION TO RECRUIT TRAIN AND
CERTIFY TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND NEW
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS. WE
ALSO BELIEVE THAT THE FUNDS
SHOULD BE ALLOCATED. TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION THREE CRITICAL
FACTORS WHICH I WILL SPEAK TO.
FIRST IT IS ESSENTIAL BACK ON
SPEAKING ABOUT COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS WE EXPLICITLY INCLUDE
PROSTHETICS. SECOND TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS MUST ALSO MEET THE
PERSONAL AND PROFESSIONAL NEEDS
OF ROAD BUT IT'S AN THIRD
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
WITH A LONG HISTORY OF
RECRUITING TRAINING AND
OVERSEEING COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS AND TALK ABOUT IT SHOULD
BE RESOURCE. AND HAVE A KEY ROLE
IN IMPLEMENTING THE SIGNATURE OF
. FIRST LET ME BEGIN BY
DISCUSSING WHY BUT ALL OF THOSE
SHOULD BE IDENTIFIED AS DISTINCT
MEMBERS OF THE LARGER. MEANING
HEALTH WORKER FIELD. BUT I'M
ABOUT AS ARE PRIMARILY WOMEN WHO
ARE TRUSTED. AND RESPECTED
COMMUNITY LEADERS COMMUNITY
LEADERS WHO PROVIDE SEVENTY SO
THE KHORASAN SERVICE FROM THE
HEART. THIS IS THE ESSENCE OF
THEIR WORK THEIR LOCAL EXPERTS
OF PARTICULAR IMPORTANCE TO
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES AND UNDERSERVED AND
UNDER RESOURCE COMMUNITIES. I
DON'T THOSE ARE OFTEN LOW INCOME
MEMBERS OF DIVERSE IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES THANK SHARON
UNDERSTANDING OF THE LIVED
EXPERIENCES OF THE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS AND UNDERSTAND THE
CHALLENGES OF NAVIGATING AND
ACCESSING ESSENTIAL RESOURCES.
SUMMER MONOLINGUAL UNDEREMPLOYED
WITHOUT DIPLOMAS OR DEGREES MANY
WERE RAISED WITH GENERATIONS OF
FAMILY MEMBERS WHO ARE THE ONES
THAT OTHERS IN THE COMMUNITY
TURN TO FOR INFORMATION AND
SUPPORT. AS WAS MY MOTHER AND MY
GRANDMOTHER. IT IS ESSENTIAL
THAT IN THE NATION WIDE MOVE TO
A MORE PROFESSIONAL LIVES TO
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKER ROLE.
SACRAMENTO HAS NOT BE SUBSUMED
INTO A MEDICAL MODEL ARE
CENTERED AND SUPPORTED IN THEIR
COMMUNITY WHERE THEY CAN
CONTINUE TO BE A CONDO TO THE
CLINICS HOSPITALS AND OTHER
PLACES. THE COMMUNITY GETS CARE
. SECOND TWENTY MUST MEET THE
PERSONAL AND PROFESSIONAL MEANS
THE PROPONENTS. OF THE REST MUST
BE ENGAGED IN IDENTIFYING CORE
COMPETENCIES FOR ANY TRAINING
PROGRAM. THIS WILL CREATE
PROGRAMSTHAT ARE FROM OTHER
CENTERS BONTA DEFINED AND MORE
LIKELY REFLECTIVE OF COMMUNITY
NEEDS. BERMAN THOUGHT AS A
MISSING BILLS ARE REPRESENTING
INVOLVED ARE INVOLVED IN
CREATING ANY RECRUITMENT
TRAINING. AND CREDENTIALING
PROGRAM THIS WILL HELP INSURE
THAT PROPONENTS AND MAKING THEIR
UNIQUE ROLES ARE REPRESENTED
FAIRLY AND EQUITABLY. THIS WILL
SET THE FOUNDATION TO HIRE COME
COMMUNITY EXPERTISE AND OFFER A
LIVING WAGE. AND FINALLY. WE
BELIEVE THAT COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS WHO HAVE A LONG
HISTORY. AND EXPERIENCE IN
RECRUITMENT TRAINING AND
OVERSEEING COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS AND PROPONENTS SHOULD BE
INTEGRATED AT THE BEGINNING. WE
RECOMMEND THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE ACCESS AND
INFORMATION ESTABLISH A FORMAL
STAKEHOLDER ADVISORY COMMITTEE
FOR THIS WORKFORCE INITIATIVE.
COMPOSED OF 51% COMMUNITY EALTH
WORKERS AND FROM WITHOUT IT'S
RACIALLY AND ETHNICALLY DIVERSE
CBO'S BENEFICIARIES AND
COMMUNITY EXPERTS IN THE FIELD
TO ENSURING THAT COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKERS AND FROM THE
PHOTOS. HAVE DECISION MAKING
POWERS AND LEADERSHIP. UNDER THE
DIRECTION OF THE NAME HOLLOW
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF HEALTH CARE
BENEFITS AND ELIGIBILITY. WHICH
HAS ENGAGE WITHCBO'S OVER THE
LAST YEAR FOLLOWING ESTABLISHED
ADVISORY COMMITTEE. AS IT HAS
DRAFTED THE STATE PLAN AMENDMENT
TO IMPLEMENT THE NEW TWENTY FOUR
COULD BENEFIT. THE FEEDBACK
PRINCIPIOS HAS BEEN ESSENTIAL TO
ENSURING THE SPA IS INCLUSIVE OF
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS AND
PRODUCT BUT IT'S NEEDS. ALTHOUGH
SOME CONCERNS REMAIN WE TRUST WE
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER
TOWARDS RESOLUTION. THIS NEW
RECRUIT TRAINING AND
CREDENTIALING PROGRAM HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO CREATE TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITIES TO SERVE OUR
COMMUNITIES. BY ENSURING THAT IT
WAS BUILT WITH AND FOR BERMAN
BUDGETS. PLEASE LET ME KNOW IF I
CAN PROVIDE ANY ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION REGARDING THE VALUE
ANY SUPPORT AMONG VOTERS CENTRAL
TO THE COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKER
PROGRAMS WHICH IS A MASSIVE.
THANK YOU NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM
COREY HOW SHE DEALT WITH THE
HELLO. THANK YOU DOCTOR
REGULATORY KOREA SHEET WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE- AS
I MENTIONED EARLIER WE HAD
PUBLISHED OUR ANALYSIS OF THE
GOVERNORS CARE ECONOMY PACKAGE
LAST WEEK- WHICH H.
GUYS MAJOR WORKFORCE FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA OR ALL B. C. P. R.
WHICH HAVE THE COMMENTS REYES-
FIRST WE FIND THAT- PROPOSED
PACKAGE OF AUGMENTATIONS IS
LARGELY CONCEPTUAL WITH SOME
INFORMATION NOT YET DEVELOPED-
YOU KNOW FOR EXAMPLE FOR SEVERAL
OF THE PROPOSALS THE ULTIMATE
SET. OF SPECIFIC PROVIDER TYPES
THAT WILL BE TARGETED WITH THIS
FUNDING IS UNCLEAR- FOR EXAMPLE
THE- KAGE INCLUDES FUNDING TO.
SUPPORT PSYCHIATRIC RESIDENCIES
AS WELL AS OTHER BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PROVIDERS- BUT A SPECIFIC
BREAKDOWN OF WHAT. SHARE WILL GO
FOR EACH PETER HEALTH PROVIDER
TYPE IS NOT NOT NOT READILY
AVAILABLE- AND WE ALSO FIND THAT
THE PROPOSED- THE LACK OF THE
PROPOSED TRAILER BILL TO
IMPLEMENT MOST OF THE PROPOSED
FUNDING. LIMITS THE
LEGISLATURE'S INPUT ON THE
DESIGN OF THESE WORK FOR
STOPPING AUGMENTATIONS- SECOND.
ALTHOUGH THERE IS EVIDENCE OF
WORKFORCE SHORTAGES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE YEAH WE FIND THAT THIS
PROPOSED PACKAGE WOULD. BENEFIT
FROM A MORE REFINED PROBLEM
DEFINITION- OF WHICH WE SUPPORT
OUTLINING THE PROPOSED SOLUTIONS
WITH IDENTIFIED CAUSES FOR
WORKFORCE SHORTAGES- YOU KNOW
THE ADMINISTRATION DOES NOT
PROVIDE A COMPREHENSIVE
ASSESSMENT OF. STATE WHITE
STREET STATEWIDE WORKFORCE NEEDS
ACROSS PROVIDER TYPES WHICH
WOULD HELP THE LEGISLATURE
UNDERSTAND JUST HOW COSE THIS
INVESTMENT WOULD GET THE STATE
TO MEETING THE TARGET NUMBER OF
UP NEEDED PROVIDERS- OR WHETHER
THIS IS THE APPROPRIATE SET OF
PROVIDERS TO TARGET OR OF ANY.
PROVIDER TYPES ARE ARE MISSING
FROM THE PROPOSED PACKAGE- IT
ALSO DOES NOT BY NECESSITY OF
SORT OF WHY THESE GAPS ARE
OCCURRING- YOU KNOW THE
INTERVENTIONS IN THE PROPOSED
PACKAGE TARGET EDUCATION AND
TRAINING- BUT WORK FOR SORT
SHORTAGES COULD BE OCCURRING FOR
OTHER REASONS SUCH AS- WORKING
CONDITIONS ON THE GROUND- AND
SO. YOU KNOW GIVEN THAT
WORKFORCE EDUCATION AND TRAINING
TAKE SOME TIME TO MATERIALIZE-
WHETHER THIS IS THE BEST
APPROACH TO ADDRESS IMMEDIATE
WORK FORCE SHORTAGES IS UNCLEAR
IN OUR VIEW- YOU KNOW WE ALSO
FIND THAT HOW THIS PROPOSED
PACKAGE WOULD COMPLEMENT PRIOR.
STATE WORKFORCE INVESTMENTS IS
ALSO UNCLEAR- FOR EXAMPLE. THIS
STATE IS UNDER WAY ON
ADMINISTERING A SUBSTANTIAL
AMOUNT OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE FUNDING TARGETED
TARGETED AT CHILDREN AND YOUTH
UNDER THE- THE UMBRELLA OF THE
CHILDREN USE. THE EITHER A
HEALTH INITIATIVE- THESE OTHER
INVESTMENTS YOU KNOW SHOULD ALSO
RESULT IN NEW PROVIDERS IN THE
FUTURE AND SO HOW THIS PROPOSED
PACKAGE WHAT SORT OF BUILT ON.
THESE EFFORTS- INCLUDING WHEN IT
COMES TO EVALUATION OF RESULTS-
AND NOT SORT OF DUPLICATE
EFFORTS IS UNCLEAR- GIVEN THESE
CONSIDERATIONS HERE WE RECOMMEND
A COUPLE OF POSSIBLE APPROACHES-
FIRST YOU KNOW WE WOULD
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
DEFER ACTION ON FUNDING FOR THIS
PACKAGE UNTIL. A FULLY FLESHED
OUT PLAN IS DEVELOPED- YOU KNOW
THE LEGISLATURE COULD PROVIDE
PLANNING FUNDS IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET FOR THE ADMINISTRATION TO
UNDERTAKE A MORE COMPREHENSIVE
ANALYSIS OF WHAT THE UNDERLYING
CAUSES FOR THESE WORKFORCE
SHORTAGES ARE- AND WITH THE
PROPER INTERVENTIONS ARE TO
ADDRESS THESE CAUSES. AND THEN
AND THEN EVALUATE PROVIDING FULL
FUNDING FOR A FLESHED OUT PLAN
FROM THE FROM THE ADMINISTRATION
NEXT YEAR- HOWEVER IF THE
LEGISLATURE DOES APPROVE OF THIS
PACKAGING CONCEPT AND WISHES TO
PROVIDE FUNDING IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET- WE WOULD RECOMMEND THAT
IT ASKED THE ADMINISTRATION TO
PROVIDE. SOME FURTHER
INFORMATION ON THE ON THE
PACKAGE AT ME REVISION- THIS
INFORMATION COULD INCLUDE YOU
KNOW- SPECIFICS BEHIND YOU KNOW
HOW FUNDING WOULD BE ALLOCATED
ACROSS SPECIFIC PROVIDER TYPES
OR- HOW MANY ADDITIONAL
PROVIDERS BY PROVIDER TYPE ARE
NEEDED TO MEET SORT OF STATEWIDE
NEED- THIS WOULD SORT OF HELP
THE LEGISLATURE- YOU ASSESS THE
MERITS OF THE PACKAGE OUT IN
TIME FOR SORT OF THE BUDGET
PROCESS TO. TO PLAY OUT- WE
WOULD ALSO RECOMMEND ADOPTING
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO ENSURE
LEGISLATIVE INPUT INTO KEY
DETAILS OF THIS THIS PROPOSED
PACKAGE OF AUGMENTATIONS- THOSE
ARE ALL OF OUR COMMENTS AT THIS
TIME- AND HAPPY TO ANSWER.
PROVIDE FURTHER ASSISTANCE WHERE
NEEDED. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL
HEAR FROM. GIBBONS IS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA PLEASE
BEGIN. THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
TWO CHAIRS MEMBERS OF MICHELLE
GIVENS WITH THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVE ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
WE REPRESENT THE LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS THROUGHOUT OUR STATE
A FIRST WE WANT TO COMMEND THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THEIR
PROPOSALS TO INVEST IN
HEALTHCARE AND SOCIAL SERVICES
WORKFORCE. I WANT TO THANK THE
SUBCOMMITTEE HOWEVER FOR
EXPANDING THE DISCUSSION TO
INCLUDE THE PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKFORCE SIMILAR HEALTHCARE
PUBLIC HEALTH RELIES ON SKILLED
AND TRAINED WORKERS AND THAT
INCLUDES- BUT IS NOT LIMITED TO
PHYSICIANS MEDICAL DIRECTORS
EPIDEMIOLOGISTS DISEASE
INVESTIGATORS AND PUBLIC HEALTH
NURSES. LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
HAVE FACED SIGNIFICANT
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION
CHALLENGES MANY WHICH EXISTS
EXISTED PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC-
AND APRIL TWENTY TWENTY TRUST
FOR AMERICA'S HEALTH REPORT
NOTED BURN OUT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS AND WAS GROWING AS
THEY HAD CONSISTENTLY BEEN ASKED
TO DO MORE WITH LESS RESOURCES.
THE REPORT HIGHLIGHTED- ALSO
HIGHLIGHTED FINDINGS FROM THE
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE
INTERESTED NEEDS ASSESSMENT
SURVEY THAT FOUND THAT
GOVERNMENTAL PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKFORCE FACES MAJOR CHALLENGES
AND TURNOVER AND ATTRITION.
SIMILARLY THE CALIFORNIA FUTURE
OF HEALTHCARE IS WORKFORCE
COMMISSION- IN THEIR FEBRUARY
NINETEENTH TWENTY NINETEEN
REPORT. LISTED PREVENTION AND
PUBLIC HEALTH IS ONE OF THE
PRIORITY PROFESSIONS INDICATING
THAT THE DEMAND FOR NEW LEADERS
WILL INCREASE RAPIDLY IN THE
COMING YEARS AS A LARGE
PERCENTAGE OF CURRENT LEADERS
WERE SLATED FOR RETIREMENT. AND
THAT MANY LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS HAD ALREADY REPORTED
CHALLENGES IN RECRUITING AND
RETAINING WELL QUALIFIED WORKERS
CITING A LACK OF TOOLS FOR
RECRUITING AND LIMITED OPTIONS
FOR ADVANCEMENT AND INSTABILITY
OF FUNDED POSITIONS. ARE
HEADLINE CHALLENGES ARE
REFLECTED IN AN ARTICLE
PUBLISHED BY THE AMERICAN
JOURNAL OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
DECIDED ONLY 17% OF GRADUATES
FROM SCHOOLS OF PUBLIC HEALTH
WHEN I'M TO WORKING GOVERNMENTAL
PUBLIC HEALTH. COMPARE THAT WITH
THE 27% THAT WENT TO WORK IN THE
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE TWENTY FOUR
PERCENT- THAT WENT TO
CORPORATIONS AND EVEN 19% THAT
WENT TO ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS.
IN CALIFORNIA LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS FACE
INCREASING COMPETITION WITH THE
PRIVATE SECTOR WHICH PROVIDES
HIGHER PAY SIGN ON BONUSES
LONGER PAYMENT OPTIONS AND
AMENITIES SUCH AS UPDATED
TECHNOLOGY. UNFORTUNATELY DURING
THE PANDEMIC OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKFORCE FACED HARASSMENT AND
THREATS WHICH RESULTED IN
LEADERSHIP TO PARK DEPARTURES
EXCUSE ME. THE NATION'S HEALTH A
PUBLICATION OF THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC HEALTH ASSOCIATION NOTED
THAT THIS NOT ONLY ENDANGERS THE
SAFETY AND MENTAL WELL BEING OF
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH WORKERS. BUT
IT COULD ALSO MAKE IT HARDER TO
RECRUIT NEW WORKERS INTO
GOVERNMENTAL PUBLIC HEALTH. AND
WELL THESE WORKFORCE CHALLENGES
EXIST FOR ALL LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS IT'S EVEN MORE DIRE
FOR ROLE IN CENTRAL VALLEY
JURISDICTIONS. AND DESPITE THESE
CHALLENGES CALIFORNIA DOES NOT
YET HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE PLAN TO
BOLSTER THE WORKFORCE PIPELINE
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH AND WE MUST
CHANGE THAT. WE RECOMMEND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE SUPPORT- PUBLIC
HEALTH WORKFORCE PIPELINES. THE
PRIORITIZING THINGS LIKE
FLEXIBLE INCENTIVES TO SUPPORT
RECRUITMENT OF NEW PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKERS. AT AND DIVERSE WORKERS
AT THAT AND THE RETENTION OF OUR
EXISTING STAFF- WITH THE SET
ASIDE FOR RURAL AND CENTRAL
VALLEY JURISDICTIONS. ALSO
THINKING ABOUT I'M SUPPORTING
EDUCATION OPPORTUNITIES FOR
EXISTING PUBLIC HEALTH STAFF TO
SUPPORT CAREER ADVANCEMENT.
WE'RE BLESSED AT PROGRAMS AND
TRAINING THAT WOULD INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF ELIGIBLE
MICROBIOLOGIST LAB DIRECTORS AN
EPIDEMIOLOGIST- PROGRAMS THAT
ARE TARGETED TO EARLY CAREER
PROFESSIONALS. THAT TARGET
DIVERSE INDIVIDUALS THAT LIVING
COMMUNITIES AND INTERNSHIPS WITH
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THE CS USING
UC'S. AND ELIMINATING COST
BARRIERS FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
NURSES I HEARD DIRECTOR
LANDSBERG MENTIONED- THE NURSE
SHORTAGE AND IN PUBLIC HEALTH WE
HAVE NURSES THAT. ARE REGISTERED
NURSES BUT THEN THEY GO ON AND
PAY AN ADDITIONAL FEE TO RECEIVE
AND MAINTAIN A PUBLIC HEALTH
NURSE CERTIFICATION SO IT MAKES
IT THAT MUCH HARDER FOR
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION. FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES. THE
PANDEMIC SHINE A LIGHT ON THE
CRITICAL ROLE OF OUR OUR LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS IN OUR
WORKFORCE AND WE JUST ASK THAT
THE LEGISLATURE CONSIDER. A VERY
AS YOU'RE CONSIDERING EXCUSE ME
VARIOUS WORKFORCE INVESTMENTS
THAT THE PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE
ALSO BE PRIORITIZED IN A PART OF
THE CONVERSATION. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR ALLOWING PUBLIC HEALTH
TO BE INCLUDED IN THIS
DISCUSSION TODAY AND I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WILL
NOW BRING IT UP TO THE DYESS AND
KEEP IT WITH THE CHAIR RIGHT
NOW- I'M GONNA FOCUS ON PAGE
THIRTY TWO OF THE AGENDA AND
ALMOST GO SEQUENTIALLY THROUGH
THE PROPER POSTAL'S TASK. I'M
GONNA BEGIN WE AGE BECAUSE I ON
THE COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS
PROPOSAL. I'D FIRST LIKE TO
UNDERSTAND HOW DID WE DECIDE ON
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKERS HAS A NICE RING
BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. BUT I'M
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND IF THIS
CURRENT ROUND OF FUNDING WILL BE
SUFFICIENT TO GET US TO THAT
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND WILL IT
REQUIRE FUTURE YEAR INVESTMENTS
FOR US TO GET TO THAT TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND. BY TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE. THANK YOU DR REHM
REALISTICALLY IN TERMS OF. WHY
WE WEAR WHY WE SETTLED ON THAT
AMOUNT I THINK WE'RE DEFINITELY
TRYING TO BE BOLD AND MEET THIS
MOMENT- I CERTAINLY AGREE WITH
THAT THE L. A- THAT ADDITIONAL
RESEARCH IS NEEDED BUT WE- THINK
THERE'S A VERY UNIQUE MOMENT IN
TIME RIGHT NOW- WHERE FOLKS ARE
WRECKED OUR OUR RECOGNIZING
HEALTH DISPARITIES. WHERE MEDIC
CALLOUS TRYING TO GET COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKERS- CERTIFIED-
THEY'VE TRYING TO GET
REIMBURSEMENT FOR THEM SO WE'RE
WE'RE TRYING TO REALLY BE BOWLS-
WILL HOLD WITH THIS PROPOSAL WE
THINK THERE'S A HUGE UNMET
NEEDS- FOR THESE CULTURAL
LINGUISTIC AMBASSADORS. TO OUR
COMMUNITY. HOPING YOU COULD DO
AGAIN WITH THE MONEY ALUMNUS HAD
SAID ABOUT THE NEED FOR
SUSTAINABILITY THAT CBO SHOULD
BE. RESOURCE AND WANTS TO.
COMBINE THE NEW COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKER SERVICE BENEFIT THAT WILL
BE COMING OUT AS WELL WILL THAT
HELP US TO CREATE THAT
SUSTAINABILITY OR- HOW DO YOU
ENVISION BEING ABLE TO SUPPORT
THOSE CBO'S- WHO WILL BE
EMPLOYING THOSE COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS. WE DO HOPE THAT THE
THAT THE NEW BENEFIT WILL
HEALTH- WITHIN SUSTAINABILITY
PEAS AND ALSO WANT TO RECOGNIZE
THAT EACH EACH CBO NEEDS
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKER AND FROM
WHAT I HAS TO DECIDE WHETHER
THEY WANT TO WORK WITHIN THAT
SYSTEM OR NOT SO I THINK OUR
GOAL. IS TO CREATE A STRUCTURE-
FOR THOSE COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS AND FROM A TAURUS YOU
CHOOSE TO CHOOSE TO GET THIS NEW
CERTIFICATE NOT TO MANDATE THAT
ANYONE DOES SO- AND WE DO THINK
THAT MEDIC CAL WILL PROVIDE AN
IMPORTANT FUNDING SOURCE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- I DON'T MAKE TO
FUND. PLEASE DO- I THINK THERE'S
A MISCONCEPTION ABOUT THE- THE
MEDICAL TOUCH MENTOR THEM UP TO
THE FUNDS ALSO FOR THOSE THAT
ARE THAT HOW ABOUT OUR MANY CAL
PROVIDERS IT THE MONEY AND THE
ELIGIBILITY IS NOT FOR COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS WHICH ARE
WHICH IS THE COMMITTEE FROM
OTHER PEACE. AND SO WE'RE ASKING
FOR A CUT OUT TO GO BACK AND
THIS IS I THINK WEBER NAY AND
DID SHE HAS TO DO WITH FOR THIS
PHAM AND THAT WAS INCLUDE THE
POSSIBILITY THE CBO'S COULD
RECEIVE FUNDS DIRECTLY TO
SUPPORT THE HIRING OF. THE REST
OF THE COMMUNITY AS OPPOSED TO
THEM HAVING TO BE ASSIGNED OR
WORK FOR A MEDICAL PROVIDER.
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND WILL
FOLLOW UP WITH MORE DETAILS I
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THE
COMPREHENSIVE NURSING
INITIATIVE- THE FIRST I WOULD
APPRECIATE A BIT MORE DETAIL- ON
THIS PART OF THE PROPOSAL HAPPY
FOR THAT. TO HAPPEN OFFLINE. BUT
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO BE MORE
INVOLVED WITHTHE DEVELOPMENT
AND IMPLEMENTATION IF POSSIBLE
ON THIS PRO ON THIS PROGRAM
SPECIFICALLY. BUT I WANT TO
FOLLOW UP ON THE TWENTY PROGRAM
GRANTS THAT WERE LISTED AGAIN
I'M GONNA BEAT THAT DRUM. HOW
ARE WE DECIDING THOSE LOCATIONS
AND REGIONS ARE WE FOCUSING ON
THE IMPACT AND PROGRAMS THAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE HOPING YOU CAN
COMMENT ON THAT. YEAH I'M NOT
SURE WHICH TWENTY PROGRAMS
YOU'RE REFERRING TO AN ALL ASK
KAREN REYES L. TO JUMP IN IF
SHE'S MORE FAMILIAR. SENATOR
AREN'T OUR NURSING PROGRAM IT IS
A IS PROPOSED NEW WHAT ARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT EXISTING SONG
BROWN SUPPORT FOR OUR AND
PROGRAMS ON PAGE THIRTY TWO OF
THE AGENDA UNDER THE NURSING
INITIATIVE AND STATED THAT THERE
WILL BE TWENTY. TRAINING PROGRAM
GRANTS FOR NURSES AND OTHER YES
SECTIONALS AND- THAT'S THE
COMMENT I WAS ASKING ABOUT.
THANK YOU DR ARAMBULA SO YES WE
DID DO- WE DID DO THE BUDGETING
TO ADD TO DETERMINE WHAT. YOU
KNOW YOU WILL HAVE BEEN VERY
CLEAR AND RIGHTLY SO ASKING US
WHAT ARE WE GETTING FOR OUR
DOLLARS SO- THEY THIS IS DATA
THAT THAT H. CAI PROVIDED TO THE
LEGISLATURE TO SPELL OUT- WHAT
THESE DOLLARS. COULD SUPPORT. I
WILL THEN MOVE ON TO THE SOCIAL
WORKERS AND APOLOGIZE IF THE
QUESTIONS ARE HARSH I AM JUST
TRYING TO. ASK QUESTIONS AS I
BELIEVE THEY NEED TO BE ASKED.
BUT I'D LIKE TO UNDERSTAND YOUR
REASONING FOR- PROPOSING
RESOURCES FOR OVER FORTY FIVE
HUNDRED LOAN REPAYMENTS. FOR OUR
NURSES AND YET ONLY FUNDING TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY LOAN
REPAYMENTS FOR OUR SOCIAL
WORKERS. HOPING YOU CAN COMMENT
ON THE SCALE AND DISCREPANCIES
BETWEEN THOSE TWO PROPOSALS. I
THINK IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
CERTAINLY STILL LOOKING AT DARK
ARAMBULA AND SO I THINK WE DO
NEED TO DIG INTO THE DATA A
LITTLE BIT MORE AND WE DO FIND
THAT THAT. NEEDS TO BE ADJUSTED-
SO I CERTAINLY HEAR YOUR POINT.
AND I DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S
ANYTHING YOU WANT TO ADD ON
THAT. NOPE AND WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
CERTAINLY HAPPY TO. HAPPY TO
LOOK AT DR RAM VILAS. I THINK-
YOU KNOW. YET YEAH THAT'S WHAT
THAT'S ALL ABOUT THE- BUT I
WILL- I APPRECIATED ALL THE
COMMENTARY THUS FAR ON
PSYCHIATRIC RESIDENCIES- I WOULD
LIKE TO INCLUDE A FOCUS ON CHILD
PSYCHIATRY EXPLICITLY. AND I'M
HOPEFUL THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
IN THIS PROPOSAL IS FOCUSING ON
CHILD PSYCHIATRY AND HOPING THAT
YOU CAN PROVIDE COMMENT. WELL
ACTUALLY- OUR CURRENT AND ELIA
REFERRED TO THIS CURRENTLY WERE
OR IMPLEMENTING THE CHILD AND
YOU'VE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE WHICH DOES INCLUDE
DOLLARS FOR PSYCHIATRIC
RESIDENCY PROGRAM SUPPORT AND SO
THERE WAS WE WILL CERTAINLY-
HAVE A PARTICULAR FOCUS ON.
PROGRAMS THAT THAT THAT OUR
TRAINING CHILD PSYCHIATRISTS-
AND THIS IS MORE OPEN BUT BUT
CERTAINLY KNOWLEDGE THAT THE
IMPORTANT I NEED THEIR- I'D LIKE
TO NOW TRANSITION TO THE OPIOD.
RESPONSE INITIATIVES AND- GIVEN
THAT WE'RE CURRENTLY IN THE
MIDST OF AN OPIOID AND
SPECIFICALLY A FENTANYL OVERDOSE
CRISIS RIGHT NOW I'M BOTH VERY
PLEASED AND SUPPORTIVE OF THE
RESOURCES THAT YOU HAVE DONE FOR
PROVIDER TRAINING HOWEVER GIVEN
THE SIZE OF THE CRISIS THAT WE
ARE FACING IS IT POSSIBLE THAT
WE NEED MORE RESOURCES THAN
TWENTY TWO MILLION. IT MAY WELL
BE AND I DO WANT TO KNOW THIS IS
THIS IS ONLY ONE PIECE AND
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THEY WANT
TO COMMENT ABOUT HOW THE- HELL
THAT ADDITIONAL OF. SETTLEMENT
DOLLARS ARE BEING USED I WOULD
KNOW THAT UNDER THE CHILDREN
pINITIATIVES WE HAVE A LITTLE
DOLLARS FOR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER SERVICES AND ARE HIGHLY
AWARE OF THE FACT THAT- SO MANY
FOLKS ARE STARTING- THEIR
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER AT AT A
YOUNG AGE- AS TEENAGERS THAT
THAT'S REALLY XCELERATED. WITH
OVERDOSES AMONG MANY PEOPLE
THEIR YOUNG TWENTIES SO JUST
WANT TO KNOW THAT WE'RE ALSO
LOOKING TO THE YOUTH INITIATIVE
SAID SELLERS AS WELL- IN THIS
AREA. RECOGNIZING THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION IS
NOT HERE ON THIS PANEL WITH
REGARDS TO THE VOCATIONAL.
REHABILITATION COMPONENT OF THIS
PROPOSAL ON PAGE THIRTY THREE.
THE PROPOSAL STATES THAT THE
PILOT WILL TRAIN THE OPIOID
PROVIDER WORK FORCE ON HOW TO
INCLUDE. EMPLOYMENT SERVICES AS
PART OF PARTICIPATION IN THE
TREATMENT. DO WE INCLUDE
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES AND MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT. OR IN OTHER
SUBSTANCE ABUSE NOT JUST OPIOID
TREATMENT. IF NOT WHY NOT AND
WOULD THAT NOT BE BENEFICIAL. I
DO NOT KNOW THE ANSWER TO THAT
QUESTION I THINK IT'S AN
EXCELLENT POINT THAT ANYONE
WHO'S- RECOVERING FROM OF SAYS
WITH SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER NEED
SUPPORT IN MANY AREAS OF THEIR
LIFE INCLUDING EMPLOYMENT
SERVICES. FINAL QUESTION I'D
LIKE TO FOLLOW UP ON WHAT
MICHELLE GIBBONS- STATED. IN
ASKING WHY WE HAVE NOT INCLUDED
OR INVOLVED PUBLIC HEALTH THUS
FAR. AS I'M QUITE SENSITIVE TO
MANY OF THE PIPELINE CHALLENGES
THAT THEY ARE STATING AS WELL
AS- THE TURNOVER AND ATTRITION
THAT'S OCCURRED TO THROUGH THIS
PANDEMIC. THAT I WANNA MAKE SURE
WERE DOING WHAT WE CAN TO
RECRUIT MORE INTO PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND I'M HOPEFUL TO ENGAGE THE
ADMINISTRATION AND CONVERSATIONS
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO BE ABLE TO
BUDGET AND RESOURCE FOR THAT AS
WELL. HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP OFFLINE
BUT- MAYBE I JUST WILL ASK WHY
WASN'T PUBLIC HEALTH INVOLVED IN
THIS CARICOM IN WORKFORCE
PROPOSAL. OKAY WELL OF COURSE
ACT ARAMBULA I'M NOT ABLE TO
SPEAK THE PUBLIC HEALTH- BUDGET
I WOULD NOTE- AS MICHELLE GIVE
INSTEAD THAT A NUMBER OF THE-
PROFESSIONS THAT WERE LOOKING TO
SUPPORT SUCH AS NURSES. ARE
INCLUDED IN PUBLIC HEALTH H.
CHI- TRADITIONALLY HAS FOCUSED
ON PRIMARY CARE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AND DENTAL CARE SO WE DO
NOT HAVE PROGRAMS FOR
MICROBIOLOGISTS EPIDEMIOLOGISTS
VERY IMPORTANT WORK- IT LOOKS
LIKE MAYBE A DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS WANTING TO JUMP IN.
YOUR OPINION CATHARINE CLARK
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
JUST NOTING THAT ARE. IN THE
BUDGET YEAR WE HAVE THREE
HUNDRED MILLION PROGRAMS FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
INCLUDING SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS AND WORKFORCE. I
STILLWANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
ASPECT OF THE BUDGET THANK YOU I
WOULD LIKE TO THEN FOLLOW UP MY
UNDERSTANDING IS TWO HUNDRED
MILLION OF THAT IS GOING TO
LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS TO
HELP US WITH. CURRENT STAFF. BUT
THAT ISN'T HELPING US TO RECRUIT
AND CREATE A PIPELINE FOR.
FUTURE PUBLIC HEALTH- EMPLOYEES
AND- OR MAYBE I SHOULD ASK
FINANCES ANY OF THAT THREE
HUNDRED MILLION HELPFUL FOR US
TO RECRUIT OR TO CREATE A
PIPELINE OR IS THAT SOLELY FOR
CURRENT EMPLOYEES. SHARE
ARAMBULA THIS IS MICHELLE
GIBBONS AB WHEN YOU GET A MOMENT
I'M HAPPY TO RESPOND TO THAT AS
WELL. LET'S BEGIN WITH YOU AS
FINANCE APPEARS TO BE HAVING
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES. SURE SO
AS YOU HAD MENTIONED- LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ARE GETTING
TWO HUNDRED MILLION ONGOING
HOWEVER THAT'S NOT NECESSARILY
AROUND RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION
STRATEGIES THAT'S REALLY FOCUSED
ON EXPANDING OUR WORKFORCE
CAPACITY SO AS YOU KNOW AT THE
START OF THE PANDEMIC WE WERE
WOEFULLY UNDERSTAFFED THOSE
THOSE THAT ADDITIONAL FUNDING IS
REALLY TO SUPPORT ADDING STAFF
TO OUR DEPARTMENTS. BUT WHAT THE
CHALLENGE IS GOING TO BE IS THAT
WE'RE GONNA NEED SUPPORTS TO
RECRUIT AND RETAIN THEM AND ALSO
TO TRAIN THEM AT LEAST THE NEW
HAN SAID OF STAFF WE HAVE A LOT
OF TRAINING TO DO AND SO THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR IS FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH TO BE A PART OF
THAT CONVERSATION AND TO REALLY
FORGE A PATH EVEN WITH EACH GUY.
TO CREATE AND SUSTAIN A
WORKFORCE PIPELINE THANK YOU.
WITH THAT I WOULD. LIKE TO THANK
VERY MUCH PANEL SEVEN WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO PANEL EIGHT. ON
THE EXCISE TAX ON ELECTRONIC
CIGARETTES. WE WILL HAVE ONE
PRESENTER ON THIS PANEL MOLD.
JEREMY MARYON DEPUTY DIRECTOR.
OF THE CAL MORTGAGE LOAN
INSURANCE DIVISION AT AGE KILEY
CAN YOU PLEASE BEGIN. GOOD
AFTERNOON HI I'M JP MILLION
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF EACH SIDE'S
CAL MORTGAGE LOAN INSURANCE
PROGRAM. AND SENATE BILL SENATE
PASSED SENATE BILL THREE NINETY
FIVE CREATES AN EXCISE TAX ON
ELECTRONIC CIGARETTES OF TWELVE
AND A HALF PERCENT ON THE SALES
PRICE. COLLECTED BY RETAILERS
BEGINNING JULY ONE OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. OF THE TOTAL TAXES
COLLECTED 5% WILL GO TO H. TIES
HEALTH PROFESSIONS CAREER
OPPORTUNITY PROGRAM AND 10% WILL
GO TO A NEW PROGRAM TO BE
DEVELOPED WITHIN H. GUY. CALLED
THE SMALL AND RURAL HOSPITAL
RELIEF PROGRAM. REGARDING THE
HEALTH PROFESSIONS CAREER
OPPORTUNITY PROGRAM H. K.
MINISTERS PROGRAMS FOR BUILDING
A DIVIDER DIVERSE PROVIDER
WORKFORCE. SUCH AS A HEALTH
CAREER EXPLORATION PROGRAM AND
PIPELINE PROGRAMS THAT PROVIDE
COMPREHENSIVE ACADEMIC
ENRICHMENT CAREER DEVELOPMENT
MENTORSHIP AND ADVISING TO
SUPPORT STUDENTS FROM
UNDERREPRESENTED REGIONS AND
BACKGROUNDS. TO PURSUE HEALTH
CAREERS. H. KABALI USE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THESE FUNDS
GOING INTO THIS PROGRAM FROM S.
B. THREE NINETY FIVE CAN BE
ABSORBED WITH EXISTING STAFF.
THE NEW SMALL AND RURAL HOSPITAL
RELIEF PROGRAM WILL AWARD
FINANCIAL GRANTS TO SMALL RURAL
AND CRITICAL ACCESS HOSPITALS
THAT NEED TO PERFORM SEISMIC
UPGRADES WITHIN THEIR FACILITIES
TO ACHIEVE SEISMIC COMPLIANCE
WITH EXISTING LAW REQUIRING
GENERAL ACUTE CARE HOSPITALS TO
COMPLY WITH SPECIFIC SIZE MADE
STATEMENTS SEISMIC SAFETY
REQUIREMENTS. BY JANUARY ONE
TWENTY THIRTY. THIS BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL REQUESTS FOR
POSITIONS AND FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
CONTRACT FUNDING TO ADMINISTER
THE PROGRAM. NOW KAREN RIGHTS AL
WILL PROVIDE AN UPDATE ON THE
HEALTH PROFESSIONS CAREER
OPPORTUNITY PROGRAM. YES SO I
JUST WANTED TO FOLLOW AND
PROVIDE AN UPDATE ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF OUR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT
AUGMENTATION PROGRAM EXPANSION
FOR THE HEALTH PROFESSIONS
CAREERS OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAM.
SO IN ADDITION TO THE FUNDING
FROM THE IMPLEMENTATION OF SB
THREE NINETY FIVE H. I RECEIVED
SIXTEEN MILLION ONGOING FUNDING
. ROUNDS IS TO ORGANIZE AND
BUILD HEALTH WORKFORCE PIPELINE
PROGRAMS UNDER THAT. RUSSIAN
CAREER OPPORTUNITY PROGRAM
PORTFOLIO WE ARE CURRENTLY
DEVELOPING A NEW PIPELINE
PROGRAM THAT WILL FOCUS ON
PROVIDING A VARIETY OF
ACTIVITIES JUSTICE FOR
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS TO
SUCCESSFULLY PERFECT PURSUE
HEALTH CAREER EDUCATION
HEALTHCARE CAREERS EXPECTED OPEN
THE SPENDING CYCLE IN MID TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. WE ALSO ON MEDICARE
HEALTH CAREER EXPLORATION
PROGRAM FORMERLY MANY GRANTS
PROGRAM TO SUPPORT CURRENT
EXPLORATION GRANTS. A RECENT
APPLICATION CYCLE DOES CLOSE
THEN WE RECEIVED THIRTY SIX
APPLICATIONS FOR REVIEW. AND
FINALLY IN THE BUDGET ACT WE
RECEIVED IN POINT FIVE MILLION
TO SUPPORT THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL SCHOLARS PROGRAM. THIS
GRANT AGREEMENT EXECUTION IS IN
ITS FINAL STAGES AND SO THAT
PROGRAM WILL BEGIN OPERATING
THIS YEAR. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- I WILL NOW BRING IT
UP TO THE DÍAS FOR QUESTIONS
I'M- IT IT SHOULD BE PRETTY
OBVIOUS I'M A HUGE FAN OF THE
HEALTH PROFESSION CAREER
OPPORTUNITY PROGRAM. BUT I'D
LIKE TO FOLLOW UP AND UNDERSTAND
YOU SAID IT WAS OPENING IN MID
TWENTY TWENTY TWO SINCE IT WAS
BUDGET DIDN'T LAST YEAR'S.
BUDGET WHAT'S GOING TO OCCUR
THAT FUNDING IS IT GOING TO
START IN MID OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO AND WHEN YOU GET ANOTHER
ROUND OF FUNDING- AS YOU STATED
IT WAS ONGOING AT. MIDDLE OF
JUNE- HOW ARE WE GOING TO ENSURE
THAT THESE FUNDS ARE. BEING
EFFECTIVELY SPENT AND WHAT
HAPPENED WITH LAST YEAR'S.
BUDGET ALLOCATION. I'M GOOD
QUESTION SO WHAT WE'VE BEEN
SPENDING TIME DOING IS
DEVELOPING THAT PROGRAM WHAT WE
WANT TO DO IS MEET WITH- OTHERS
AND LEARN ABOUT WHAT ELEMENTS WE
NEED TO INCLUDE IN THE PROGRAM
SO I'VE BEEN IN THE PROCESS OF
BUILDING AND- KIND OF DEVELOPING
WHAT THE FRAMEWORK WITH THIS
PROGRAM WOULD INCLUDE- TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE- TRYING TO. DEVELOP
AS ROBUST AND COMPREHENSIVE OF A
PIPELINE PROGRAM- THAT
ORGANIZATIONS COULD PARTICIPATE
IN SO WE'VE BEEN DOING FROM OUR
PLANNING AND- DESIGN WORK- IN
LIGHT OF WHAT WE TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER TODAY I WANT TO ENSURE
THAT THE 5% OF REVENUE WILL NOT
BE SUPPLANTING. ANY OF THE
CURRENT SIXTEEN MILLION HONG
GOING THAT WE HAVE AN REVENUE
AND INSTEAD WILL BE GOING TO
HELP TO SCALE THE PROGRAM AND
HOPING YOU CAN CLARIFY THAT.
EXACTLY THAT'S THE PURPOSE IS
THAT THIS WILL BE ABLE TO
AUGMENT FACT FINDING AND BUILD A
STRONGER PIPELINE PROGRAM. I'LL
TALK A LITTLE BIT LATER BUT
WE'RE ALSO WITH SOME WITH
CHILDREN AND YOUTH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH INITIATIVE DOLLARS- YOU
KNOW THAT WE RECOGNIZE THAT WE
WANT TO BUILD A PIPELINE THAT
SUPPORTS PRIMARY CARE OF SPORTS
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SUPPORTS
ALLIED HEALTH. I'M SORT OF
REALLY THAT THIS KIND OF
SPENDING IS BASED FUNDING AND
THEN WE'RE ABLE TO ADD
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO IT TO
BUILD A PROGRAM THAT REACHES
MORE STUDENTS. I'D LIKE TO
TRANSITION NOW TO ON PAGE THIRTY
SIX OF OUR AGENDA WHERE WE TALK
ABOUT THE HOSPITAL. SEISMIC
RELIEF PROGRAM. I WOULD LIKE TO
UNDERSTAND HOW MUCH REVENUE THE
STATE EXPECTS THE TAX WILL
GENERATE BY TWENTY THIRTY. AND
WHAT ARE THE ESTIMATED COSTS FOR
US TO UPGRADE THE REMAINING TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE
HOSPITAL BUILDINGS THAT WERE
IDENTIFIED IN THE AGENDA. IN
OTHER WORDS IS THERE A LARGE GAP
IN FUNDING. THAT'S NEEDED TO
ENSURE THAT ALL OF CALIFORNIA
SMALL AND RURAL HOSPITALS WILL
BE SEISMICALLY COMPLIANT. AND IF
WE DON'T HAVE SUFFICIENT
FUNDING. HOW DO WE PRIORITIZE
THE LIMITED FUNDING FOR THIS
PURPOSE IT'S- REGARDING THE- HOW
MUCH REVENUE IS GOING TO BE
HEADED TO THE- TO THE SMALL
RURAL HOSPITAL RELIEF PROGRAM-
THE PROJECTIONS ARE SHOWING THAT
IT'S ABOUT- TWO MILLION DOLLARS
A YEAR. FOR THE FIRST TWELVE
MONTHS AND- THERE. IT'S SOLELY
DRIVEN BY THE- THE TAX REVENUES
COLLECTED ON THE SALES OF E.
CIGARETTES SO- IT COULD BE
VARIABLE BY THAT BUT THE
PROJECTIONS ARE ABOUT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS REGARDING THE-
THAT THAT GAP IN TERMS OF- IS
THERE A GAP BETWEEN. THE FUNDING
AVAILABLE THROUGH THIS PROGRAM
AND WHAT'S NEEDED I WOULD SAY
IT'S SAFE TO SAY THAT THERE IS A
WIDE GAP- HOWEVER REGARDING- THE
SEISMIC STATISTICS I'M GOING TO
ASK THAT CARL SURE MEN JUMP IN
HERE- WHO IS A- WORKS WITHIN
FACILITIES DEVELOPMENT DIVISIONS
SEISMIC COMPLIANCE UNIT TO
ADDRESS YOUR QUESTION FOR THEIR-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND- AND-
CHAIR. ARAMBULA THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE QUESTION R. TWO
MILLION DOLLARS WHEN IT COMES
TO- BUILDING IMPROVEMENT IS A
VERY SMALL NUMBER- ESPECIALLY
GIVEN THE NUMBER OF BUILDINGS
THAT ARE IN NEED. SO AS WE LOOK
AT SPENDING UP THE PROGRAM ARE
AND KNOWING THAT WE HAVE VERY
FEW DOLLARS- IT TO BEGIN WITH.
WE'RE LOOKING AT- THE CONDITION
OF THE BUILDINGS AND ATTEMPTING
TO ESTIMATE THEIR- WITH THE BOND
CAPITAL NECESSARY AND THE FACT
IS THAT WE SIMPLY DON'T HAVE THE
INFORMATION ON FILE NECESSARY TO
TELL US WHAT THE CONDITION OF
THESE BUILDINGS ARE. MOST OF
THEM ACHEVED A. R. A. N. S. B.
C. TO PERFORMANCE RATING THROUGH
THE HOUSES PROCESS WHICH DOES
NOT REQUIRE THAT THE BUILDINGS
BE EVALUATED THEREFORE WE DON'T
REALLY HAVE AN IDEA OF THEIR
DEFICIENCY. TO MOVE THE PROGRAM
FORWARD AND TO HELP ANSWER THE
QUESTION THAT YOUPOSED AS WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE INITIAL ROUND OF
FUNDING AVAILABLE- WE ARE
INTENDING TO LOOK CLOSELY AT
THOSE FACILITIES THAT HAVE NOT
DONE THEIR SEISMIC EVALUATIONS
YET. IN TERMS OF IDENTIFYING
WITH THE BUILDINGS DEFICIENCIES
ARE AND THOSE ARE RELATIVELY LOW
COST- STUDIES WHERE WE CAN VERY
QUICKLY UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
DEMAND IS ACROSS THE ENTIRE
STATE FOR THIS CATEGORY OF
FACILITY AND I WOULD HOPE THAT
BABY BY- MIDDLE OF TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. WE WOULD HAVE A MUCH
BETTER ABILITY TO ESTIMATE THAT. AS OF TODAY WE DO NOT HAVE
THAT. FOLLOWING UP ON THAT AND-
SO IT SOUNDED LIKE YOUR
PRIORITIZATION THEN WAS TO FOCUS
ON THE HOSPITALS THAT CURRENTLY
HAVE NOT DONE A SEISMIC
EVALUATION IS THAT CORRECT BUT
NOT ABOUT TO FIX ANY OF THE TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE
BUILDINGS THAT HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED AS NEEDING
IMPROVEMENT. IT WOULD BE VERY
EASY FOR ONE VERY BADLY DESIGNED
COMPLIANCE PROGRAM TO ABSORB ALL
OF THE FUNDS ARE AVAILABLE. SO
IT IS NECESSARY TO ASSURE RIGHT
UP FRONT TO THAT THE MONEY IS
BEING SPENT WISELY AND THAT'S
WHERE WE'RE LOOKING AT. PUTTING
THE MONEY FIRST- I WILL PUT A
PIN IN THIS CONVERSATION AND YET
I BELIEVE IT NEEDS TO BE
DISCUSSED WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. AS WE ARE HAVING
A BROADER DISCUSSION ABOUT
AFFORDABILITY HOW ARE ABLE TO
MEET THE ALL QUEST ACT AND
ADDRESS THE NUMBER OF BUILDINGS
IN OUR STATE. IS A VERY
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION FOR US TO
HAVE AND JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THAT IT DOES NOT. APPEAR
APPARENT BASED ON THE
CONVERSATION TODAY THAT THE
FUNDS FROM THIS EXCISE TAX WILL
BE SUFFICIENT TO ADDRESS. THE
UNDERLYING NEED AND THUS WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE COME BACK TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE THAT CONVERSATION
LATER. WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK VERY MUCH PANEL EIGHT WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON THE PANEL NINE
WHICH IS ON THE H. BECAUSE I
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE WORK
FORCE IN CAPITAL INFRASTRUCTURE
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL. WE WILL
HAVE ONE PRESENTER ON THIS PANEL
PANEL IT WILL BE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
KAREN RESULT WITH H. CAI PLEASE
BEGIN. I'M SO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET INCLUDES ONE
TIME SPENDING OF FORTY MILLION
GENERAL FUND THE H. CARE SUPPORT
ACCESS TO REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
SERVICES. I'M THERE ARE TWO
PARTS TO THIS PROPOSAL. H.
PRAYER WILL DIRECT TWENTY
MILLION GENERAL FUND TOWARD
EXISTING SCHOLARSHIP AND LOAN
REPAYMENT PROGRAMS. FOR
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE PROVIDERS. WHICH
INCLUDES CAN INCLUDE PHYSICIANS
NURSE MIDWIVES PHYSICIANS
ASSISTANTS. AND NURSE
PRACTITIONERS WHO COMMIT TO
PROVIDING REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE. USING EXISTING PROGRAM
INFRASTRUCTURE ENABLES US H. CRY
TO INCREASE THE WAR TO
PRACTITIONERS MORE QUICKLY THAN
DEVELOPING A NEW PROGRAM. THESE
PROGRAMS INCLUDE FOR EXAMPLE THE
CALIFORNIA'S DAILY REPAYMENT
PROGRAM STEPHEN M. THOMPSON
PHYSICIAN OR MONEY PAYMENTS AND
THE ADVANCED PRACTICE HEALTHCARE
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAMS. H. CHI
WILL ALSO DIRECT TWENTY MILLION
TOWARDS ASSISTING HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES TO ADDRESS CAPITAL
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS INCLUDING
SECURITY AND PRIVACY PROTECTIONS
BROADLY. BASILIDES SECURITY
CYBER SECURITY SECURITY
PERSONNEL AND RELATED FOR
TRAINING STAFF. H. CAR WILL WORK
WITH THE MANAGING ORGANIZATIONS
TO IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAM TO
ADMINISTER THESE ONE TIME FUNDS
. PROVIDERS OF REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH SERVICES WE'VE TALKED
WITH CAROL- YES ABOUT A GRANT
PROGRAM DAVID MINISTERS IN THE
PAST FOR A SIMILAR PURPOSE AND
PROVIDER ORGANIZATIONS. WE PLAN
TO EXPLORE POTENTIAL INTER
AGENCY AGREEMENT WITH CALLAWAY
YES TO LEVERAGE ITS EXISTING
PROGRAM INFRASTRUCTURE ALREADY
IN PLACE FOR THIS COMPONENT OF
FINDING. OUT WE HAVE SET AT NINE
POINT FIVE MILLION PROGRAM IN
TWENTY TWENTY WHO CURRENTLY HAS
A FORTY SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION
NONPROFIT SECURITY GRANT PROGRAM
IT IS A MYSTERY FOR TWENTY
TWENTY TWO SO WE THINK THAT WE
COULD APARTMENT WITHOUT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I WILL
THANK PANEL NINE WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO A PANEL TEN ON H. CAI
WORKFORCE AUGMENTATION AND
BUDGET ALIGNMENT B. C. P. WE
WILL HAVE ONE PRESENTER ON HERE
WHO WILL BE MONICA ERICKSON THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES DIVISION
ACT H. CARLY PLEASE BEGIN DEPUTY
DIRECTOR ERICSON. HE VERY MUCH
DOCTOR ARAMBULA GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE MONICA ERICKSON
ADMINISTRATIVE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
THIS PROPOSAL REQUEST FOR NET
ZERO SHIFT BETWEEN STATE
OPERATIONS AND LOCAL AFFECT
THEM. AND YOUR POINT EIGHT
MILLION OF WHICH TWO POINT SEVEN
MILLION ITS ONGOING H. KALRA
QUITE ONGOING REIMBURSEMENT
AUTHORITY FOR TO HELP WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS. THE
PHILLIP PROGRAM IS THE COUNTY
MEDICAL SERVICES LOAN REPAYMENT
PROGRAM AND INCLUDES MULTI YEAR
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGES WE EXPECT
EIGHT FIVE WORK TO CONTINUE WITH
THE COUNTY MEDICAL SERVICES
PROGRAM. AND THE SECOND IS THE
SONG BROWN HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE
TRAINING PROGRAM THE PROGRAM
RECEIVED REIMBURSEMENT FROM THE
U. S. B. AT THE TIME OF
LICENSURE ORDINAL POSITION CAN
MAKE A TWENTY FIVE DOLLAR
VOLUNTARY CONTRIBUTION AND THE
UC'S WILL MATCH THIS
CONTRIBUTION. NEARLY
CONTRIBUTIONS ARE STEADILY
INCREASING AND H. K. WILL NOT
HAVE THE REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY
TO AWARD THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING
. SECONDLY WE REQUEST AN
INCREASE IN THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH DATA AND PLANNING FUNDS
FOR THE MANY GRANTS PROGRAM THE
MANY GRANTS PROGRAM IS A
PIPELINE PROGRAM THAT SUPPORTS
UNDERREPRESENTED ECONOMICALLY
AND EDUCATIONALLY DISADVANTAGED
STUDENTS. INTERESTED OF
HEALTHCARE CAREERS DURING THE
PAST RECYCLED H. CHI HAS
RECEIVED BETWEEN TWENTY EIGHT
AND FORTY ONE GRANT APPLICATIONS
PER YEAR AND HAS ONLY BEEN ABLE
TO AWARD EIGHT. FINALLY WE
REQUEST A ONE TIME INCREASE THAT
WOULD ALLOW H. CHI TO REWARD
FUND RETURNED BY A RESIDENCY
PROGRAM THAT SUPPORTS THE
EDUCATION AND TRAINING OF
PRIVATE OF RESIDENCE. IN
ADDITION TO THESE INCREASES H. I
REQUEST THE BUDGET ALIGNMENT
THAT WOULD MOVE TWO POINT ONE
MILLION FROM STATE OPERATIONS
THE LOCAL ASSISTANCE. THEY
SHIPPED WOULD REFLECT THE
CURRENT OPERATION OF THE CARE
PERSONNEL AND MANY GRANTS
PROGRAM- THAT CONCLUDES MY
PRESENTATION IF THERE ARE ANY
QUESTIONS HAPPY TO ANSWER THEM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'LL STAY
WITH THAT YOUR PERSONAL TRAINING
AND PLACEMENT PROGRAM AND WOULD
LIKE TO HEAR HOW IT CONNECTS
WITH THE NEW BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROGRAMS AND INVESTMENTS THAT WE
ARE DISCUSSING. AS WELL AS-
QUESTIONING ON THE TOP OF PAGE
FORTY TWO IF ANY OF THOSE
FIFTEEN SITES THAT HAVE BEEN
SELECTED ARE- IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY SAYS I DON'T RECOGNIZE
ANY OF THOSE. AND HOPING. YOU
COULD COMMENT STARTING THEIR-
THANK YOU DR I GO AHEAD AND PASS
THIS ON TO MY COLLEAGUE KAREN
REBELS WITH THE PROGRAM EXPERT
IN THIS AREA THANK YOU.
CERTAINLY I'M SO THE PAIR
PERSONAL. TRAINING AND PLACEMENT
PROGRAM- YOU KNOW FUNDS GRANTS
TO TRAINING ORGANIZATIONS.
PUBLIC PRIVATE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS RECRUIT TRAINING
PLACE INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE LIVED
EXPERIENCE- IN IN AND IN
DESIGNATED YOUR POSITIONS- AND
SO. THEY RE DID AWARD FIFTEEN
ORGANIZATIONS THIS LAST YEAR
AND- I JUST WANTED TO GET MY
INFORMATION THAT. OF THOSE FIVE
OF THE GRANT TEAMS WERE ACTUALLY
PROVIDING SERVICES IN CENTRAL
VALLEY AREAS- IS THAT MANY OF
THE GRANTEES HAVE ARE. YOU
SERVICES ACROSS. MULTIPLE
COUNTIES. AND SO AND SO FIVE OF
THEM ARE PROVIDING SERVICES IN
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY. AND WITH
PLANS TO SERVE OVER INCREASE THE
NUMBER. OF PERSONNEL BY OVER
FIVE HUNDRED. I LOOK FORWARD TO
THAT FOLLOW IN. AND JUST BECAUSE
WERE FUNDING NAMI CALIFORNIA
DOESN'T INHERENTLY MEAN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IS SEEING. THE
SAME AMOUNT OF BENEFIT IS HAVING
A SPECIFIC PROGRAM AND TRAINING
CITED IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND SO
HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP WITH THE NEXT
LEVEL OF DETAIL I'D LIKE TO
THANK VERY MUCH PANEL TEN AND WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON. TO PANEL
ELEVEN WHICH WILL FOCUS ON THE
SPECIFIC CHALLENGES AND ISSUES
RELATED TO THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CARE WORK FORCE. WE WILL HAVE
FIVE PRESENTERS WHO ARE ON ON
THIS PANEL WE WILL BEGIN WITH
DEPUTY DIRECTOR KAREN RESULT OF
H. CHI. FOLLOWED BY DR RYAN
QUEST OF THE SACRAMENTO COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTOR. THEN
WE WILL HAVE DOCTOR JANET
COFFMAN WITH THE UC S. AB HELPED
FORCE CENTER AND THEN DOCTOR LEE
ANDREA CLARK HARVEY CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AGENCIES. AS
WELL AS TYLER RINDE THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ALCOHOL AND DRUG PROGRAM
EXECUTIVES. LET US BEGIN WITH
DEPUTY DIRECTOR RESULT. MACINNES
BEGAN- SO I WAS ASKED TO PROVIDE
AN OVERVIEW OF OUR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH WORKFORCE PROGRAMS I'LL
GIVE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF AN
UPDATE ON A VERY IS BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH WORKFORCE INVESTMENTS.
ARM THAT WERE PRESENTED IN THE
AGENDA ON PERSONAL PROVIDE AN
UPDATE ON THE FUNDING AND
ACCOMPLISHMENTS FOR THE FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY NINETEEN FIFTEEN
MILLION MENTAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
INVESTMENT. THIS FUNDING
PROVIDED FUNDING TO SUPPORT OF A
VARIETY OF MENTAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS AND I JUST
WANT TO SHARE SOME OF THAT.
ACCOMPLISHED OUT OF THIS FUNDING
IS WITH THIS FUNDING WE HAVE
AWARDED A HUNDRED SIXTY TWO
SCHOLARSHIPS TO PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDERS PARTICIPATING IN THE
UC IRVINE TRAINING TRAINERS
PRIMARY. CARE PSYCHIATRY
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM. WE MADE OVER
HUNDRED LOAN REPAYMENT AWARDS
SINCE FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. AND WITH THIS FUNDING
WE WERE ALSO ABLE TO AWARD TEN
ADDITIONAL ORGANIZATIONS FOR THE
PURE PERSONAL TRAINING PROGRAM
THAT I JUST TALKED ABOUT- THAT
WE WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
AWARD WHICH WILL RESULT IN ABOUT
ELEVEN HUNDRED MARKET PERSONAL
SPECIALISTS WILL BE TRAINED TO
SERVE. IN THE PUBLIC BE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SYSTEM. I ALSO
WANT TO TALK ABOUT OUR FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY NINETEEN BY FUNDING
FOR THAT WORKFORCE EDUCATION AND
TRAINING ARE WHAT INVESTMENT.
THAT BUDGET APPROPRIATED SIXTY
MILLION TOTAL FROM THE GENERAL
FUND IN MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ACT. WE HAVE AWARDED FORTY
MILLION TO YOU ARE FIVE WET
REGIONAL PARTNERSHIPS. THESE
BILLS FUNDING SUPPORTS THEM
BEING ABLE TO SCHOLARSHIP LONELY
PAYMENT STIPENDS RETENTION AND
PIPELINE ACTIVITIES. WE ESTIMATE
THAT THESE FUNDS WILL HELP
SUPPORT OVER TWO THOUSAND
MONTHLY PAYMENT AWARDS. AND
ABOUT THREE HUNDRED STATEMENT
JUST AS A AS. AN INDICATION OF
SOME OF THE WORK THAT WE DON'T.
ARM AS I MENTIONED EARLIER WITH
THIS FUNDING WE ESTABLISHED OUR
PSYCHIATRY EDUCATION CAPACITY
EXPANSION PROGRAM- WHICH I'VE
TALKED ABOUT IT AGAIN THAT'S
ABOUT EXPANDING- AT THE NUMBER
OF PSYCHIATRISTS IN PART AND
PSYCHIATRIC MENTAL HEALTH NURSE
PRACTITIONERS ARE TRAINED. ON
HAND WITH A FOCUS REALLY ON ALSO
TRAINING A JOB CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT- RESIDENCY PROGRAMS
THEN I'LL PROVIDE A QUICK UPDATE
ON OUR ACTIVITIES FOR THE
CHILDREN USE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE- WE RECEIVED EIGHT
HUNDRED MILLION IN FUNDING FOR
THAT INITIATIVE SPREAD ACROSS A
VARIETY OF. OUR WORKSTREAMS. ALL
HIGHLIGHTS SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT WE'RE DOING THERE- WE'RE
CREATING A NEW SCHOOL BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH COACH AND COUNSELOR
WORKFORCE. WHEN THE PROCESS OF
DOING STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT BY
MEETING WITH A VARIETY OF
STAKEHOLDERS IN EDUCATION AND
HEALTHCARE HELP US UNDERSTAND ON
HOW DOMESTIC TO DESIGN A
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH COACH TO SERVE
IN SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITIES. AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER WE'RE WE'RE
SUPPORTING CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
THE UC IRVINE TRAIN THE TRAINER
PSYCHIATRY FELLOWSHIP
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM. ON WHICH IS
IT REALLY IMPORTANT PROGRAM
EXPANDS THE CAPACITY OF PRIMARY
CARE PROVIDERS- TO SERVICE
ALRIGHT ARE. COMMONLY
ENCOUNTERED PSYCHIATRIC
CONDITIONS WE'VE AWARDED. OVER
ONE POINT FOUR MILLION SO FAR IN
TRAINING OVER ONE HUNDRED NEW
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS. WE'RE
PREPARING TO OPEN A NEW GRANT
CYCLES FOR OUR PSYCHIATRY
EDUCATION CAPACITY PROGRAM FOR
OUR PIPELINE PROGRAM THAT I
MENTIONED. AND NOW AND WE'RE
ALSO OPENING AGAIN ADDITIONAL
LOAN REPAYMENT AND SCHOLARSHIP
PROGRAM CYCLES TO RECRUIT AND
RETAIN A BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE SERVING CHILDREN YOUTH
AND FAMILIES. I WAS TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER WITH SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER WE RECOGNIZE HOW
CRITICAL THAT IS AND YOUR FLOOR
DEVELOPING A FRAMEWORK AND PLAN
TO AUGMENT AND BUILD A SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER WORKFORCE. AS WE
KNOW THIS IS ESPECIALLY KEY FOR
SERVING CHAU ADOLESCENTS AND
YOUTH WE KNOW WHERE OUR THAT IT
STARTS AT THAT AGE AND WE'RE
WORKING TO TRY TO MITIGATE THAT
. WE'RE ALSO CONDUCTING WORST
RESEARCH- TO UNDERSTAND TO BUILD
US TO EXPAND THE CAPACITY TO
TRAIN SOCIAL WORK TO START THE
WORK. THAT WE TALKED ABOUT
BUILDING ON- WITH FUTURE FUNDING
BUT TO REALLY FOCUS ON SOCIAL
WORKERS TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
CHILDREN AND YOU. WHERE WE ONLY
HAVE THINK IT'S IMPORTANT WE'RE
LOOKING AT WAYS THAT WE CAN
AUGMENT OUR UNDERSTANDING AND
BUT WORKFORCE TO SERVE SYSTEM
AND JUSTICE INVOLVED YOUTH. AND
WE'RE ALSO LOOKING TO AUGMENT
EXISTING PROGRAMS TO DEVELOP
MANY OF THE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS THAT WE HEARD DISCUSSED
EARLIER. WE RECOGNIZE THAT THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
NEEDS ARE CRITICAL NOW AND THAT
WE MUST ALSO BE SETTING THE
STAGE FOR THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE OF TOMORROW. SO WE
ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT WE HAVE
PROBABLY BE HERE TO HELP
WORKFORCE SHORTAGES EXIST ACROSS
ALL SECTORS INCLUDING IN THE
PUBLIC BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SYSTEMS
SCHOOLS STATE RUN FACILITIES. SO
WE WANTED TO LOOK OUT WE ADDRESS
THE MOST CRITICAL WORKFORCE
SHORTAGES NOW WITH OUR EXISTING
LOAN REPAYMENT PROGRAMS THEY
PROVIDE CLINICS AND
ORGANIZATIONS A KEY WAY TO
RECRUIT AND RETAIN NEEDED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH STAFF. AND
THESE PROGRAMS FOCUS ON PLACING
PROVIDERS IN UNDERSERVED AREAS
AND FACILITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. OUR WEB REGIONAL
PARTNERSHIP GRANTS PROVIDE
FUNDING TO HELP ATTRACT AND
RETAIN BEHAVIORAL STAFF WORKING
IN THE PUBLIC BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SYSTEM. WE KNOW THAT
CALIFORNIA'S LAGGING BEHIND IN
THE NUMBER OF PSYCHIATRISTS
NECESSARY. WE YOU KNOW HOW FOR
CENTER AT UC SAN FRANCISCO IS
REPORTED THAT VERY SOON WE WILL
HAVE A SEVERE SHORTAGE OF
PSYCHIATRISTS AND EVEN TODAY IN
SOME AREAS WE HAVE FEWER THAN
ONE PSYCHIATRIST PER TEN
THOUSAND RESIDENTS. OUR SUPPORT
IN THE UC IRVINE TRAINING
TRAINING TRAINING PROGRAM WE
THINK IT'S CRITICAL I'M TO
EXPAND THE CAPACITY THE PRIMARY
CARE PROVIDERS. IT ALSO SUPPORTS
TRAINING OF INTEGRATED MODELS
THAT INCLUDE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AND PRIMARY CARE. AND OUR
PSYCHIATRY EDUCATION CAPACITY
EXPANSION PROGRAM PROVIDE NEEDED
TO THE SPORT TO EXPAND THE
CAPACITY TO TRAIN MORE
PSYCHIATRISTS. WE ARE AWARE OF
THE SHARP RISE IN SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER ANXIETY AND DEPRESSION
A MONSTER YOU. CALIFORNIA
STATISTICS SHOW THAT YOUTH AGES
FIFTEEN TO NINETEEN OF THE
HIGHEST EMERGENCY EPARTMENT
VISITS. AND HOSPITALIZATION
RIGHTS PROJECT OVERDOSES AND USE
AGE TWENTY TO TWENTY FOUR OF THE
HIGHEST RATE OF OVERDOSE RELATED
DEATHS. WE KNOW THAT THERE IS A
SEVERE SHORTAGE OF SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER WORKFORCE TO MEET THOSE
NEEDS AND SO WE'RE WORKING ON.
WAYS THAT WE CAN BUILD THAT-
WORKFORCE. ONE REPAIR PROGRAMS
HELP DEVELOP RECRUIT AND RETAIN
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROVIDERS.
WITH THEIR WORK ON THE CHILDREN
AND YOUTH BEHAVIOR HEALTH
INITIATIVE WE ARE FOCUSING ON
EDUCATIONAL WAYS TO INCREASE
CAPACITY OF THIS AS YOU
WORKFORCE. I JUST WANTED TO JUST
QUICKLY ANSWER THE QUESTIONS
ABOUT IN TERMS OF THAT CHILDREN
YOU'D BE ABLE HEALTH INITIATIVE
FUNDING BEING USED FOR PEER T
PEER SUPPORT- AS WE DISCUSSED
EARLIER THE PAIR PERSONAL
TRAINING IN PLACING PLACEMENT
PROGRAM WE FEEL IS CRITICAL AND
IMPORTANT AND ENJOYABLE. TO THE
OUR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
OUR PROGRAMS INTO THE CHILDREN
WITH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS YOU
CAN. ANSWER THIS THIS WE WILL
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THAT
PROGRAM- THROUGH THE CHILDREN
YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE AND WE WILL BE
OPENING A NEW CYCLE HERE AT THE
END OF MARCH. I ONE TWENTY TWO.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WE
WILL HEAR FROM DOCTOR RYAN QUEST
WHO IS THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTOR FOR SACRAMENTO COUNTY
PLEASE BEGIN. CHAIRS AND
MEMBERS- MY NAME'S REHNQUIST AND
I'M THE BEHAVIOR HEALTH DIRECTOR
FOR SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I'M
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION OF A OF CALIFORNIA
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF C. B. H.
TA. FIRST WE WANT TO EXPRESS OUR
GRATITUDE TO THE LEGISLATURE IN
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR THE
HISTORIC INVESTMENT OF RESOURCES
TARGETING THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE. IN THE LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET AND ADDITIONAL FUNDING
PROPOSED THIS YEAR. THE PANDEMIC
HAS TURNED OUR WORK FOR SHORTAGE
INTO A CRISIS INCREASED DEMAND
FOR SERVICES IN THE PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE SECTOR COUPLED WITH
IMMENSE STRESS BURNOUT WHICH
INFLATION THE EXPANSION OF
TELEHEALTH JOB OPPORTUNITIES HAS
RESULTED IN SOME. IN SOME PUBLIC
BEHAVIOR HEALTH AGENCIES
EXPERIENCING WORSE WORKFORCE
VACANCIES OF 3240% OR MORE. D.
H. DA HAS WAS ABLE TO LEVERAGE
THE WORK FORCE GRANT RECEIVED
THROUGH KAISER FOUNDATION AND
LEARNED THAT WHILE ALMOST HALF
OF COUNTIES ARE DESIGNATED AS
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONAL
SHORTAGE AREAS. SHORTAGES DIFFER
SIGNIFICANTLY WITH THE CENTRAL
VALLEY VALLEY EXPERIENCING. THE
MOST EXTREME SHORTAGES. WELL
SOMETHING USED HAVE CLIMBED
DURING THE PANDEMIC R. S. U. D.
WORKFORCE HAS BEEN HISTORICALLY
UNDERVALUED WHICH IS ONLY
EXACERBATED SIGNIFICANT
WORKFORCE SHORTAGES. ALTHOUGH S.
U. D. CANCERS MAKE UP THE CORE
OF OUR S. U. D. WORK FORCE A
COMPREHENSIVE ANALYSIS CONDUCTED
BY THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DIVISION OF SUBSTANCE ABUSE
PREVENTION AND CONTROL. FOUND
THAT THEY NEEDED TO GROW THEIR
S. U. D. COUNCIL WORKFORCE BY
EIGHTY FOUR PERCENT. IN
REVIEWING THIS ANALYSIS WAS
STATE WIDE DATA WE ARE FINDING
SIMILAR GAPS AND S. U. COUNCIL
WORKFORCE STATEWIDE. SACRAMENTO
COUNTY I'M WATCHING MY PROVIDER
AGENCIES WORK FORCE GET
DECIMATED BY COMPETING EMPLOYERS
THEY'RE OFFERING GREATER PAY AND
EASIER WORK SERVING LESS COMPLEX
POPULATION. IN JANUARY WE
INCREASED RATES BY 10%
SPECIFICALLY TO ALLOW AGENCIES
TO INCREASE SALARIES BUT THIS
STILL DOESN'T SEEM TO BE ENOUGH.
THERE AREN'T ENOUGH SKILLED AND
EXPERIENCED PEOPLE OUT THERE TO
DO THIS IMPORTANT AND
CHALLENGING WORK. BECAUSE OF
VACANCIES EXISTING STAFF FOR
HAVING TO CARRY THE CASELOADS OF
THREE AND FOUR OTHER PEOPLE
LEADING TO BURNOUT RISK. WE HAVE
A BEHAVIORAL HEALTH URGENT CARE
PROGRAM THAT WE DECIDED TO FIND-
UP. SO THEY COULD OPEN UP TO
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN TO ADDRESS THE
NEEDS THAT WE'RE SEEING IN THE
COMMUNITY. THEY CAN'T FIND
ENOUGH STAFF TO EXPAND THEIR
HOURS YET. IN SMALLER COUNTIES
THIS WORK FIRST WORKFORCE CRISIS
IS PARTICULARLY DEVASTATING FOR
EXAMPLE IN NEVADA COUNTY THEIR
S. U. D. RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT
PROVIDER HAS CLOSED ONE. OF
THEIR TWO FACILITIES TEMPORARILY
DUE TO STAFFING ONE OF THE REST
ONE OF THEIR S. T. R. T. PIECES
SHUT DOWN. AND WHEN YOU'RE WORK
FORCES SMALL TO VACANCIES ON ONE
TEAM CAN EASILY BE 25% OF YOUR
THERAPIST. AND TO TOP IT ALL
OFF- THE DIFFICULTY FINDING
BILINGUAL STAFF HAS BEEN
MAGNIFIED. SO GIVEN THESE
CHALLENGES C. H. D. A IS DEEPLY
GRATEFUL TO THE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION FOR PRIORITIZING
THE NEED TO INVEST BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH WORKFORCE WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COURSE CORRECT
AND EXPAND IN NEW WAYS TO BETTER
SUPPORT THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC DELIVERY
SYSTEM AND THE DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES WE SERVE. C. H. T.
IN THE STEINBERG INSTITUTE ARE
WORKING IN COALITION TO PUT
TOGETHER TO PUT FORWARD A SERIES
OF- BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT INCLUDE THE
FOLLOWING. FIRST WE NEED TO
EXPAND THE EDUCATIONAL SLOTS TO
SUPPORT HER CAREER PATHWAYS
TOWARDS LICENSURE FOR ELEMENT
TEAS- L. PCC'S AN LCSW AS WELL
PSYCHIATRISTS. AND SPECIAL
SPECIALIST IN ADDICTION MEDICINE
. WE ALSO NEED TO EXPAND
INTERNSHIPS WITHIN THE PUBLIC
HEALTH A PUBLIC BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DELIVERY SYSTEM TO TRAIN
OUR FUTURE WORKFORCE TO WORK IN
THE COMMUNITY AND FIELD BASED
TREATMENT MODALITIES TO SERVE
THE COMPLEX POPULATION WE SERVE
AS INTO YEAH AND IT'S SUCH AS
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE JUSTICE
INVOLVED. IN THOSE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. WE NEED FUNDING TO
SUPPORT TO WORK TUITION
ASSISTANCE TEST PREP PREPARATION
PAID INTERNSHIPS AND LOAN
REPAYMENT FOR LICENSED AND NON
LICENSED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS. NESTOR ARAMBULA
HAS BEEN BESIDES WE NEED TO
DEVELOP A MORE A BURST PIPELINE
WE'RE- THE PROPOSAL THERE IS BY
PARTNERING WITH HIGH SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN UNDER
STRICT SERVE COMMUNITIES. IN
ADDITION C. H. D. A BELIEVES IT
IS IMPORTANT THAT AND BUILDING
OUR EDUCATIONAL SLOTS WE INVEST
IN DEVELOPMENT OF A SPECIALIZED
CURRICULUM FOCUSED ON PREPARING
GRADUATES TO WORK IN THE PUBLIC
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SYSTEMS. AND
MENTAL HEALTH AN SUV AND A
GRATION. DOESN'T WORK IS NOT THE
TYPICAL THE STEREO TYPICAL
OFFICE SPACE THERAPY THAT WE SEE
ON TV AND IN MOVIE THIS REQUIRE
SPECIALIZED TRAINING TO
EFFECTIVELY DO THIS COMMUNITY
BASED WORK. AND WHILE WE'RE
EXCITED TO BRING IN MORE FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENT TO LEVERAGE
EXISTING COUNTY INVESTMENTS AND
CARES. UNLESS AND UNTIL WE
ESTABLISH PEERS AS A STATEWIDE
MEDICAL BENEFIT FOR ALL COUNTIES
CALIFORNIA WILL CONTINUE TO FALL
SHORT. MOMENTS AND POTENTIAL OF. OUR PEER SUPPORT SPECIALIST
WORKFORCE. WITHOUT A C.
INVESTMENT IN BUILDING OUT THE
BEHAVIOR HEALTH WORKFORCE
PIPELINE ALL OF THE SYSTEM
REFORMS IMAGINE WHETHER FOR
COMMERCIAL INSURANCE PARITY
MOBILE CRISIS SCHOOL BASED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. THE AWFUL
SHORT OF OUR HOPES FINALLY IN
ADDITION TO THE INITIATIVES
WE'VE REVIEWED WE ALSO EED
ADDITIONAL SUSTAIN FUNDING
DEDICATED TO ONGOING SERVICES SO
WE CAN OFFER BETTER SALARIES AND
ATTRACT OUR FUTURE WORKFORCE.
INTO CHOOSING US AS THEIR CAREER
PATH. LOOK FOR DANCING QUESTION
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE AND
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT TODAY. THANK YOU NEXT WE
WILL HEAR FROM DOCTOR JANET
COFFMAN WHO IS FACULTY AT UCSF
HEALTH FORCE CENTER PLEASE BE IN
. YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AROUND THE LINE
THANK YOU HI TO ALL OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- I WILL BE
SPEAKING YOU KNOW FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE AS EASY A
RESEARCHER- ARE WHOSE KIND
KNOWLEDGEABLE ABOUT THESE TOPICS
NOT TALK FIRST ABOUT CHALLENGES
AND RECOMMEND AND THEN ABOUT
RECOMMENDATIONS. IT WILL BE A
LOT OF OVERLAP BETWEEN WHEN I
HAVE TO SAY AND SOME OF WHAT'S
BEEN SAID PREVIOUSLY. SO I THINK
THE- CHALLENGES AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH WORKFORCE THAT WE FACE IN
CALIFORNIA CAN LARGELY BE
GROUPED INTO THREE MAJOR
CATEGORIES SUPPLY. DISTRIBUTION
DEMOGRAPHIC CHARACTERISTICS ARE
AS THAT TERM IS ON MENTIONED
EARLIER FORECAST THAT I AND MY
COLLEAGUES AT UCSF CONDUCTED.
SUGGEST THAT CALIFORNIA'S FACING
SHORTAGES OF PSYCHIATRISTS
PSYCHOLOGISTS MARRIAGE AND
FAMILY THERAPIST PROFESSIONAL
CLINICAL COUNSELORS SOCIAL
WORKERS- AND WHILE OVER THE NEXT
DECADE AND WHILE WE HAVEN'T
LOOKED SPOKE SPECIFICALLY OF
FORECASTING SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER COUNSELORS I THINK
THAT'S ANOTHER AREA OF NEED- ONE
MAJOR SOURCE OF THESE PROJECTED
SHORTAGES IS THE AGENT OF THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE.
LARGE SHARES OF PEOPLE IN THESE
PROFESSIONS ARE LIKELY TO RETIRE
REDUCE THEIR WORK HOURS WITHIN
THE NEXT DECADE. YOU KNOW I'M
GRADUATES OF EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS THAT PREPARE PEOPLE TO
BECOME BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS SUGGEST THAT THE
NUMBER OF GRADUATES IS NOT
ADEQUATE TO REPLACE ALL RETIREES
. DURING THE TIME CREATE FROM
TWENTY SIXTEEN TO TWENTY
NINETEEN. AND THAT'S THE MOST
RECENT YEARS FOR WHICH DATA ARE
AVAILABLE THE NUMBER OF
GRADUATES OF SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER COUNSELOR PROGRAMS
ACTUALLY DECREASED AND THERE'S
BEEN LITTLE GROWTH AND GRADUATES
FROM MASTER'S DEGREE PROGRAMS TO
TRACK PREPARE PEOPLE FOR
LICENSURE. NUMBER PSYCHIATRY
RESIDENCES INCREASE BUT IT'S
STILL FAR BELOW THE NUMBER
NEEDED TO REPLACE RETIREES. IN
HIS LONGSTANDING CHALLENGES
RELATED TWENTY AGING WORKFORCE
HAVE BEEN EXACERBATED. AB ALSO
SERVICES WE'VE SEEN THE ENTRY OF
NEW TELEVISION APRIL HEALTH
PROVIDERS INTO THE MARKET AND
THIS HAS RESULTED IN KEEN
COMPETITION. AMONG EMPLOYERS AS
OUR LAST SPEAKER JUST DESCRIBED
. AND IN THIS IS ESPECIALLY
CHALLENGING FOR THE PUBLIC
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH OUR SYSTEM A
SURVEY THAT OUR TEAM CNDUCTED
FOR THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION LAST FALL
FOUND THAT OVER 60% OF COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AGENCIES. HAD
DIFFICULTY RECRUITING ALL TYPES
OF LICENSED AND CERTIFIED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
. THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE IS WHERE WE
DISTRIBUTED ACROSS THE STATE AS
WELL THE INLAND EMPIRE AND SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY REGIONS HAVE
RATIOS OF LICENSED BEHAVIOR
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS PER
POPULATION THEY'RE SUBSTANTIALLY
LOWER THAN THE STATE OVERALL.
THE NORTHERN SYRIAN REGION HAVE
SUBSTANTIALLY LOWER RATIOS OF
PSYCHIATRISTS AND PSYCHOLOGISTS
FOR POPULATION. CALIFORNIA'S
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE ALSO
DOES NOT RELENT REFLECT THE
DEMOGRAPHIC CHARACTERISTICS OF
THE STATE'S POPULATION THAT'S
WHY IT'S SO HARD TO FIND A
DIVERSE PROFESSIONALS. BLACK AND
LATIN NEXT UNDER REPRESENTED
AMONG PSYCHIATRISTS AND
PSYCHOLOGISTS AND LATIN X. ARE
ALSO UNDER REPRESENTED AMONG
MASTER'S-LEVEL BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS. ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDERS ARE UNDER REPRESENTED
AMONG TYPE ALL TYPES OF BEHAVIOR
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS ACCEPT
PSYCHIATRIST BUT EVEN AMONG
PSYCHIATRISTS WHEN WE UNPACK
ASIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDER INTO
SPECIFIC ETHNIC GROUPS THE
COMPOSITION OF PSYCHIATRISTS
DOESN'T REFLECT THE COMPOSITION
OF POPULATION. WE ALSO DIVERSE
OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS WHO SPEAK
LANGUAGES OTHER THAN ENGLISH AND
THE LACK OF SPANISH SPEAKERS IS
ESPECIALLY SEVERE AMONG
PSYCHIATRISTS AND PSYCHOLOGISTS
. SO HAVING OUTLINED THESE
CHALLENGES WE FACE I'D NOW LIKE
TO LEARN TO POSSIBLE TO TURN TWO
POSSIBLE SOLUTIONS AND I THINK
FIRST AND FOREMOST WE NEED A
COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY TO
ADDRESS THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE NEEDS ARE A LOT OF.
INITIATIVES OUT THERE THAT HOLD
A LOT OF PROMISE BUT IT'S NOT
ALWAYS CLEAR HOW THEY FIT
TOGETHER. THANK KEY COMPONENTS I
THINK OF A COMPREHENSIVE PLAN
INCLUDE PROMOTING BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CAREERS DEVELOPING THE
PIPELINE OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WORKERS AND IMPROVING GEOGRAPHIC
DISTRIBUTION. I THINK PROTECT
AROUND PROMOTING BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CHRIS MANY CREATIVE
APPROACHES TO WASTE AWARENESS OF
BEHAVIORAL CAREERS AMONG
RACIALLY ETHNICALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY DIVERSE YOUNG
PEOPLE AND WE NEED TO SUPPORT
LGBTQ PERSONS WHO WANT TO STICK
TO INTERNEES PROFESSIONS. ARE
UNLIKELY EMPTIES WE ALSO NEED
MORE MEN HERE THE KEY
DIFFERENCES BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF
PSYCHIATRISTS THESE OCCUPATIONS
ARE PREDOMINANTLY FEMALE SO WE
KNEW WE NEED TO THINK OF HOW DO
WE GET MORE MEN PARTICULARLY
YOUNG MEN. INTO THESE
PROFESSIONS TO SERVE PEOPLE IN
NEED. HI POINT DEVELOPMENT XIN
COMPASS BOTH INCREASING NUMBERS
OF GRADUATES OF EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS AND THE DIVERSITY OF
GRADUATES. AND SO KAREN RIZZO
HAS TALKED ABOUT EACH CASE
EXISTING PROGRAMS FOR EXPANDING
CAPACITY TO TRAIN BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS INTO SOME
MODELS- THAT CAN BE EASILY BUILT
ON THERE- I WOULD SAY WE OUGHT
TO TAKE PAGE FROM THE SONG BROWN
PROGRAM. AND AWARD INCLUDE
CRITERIA FOR AWARDING FUNDING
THAT PRIOR TORIES AREAS OF THE
STATE WITH THE GREATEST NEED FOR
BEHAVIOR HEALTH PROFESSIONALS.
AND ALSO I WOULD SAY WE NEED TO
LOOK AT PRIVATIZING ACCELERATED
PROGRAMS LIKE THE ONES THAT WAS
WITH LANCE BYRD. MENTIONED
BECAUSE THEY ENABLE US TO GET
FOLKS INTO LICENSED PROFESSIONS
MORE QUICKLY- CRITICAL THAT
EXPANSION TRAINING SLOTS BE
ACCOMPANIED BY FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE. FOR STUDENTS I THINK
A GOOD EXAMPLE WAS THE STIPEND
PROGRAM FOR MASTER'S OF SOCIAL
WORK STUDENTS THAT H. CHI-
PREVIOUSLY OPERATED UNDER THE
AUSPICES OF THE MENTAL MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT. AND THAT
PROGRAM HAD PAID BACK
REQUIREMENT UNDER WHICH PEOPLE
WHO RECEIVED A STIPEND MUST WORK
IN THE PUBLIC BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SYSTEM FOR SEVERAL YEARS
FOLLOWING GRADUATION. AS WELL AS
THE CURRICULUM TO RENT THEM TO
THE NEEDS OF PEOPLE SERVED BY.
THE PUBLIC SYSTEM- SOME YOU KNOW
SOME FUNDING FOR THAT HAS GONE
OUT TO THE REGION'S UNDER WET
BUT I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
VALUE PERHAPS TO RE. RE
CENTRALIZING AND REFOCUSING-
ELIZABETH LANSFORD MENTIONED
STIPENDS AND SCHOLARSHIPS
REALLY- IMPORTANT CAN HURT THESE
ARE OCCUPATIONS IN WHICH FOLKS
JUST DON'T MAKE ENOUGH EVEN AT
THE MASTER'S LEVEL. EASILY PAID
LOANS AND CERTAINLY PRIORITY
SHOULD BE GIVEN TO STUDENTS
WHOSE BACKGROUNDS REFLECTING THE
DIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIANS WITH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS. I'M
SPENDING ABOUT TALKS SO MUCH
ABOUT TODAY IS CAREER LADDER AND
I GUESS IT'S CRITICALLY.
IMPORTANT DIMENSION OF PIPELINE
DEVELOPMENT. MAKING ENTERED
HEALTH AND INTRIGUED OCCUPATIONS
AS HMAN SERVICES ASSISTANCE
CARE PROVIDERS OR SUBSTANCE USE.
DISORDER COUNSELORS. AND ENTER
THESE OCCUPATIONS HAS OFTEN BEEN
HIGH- FOR THE REASONS THAT RANK
WAS JUST TALKED ABOUT THE PEOPLE
SPIRITS BURNOUT AND CONFINED
LESS STRESSFUL JOBS IN OTHER-SECTORS THAT PAY SIMILAR WAGES.
THEY DON'T NECESSARILY SEE A
CLEAR PATHWAY HOW THEY CAN HOW
THEY CAN ADVANCE. TO A BETTER
WAGE- AND MORE RESPONSIBLE
POSITION IN BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
AND SO I THINK WE CAN TAKE A
PAGE FROM SOME WORK THAT THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE WHO'S DONE
THAT MAPS OUT CREATE EDUCATIONAL
PATHWAYS. FOR PEOPLE IN ENTRY
LEVEL OCCUPATIONS TO ADVANCE AND
I THINK THIS MAPPING SHOULD BE
LEVERAGED TO DEVELOP MORE FORMAL
PARTNERSHIPS AMONG EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS AND EMPLOYERS. TO
FACILITATE CAREER LADDERS FOR
INCUMBENT WORKERS IN THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SYSTEM. AND
THEN LASTLY JUST TO FOLLOW UP ON
RECURRING CHRIS SAID WE NEED TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE SYSTEM LEVEL
CHALLENGES THAT AFFECT THE
ABILITY OF THE PUBLIC BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SYSTEM TO RECRUIT RETAIN
PERSONNEL. AND THAT INCLUDES THE
LEVEL OF MEDICARE REIMBURSEMENT
AS WELL AS THE TYPES OF SERVICES
INCLUDING PEERS. THAT ARE
REIMBURSED STATEWIDE. SO I'LL
STOP THERE AND THANK YOU MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU NEXT WE
WILL HEAR FROM DOCTOR LEE ANDHRA
CLARK HARVEY CEO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF. COMMUNITY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AGENCIES
PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU AND GOOD
EVENING CHAIRS AND MEMBERS AND
THANK YOU FOR THE INVITATION TO
SHARE THE PERSPECTIVE OF OUR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION
MEMBERS THAT PROVIDE CARE TO
OVER EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND
KIDS. ADULTS AND OLDER ADULTS I
SUPPOSE SHARED SO ELOQUENTLY BY
THE CHAIRWOMAN DURING PANEL FIVE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
ARE OFTEN LOOK TO ASK THE ANSWER
BUT OFTEN UNDER FUNDED AND
YOU'VE HEARD THE STATISTICS ON
THE ANTICIPATED INCREASE.
SYSTEMATIC HOW AND ROMAN AS A
RESULT OF THE PANDEMIC OUR
PROVIDERS ARE EXPERIENCING
UNPRECEDENTED STAFFING ISSUES
CBO SO SHUT DOWN BEDS AND
CLINICS SPACE DUE TO LACK OF
STAFFING. AND ECHOING AGAIN THE
CHAIRWOMAN YOU CAN NOT TALK
ABOUT WORK FORCE FOR CBO'S
WITHOUT TALKING ABOUT THE
FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE OF PAYMENT
WHICH IS A SIGNIFICANT DRIVER OF
WORKFORCE CHALLENGES. I CAN'T
TELL YOU HOW MANY TIMES ARE
PREVALENT PROVIDERS RAISE THE
ISSUES ARE PROBLEMATIC
REIMBURSEMENT RATES WITH THEIR
COUNTIES AND THE STATE
LEGISLATURE DON'T CONTROL THESE
RATES. I'D BE REMISS TO DISCUSS
DISCUSS WORKFORCE WITHOUT
HIGHLIGHTING THIS PROBLEM SIMPLY
COUNTIES CONTRACT WITH PROVIDERS
TO PROVIDE DIRECT SERVICE TO
YOUR CONSTITUENTS. AND WHILE
THANKFULLY SOME COUNTIES LIKE
SACRAMENTO OR DR CHRISTOPHER
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTOR OF
WORK TO INCREASE REIMBURSEMENT
RATES ARE EVEN PROVIDE ADVANCE
PAYMENTS DURING THE PANDEMIC
WHEN WORKFORCE IS HAMPERED AND
SERVICE DEMAND IS HIGH. IN SOME
CASES RATES ARE SO LOW THAT
STAFF WHO ARE WILLING AND ABLE
TO WORK CAN'T BE RETAINED. THIS
ISN'T THE PLIGHT OF ALL
CONTRACTS BETWEEN COUNTY SAN
PROVIDERS BUT IT'S THE STORY OF
FAR TOO MANY. OUR MEMBERS A
BRAVE THIS PANDEMIC AND MANY
AGENCIES ARE ON THE BRINK OF
CRISIS WE'VE HEARD FROM MY.
COLLEAGUE ALICK BRISCOE WHO
TESTIFY ABOUT EIGHTEEN TO AN
HOUR. THAT MATTER ARE PAID WELL
COMMITTEE BASED OKAY. ARE CA
WITH PRIVATE HEALTH PLANS
TECHNOLOGY APPS AND EVEN AMAZON
YES AMAZON WHO IS PAYING UP TO
FORTY DOLLARS AND POWER WHEN I
CHECKED LAST NIGHT. A MATCH AND
GETTING YOUR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS CERTIFICATE OR
MASTER'S DEGREE IN SOCIAL WORK
OR MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPY
TO WORK IN THE PUBLIC BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SYSTEM BUT ONLY TO BE
MATCHED. WITH LOW PAY
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN SUCH AS
ONEROUS PAPERWORK AND CASELOADS
BURSTING AT THE SEAMS. AT HOME
YOUR FAMILY AND YOU HAVE TWO
MONTHS TO REPAY. I'M MATCHING
OVERSEEING AGENCIES IN MULTIPLE
COUNTIES WHERE YOU HAVE TO HIRE
A TEAM OF STAFF JUST TRACK
VARYING INTAKE PAPERWORK
REQUIREMENTS FOR EACH COUNTY YOU
HAVE A CONTRACT THEN. THAT MONEY
AND THOSE INDIVIDUALS TIME COULD
BE BETTER SPENT. IMAGINE YOU'RE
A CLIENT WAITING FOR WEEKS FOR
AN APPOINTMENT AND SPENDING THE
FIRST SESSION COMPLETING
PAPERWORK. WE SIMPLY WANT TO PUT
THE AGENCY ADMINISTRATORS
CLINICIANS AND CLIENTS BEFORE
DESPERATE AND IN SOME CASES
UNNECESSARY AND ADMINISTRATIVE
REQUIREMENTS I CONTRIBUTE TO
BURNOUT OF THE HERO WORKERS. AND
OUR STATE HAS NOT BEEN THE MOST
FRIENDLY TAX OUT OF STATE
PROVIDERS WHO LOOK TO TRANSITION
OUR LICENSES TO CALIFORNIA TO
BOLSTER OUR WORK FORCE. SO
LICENSE RECIPROCITY SOLUTIONS
MUST ALSO BE EXAMINED ESPECIALLY
SOMETIMES WITH DISCUSSED ON THE
FIRST PANEL THERE AREN'T ENOUGH
TRAINING PROGRAMS AND RESIDENCY
SLOTS FOR PSYCHOLOGISTS. AND
PSYCHIATRISTS IN CALIFORNIA. AND
THE TYPE OF WORK RESPONSE. AND
BUILDING IN AGREE TEAMS ALSO
BUILDS THE PIPELINE AND ALLOWS
OPPORTUNITIES FOR DIVERSE
INDIVIDUALS TO ENTER THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE.
MEMBERS YOUR CONSTITUENTS ARE
EXPERIENCING PHYSICAL AND
EMOTIONAL CRISES PARTICULARLY
YOUTH AND OLDER ADULTS AND WE
NEED TO A STEP ESSENTIAL
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROVIDERS
READY TO ASSIST US WITH THE
EMOTIONAL TOLL OF THE PANDEMIC.
AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE SUPPORTING
THE H. HIGH PROPOSAL'S
INCLUSIONS APPEAR FROM
CHROMODORIS COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS COACHES SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER PROFESSIONALS AND
OTHERS. WE NEED FUNDING FOR THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND YOUTH
INITIATIVE AND I PERSONALLY
BENEFITED BENEFITTED FROM H. CHI
AND THEN THEN IT WAS CALLED
ASPECTS STATEMENTS TEN YEARS AGO
IT STILL TOOK SEVEN YEARS FOR ME
TO BECOME A PSYCHOLOGIST. MAYBE
EVEN GET TO THE POINT OF
APPLYING FOR THOSE FUNDS. OUR
WORKFORCE NEEDS IMMEDIATE
FINANCIAL SOLUTIONS TO ACCOUNT
FOR RECENT CHANGES TO MINIMUM
WAGE THE DIRE WORKFORCE
SHORTAGES DUE THE PANDEMIC AND
ALLOW FOR MORE COMPETITIVE WAGES
IN ORDER TO RETAIN AND RECRUIT.
ESSENTIAL PERSONNEL. WE REALIZE
THAT SOLUTIONS MUST BE PURSUED
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH COUNTY AND
STATE PARTNERS WITH KNOWLEDGE OF
THE ADMINISTRATION AND
SPECIFICALLY DH CS AND HOW
THEY'RE WORKING TO RE ENVISION
OUR DELIVERY SYSTEM OPERATES. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO PARTNERING
AROUND MORE SYSTEM. CHANGE AND
INNOVATION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WE WILL HEAR THAI RENT WHO
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION. OF
ALCOHOL AND DRUG PROGRAM
EXECUTIVES PLEASE BEGIN. GOOD
EVENING CHEN ARAMBULA AND
MEMBERS- TAVR RANDY AND THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ALCOHOL AND DRUG PROGRAM
EXECUTIVES OR CAT HE THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
THE SUBCOMMITTEE. KATHY
REPRESENTS FIFTEEN AT SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER TREATMENT PROVIDERS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA AS STATED BY
YOU KNOW MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES
TONIGHT WORKFORCE IS A CRITICAL
ISSUE FOR SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT PROVIDERS IN IS A REAL
BEAR YOUR FRIEND PROVIDING MORE
SERVICES TO INDIVIDUALS IN NEED.
WE HAD A WORKFORCE- YOU KNOW-
CRISIS PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC I'M
SORRY AND THESE A BONY BEEN
EXACERBATED BY COBIT NINETEEN.
CAN'T BE APPRECIATES THE
DEDICATION ON SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER WORK FORCE THROUGH THE
PROPOSED TWENTY SIX MILLION OF
FUNDING FOR OPIOID PROVIDER
CAPACITY THE SEVENTY MILLION FOR
PROVIDER WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
THROUGH THE CHILDREN YOUTH
BEHAVIOR HEALTH INITIATIVES. AND
ASSIGNING OF AB SIX SIX SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK-SILVA JUST-
IF YOU DAYS AGO HOW TO CREATE A
STATEWIDE SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
WORKFORCE NEEDS ASSESSMENT AND
AUTHORIZING EACH KIND OF FIND
SEVERAL WORKFORCE INITIATIVES.
WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE
ENGAGEMENT SO FAR BY EACH CHI
AND A LOT OF THE WORK FORCE
AREAS BUT SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
ON ALTHOUGH WE WOULD ARGUE THAT
THERE NEEDS TO BE- LARGER
INVESTMENT IN THAT CITY
WORKFORCE ARM. WHICH WAS
INSTIGATED BY THE CHAIR. I DON'T
TO REMIND THE CAN THAT. THERE'S
NOT A DAY. SOURCE OF WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT FUNDS FOR THE SUV
FIELD AS THERE IS WITH THE FIVE
YEAR WORKFORCE EDUCATION AND
TRAINING ARE THE BLACK. PLANTS
UNDER THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ACT WE BELIEVE THAT THERE NEEDS
TO BE THE SAME LEVEL OF
ATTENTION AND DEDICATION. TO THE
WORK FORCE AS IN THE WETLANDS- I
LIVE IN A CALL SERVICES ACT. WE
NEED TO CREATE EASIER ACCESS TO
TUITION ASSISTANCE AND
REIMBURSEMENT AND INCENTIVES FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO FURTHER
EDUCATION- IN WORKING IN THE
PUBLIC BROWN STDS- VITAMIN. TELL
ME THAT THEY'RE STRUGGLING WITH
WORKFORCE ACROSS THE BOARD FOR
MASTER'S-LEVEL CLINICIANS LACK
OF CERTIFIED SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER COUNSELORS. VISIONS AND
NURSES. ADDITIONALLY CURRENT
REIMBURSEMENT ROLES LIMIT OF WHO
WE CAN TELL SERVICES FOR AND
PREVENT STD PROGRAMS FROM TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF A BROAD SCOPE OF
POTENTIAL WORKFORCE. EXAMPLE
ALBION'S WHICH ARE KEY STAFF YOU
KNOW WOMEN AND NON DRUG MEDI CAL
RESIDENTIAL DETOX PROGRAMS-
UNDER DRAMATIC HOW THEY CANNOT
PROVIDE CASE MANAGEMENT
INDIVIDUAL COUNSELING SESSIONS.
OR DEVELOP A TREATMENT PLAN THEY
MUST BE REGISTERED AS THAT CITY
COUNCILORS TO PROVIDE ANY
SERVICE OTHER THAN MEDICATION
MANAGED AT. ALL FOR THE ABILITY
OF THE CERTIFYING ORGANIZATIONS
FOR SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
COUNSELORS TO TIMELY PROCESS
COUNSELOR CERTIFICATION AND RE
CERTIFICATION APPLICATIONS
BECAUSE BY THE PANDEMIC HAMPERS
OUR ABILITY TO HIRE QUALIFIED
STAFF. AS STATED BY MY COLLEAGUE
DR KERR CARDI WAS CVHS WE NEED
TO LOOK AT RECIPROCITY BETWEEN
CALIFORNIA AND OTHER STATES EVEN
BETWEEN- AND WITHIN COUNTY IS.
WHILE NOT A POLICY COMMITTEE
HERE AND I WOULD BE REMISS IF I
DID NOT MENTION A BILL THAT WE
ARE BRINGING FORWARD TO ADDRESS
WORKFORCE POLICY BARRIERS- CAN'T
BE HAS PARTNERED WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHRIS WARD. INTRODUCED AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY WHICH REMOVE
A BARRIER THAT PREVENTS FUTURE
LICENSE MASTER'S LEVEL CONNECT
CLINICIANS FROM WORKING WITHIN.
THE FIELD OF SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER CARE GRADUATE STUDENTS
IN MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPY
SOCIAL WORKER CLINICAL
COUNSELING MUST COMPLETE A
PRACTICUM AND FIELD WORK IN
ORDER TO COMPLETE THEIR DEGREE
PROGRAM. UNIVERSITIES PARTNER
WITH COMMUNITY PROGRAMS FOR
FIELD PLACEMENTS TO PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES TO LEARN ON THE
GROUND. IF A PERSON WANTS TO
COMPLETE A PRACTICUM IN A
LICENSE STD TREATMENT PROGRAM
THEY MUST ALSO REGISTER WITH A
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER COUNSELOR
CERTIFYING ORGANIZATION AS IF
THEY WERE ON THE PATHWAY TO
BECOMING. A CITY COUNCILOR.
SOMETHING THEY WOULD NOT HAVE TO
DO IN A MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAM
THIS PREVENTS THE BAY AREA
RECRUITING FEUD ARCHER MASTER
LEVEL CLINICIANS AND TO THE
FIELD OF SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT- AN APOLOGIZE THE BILL
WOULD BE- TO EXEMPT THESE
INDIVIDUALS FROM HAVING TO
REGISTER WITH THAT CITY COUNCIL
ORGANIZATION. WE ARE GRATEFUL TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD FOR
INTRODUCING THIS BILL AND
HOPEFUL THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WILL SUPPORT THE BILL. ONE AREA
THAT WE'RE HOPING TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE WITH WORKFORCE IS THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF CALAMP. LIKE
TO MENTION THAT PAYMENT REFORM
AND DOCUMENTATION ARE CRITICAL
FOR OUR PUBLIC S. U. D. DELIVERY
SYSTEM TO ATTRACT AND RETAIN
QUALIFIED STAFF TO DELIVER.
SERVICES TO SOME OF THOSE
INCLUDE GREATEST NEEDS I'M
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN AND
DOCUMENTATION BEATS THE BURN OUT
OF PROVIDERS WHICH WAS
ELOQUENTLY STATED BY MY
COLLEAGUE AT CVHS. WE'RE HOPEFUL
THAT PER PAYMENT REFORM WILL
LEAD TO HIGHER RATES THAT'LL
MAKE DRAMATIC HOW MORE
COMPETITIVE. RIGHT NOW PROVIDER
RATES ARE TOO LOW TO OFFER
COMPETITIVE PAY THAT'LL ATTRACT-
LICENSE MASTER'S-LEVEL
CLINICIANS IN THE FIELD AND
ENCOURAGE OUR REGISTERED STV
COUNSELLORS TO CONTINUE ON TO
BECOME CERTIFIED AND GAIN
FURTHER COMPETENCIES. I'M THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE. TESTIMONY TODAY AND
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL NOW IT
UP TO THE DIET AND- WILL BE-
WITH DOCTOR DEFIED CAN- LAST
WEEK IN A HEARING WE HAD HEARD
ANECDOTALLY THAT THERE WAS A
GIVEN. THERE WAS A DECREASE
DEMAND FOR SERVICES- OVER THE
PAST TWO YEARS DURING THE
PANDEMIC DUE TO. PEOPLE'S
INABILITY TO COME OUT AND SEEK
SERVICES. AS WELL AS OVER THE
LAST TWO YEARS WE HAVE SEEN
SIGNIFICANT INCREASES IN PROP
SIXTY THREE REVENUES. THAT I'D
LIKE TO UNDERSTAND WHETHER OR
NOT COUNTIES ARE SITTING
CURRENTLY ON NEW LARGE RESERVES.
FROM PROP SIXTY THREE AND HOPING
YOU COULD COMMENT ON IT. AND IF
THEY ARE SITTING ON LARGE
RESERVES WOULD YOU AGREE WITH
PRIORITISING WORK FORCE FOR
THESE RESOURCES. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE QUESTION- I THINK
SO YOU HAD A COUPLE QUESTIONS
AND THEY'RE SORT OF START WITH
THE- DEMAND FOR OUR SERVICES
THAT STARTED OUT. AT THE
BEGINNING OF COVETED- WE DID SEE
A REDUCTION IN HOW MANY PEOPLE
WERE SEEKING SERVICES HOWEVER WE
KNOW THAT THAT DID THAT DID NOT
REFLECT THE ACTUAL NEED WITHIN
OUR COMMUNITY. PEOPLE WERE NOT
HAVING NOT UNDERSTANDING HOW
THEY COULD CONTINUE TO SEEK TO
ACCESS SERVICES SO PEOPLE WERE
UNDER THE IMPRESSION WE'RE NOT
AWARE THAT IT BUT SERVICES WERE
AVAILABLE THROUGH TELEHEALTH-
MORE RECENTLY I DO NOT SEE A
REDUCTION IN DEMAND WE HAVE- WE
HAVE A VERY HIGH LEVEL OF DEMAND
TO THE EXTENT TO WHICH- OUR
PROVIDER AGENCIES ARE NOT ABLE
TO- KEEP UP WITH. WITH THE
DEMAND- THAT SO MORE MORE
RECENTLY THAT'S THE CASE WE DID-
IN TERMS OF THE MHSAA FUNNY I
WILL SAY THAT- NOT ALL OF OUR-
PROVIDER AGENCIES WERE ABLE TO-
I. PULLED OUT PULLED DOWN AS
MUCH ALL OF THEIR MONEY
OFTENTIMES BECAUSE THEY ASK OUR
STAFF FOR OUT- DUE TO COPE ED
AND- OTHER CIRCUMSTANCES
RELATING TO KOBE AND- WHERE WE
DID SEE IN PEOPLE. PROVIDERS NOT
ABLE TO PULL DOWN THEIR FULL
CONTRACTS SO WE DID HAVE SOME-
WE DID HAVE SOME SAVINGS THAT WE
DIDN'T EXPECT. THAT IN SOME
AREAS AND OTHER AREAS WE SAW
INCREASED COST BECAUSE- AN
INPATIENT FACILITY LIKE A
PSYCHIATRIC HEALTH FACILITY. I'M
IN THE SAME AMOUNT OF COST NO
MATTER HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE IN
THOSE BEDS. SO IT. IT WAS IT WAS
A LITTLE BIT OF- BOTH SIDES OF
THINGS IN TERMS OF- THE
EXPENSES- I CAN TELL YOU FROM MY
EXPERIENCE AND SACRAMENTO WE ARE
NOT SITTING ON A WHOLE LOT OF
MONEY. AND WE ARE WE ARE NOW YOU
KNOW WE MAKE ADJUSTMENTS EACH
YEAR BASED ON- WHAT FUNDS ARE
AVAILABLE IN ORDER TO INCREASE
OUR CAPACITY AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE- SO. YOU KNOW I THINK
THAT I THINK THEY WERE TRYING TO
BE AS RESPONSIVE TO WHATEVER
EACH OF OUR COMMUNITIES. ARE
ARE- REPORTING AND EXPERIENCING
AS A RESULT OF THIS THIS- WHAT
ENDEMIC NOW- SIX SITUATION WITH
THE DEMANDS OF OUR OF OUR WORK
ON A WORK FORCE IS MOST. ON OUR
COMMUNITY IN THE NEEDS WITHIN
THE COMMUNITY. DR QUESTION YOU
QUANTIFY WHAT YOU SAID WITH
SAVING AND I WANT TO. MAKE SURE
WE'RE ONLY TALKING ABOUT
SACRAMENTO COUNTY HERE BUT IN
LARGE PART I'M WANTING TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE FOR ALL OF OUR
COUNTIES THAT MAY ALSO HAVE
SAVINGS AND WHILE WE HAVE COME
UP WITH. A PLAN FOR ENSURING THE
SPENDING OF THOSE RESOURCES. I
DON'T BELIEVE WE EXPECTED THE
SAVINGS THAT WE HAVE NOW. AND SO
I WANT TO ENSURE THAT THOSE
DOLLARS ARE GOING OUT AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE IN LIGHT OF WHAT YOU
SAID REGARDING VACANCIES AND THE
FACT THAT THE STATE DOESN'T
CONTROL THE RATES TO HELP WITH
THAT. HOW CAN WE INCENTIVIZE OUR
COUNTIES TO PRIORITIZE WORK
FORCE FOR THE INCREASES THAT WE
HAVE SEEN WITHIN PROP SIXTY
THREE REVENUES. WELCOME THE
CONVERSATIONS I HAVE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES- WE'RE ALL
PRIORITIZING WORK FORCE RIGHT
NOW- WOULDN'T AND I HAVEN'T
HEARD ANYONE SAY THAT THEY'RE
HAVING A GOOD TIME WITH IT-
WE'RE ALL DOING EVERYTHING WE
POSSIBLY CAN IN ORDER TO. MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS AND SUPPORT OUR
PROVIDER AGENCIES IN TERMS OF
BEING ABLE TO. SUPPORT THEM IN
THEIR RECRUITMENT EFFORTS- I SEE
. SORRY- I THINK I LOST TRACK OF
YOUR QUESTION THEIR CONCERN
ABOUT THAT. NO I. I'M HAPPY TO
FOLLOW UP WITH MORE DETAILS BUT
I WILL NOW THEN TRANSITION TO
THE L. A. O. HAS THE L. A.O.
DONE AN ANALYSIS OF THE COUNTY
PROP SIXTY THREE RESERVES OR
THEIR UNSPENT FUNDS. IS IT
SOMETHING THAT YOU WOULD BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE THE LEGISLATURE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION
DOCTOR AND- WE- DON'T HAVE A
READILY PREPARED ANALYSIS TO
PROVIDE ONLINE JUST SORT OF THE
LEVEL OF UNSPENT FUNDS THAT
COUNTIES HAVE SORT OF AT THEIR
DISPOSAL WITH THEIR WITH THEIR
IMAGES SAY REVENUES- WHEN IT
COMES TO A COUNTY IMAGES THEY
SPENDING YOU KNOW WE UNDERSTAND
THAT. YOU KNOW COUNTIES TO
MAINTAIN A RELATIVELY SMALL
DESIGNATED PRUDENT RESERVE TO
KEEP AND STORE OF. TO KEEP IN
STORE HE'S OF REVENUE WELL UNTIL
VOLATILITY. WE DO HAVE ACCESS TO
WHAT THOSE BALANCES ARE BUT BUT
OUTSIDE OF THE PRUDENT RESERVES.
UNSPENT A MAJOR STATE FUNDING.
CAN BE ANCHORED INTERPRETED A
COUPLE OF DIFFERENT WAYS IT CAN
REFER TO FUNDING THAT'S ALREADY
SORT OF. COMMITTED OR ENCUMBERED
FOR A SPECIFIC PURPOSE BUT FOR
WHICH YOU KNOW FUNDING HASN'T
BEEN DISTRIBUTED TO A SPECIFIC
PROGRAM ACTIVITY YET OR IT CAN
REFER TO. IMAGES IMAGES THE
FUNDING THAT IS ACTUALLY SORT OF
NOT ENCUMBERED AT ALL FOR. FOR
ANY PURPOSE- AND SO WHILE WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS SOME
DATA AVAILABLE THAT. SEVERAL
SEPARATE OUT THIS CONCEPT OF
UNSPENT FUNDS FROM COUNTIES
PRINT RESERVES. WELL WE'RE LESS
CLEAR ABOUT IS. WHETHER DATA
EXISTS THAT FURTHER BREAKDOWN.
ANY SORT OF COUNTY UNSPENT FUNDS
BETWEEN SORT OF ENCUMBERED AND
UNENCUMBERED SHARE OF THIS TYPE
OF INFORMATION WOULD BE
NECESSARY TO PROVIDE A SORT OF
AN ACCURATE PICTURE OF WHAT
COUNTY UNSPENT FUNDS TRULY SORT
OF REPRESENT- OUR OUR SUGGESTION
WOULD BE TO PERHAPS ASK THE
ADMINISTRATION WHETHER THIS THIS
DATA BREAK DOWN EXCESS- AND IF
IT DOES- YOU KNOW WE WOULD SORT
OF THEN BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION TO REPORT
BACK. ON THIS SORT OF AMOUNT OF
UNSPENT FUNDS THAT YOU THAT
YOU'RE SERVE INTERESTED THAT
COULD BE TARGETED FOR USE BY THE
LEGISLATURE. LIKE TO THEN FOLLOW
UP WITH THE ADMINISTRATION AND
SEE IF THIS IS INFORMATION THAT
CAN BE PROVIDED TO THE
LEGISLATURE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR WELCOMED TO GUESS
WHAT THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I
WILL TAKE YOUR QUESTION BACK AND
SEE IF THERE IS INFORMATION THAT
WE CAN'T PROVIDE ON THIS
QUESTION- I WILL THEN FOLLOW UP
WITH THE L. A. O. WHEN DO YOU
THINK IT'S AN APPROPRIATE TIME
FOR US TO REASSESS THE COUNTY
PROP SIXTY THREE RESERVES. IN A
FOLLOW UP TO THE TWENTY THIRTEEN
STATE AUDIT THAT IDENTIFIED
LARGE RESERVES IN SOME COUNTIES
IS THERE AN APPROPRIATE TIME FOR
US TO DO THAT FOLLOW UP. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION DOCTOR IN
THE LAB I DON'T KNOW IF WE- HAVE
SORT OF A- I THINK MADE A TIME
FRAME THAT WE'VE SORT OF COME UP
WITH IN THE COURSE OF LIKE OUR
ANALYSIS FOR WHAT WOULD BE AN
APPROPRIATE SORT OF. LATE THE
TIME TO SORT OF REASSESS THINGS-
WE DO WE ARE AWARE THAT- IN
RESPONSE TO SOME FINDINGS FROM.
THIS IS THE AUDITOR'S REPORT
THAT- CAME OUT SOME YEARS AGO
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES HAS SORT OF IMPLEMENTED
A NUMBER OF. CHANGES TO SORT OF
THE MHSAA REVERSION POLICY AND
JUST GENERALLY FISCAL OVERSIGHT
MATTERS OVER AN HSA IN GENERAL-
SO I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S THAT'S
ARE HELPFUL FOR YOU BUT WE CAN
WE CAN KIND OF TAKE THAT BACK
AND SORT OF SEE WHAT ELSE WE CAN
WE CAN PROVIDE FOR YOU. BERMAN
AND ONE MORE THING. PLEASE THE-
DOCTOR QUEST THANK YOU. KNOW THE
ONE THING I SHOULD KNOW IS THAT
WE'RE ALL MANAGING THIS IN OUR
OWN WAY AND YOU CAN SEE THAT
WE'RE SUCCESSFULLY DOING THAT IN
THAT- LESS THAN ONE PERCENT. OF
OUR IMAGE AS A FUNDS. ARE
REVERTED SO- WE JUST MENTIONED
ARE THERE IS A REVERSION POLICY
AND SO WE'RE ALL MANAGING TO
MAKE SURE THAT. THAT WE AVOID
THAT REPRESENT. HAVING HELPED.
IF I COULD ADD I'M NOT SURE THAT
DATA POINT IS. GOING TO SUFFICE
THE CURIOSITY WE HAVE WITHIN THE
LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE THAT THE
DOLLARS. ARE BEING SENT
EFFECTIVELY JUST BECAUSE YOU
HAVEN'T REVERTED ON DOESN'T
MEAN. WE DON'T HAVE THE
OVERSIGHT THAT IS NECESSARY TO
ENSURE. THE ACCOUNTABILITY THAT
IS NEEDED WITH THESE DOLLARS AND
I WOULD JUST POINT TO HISTORY.
AND THE AUDIT RESULTS TO FIND
THE IMPETUS FOR US TO BE ASKING
THE NATURE OF OUR QUESTIONS AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
OUR COUNTIES AND ENSURING THAT
THOSE PROP SIXTY THREE RESERVES
ARE AT THE PRUDENT RESERVES
LEVEL THAT WE SPOKE ABOUT. BUT
IT'S IN. BECAUSE WE'RE IN THE
MIDST OF THE CRISIS AND WE NEED
TO SPEND THOSE DOLLARS AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE IF WE CAN'T. AND I
BELIEVE THAT WHAT WERE IN IN THE
MOMENT IS. WE'VE HAD A LOT OF
TOP EARNERS DO QUITE WELL AND
DUE TO THE NATURE OF MHSAA
COLLECTING ON THOSE TOP EARNERS
WE'VE SEEN SIGNIFICANT INCREASE
IN REVENUES AND- REALLY WOULD
LIKE TO UNDERSTAND WHAT COUNTIES
ARE SITTING ON HOW WE CAN
INCENTIVIZE THOSE COUNTIES. TO
BE SPENDING EFFECTIVELY INTO
WORK FORCE AND- WILL BE
FOLLOWING UP WITH QUESTIONS BUT
I BUT I DO WANT TO. DIG INTO
SOMETHING BECAUSE I ACTUALLY
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT. WHEN
WE CREATED THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT WE DIDN'T HAVE THE
SAME UNDERSTANDING OF MENTAL
HEALTH THAT WE DO NOW. IN
CALLING IT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND
THE INTEGRATION BETWEEN MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS. THAT I'D LIKE TO
UNDERSTAND- AND MAKE SURE I'M
CLARIFYING THAT CURRENTLY THE
WHAT FUNDING WE'VE BEEN DOING
THE FIVE YEAR PLANS DO NOT APPLY
TO SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS. AND
WHETHER OR NOT. ANY OF OUR-
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AGENCIES
BELIEVE THAT THAT IS A MISSING
LINK AND AN AREA WHERE WE NEED
TO BE LOOKING TO INVEST INTO.
FOR EITHER DOCTOR QUESTOR DR
LEANDRA CLARK HARVEY. HEY WE
DEFINITELY ARE ARE INTERESTED IN
DEVELOPING OUR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER WORKFORCE- RIGHT NOW
OUR UNDERSTANDING- I WOULD HAVE
TO CHECK I DON'T I DON'T I DON'T
THINK OUR UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
THERE ARE WEAPONS ARE SUPPOSED
TO BE FOR THAT PURPOSE. SO IN
TERMS OF AN HSA FUNDS BUT I'D BE
HAPPY TO EXPLORE THAT THAT
THAT'S SOMETHING I'D LOVE TO BE
ABLE TO WORK TOWARDS. THANK YOU
SIR CBJ OBVIOUSLY ARE FOUND
URESTI FELIX AUTHOR PROPOSITION
SIXTY THREE WITHIN THEIR
OFFSPRING SAMBERG- AND- WHEN
THIS ACT WAS FIRST RENDON IT WAS
ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH CARE AND I
REMEMBER TALKING TO RUSTY YOU
KNOW WHEN I CAME ON TO CBO
CHENEY SAID ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I MESSED WITH INCLUDING
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
PROFESSIONAL SO TERROR RAMBLING
YOU ARE. RIGHT ON SPOT ON AND I
THINK IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
HAVE BEEN ADVOCATING FOR A VERY
LONG TIME YOU HEARD IT
THROUGHOUT THE CONVERSATIONS
TODAY AND THE POINTS MADE I
THINK WE'RE ALL IN AGREEMENT I
HEARD YOU KNOW DR CHRIS TALK
ABOUT THAT AS WELL THE
IMPORTANCE OF IT- BUT WE KNOW
THERE'S A LOT THAT GOES INTO YOU
YOU KNOW REFORMING THE ACT IN
MAKING CHANGES. BUT DEFINITELY
SOMETHING THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT
TO OUR PROVIDER COMMUNITY. I
LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO FIGURE OUT HOW
WE CAN ENSURE WE ARE- WORKING
ON- ON THIS SPECIFIC. ISSUE AND
BELIEVE THAT IT WILL BE
IMPORTANT FOR US. GOING FORWARD.
AND WOULD SIMPLY. POINT OUT HOW
IN THE LAST WHAT. PLAN WE
REQUIRED A 33% COUNTY MATCH. AND
I'M WONDERING IF WE'RE SITTING
ON. LARGE RESERVES WHETHER OR
NOT IT'S APPROPRIATE FOR US TO
INSIST ON COUNTIES. HELPING US
TO PARTICIPATE- AS WELL TO BE
ABLE TO CREATE THIS FUNDING. AND
SUSTAINABILITY LONG TERM. WITH
THAT I WILL THANK ALL OF THOSE
WHO HAVE BEEN ON PANEL ELEVEN WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO OUR FINAL
PANEL WHICH IS ON WORKFORCE
CHALLENGES IN THE SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES. A
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC AND OF COURSE IS EVEN
MORE SO AS WE HAVE WATCHED CODED
RAVAGE OUR MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS IN NURSING HOMES. WE
WILL HAVE FIVE PRESENTERS ON
THIS PANEL WE WILL BEGIN WITH
DEPUTY DIRECTOR KAREN RESELL AT
H. CHI FOLLOWED BY AMANDA STEELE
WHO IS THE DEPUTY POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR SEIU LOCAL TWENTY
FIFTEEN. THEN NICOLE HOW OLD THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR EMPOWERED
AGING. FOLLOWED BY DR ELIZABETH
HALIFAX AN ASSISTANT PROFESSOR
AT UCSF AND FINALLY CLEAR N.
RIGHT EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
QUALITY CARE HEALTH FOUNDATION.
LET US BEGIN WITH DEPUTY
DIRECTOR RESULT. I'M I WILL TALK
ABOUT OUR FINDINGS THAT WE
RECEIVED IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET TO SUPPORT OUR
CERTIFIED NURSING ASSISTANTS-
THE IN THE BUDGET ARE IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE INCLUDED ONE TIME
FINDING A FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE
MILLION GENERAL FUND H. CARD
SUPPORT CERTIFIED NURSING
ASSISTANT WORKFORCE PROGRAMS
THIS FUNDING INCLUDING THE
ABILITY TO SUPPORT ESTABLISHING
NEW TRAINING PROGRAMS OR
EXPANDING EXISTING PROGRAMS. AND
SCHOLARSHIPS AND STIPENDS TO
NURSING ASSISTANTS WERE
OBTAINING THEIR CERTIFICATION.
ARE CONTINUING THEIR EMPLOYMENT
. H. CAI PARTNERED WITH A
CONSULT TO BETTER UNDERSTAND THE
WORKFORCE LANDSCAPE VERY YEARS.
INCREASING THE CERTIFIED NURSING
ASSISTANT WORKFORCE WRECKED YOUR
WORKFORCE IN OPPORTUNITIES. AS
THE CERTIFIED NURSING ASSISTANT
WORKFORCE OVER THE PAST SEVERAL
MONTHS WE HAVE CONDUCTED TWENTY
SEVEN INTERVIEWS WITH HOW HHS
AGENCIES WORKFORCE RESEARCH
ORGANIZATIONS ADVOCACY AND
POLICY ORGANIZATIONS HOME HEALTH
PROVIDERS AND REPRESENTATIVES TO
LABOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE ADULT
EDUCATION PROGRAMS. AS A RESULT
OF OUR ANALYSIS AND STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT WE HAVE IDENTIFIED
SEVERAL PRIORITIES TO HELP BUILD
THE CNA WORKFORCE. THESE INCLUDE
PROVIDING FINANCIAL SUPPORT TO
ALLOW DIVERSE STUDENTS TO PURSUE
CNA TRAINING. THE FUND STAFFING
FOR FACULTY IN SUPERVISORY STAFF
. TO CREATE A CAREER PATHWAY
TRAINING PROGRAMS THAT BUILD AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE TO ENTER
AND MOVE THROUGH- CNH OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES. I'M TO INCREASE
AWARENESS OF CAREERS IN DIRECT
CARE THROUGHOUT REACH STRATEGIES
. AND THEN AND THEN ALSO TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF TRAINING
SITES WHERE STUDENTS CAN GAIN
EXPERIENCE. WEARING CONVERSATION
THAT WITH AN ORGANIZATION TO
FIND THE CNA CAREER PATHWAYS
TRAINING PROGRAM THAT WOULD
TRAIN OVER TWO THOUSAND C. NH
THREE YEARS. WE PLAN TO RELEASE
ADDITIONAL OUTPUT FUNDING FOR
NEW PROGRAMS STARTING TWENTY
TWENTY TO DO SUPPORT THE ABOVE
MENTIONED PRIORITIES- AND ALSO
FINANCIALLY SUPPORT INDIVIDUALS
PURSUING CNH RAINING WE ARE
PLANNING A SPRING TWENTY TWENTY
TWO RELEASE OF SEVERAL OF OUR
SCHOLARSHIP AND LOAN REPAYMENT
PROGRAMS. THAT WILL INCLUDE
CERTIFIED NURSING ASSISTANTS.
ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS. THE STATE
BUDGET ALSO INCLUDED FIVE
MILLION FOR THE HEALTH CARE
PATHWAY PROGRAM THE START
CERTIFIED NURSING ASSISTANT
TRAINING PROGRAMS AND UP TO SIX
COUNTY. FOR THE BUDGET
PROVISIONS WE EXECUTED A GRANT
AGREEMENT WITH EMPOWER AGING. MR
AN EXPAND THEIR HEALTH CAREER
PATHWAY PROGRAM ON THAT YOU'LL
HEAR ABOUT MORE ABOUT THIS
PROGRAM AND THEN LATER THANK YOU
. THANK YOU NEXT WILL HAVE
AMANDA STEELE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
SEIU LOCAL TWENTY FIFTEEN PLEASE
BEGIN. IN CARE I'M AND THANK YOU
TO ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THE CHAIRS FOR
INVITING ME TO SPEAK TODAY- MY
NAME'S AMANDA STEELE I'M THE
DEPUTY POLICY DIRECTOR AT SEIU
LOCAL TWENTY FIFTEEN AND WE ARE
THE LARGEST LONG TERM CARE LOCAL
IN THE NATION WE- REPRESENT MORE
THAN TWENTY THOUSAND NURSING
HOME WORKER. THEY FILL ROLES
SUCH AS CERTIFIED NURSING
ASSISTANTS LICENSED VOCATIONAL
NURSES DIETARY AIDES
HOUSEKEEPERS ACROSS MORE THAN
TWO HUNDRED SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES IN CALIFORNIA. I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE TIME TO
TALK ABOUT- THE MANY ISSUES THAT
NURSING HOME WORKERS ARE FACING
TODAY AND THESE ARE ISSUES THAT
HAVE ONLY BEEN EXACERBATED SINCE
THE ONSET OF OVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC THEY'VE ALSO
DRASTICALLY IMPACTED THE QUALITY
OF CARE FOR NURSING HOME
RESIDENTS. UNFORTUNATELY NURSING
HOMES HAVE BEEN AT THE CENTER OF
THE PANDEMIC WITH NURSING HOME
WORKERS DISPROPORTIONATELY
EXPOSED TO COVER NINETEEN WHILE
CARING FOR SOME OF THE STATE'S
MOST VULNERABLE RESIDENTS FROM
JUNE. OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO MARCH
TWENTY TWENTY TWO I'M OVER A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY SEVEN THOUSAND
NURSING HOME WORKERS AND
RESIDENTS CONTRACTED COVE IN
NINETEEN AND UNFORTUNATELY MORE
THAN TEN THOUSAND PASSED AWAY
FROM THE VIRUS. SO ALTHOUGH
NURSING HOME WORKERS WERE
LABELED AS ESSENTIAL WORKERS
THEY STRUGGLE TO GET THE
CRITICAL PROTECTIONS THEY NEEDED
TO KEEP THEMSELVES THEIR
FAMILIES AND THE RESIDENTS OF
NURSING HOME SAFE SOME WORKERS
EVEN RESORTED TO WEARING TRASH
BAGS- WHEN THE PROTECTIVE AT
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
WAS SCARCE THEY ALSO. HAD TO RE
USE THINGS LIKE N. NINETY FIVE
MASKS OVER AND OVER AGAIN
BECAUSE THE ALTERNATIVE WAS JUST
NOT HAVING THAT- PROTECTION AT
ALL- CALLS FOR HAZARD PAYING
PAID TIME OFF WENT LARGELY AN
ANSWER AS WORKERS TO CONTINUE TO
RISK THEIR LIVES DAILY-
MEANWHILE FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
FOR NURSING HOME OPERATORS WAS
GIVEN READ ONLY. INCLUDE A 10%
MEDICARE REIMBURSEMENT RATE
INCREASE AND FOUR POINT NINE
BILLION DOLLARS FROM THE FEDERAL
PROVIDER BUT WE FIND THAT WAS ST
STE DISTRIBUTED TO OVER THIRTEEN
THOUSAND NURSING HOMES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY. AND AS MUCH AS I'D
LIKE TO SAY ABOUT THESE TERRIBLE
SITUATIONS WERE JUST AN ANOMALY.
THAT SURFACED DURING THE
PANDEMIC THAT'S JUST NOT TRUE-
NURSING HOME WORKERS HAD ALREADY
BEEN EXPERIENCE SEEN MANY OF THE
PROBLEMS WITH STAFFING WAGES
BENEFITS WORKPLACE PROTECTIONS
THAT PREDATED THE PANDEMIC BY
MANY YEARS- THE WORK THAT THESE
WORKERS PERFORM IS. IT'S
PHYSICALLY EMOTIONALLY AND
MENTALLY DRAINING AND THERE'S
LITTLE RECOGNITION FOR THE
COMMITMENT TO CARING FOR THE
ELDERLY DISABLED AND CHRONICALLY
ILL. I NURSING HOME MORE
CONSISTENTLY RANKS AMONG THE
JOBS WITH THE HIGHEST RATES OF
OCCUPATIONAL INJURY AND ILLNESS
GET THE PAY AND BENEFITS
GENERALLY DO NOT REFLECT THE
REALITY OF THE WORK. THE MEDIAN
INCOME FOR NURSING HOME WORKERS
IN TWENTY TWENTY WAS JUST THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS SO IT'S NO
SURPRISE THAT THERE IS MORE THAN
A 50% TURNOVER RATE AMONG DIRECT
CARE WORKERS IN SNACKS. AND MORE
THAN SIXTEEN THOUSAND WORKERS
HAVE LEFT THE INDUSTRY SINCE
JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY.
INSTEAD OF IMPROVING WORKING
CONDITIONS WAGES AND BENEFITS TO
ADDRESS THE TURNOVER AND
RETENTION ISSUES NURSING HOMES
WERE INSTEAD GIVEN STOPPING
WAIVERS THAT ALLOW THEM TO
OPERATE AT STAFFING LEVELS. THAT
ARE LOWER THAN THE MINIMALLY
MANDATED LEVELS FOR DIRECT CARE
WORKERS SINCE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
OVER FIFTEEN HUNDRED STAFFING
WAIVERS HAVE BEEN APPROVED AND
OVER FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS WERE
PROVIDED AS ADAM PAYMENTS OF
FACILITIES. TO COVER THE COST OF
HIRING NEW WORKERS BUT THIS
FUNDING SNAPS CONTINUE TO BE
UNDER STAFFED AND THE UNDERLYING
PROBLEMS HAVE YET TO BE FULLY
ADDRESSED. WE WILL ONLY SEE REAL
CHANGE IN NURSING HOMES IF
EMPLOYERS ARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
TO THE PUBLIC DOLLARS THEY
RECEIVED AND IF WORKERS AND
RESIDENT ADVOCATES ARE ABLE TO
DIRECTLY PARTICIPATE IN THE
ADVANCEMENT OF INDUSTRY
STANDARDS- BY BRINGING TOGETHER
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE WORK
FORCE EMPLOYERS ADVOCATES AND
STATE AGENCIES IN AN OFFICIAL
CAPACITY. SEVEN ENFORCE
WORKPLACE STANDARDS THAT COVER
ALL WORKERS IN THE SNIFF
INDUSTRY QUALITY STANDARDS BOARD
WOULD CREATE A VENUE FOR WORKERS
TO COME TOGETHER SHARE LESSONS
THEY'VE LEARNED FROM THEIR DAY
TO DAY EXPERIENCE AND GAIN A
STRONGER VOICE TO ADVOCATE FOR
THEMSELVES. MEASURABLE STANDARDS
THAT APPLY INDUSTRY WIDE WHEN
INSURE THAT ALL WORKERS
REGARDLESS OF RACE GENDER. OR
DISABILITY STATUS EARN FAIR
WAGES UNDER BETTER CONDITIONS
REDUCING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
DISCRIMINATION BOTH DIRECTLY AND
INDIRECTLY BY ADDRESSING OTHER
CAUSES HE GAPS SUCH AS
INCONSISTENT SCHEDULING OR A
LACK OF MEDICAL OR- FAMILY
LEAVE. THESE EFFORTS WOULD ALSO
DIRECTLY THE END IMPACT THE
QUALITY OF CARE FOR NURSING HOME
RESIDENTS MAKING SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES A DESIRE LONG TERM
CARE OPTION FOR THOSE WHO NEED
IT. WE CAN ALSO BEGIN TO MOVE
THE INDUSTRY FORWARD BY MAKING
MEANING MEANINGFUL FORMS OF THE
MEDICARE REIMBURSEMENT RATE
SYSTEM SNAPS HAVE BEEN
REPEATEDLY REWARDED BY THE STATE
WITH RATE INCREASES AS WELL AS
INCREASES TO THE PERCENTILE
CAPS. ON DIRECT AND INDIRECT
HERE LABOR CALL CENTERS WITH THE
INTENTION OF ELEVATING THE
QUALITY OF CARE YEAH WE CONTINUE
TO SEE THE USE OF RELATED
PARTIES AND COMPLICATED
OWNERSHIP STRUCTURES THAT OPEN
THE DOOR FOR EXCESSIVE PROFITS
FOR NURSING HOME OWNERS AND
OPERATORS. THERE'S BEEN NO
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE IN THE
FUNDING BEING UTILIZED FOR LABOR
WHICH LARGELY DICTATES THE
AMOUNT AND QUALITY OF CARE
PROVIDED TO NURSING HOME
RESIDENTS. CURRENT QUALITY
METRICS DO NOT INCLUDE. ENOUGH
CARE CENTER CATEGORIES SUCH AS
STOPPING LEVEL IMPROVEMENT
ENHANCED TRAINING AND
DEVELOPMENT AND CONSISTENT
NURSING STAFF ASSIGNMENTS. IN
ADDITION THE FARMERS BE SET
HIGHER SO THAT NURSING HOMES
WITH A HISTORY OF SERIOUS
VIOLATIONS THOSE ON THE CMS
SPECIAL FOCUS WAS SOLELY LESS.
THOSE THAT HAVE FAILED TO PAY
THEIR QUALITY ASSURANCE FEES AND
THOSE NOT IN COMPLIANCE WITH
STATE OR LOCAL MINIMUM WAGE AND
PASSED THROUGH LAWS WILL NOT
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO RECEIVE
ALL THE PAYMENTS QUALITY RATE
INCREASES. THESE ARE SIGNIFICANT
AND NECESSARY CHANGES THAT WILL
PAVE THE WAY TO NURSING HOME
REFORM. WE HAVE BEGUN TO SEEN
SOME CHANGES OF THIS NATURE
BEING PROMOTED AT THE NATIONAL
LEVEL TO ENSURE STAFF SAFE
STAFFING RATIOS IN ALL
FACILITIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY
THE WHOLE NURSING HOMES
ACCOUNTABLE WHEN THEY DON'T
PROVIDE EXCEPTIONS. OR THEIR
WORKERS AND RESIDENTS AND TO
EDUCATE THE PUBLIC ABOUT NURSING
HOMES AND INCREASED. RECALL
THESE FEDERAL EFFORTS AND
ENCOURAGE CALIFORNIA TO LEAD THE
WAY AND BECOMING A MODEL FOR
NURSING HOME INDUSTRY THAT
INVESTS IN ITS ESSENTIAL WORKERS
AND THE PEOPLE AND FAMILIES.
RELY ON. THIS CARE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT WE WILL HEAR
FROM NICOLE HOWELL WHO IS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR EMPOWERED
AGING. PLEASE BE AN INFORMED
DECISION YES. HELLO DOCTOR
AMBULANCE OTHERS THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR INVITING ME BACK TO
SHARE WITH YOU MORE ABOUT
HEALTHCARE CAREER PATH LEADING.
UP I WANT TO REMIND YOU THAT THE
HEALTHCARE CAREER PATHWAY BEGAN
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC BUT IT WAS
CERTAINLY PROVEN OUT DURING THE
PANDEMIC. IT IS A WRAPAROUND
HOLISTIC APPROACH TO TRAINING
CERTIFIED NURSING ASSISTANTS AS
WE BUILD A PATHWAY TO FUTURE JOB
OPPORTUNITIES IN ADDITION TO
SIMPLY ARE MEETING THE BASIC ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY HOURS OF TRAINING
WE DOUBLES. YEAH I NEED. TO
ENSURE THAT IS A HOLISTIC
APPROACH AT A TO BOTH THE HARD
SKILLS THAT THE CNA'S MUST HAVE
TO THEIR DILIGENT AND
CHALLENGING WORK. BUT ALSO GO
OUT TO INCLUDE THOSE SOFT SKILLS
THAT WE HEARD FROM EMPLOYERS AND
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES THAT
THEY SO DESPERATELY NEEDED. AND
TODAY OUR PROGRAM THAT'S TAKEN
PLACE OVER THREE YEARS NOW AT
TWO LOCATIONS HAS GRADUATED
SEVENTY ONE STUDENTS. UP WITH
TWO MORE CLASSES CURRENTLY IN
SESSION. 80% OF THOSE ARE STILL
WORKING IN THE LONG TERM CARE-
WORK FORCE. BUT IT IS CERTAINLY
NOT BEEN WITHOUT ITS CHALLENGES
WE ACTIVELY SEEK OUT STUDENTS
WHO HAVE ADDRESSABLE BARRIERS
EITHER THEY'VE EXPERIENCED
EDUCATIONAL TRAUMA MAYBE THEY'RE
THE FIRST IN THEIR FAMILY TO
ACHIEVE ANY POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION. MAYBE THE EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS OR PRIOR SUBSTANCE
ABUSE DISORDERS- AND SO WE MAKE
SURE THAT OUR STUDENTS HAVE ALL
OF THE WRAPAROUND SUPPORT
SERVICES WHICH INCLUDE
TRANSPORTATION- SUPPORT WORKING
THROUGH PROBLEMS FOOD THAT GOES
HOME WITH THEM ON THE WEEKENDS
AND ENSURING THEY HAVE LUNCH
EVERY DAY DURING CLASS. AND OUR
STUDENTS REMAIN SUCCESSFUL AND
COMMITTED TO THE LONG TERM CARE
INDUSTRY. AND THROUGH OUR
CONVERSATION IN FALL OF TWENTY
TWENTY IF YOU COULD. THROW
YOURSELF BACK TO THAT PLACE- YOU
RIGHT FULLY INVESTED IN THIS
PROGRAM AND ASK US TO EXPAND IT
TO ADDITIONAL COUNTIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA SO UP TO
FIVE LOCATIONS- OVER FIVE YEARS.
AND WE HAVE BEEN WORKING TOWARDS
DOING THAT- BUT THERE IS
SOMETHING THAT IS DEEPLY
CHALLENGING ABOUT A CERTIFIED
NURSING ASSISTANT PROGRAM AND
YOU HEARD SOME OF IT EARLIER AS
WE TALKED ABOUT THE M. TEES. IT
IS AN ENTRY POINT INTO THE
ALLIED HEALTH CARE FIELD. BUT
UNLIKE OTHER ALLIED HEALTH CARE
FIELD TRAINING PROGRAMS IT
REQUIRES THAT THE DO YOU HAVE A
DIRECTR THAT IS A REGISTERED
NURSE. WHO HAS HAD TWO YEARS OF
NURSING AND ONE YEAR OF
EXPERIENCE WORKING IN LONG TERM
CARE FIELD AND ONE YEAR OF
EXPERIENCE TEACHING ADULTS. IT
ALSO REQUIRES THAT YOU FOR THE
INSTRUCTOR YOU HAVE AN LPN.
UNLIKE OTHER PROGRAMS SAY AN EMT
A SURGE TECH DENTAL ASSISTANCE
WHICH CAN BE LED AND INSTRUCTED
BY A COLLEAGUE. AT WE'VE ALREADY
HEARD HOW SHORT STAFF NURSES ARE
IN CALIFORNIA ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. AND THIS REQUIREMENT AT
IN CALIFORNIA TO HAVE IT OUR AND
LEADING A CNA TRAINING PROGRAM
WHO MAY THEMSELVES HAVE NEVER
WORKED AS A CNA. AS OPPOSED TO
SOMEONE WHO HAS DONE IT FOR
THREE FIVE TEN OR FIFTEEN YEARS.
IS REALLY WHAT MAKES THIS
PROGRAM VERY CHALLENGING OUT WE
HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO HIRE A
PROGRAM DIRECTOR THAT MEETS
THESE RIGID REQUIREMENTS. AND IT
IS TRULY TO OUR DETRIMENT
BECAUSE MANY C. N. A.'S WHO
WORKED IN THE FIELD FOR. DECADES
WOULD ACTUALLY BE GREAT IN THIS
ROLE. AND AT DR RAM TO THE TO
YOUR EARLIER POINT AROUND EQUITY
AND INCLUSION- THIS IS WHAT IS
THE UNDERVALUING OF PARTICULARLY
WOMEN. PARTICULARLY WOMEN OF
COLOR AND THEIR LONG EXPERIENCE
IN THE SECTOR WE NEED NEW
CREATING MORE PATHWAYS AND
SOMETIMES OUR RESTRICTIONS. ARE
MAKING IT MORE DIFFICULT TO
LAUNCH PROGRAMS OF WHAT NEEDS TO
BE. AS YOU MAY RECALL THE BEAUTY
OF OUR PROGRAM WAS THAT FIVE
SITES COULD SHARE ONE PROGRAM
DIRECTOR THEREFORE IT COST
SAVINGS- BUT THAT DOESN'T MATTER
IF WE CAN ACTUALLY GET IN OUR
AND BECAUSE THERE ARE SO RIGHT
RT. IN A DESPERATE SHORT SUPPLY.
ADDITIONALLY SIMPLY BECAUSE
SOMEONE OF THE TREMENDOUS RN
DOES NOT NECESSARILY MEAN THAT
THEY ARE STEEPED IN ADULT
LEARNING PRINCIPLES.
PARTICULARLY WORKING WITH
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES AND
COMMITTING TO A RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE FRAMEWORK. SO WHEN WE
SAY WE NEED TO PROGRAM DIRECTOR
IT'S A LITTLE BIT LIKE WRITING
TO SANTA AND ASKING FOR A
CHRISTMAS GIFT EARLY-
ADDITIONALLY. OUT WE HAVE HAD
HEARD MANY THINGS TODAY ABOUT
THE PROGRAMS IN SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES AND ACROSS THE HEALTH
CARE SECTOR. AND I WANT TO
REALLY HIGHLIGHT TO YOU THAT THE
WHITE HOUSE RECENTLY MADE AN
ANNOUNCEMENT IN THE STATE THE
UNION THAT THEY ARE INVESTING IN
SKILLED NURSING IMPROVEMENTS AND
ARE DIRECTING- THE HEALTH HUMAN
SERVICES AND CENTER FOR MEDICARE
AND MEDICAID SERVICES. TO
UNDERTAKE SEVERAL KEY
INITIATIVES. ONE OF THOSE
ENSURING ADEQUATE PAY. ALL OF
THESE PROGRAMS WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT OUR GREAT AND LOVELY. BUT
IF WE DO NOT RAISE THE WAGES FOR
CERTIFIED NURSING ASSISTANTS AND
THOSE WORKING IN THE LONG TERM
CARE SECTOR. WE WILL NOT SEE THE
INCREASE IN RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION THAT WE ALL
DESPERATELY DESIRE. ACCORDING TO
SOME RECENT- BUT THAT WORK DONE
OUT OF UCS AFTER CHARLENE
HARRINGTON IT SAYS THAT OPIS
TURNOVER IN SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES IS ROUGHLY A HUNDRED
AND 20% ANNUALLY. THAT IS
UNACCEPTABLE AND THAT CREATES
TREMENDOUS CHANGES FOR THE
RESIDENTS THAT LIVE IN THESE
FACILITIES. AND SO I'M HERE
TODAY TO UPDATE YOU ABOUT OUR
PROGRAM BUT ALSO TO IMPROVE FOR
YOU AND YOUR COLLEAGUES TO
FINALLY GAIN DEEPER
UNDERSTANDING ABOUT THE
REIMBURSEMENT PROCESS. IN OUR
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES. IF
WE CANNOT PAY OR CARE GIVERS
MORE WE WILL NOT KEEP THEM AND
WE WILL KEEP SEEING THESE
TERRIBLE INCIDENTS IS THAT WE'VE
SEEN THROUGHOUT COBIT. AND SO I
ASK THAT YOU LOOK AT THAT IN TWO
WAYS FIRST OF ALL. WHAT IS THE
CURRENT REIMBURSEMENT RATE AND
DOESN'T MEET THE NEEDS OF THE
PROVIDERS. AND SECONDLY WHAT IS
BEEN THE ROLE OF PRIVATE PRIVATE
EQUITY AND PRIVATE INVESTMENT IN
LONG TERM CARE FACILITIES AND IS
ALL OF THE MONEY GOING DIRECTLY
TO THE CARE OF THE RESIDENT.
THAT'S THEY SO DESERVE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND I'M HERE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM DR
ELIZABETH HALIFAX AN ASSISTANT
PROFESSOR AT UCSF PLEASE BEGIN.
RIGHT CAN YOU SEE ME. YES AS
SOON AS YOU BEGIN SPEAKING
YOU'LL SHOW UP ON THE SCREEN.
YES I'M ELIZABETH HALIFAX AND- I
AM I AM THE- ASSISTANT PROFESSOR
AT UCSF. I'M UNDERTAKING
RESEARCH IN NURSING HOME CARE
THAT IS INCLUDED SAY STALKING
STANDARDS. BUT I DID START THIS
JOURNEY AS A NURSING ASSISTANT
AND I HAVE BEEN LICENSE AS A
REGISTERED NURSE FOR THIRTY FIVE
YEARS. I'M A MEMBER OF THE
GERIATRICS CIRCLE A GROUP OF
ACADEMICS AND PROVIDERS OF
ADVISED CALIFORNIA'S DEPARTMENT
OF AGING PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SOCIAL SERVICES. ON ISSUES
RELATED TO CONVERT NINETEEN OF
LONG TERM CARE. THE MOST
ESSENTIAL SYSTEMIC ISSUE IN AN
ENVIRONMENT THAT CAST FOR
VULNERABLE PEOPLE IS ADEQUATE
AND APPROPRIATE STOPPING TO
ENSURE QUALITY CARE IS PROVIDED
. MULTIPLE RESEARCH STUDIES SHOW
STRONG POSITIVE IMPACT OF
NURSING STOPPING THE TYPICALLY
AREN'T STOPPING. ON THE
PROCESSES AND OUTCOMES OF K. THE
RECENT TRAGIC FAILINGS TO KEEP
CALIFORNIA NURSING HOME
RESIDENTS SAFE AND WELL CARED
FOR DURING THE PANDEMIC I'M NOT
NEW. BUT PART OF AN ONGOING KIND
OF UNDERSTAFFING AND HIGH TENER
. INADEQUATE STAFFING AFFECTS
RESIDENT QUE IN TWO WAYS.
RESIDENTS TO NOT RECEIVE THE
CARE THEY NEED RESULTING HOMES
ABUSES OKAY REPORTED AS THE TO
TALK CALIFORNIA NURSING HOME
COMPLAINTS OVER THE LAST THREE
YEARS. SECONDLY BURTON STOKE
SOCCER POOL WORKING CONDITIONS
COMPASSION FATIGUE BURNOUT THAT
IN TURN IMPACTS RECRUITMENT
RETENTION AND HIGH TURNOVER
TURNOVER AS WE HEARD FROM AND TO
STEAL. IN CALIFORNIA IN TWENTY
TWENTY THE AVERAGE ANNUAL
TURNOVER RATE FOR DIRECT INSTALL
THING WAS 55% BUT IS THAT IMPACT
SO THAT AS I SAID INCLUDE HEAVY
WORKLOAD LOW WAGES CALL BENEFITS
LIMITED RESPECT RECOGNITION ALSO
POOLS AND FEW PROSPECTS FOR
ADVANCEMENT I KNOW THAT'S BEEN
SPOKEN ABOUT READY. BUT
INCREASINGLY WITH THE PANDEMIC
WE'RE SEEING A MOTIONAL ON MORAL
DISTRESS IS ONE OF THE BURN OUT
PRACTICE. IN JUNE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THE NATIONAL CONSUMER VOICE
ISSUED REPORTS RESIDENTS AND
FAMILY SURVEYS AND WHEN ALMOST
RESIDENTS ARE YOU RECEIVING THE
CARE YOU NEED WHEN YOU NEED IT.
A MAJORITY 60% SAID NONE. SOME
DESCRIBED FEELING IMPRISONED ONE
RESIDENT STATUS IT. OFTEN LEFT
IN SOILED BRIEFS LEFT IN BED TOO
LONG OR THE CHAIR TOO LONG NO
SCHOOL RIGHT NOT ALWAYS ONSTAGE
WAITING FOR HOURS THE STOCK
NUMBER TWO ALSO MICHAEL WHITE
MEETINGS AND WEEKENDS. THAT'S
NOT ANY HOLD FOR THE RESIDENTS
IT'S HARD FOR THE STOP TRYING TO
COPE WITH THOSE NEEDS. STOPPING
IN NURSING HOMES ALL ACTUAL AND
ISSUE OF EQUITY. HEALTHEQUITY
RESIDENTS WHO ARE DENIED ACCESS
TO QUALITY CARE BECAUSE OF LOS
STOPPING. WHERE RESIDENTS TO
RACIAL AND ETHNIC MINORITIES ARE
MORE LIKELY TO RESIDE IN NURSING
HOMES RECALL STOPPING AND HIGH
NUMBERS OF DEFICIENCIES. I WENT
MISSING HOMEWORK OFTEN DON'T
HAVE HEALTHCARE COVERAGE. IT'S
ALSO WORKFORCE EQUITY ISSUE WITH
37% OF CMA'S DEPEND ON SOME FORM
OF PUBLIC ASSISTANCE 15% LIVE
BELOW THE FEDERAL POVERTY LINE.
AND MORE THAN ONE HALL FOR THE
NURSING HOME SEE AN ACE UP
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND MAJORITY
WOMEN. TO BE CLEAR THIS MEANS
THE HIGH TURNOVER REPORTED
SHORTAGES OF ALL RAIMES IN
NURSING ASSISTANTS I'M NOT
DURING TIMELY TO AN ADEQUATE
LABOR SUPPLY BUT ROTH OF THE
RESULT OF COOL WORKING
CONDITIONS. LOW WAGES AND HEAVY
WORKLOADS. NURSING HOME
OPERATORS NEED TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES WHILE USING THE MONEY
THEY RECEIVE FROM GOVERNMENT
WHICH IS ALMOST A 100% OF THEIR
REFUSE ON DIRECT CARE FOR
RESIDENTS INCLUDING ADEQUATE
STOPPING. RATHER THAN RECEIVING
. CORPORATE WELFARE. WE NEED TO
ACT AND WE HAVE FIVE
RECOMMENDATIONS THE FIRST IS TO
ENACT STOPPING MINIMUM OF FOUR
POINT ONE HOURS PER RESIDENT DAY
. THIS NUMBERS FROM A TWO
THOUSAND ONE SENTENCE TO
MEDICARE MEDICAID BENCHMARK
STUDY THAT DETERMINED THIS
MINIMUM IS NECESSARY TO PREVENT
HOME IN JEOPARDY TO RESIDENTS.
WITH THE MASSIVE EVIDENCE BASED
RESEARCH THAT EXIST CALLS FOR A
NEW STUDY TO DETERMINE NEEDED
STOPPING MINIMUMS MAKE NO SENSE
. THE ONLY DELAYED DESPERATELY
NEEDED REFORMS. SECONDLY I WOULD
ALSO YOU STOP ISSUING STOPPING
WINTERS WHEN STOPPING WHEN WAS
ISSUED NURSING HOMES ARE EXEMPT
FROM BEATING CALIFORNIA'S
INADEQUATE THREE POINT FIVE
HOURS CONVINCING RESIDENT DAY
STOPPING MINIMUM. THIS AFFECTS
ALL ASPECTS OF CARE AND WORKING
CONDITIONS AND RESEARCH HAS
SHOWN THAT INCLUDING- IT
INCLUDES RECENT CREASED RESIDENT
AND SELF CONFIDENCE SECTIONS AND
DEATHS IN NURSING HOMES WITH-
WITH WAITERS. WHEN COMPARED TO
THOSE WITHOUT THE- IF WE NEED TO
REQUIRE A REGISTERED NURSE TO
BEYOND YOU SEE AN OLD LISTING
HOMES TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY.
AS THE ONLY FULL TIME STOP IN A
NURSING HOME WITH THE TRAINING
TO CLINICALLY ASSESS THE
RESIDENTS AND KEY TO ENSURING
INFECTION CONTROL. ARMS CANNOT
BE SUBSTITUTED BY LICENSED
VOCATIONAL NURSES. FALSELY
ENSURE ADEQUATE WAGES TO REDUCE
REDUCE THE STOCK TURNOVER. WE
NEED TO ENSURE THAT WAGES FOR
LICENSING MISSING STYLE A
COMPATIBLE TO HOSPITAL WAGES
WITHIN THE AREA. WE NEED TO GROW
CERTIFIED NURSING ASSISTANTS
MINIMUM WAGES TO TWENTY FIVE
DOLLARS AN HOUR. AND FINALLY I
WE ALREADY TALKED ABOUT DURING
THIS. SESSION WE NEED TO INVEST
IN WORKFORCE TRAINING AND CAREER
PROGRESSION. AND I SUPPORT
EVERYTHING THAT CARE RESULTS
THAT THAT WE NEED TO PROVIDE
INDEPENDENT AGENCIES NOT THE
NURSING HOMES WITH FUNDS TO
OPTIMISING STRESS SYSTEM
CERTIFICATION TRAINING WITH NO
OUT OF POCKET EXPENSES. AND WE
NEED TO FIND WAYS TO PROVIDE
CRITICAL LISTENING STYLE THROUGH
TRAINING AND EDUCATION. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR HEARING ME TODAY
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WE
WILL HEAR FROM CLAIRE AND RIGHT
WHO IS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE QUALITY CARE HEALTH
FOUNDATION PLEASE BEGIN. YOU FOR
AROUND THE WORLD AND REMEMBER
THANK YOU. THANK THE FIRE IN
WRITING DIRECTOR THE BODY CARE
HEALTH DASCHLE EDUCATIONAL ARM
CALIFORNIA PROBATION OFFICER
WITH. A REGISTERED MARK. AFTER
TWENTY FIVE YEARS OKAY. IN
ADDITION TO MY DID YOU THE EXACT
CORRECT THE EDUCATIONAL. MISTER
ENRIGHT YOUR SOUNDS CHANGED I
DON'T KNOW WE HEARD YOU CLEARLY
FOR THE FIRST THIRTY SECONDS AND
THEN SOMETHING HAPPENED. CAN YOU
HEAR ME NOW MAYBE WE'LL HAVE YOU
PROJECTED SOUNDS MUFFLED.
BARROWCLOUGH OPTO BETTER
SOMETHING JUST HAPPENED THAT.
WHAT WHAT DO YOU THINK MAYBE
IT'S BECAUSE ON THE VERY LAST
PERSON THAT VERY LONG AFTER.
EVERYBODY THOUGHT. BOB PLEASE
CONTINUE OKAY I'D LIKE TO
PROVIDE YOU WITH PERSONAL
INFORMATION ABOUT THE PROBLEM
FOR NURSING HOMES TO PAY FOR
SHORTAGES EVEN BEFORE THE
CABINET NINETEEN PANDEMIC
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES WAS
STRUGGLING TO ATTRACT AND RETAIN
QUALIFIED NURSING STAFF IN
TWENTY NINETEEN PRIOR TO THE
PENT UP BY THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY STATE AGENCIES
ESTIMATED THAT CALIFORNIA WOULD
NEED TWENTY THOUSAND ADDITIONAL
CERTIFIED NURSING ASSISTANT FOR
THE UPCOMING YEARS. AFTER TWO
YEARS OF THE CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC THE INCREASED.
EXACERBATED THE STAFFING
SHORTAGE CRISIS TO CRISIS
PROPORTIONS. THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE DOC OF
THE PROBATION INDICATE. THREE
THIRTY SEVEN HUNDRED SAN I'VE
FOUGHT THE PROFESSION IN TWENTY
TWENTY WE HAVE TO BELIEVE THAT
THE FACT THAT WITH ONLY
INTENSIFIED IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. NURSING FACILITIES IN
CALIFORNIA ALMOST A 100%
GOVERNMENT FUNDED. MOST
FACILITIES RECEIVE APPROXIMATELY
56% OF THE FUNDING FROM MEDICARE
PROGRAM. THE GOVERNMENT PAYMENTS
FUND WAGES FOR NURSING STAFF
WERE SUPPORT STAFF PROVIDING NON
NURSING SERVICES. PAYMENT FOR
OPERATING EXPENSES INCLUDING
UTILITIES SUPPLIES AND FOOD FOR
RESIDENTS AND RENT TO COVER THE
HOUSE HOUSING AROUND. THE
CURRENT LACK OF STAFF
AVAILABILITY AND I THINK IS THE
FOLLOWING IT VERY CURRENT.
PROVIDERS ARE CURRENTLY UNABLE
TO ACCEPT PATIENTS TO THEIR
INABILITY TO MEET THE REGULATED
STAFFING HOURS NURSING HOME
CENSUS WILL NOT RETURN TO PRE
PANDEMIC RIGHT INTO FACT THAT
COMPUTERS CAN BE BUILT- THANK
THIS REMAINED EIGHT POINT 7%
BELOW DECEMBER TWENTY NINETEEN.
PROVIDERS ARE UNABLE TO ATTRACT
NEW RECRUITS TO THE SECTOR DUE
TO CULVERT MAKING FARES FOR
WAGES LACK OF ITS REAR DANCE
MEANT. PROVIDERS OF LOSING
FIFTEENTH AFTER THE ACUTE
HOSPITAL STAFFING AGENCIES AND
OTHER HEALTH CARE SETTINGS
RELATED TO HIGHER WAGES AND
BENEFITS PACKAGES BEING OFFERED
. CALVET JEFF THE FOLLOWING
MEASURES TO ADDRESS THE CURRENT
WORKFORCE ISSUES A LONG TERM
CARE FACILITIES. NUMBER ONE
CERTIFIED NURSING ASSISTANT
WAGES MUST INCREASE. THEIR
ABILITY DIRECT CARE STAFF OF
PIVOTAL IN THE DELIVERY OF
QUALITY CARE. CAP NUMBERS ARE
INDEBTED AND GRATEFUL TO THE
CERTIFIED NURSING HEALTH. CARE
FOR THE ELDERLY THE RESIDENTS OF
OUR STATE. CNA'S WITH THE WAGES
BECAUSE LIKE THE SKILLED CARE
THEY PROVIDE TO THE STATE
BECAUSE RESIDENTS. THIS REQUIRES
THAT THE MEDICARE PROGRAM
PROVIDE THE NECESSARY FUNDS
PASSED THROUGH A WAY TO INCREASE
. NUMBER TWO THE STATE
INVESTMENTS AND CERTIFIED
NURSING ASSISTANT WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT MUST CONTINUE TO BE
ENHANCE. THE STATE NEEDS TO
PRIORITIZE RECRUITMENT AND
TRAINING OF NURSING FACILITIES
STAFF AS- IT MOVED TO INVESTMENT
FUTURE WORK CALIFORNIA. WITHOUT
THIS INVESTMENT NURSING
FACILITIES WILL CONTINUE TO LACK
OF STAFF NEEDED TO PROVIDE
HIGHLY SKILLED CARE TO OUR
STATE'S MOST VULNERABLE SENIORS.
CAN OFTEN SUGGESTING FIFTEEN
PROGRAM TO EXPAND FUNDED SUPPORT
RECRUITMENT RETENTION SOLUTION
TO INCREASE THE CNA LPN AND. RN
WORKFORCE QUICKLY AND
EFFICIENTLY. VERY MUCH OF THE
COMMITTEE'S FROM THREE MILLION
DOLLARS IN BONDS WITH CNA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT. WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE ACCESS
AND INFORMATION WE'RE PLEASED
AND EXCITED ABOUT THIS FUNDING
AND HOW IT WILL IMPACT THE NAY
TRAINING SCHOLARSHIPS WE LIKE
THE PROGRAM INCREASE IN BONDS
INTEGRATION. NUMBER THREE THREE
NEEDS ME TO BE PROFESSIONAL I'VE
BEEN GIVEN A CAREER LADDER
OPTION. YOU NEED TO STORE WE'VE
BEEN VIEWED AS ENTRY LEVEL
WORKERS ARE FEW OPPORTUNITIES
FOR UPSKILLING LITTLE
RECOGNITION OF THE FANSEDGE
CATION OF FIELD TRAINING AND
LACK OF COMPENSATION TO REFLECT
WORK EXPERIENCE OR SKILLS THAT.
APPELLEES TO PROFESSIONAL I'VE
SEEN A WORKFORCE THEY NEED TO
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT WOULD
BEST BE REPRESENTED AND OVERSEEN
BY LICENSE FOR. THE CURRENT
NURSING HOME STAFFING CRISIS
LIKE NOTHING I'VE SEEN IN MY
ENTIRE FORTY PLUS YEARS
REGISTERED NURSE. THE CRISIS
CANNOT BE SOLVED WITHOUT THE
COMMITMENT OF THE STATE TO
INVEST IN WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS AND TO SUPPORT THE
FIELD. TO INCREASING STOP WHICH
IS. NUMBER STRONG SUPPORT THESE
BASKETBALL COMMITTING I'M FINE
HI AND EFFORTS. TOWARDS
IMPROVEMENT WORKFORCE TODAY'S.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THIS COMMITTEE THE LEGISLATURE
AMBIENT MINISTRATION TO SOLVE
WORKFORCE CRISIS I APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME AND EVERYTHING TO BE
DONE FIRST SO FAR. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I WILL NOW BRING IT UP
TO THE DÍAS FOR QUESTIONS- I'M
GONNA BEGIN. I'M I'M STRUCK AND
I WILL. THISFIRST QUESTION IS
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES WE'VE HISTORICALLY
HAD A 95% REIMBURSEMENT FOR
SMITH LABOR COSTS WITH OUR MEDIC
CAL RATES THAT I'D LIKE TO
UNDERSTAND WHY IT'S NOT. A 100%
WHAT'S THE LOGIC FOR US FOR
MAINTAINING IT AT 95% RATHER
THAN. COVERING THE TRUE LABOR
COSTS. ARAMBULA LINDY HARRINGTON
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR HEALTH CARE-
FINANCING WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES- SO I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO SERVICING.
DEPARTMENT RECOGNIZES THE
IMPORTANCE OF LONG TERM
FINANCING STABILITY FOR THE
HEALTH OF THE MEDIC HOW PROGRAMS
AND IT IS ONE OF THE KEY
COMPONENTS OF CALLIE AND TO HAVE
A FOCUS ON TRANSFORMING THE
DELIVERY SYSTEM. THROUGH VALUE
BASED INITIATIVES MODERNIZATION
AND PAYMENT REFORM TO FURTHER
THIS FOCUS AND DEPARTMENT OF THE
DEPARTMENT CONTINUES TO ENGAGE
WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO PERFORM
REIMBURSEMENT FOR SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES THAT
RECOGNIZES BOTH COST AND
INCENTIVIZES QUALITY WHILE
MAINTAINING FIDUCIARY
RESPONSIBILITY TO BE GOOD
STEWARDS OF PUBLIC FUNDS. THE
CURRENT REIMBURSEMENT
METHODOLOGY FOR SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES IS GOVERNED BY
STATUTE THAT ESTABLISHED AT THAT
PROCESS FOR DETERMINING THE
ANNUAL RATE INCREASES WHICH ARE
CURRENTLY CAPPED AT TWO POINT
FOUR PERCENT. AND IS PART OF
THAT PROCESS IT DOES CAP THE
PERCENTILE OF LABOR COSTS THAT
ARE INCLUDED SO IF A FACILITIES
LABOR COSTS ARE ABOVE THE NINETY
FIFTH PERCENTILE IT IS CAPS- AT
THAT NINETY FIFTH PERCENTILE FOR
INCLUSION IN THE OVERALL
CALCULATION SO IT DOESN'T. ONLY
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT 95% OF THE
FACILITIES LABOR COSTS IT ONLY
IT CAPS AT THAT NINETY FIFTH
PERCENTILE. AB ADDITIONALLY-
STATUTE PROVIDES AUTHORITY FOR
THE QUALITY INITIAL ALL RIGHT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENT PROGRAM DON'T EXPOSTO
WHICH IS INTENDED TO REWARD
FACILITIES FOR THEIR QUALITY
OUTCOMES. AND SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES ARE ONE OF VERY FEW
PROVIDER TYPES THAT RECEIVE AN
ANNUAL RATE INCREASE- AND THE
DEPARTMENT AS WE WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS ON ENGAGING WHAT.
NEXT ITERATION OF REIMBURSEMENT
FOR- SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
LOOKS LIKE AND HAVE AND YOU KNOW
DISCUSS A PROPOSAL THAT WOULD
UPDATE. THAT METHODOLOGY TO HAVE
A SEPARATE- BUDGETARY GROW LIMIT
FOR COSTS VERSUS OTHER KIND OF
IN ORDER TO RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF LABOR COST. AND
THE FACT THAT THEY GROW IN A
DIFFERENT RATE THAN OTHER
CATEGORIES AND ADDITIONALLY THE
DEPARTMENT'S GOAL IS TO IMPROVE
UPON THE QUALITY PROGRAM BY
MOVING AWAY FROM A PERCENTILE.
I'M PROGRAM TO A THRESHOLD
PROGRAM SO IT'S A FACILITY MEETS
OUR QUALITY THRESHOLD ALL
FACILITIES ARE INCENTIVIZED TO
IMPROVE QUALITY VERSUS JUST
THOSE THAT ARE AT THE VERY TOP.
I LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
THAT CONVERSATION IT HAS BEEN A
LONG RUNNING CONVERSATION. BUT
THE CONCERNS MANY OF US HAVE IS
A FOR NOT FULLY REIMBURSING THE
LABOR COSTS. ARE WE GOING TO
HAVE THE ADEQUATE AND
APPROPRIATE STAFFING WHICH WE
HEARD TO SOME NECESSARY WITHIN
OUR SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES.
I'D LIKE TO NOW MOVES TO THE
QUESTION THAT- NICOLE HOWELL HAD
ASKED ABOUT THE CNA PROGRAM
TRAINING. AND THE NECESSITY FOR
US TO HAVE AN R. AND LEAD AND
THEIR INABILITY TO FIND A
DIRECTOR AT THE US FAR- IT.
PROBABLY SHOULDN'T ASK BUT
EITHER TO ELIZABETH HALIFAX ARE
CLEAR IN RIGHT YOU BOTH SET YOU
ARE OUR ENDS HOW DO WE ENSURE-
WE EITHER FIND A DIRECTOR OR DO
WE NEED TO CONTINUE HAVING IN
OUR AND LEAD THIS CNA PROGRAM.
I'VE ACTUALLY DONE THAT BOB
MILLER PRIOR LIFE. BOB AND WILL
CONSIDER DOING IT AGAIN BUT I
HAVEN'T. POINT THIRTY FIVE. I
THINK THERE ARE ARE IS. AND IF
THEY'RE NOT READY FOR IT YET
THEY ARE STILL WORKING OUT THERE
AND THEY'RE IN THEIR- I THINK
THAT IN. AT. COULD IT BE DONE BY
AND ON OUR END I THINK THERE'S
ALWAYS ROOM FOR OPPORTUNITY AND
GROWTH YEAH AND IT DOESN'T
ALWAYS NEED TO BE A REGISTERED
NURSE. I WOULD LOVE TO HEAR FROM
THE DEPARTMENT THEIR TAKE ON
THAT QUESTION. I BELIEVE THAT
WOULD BE FOUR CD P. H. AND
THEY'RE NOT HERE SO HE WILL
FOLLOW UP WITH THAT QUESTION FOR
THEM AT ANOTHER TIME. I'M MY
FINAL QUESTION CLEAR AND RIGHT
HAD STATED THAT. WE ARE TWENTY
THOUSAND CNA'S DOWN I'VE HEARD
RESEARCH AND ANALYSIS THAT I'VE
LISTED IT AS HIGH AS TEN
THOUSAND C. N. A.'S. GIVEN THIS
HOW MUCH WILL THIS YEAR'S
CURRENT INVESTMENT HELP US TO
CLOSE THAT GAP AND WHAT MORE
DOES THE STATE NEED TO DO TO
ADDRESS THIS SHORTAGE. I CAN.
CAN TO ENSURE THAT SO- WE
BELIEVE THAT THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE INVESTMENTS WILL ASSISTANCE
TO TRAIN A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
TEENAGE OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS
I MEAN WE'RE LOOKING AT-
HOPEFULLY BEING ABLE TO TRAIN
SEVERAL THOUSAND- WE ALSO
BELIEVE THAT IN INVESTING IN THE
OTHER PRIORITIES IDENTIFIED
BUYERS STAKEHOLDERS ARE KIND OF
EASY TO THE WORK THAT WE'RE
DOING IN TERMS OF BUILDING THE
CLEAR AWARENESS- AND SUPPORT OF
THE FACULTY AND THE TRAINING
SUPERVISORS TO BE ABLE TO TRAIN-
AND SO. WE JUST RECOGNIZE IT IS
THAT INTENTION AS EXPANDING THE
NUMBER OF TRAININGBUT ALSO
BUILDING THAT CAREER AWARENESS-
AS WE HEARD IN TERMS OF
UNDERSTANDING AND- IN SOME.
RECOGNIZING THAT THIS IS WORK TO
ADD THAT IS GOOD WORK TO DO- SO
. GIVEN THAT WE ARE- DISEASE OF
THE PRIORITIES THAT WE'RE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO PERSONNEL- WITH
THE EXISTING FUNDING BUT WE HAVE
. FINAL COMMENT I'LL HAVE I
REALLY WANTED TO UPLIFT THE
COMMENTS OF NICOLE HOW AGAIN I
WAS IMPRESSED IN TWENTY NINETEEN
HEARING YOU AND AGAIN TODAY
ABOUT HOW YOU'RE ACTIVELY
LOOKING OUT FOR THOSE WHO HAVE
BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT. AND HOW
IT REALLY IS THE WRAPAROUND
HOLISTIC APPROACH THAT ALLOWED
YOU TO HAVE SUCCESS WITH THE
STUDENTS WHO WENT THROUGH YOUR
PROGRAM. TO HIGHLIGHT THAT AS AN
EXAMPLE OF HOPEFULLY WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR ANOTHER CNA PROGRAMS
THAT WE ARE GROWING. WITH THAT I
WILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL OF
PANEL TWELVE AND ALL OF OUR
PANELISTS WHO HAVE PARTICIPATED
TODAY. WE WILL HAVE WE CURRENTLY
HAVE A SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT AND THEREFORE I
WANT TO URGE YOU TO KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS AS BRIEF AS YOU CAN SO
THAT WE CAN HEAR FROM EVERYONE.
WE WILL START WITH IN PERSON
PUBLIC COMMENT IN THE HEARING
ROOM IF YOU CAN PLEASE COME
FORWARD TO THE MICROPHONE IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT.
GOOD EVENING. SHARE. KIND OF GOT
OFF AN AWFUL SITUATION
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORTABLE LAID
OUT THE MOVIE CARE CONNING
WORKHORSE PACKAGES EACH POSTAL
ADDRESSES CRITICAL NEEDS AN ORAL
CARE WORKFORCE ESTATE ARE
REVERSES DOWN 20% AND IT WOULD
TAKE YEARS TO WORK OUR WAY BACK.
ENTER THE INTENTIONAL FOCUS TO
RECRUIT TRAIN RETAIN AND RETRAIN
DIFFERS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES WILL HELP ENSURE OUR
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS. KEEP
MOVING. THE- THE RECALL. THANK
YOU I WON'T RESTORE. MOVING TO
JIMMY CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY IS
THE HOME THE SECOND LARGEST
NUMBER OF TEACHING HOSPITALS AND
RESIDENTS IN THE COUNTRY WHAT
CALIFORNIA'S HOSPITALS
APPRECIATE THE VARIOUS GME
PROGRAMS EXISTING TODAY THE
REALITY IS THE FUNDING DOESN'T
COVER THE COSTS. OF THESE
PROGRAMS FOR EXAMPLE OUR PRIVATE
IN DISTRICT HOSPITALS DO NOT
RECEIVEMEDIC CAL GME FUNDING TO
SUPPORT THEIR WORK WE APPRECIATE
THE COMMUNITY THE COMMITTEES
FOCUSED ON OVERSIGHT- HOWEVER
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT NEED AN
ONGOING INVESTMENT OTHERWISE WE
WILL AS WE RECOVER FROM CODED
THERE WILL BE LESS GME PROGRAMS
AVAILABLE AND LASTLY RELATED TO
THE CIGARETTE TAX FOR SMALL
RURAL HOSPITALS WE APPRECIATE
THE RECOGNITION OF THE TWENTY
THIRTY SEISMIC STANDARDS ARE OUT
ARE OUT OF TOUCH IN OUT OF REACH
FOR HOSPITALS. NEARLY TWO THIRDS
OF OUR HOSPITALS ARE REQUIRED TO
MEET THAT STANDARD INCLUDING THE
FIFTY SMALLER RURAL HOSPITALS AT
AN ESTIMATED HUNDRED BILLION AS
REFERENCE FOR THE CHAIR WE MUST
CONSIDER MODERNIZING THIS
PROPOSAL TO PRIORITIZE THE NEEDS
SERVICES NEED TO START NEEDED
SERVICES POST DISASTER. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
GOOD EVENING CHAIR- MEMBER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- I AM
CRISTINA BOSS HAMILTON I'M HERE
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR ADULT DAY
SERVICES AND- ONE OF THE
COMPONENTS OF THE CARICOM TO ME
THAT WAS NOT ADDRESSED IN
TODAY'S HEARING BUT IT IS
ABSOLUTELY NEEDS TO BE PART OF
THE CONVERSATION ARE THE DIRECT
CARE WORKERS WHO WORK FOR THE
ADULT THE HEALTH CARE AND ADULT
THE PROGRAMS. AROUND THE STATE
THE SAME WORK FORCE CRISES THAT
EXIST IN THESE OTHER AREAS ALSO
EXIST NEEDS FACILITIES- I DO YOU
KNOW WANT TO CALL ATTENTION THAT
CATS IS REQUESTING SIXTY ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONE TIME BUDGET FUNDING
SPECIFICALLY- IT COULD BE USED
FOR ONE OF TWO PURPOSES ONE
BEING INFRASTRUCTURE BUT THE
OTHER BEING WORK FORCE
RESILIENCY- SPECIFICALLY TO BE
ABLE TO STABILIZE. THE SHORTAGE
THAT RIGHT NOW IS KEEPING A LOT
OF THE CENTERS FROM OPERATING A
FULL CUP CAPACITY BECAUSE THEY
HAVE SIMILAR STAFFING
REQUIREMENTS THAT SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES TO AND WE
HAVE TO REMEMBER THAT IF PEOPLE
ARE NOT BEING SERVED IN THOSE
SETTINGS IN THE COMMUNITY THEY
ARE IN NURSING HOMES AND SO IF
WE WANT TO KEEP THEM IN THE
COMMUNITY WE NEED THOSE DOORS
OPEN AND THAT MEANS HAVING.
STAFFING APPROPRIATE SAID THAT
IN A VERY- KEEN EXAMPLE IS THE
COST OF HIRING A TEMPORARY OUR
END BECAUSE ARE HAVING IN OUR
AND ON STAFF IS A REQUIREMENT
CAN BE UPWARD OF EIGHTY DOLLARS
PER HOUR AND- FACILITIES ARE
ONLY WERE REIMBURSED SEVENTY SIX
DOLLARS PER DAY PER RECIPIENT SO
THERE IS A NEED JUST AS MUCH
THERE IN TERMS OF- ECONOMIC
ASSISTANCE WE DO WANNA. PROMOTED
TO THE SUB ONE INTO THE SUB OF
FOR COMMITTEES TO. PLEASE LOOK
INTO IN SUPPORT THE SIXTY ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION I WOULD ALSO
JUST LEAVE WITH IT IS VERY MUCH
DIRECTLY RELATED TO THE
PANDEMIC. AND THEREFORE- IF THE
LEGISLATURE AGREES WOULD BE
EXEMPT- SPENDING UNDER THE STATE
CAN LIMIT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WE WILL NOW GO TO OUR PHONE
LINES FOR PUBLIC COMMENT AND AS
A REMINDER THE PHONE NUMBER TO
CONNECT IS ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND SHOULD BE ON THE
SCREEN IF YOU ARE WATCHING OVER
THE INTERNET. THE NUMBER AGAIN
IS TOLL FREE. 1-877-692-8957 AND
THE PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS ONE
THREE ONE. FIVE ONE TWO SEVEN.
HI IF YOU ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS
PLEASE CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE AT.
916-319-2090 NINE AND A STAFF
MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU. OPERATOR
WE ARE READY TO BEGIN PUBLIC
COMMENT. THANK YOU FIRST WE'LL
GO TO LINE TEN GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIR IN MEMBERS
CONNIE DELGADO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY NURSES
ASSOCIATION WE WANT TO THANK THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE MEMBERS
OF BOTH COMMITTEES FOR THE
ROBUST DISCUSSION TODAY. THE
IMPACT OF THE WORK FORCE
SHORTAGES OF PLAYED OUT IN OUR
HOSPITAL EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT
EVERY DAY WITHOUT ADEQUATE
WORKFORCE ACROSS THE HEALTHCARE
CONTINUUM PEOPLE IN NEED TURN TO
THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT FOR
CARE. THIS RESULT IN A NUMBER OF
ISSUES THAT WERE DISCUSSED HERE
TODAY AND WE'D ALSO LIKE TO CALL
IN ADDITION THE AMBULANCE
PATIENT OFFLOAD DELAYS REALLY
AND AN IMPACT THERE WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU OPERATOR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. FIND. TWELVE GOOD
EVENING SHARED HER AGAIN ABOUT
YOU KNOW WHAT THE SIGN BURKE AND
IF YOU AREN'T THERE AT ATTHE
NINE FIFTY FOR THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH WORKFORCE REVITALIZATION
ACT BY SENATOR WIENER ND THE
ABILITY TO BUDGET REQUEST AND I
THINK DOCTOR EARLIER BY RYAN
QUIT WORKING WITH THE BEACH HERE
TO DEVELOP JOINT STAKEHOLDER
PROPOSAL TO ATTRACT BETA HELP
LOOK FOR IT. WE WANT TO EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT FOR THREE OF THE
COMPONENTS WITHIN THE GOVERNOR-ONE POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLAR
WORKFORCE PROPOSAL THAT THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION FOR
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS TWO
HUNDRED AND TEN MILLION IN
SOCIAL WORKER INVESTMENT UNDER%
TWENTY MILLION FOR THE THANK
YOUNG TECH RESIDENCY PROGRAM WE
APPLAUD THESE AFRICAN AT THE
SAME TIME THE SHORTAGES SO
SIGNIFICANT THAT WE NEED
ADDITIONAL HOLISTIC AND
COORDINATED IMMEDIATE AND LONG
TERM INVESTMENT. WE'D ALSO LIKE
TO ASK OUR SUPPORT FOR THE CALL
YOU PUT OUT TODAY TO INCREASE
OUR FOCUS ON UPLIFTING INCLUDING
RACIAL ETHNIC AND GEOGRAPHIC
DIVERSITY APART TO WORKING WITH. YOU ON THE VITAL ISSUE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. OPERATOR NEXT
PLEASE. NINE TWENTY ONE. HILLARY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN DUE
RESPECT TO THE LIMITED TIME
FRAME TODAY SAM I WILL FILE
WRITTEN RESPONSES TO SPECIFIC
BUDGET PROPOSAL CRITICAL TO OUR
MEMBERSHIP ENSURING FULL
ANALYSIS OF RELEVANT TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE PRIOR TO
COMMENTING GENERALLY CMA WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS
RELATED TO INCREASING HEALTH
CARE WORKFORCE AND INCREASING
ACCESS TO GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION. ECCLES I WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS THE COURT IN CONTACT
OF THE CARE ECONOMY WORKFORCE
PROPOSAL THE COMMENTS FORCED
FONG BROWN AND YOU SEE CRIME GME
PROPOSAL. THE PSYCHIATRIC
RESIDENCY COMPONENT OF THE WORK
FORCE FOR HEALTHY CALIFORNIA FOR
ALL PROPOSAL IN THE REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE EMISSIONS.
AS ALWAYS HOWEVER THE DETAILS OF
IMPLEMENTATION MATTER WHILE CMA
SUPPORTS THE OVERALL DIRECTION
THE ADMINISTRATION SEEMS TO BE
TAKING ON THE ISSUE. QUESTIONS
REMAIN FOR EXAMPLE THE
PSYCHIATRIC RESIDENCY PROGRAMIS
SLATED TO FIND EIGHT TO TWELVE
NEW RESIDENCY THE YEAR OVER THE
NEXT THREE BUDGET CYCLES.
HOWEVER THOSE SLOTS ARE SPREAD
ACROSS SEVERAL DIFFERENT LICENSE
KEY TYPES WITH NO BREAK OUT OF
HOW MANY ARE FOR PSYCHIATRISTS.
NURSES VERSUS BY COLLEGE.
ADDITIONALLY WHILE ALL THE TEA
IN THE PROPOSAL OUR STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION. EVEN TAKEN
COLLECTIVELY THEY BARELY MAKE A
DENT IN EVEN THE CURRENT
SHORTFALL OF PHYSICIANS SURGEONS
AND PSYCHIATRISTS THANKS IN
CALIFORNIA LET ALONE BEGIN TO
TACKLE THE SCALE OF THE SHORTAGE
IN THE COMING YEARS. NATIONWIDE
THE RESIDENCY FOUGHT SHORTAGE IS
ESTIMATED AT. FIFTEEN THOUSAND
FIVE. CMI- JUST SUB CAN TO
CONSIDER THE STATE CALLED
PROPOSAL. TO GM AND PUBLIC
HEALTH LONG FORGIVENESS THAT
WILL BE HEARD BY THE
SUBCOMMITTEE LATER IN THE
PROCESS. THE PROPOSAL SEEKS TO
FIND SOLUTIONS TO THE SHORTFALL
OF TRAINED HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
IN CALIFORNIA. VMA LOOKS FORWARD
TO WORKING TOGETHER WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION AS WE
COLLECTIVELY STRIVE TO INCREASE
ACCESS TO HEALTHCARE IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT. THANK
YOU OPERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE
. I'M. THIRTY THREE. HI MY. WE
MIGHT END UP WHAT FINE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIBRI CAT IN YOUR
FAMILY PHYSICIANS AND I'M MORE
THAN TEN THOUSAND THAT RIGHT WE
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION
PERTAINING TO THE PRIMARY CARE
WORKFORCE SHORTAGE AND GRADUATE
MEDICAL EDUCATION EVIDENCE SHOWS
THAT INVESTING IN PRIMARY CARE
IMPROVE HEALTH OUTCOMES HEALTH
EQUITY IN REDUCE HEALTHCARE
SPENDING THEREFORE WE ASK THAT
YOU PRIORITIZE INVESTMENT IN THE
FUND BROWN PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIAN TRAINING PROGRAM WHICH
FOCUSES ON RECRUITING MINORITY
PHYSICIANS AND PROVIDE FUNDING
FOR PRIMARY CARE RESIDENCY
TRAINING PROGRAMS. WITH A PROVEN
TRACK RECORD OF GRADUATING
PHYSICIANS WHO PRACTICE PRIMARY
CARE IN UNDERSERVED AREAS
UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS THIS
WILL PREVENT THE PRIMARY CARE
AND MAYBE HELP WORKFORCE
ASSEMBLY POSITIONS WITHIN TWO
HUNDRED HOURS OF TRAINING AND
HEALTH THIS WILL ALSO IMPROVE
ACCESS TO PRIMARY CARE AT FAMILY
MEDICINE RESIDENTS COMBINED
AVERAGE OF AT LEAST SIX HUNDRED
ADDITIONAL PATIENT VISITS PER
YEAR AND STAY IN FACT THAT THE
COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY RECEIVE
THEIR TRAINING. ACCORDINGLY WE
ASK THAT YOU SUPPORT OUR BUDGET
REQUEST FOR ADDITIONAL GENERAL
FUND EXPENDITURE OF SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS ALLOCATED OVER
THREE YEARS TO THE FONG BROWN
PROGRAM FOR PRIMARY CARE
GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION
PROGRAM DOING SO WILL INCREASE
THE BY PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIANS
IS OPEN IN IMPROVE HEALTH
OUTCOMES THAT ATHLETES
PRACTICALLY FOR THE SEVEN
MILLION CALIFORNIANS THAT WOULD
HELP THE FASHION SHORTAGE AREAS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
CONSIDERATION AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE CALIFORNIA
CONTINGENT. OF THE PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIAN WILL OF COURSE. THANK
OPERATOR NEXT CALL PLEASE. LINE
TWENTY. THE COURT BERMAN ON THE
OF THE PARTNERSHIP IN TWO OF A
CARE FUNDING COMMUNITY HEALTH
AND CHROMODORIS WHICH WILL HELP
MAKE THE GOAL OF A MORE
ETHNICALLY AND CULTURALLY
INCLUSIVE WORKFORCE BY TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. WE WOULD ENCOURAGE
IN THIS EXPANSION OF THE SPECIAL
POPULATIONS TRAINING TO INCLUDE
TRAINING IN CHILD HEALTH IN
ORDER TO ADDRESS ACCESS AND
EQUITY GAPS IN CHILDREN'S
PREVENTIVE SERVICES AND INVEST
UPSTREAM. TO PREVENT HEALTH
INEQUITIES FROM OCCURRING LATER
IN LIFE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OPERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NINE FORTY NINE. HI THIS IS
DARBY KERNAN TESTIFYING ON
BEHALF OF LEADING AGENT
CALIFORNIA THE LARGEST AND ONLY
ASSOCIATION FOCUSED ON THE
NONPROFIT SECTOR PROVIDING
HOUSING CARE AND SERVICES TO
OLDER ADULTS WE SUPPORT THE WORK
FORCE PACKAGE WITH A SPECIFIC
FOCUS ON ISSUE TWELVE FOCUSING
ON THE SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES LEADINGAGE AND
CALIFORNIA IS IN A UNIQUE
POSITION AND CAN REALLY DEVELOP
AND IMPLEMENT. AND THIS
WORKFORCE TRAINING PROGRAMS FOR
CERTIFIED NURSING ASSISTANTS AND
HOME HEALTH AIDE BUT CAN ALSO
SUPPORT AND EMPLOYMENT TRAINING
PROGRAMS FOR L. B. AND R. AND
LEADINGAGE BELIEVES WE CAN
DEVELOP THE COUNTER TYPE PLANE
OF NEW- IN NEW AND UNDERSERVED
REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES FOR
POPULATION BOTH IN RURAL AND
URBAN AREAS THIS IS SO NEEDED
AND WE ARE READY TO WORK WITH
EACH TYPE TO DEVELOP THESE
IMPORTANT. TRAINING PROGRAM.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OPERATOR
MEXICO PLEASE. NINE FORTY FOUR.
GOOD EVENING I'M THIS IS KELLY
MCMILLAN AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION- THEY'RE ALSO
CONSIDERABLE WORK FIRST
CHALLENGES AND CHARGES AND
DENTAL WORK FORCE- THE LACK OF
DENTAL ASSISTANTS IS ESPECIALLY
CUTE WITH NEARLY 90% OF DENTAL
PRACTICES REPORTING GREATER
CHALLENGES RECRUITING AND HIRING
DENTAL ASSISTANTS. AND EVEN
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC THERE WAS AN
ISSUE IN 44% OF PRACTICES REPORT
THAT IT'S LIMITING THEIR ABILITY
TO SEE MORE PATIENTS ALSO IS A
TERRIBLE IS POINTED OUT TODAY
THAT THERE IS DEFINITELY A MAIL
DISTRIBUTION OF DENTAL CARE
WHICH ADDS TO GEOGRAPHIC
DISPARITIES OF DENTAL DISEASE
AND WE NEED TO DO MORE TO
INCREASE THE CULTURAL AND DO
WITH LINGUISTIC COMPACT-
COMPETENCY TO MEET THE BAD THE
BUT GIVE ME. TO MEET THE DENTAL
NEEDS OF OUR STATE'S DIVERSE
POPULATION- A CDA SUPPORTS A
SIGNIFICANT VESTMENTS PROPOSED
TO EXPAND HEALTH CARE WORK FORCE
AND WE URGE THAT DENTAL TEAMS
ALSO BE INCLUDED IN THE HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL TARGETED BY THESE
PROGRAMS WHENEVER POSSIBLE WE'VE
ALSO SUBMITTED WRITTEN COMMENTS
THANK YOU SO MUCH. CONTINUE NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINE FIFTEEN.
HELLO- MY NAME IS WILLIAM. AND
I'M CALLING FROM LOCAL RESIDENTS
I WANTED TO COMMENT ON SOMETHING
THAT WAS DISCUSSED TODAY- THE
HEALTHCARE WORKER SHORTAGE. THE
IMPORTANT PROJECT THAT. OF THE
HEALTHCARE WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA
WHAT YOU MEANT OKAY CAN TO GET
THEM CONTACT OR BE TERMINATED.
AND ALONG WITH SOME OF MY
FRIENDS. OKAY SOME OF THE- TO OF
THE HOUSES AN I SPOKE TO THE
STATE. I WANTED TO BRING THE-
ASSEMBLY BILL NUMBER. ONE NINE
NINE THREE. WOULD REQUIRE ALL
EMPLOYEES TO BE VACCINATED
AGAINST KOBE NINETEEN- THERE'S
TWO ONE CAN CALIFORNIA. I'VE
ALWAYS WANTED TO THINK ABOUT THE
BILL MORE ASKED WE CAN- HELLO
THIS ANOTHER WAY FOR CAUSED ALL
STEM SOME OF OUR WORKERS. IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. NEXT CARP. IN. SIXTY SIX. HI
MY NAME IS REBECCA HANSON I'M
CALLING FROM THE S. C. A. U. U.
H. W. JOINT EMPLOYER EDUCATION
FUND- AND I JUST WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE
MY COMMENTS- THERE HAS BEEN A
REALLY INFORMATIVE SESSION AND
JUST REALLY APPRECIATE THE
ROBUST KIND OF APPROACH TO
THINKING REALLY BROADLY ABOUT
THE ENTIRE SECTOR- WE SERVE A
HUNDRED THOUSAND HEALTH CARE
WORKERS AND IN ALLIED HEALTH IN
CALIFORNIA AND- HAVE BEEN
RECIPIENT OF H. R. T. P. FUNDS
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE PRAYED
THAT TOGETHER. WITH ETP FINDING
AN EMPLOYER FUNDING AND OTHER
GRANTS- TO SERVE TWENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND STUDENTS A YEAR WE'VE
SEEN A HUGE INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS ACCESSING
TRAINING DURING THE- PANDEMIC-
IN OTHER AT MY A TO YOUR
COLLEAGUE AND GIVE TESTIMONY 70%
OF OUR- UNITS ARE- WORKERS OF
COLOR WOMEN- AND- WE HAVE. 90%
COMPLETION RATES 45% WAGE
INCREASE SAID- IN OVERALL 50%
HIGHER RETENTION FOR THOSE
WORKERS. WORKFORCE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR INCUMBENT WORKERS IS. AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE
CERTIFICATES LIKE REALLY GROW
THE TALENT PIPELINE- IN A
DIVERSE WAY. I'M EXCITED BY THE-
THE VISION BEHIND YOU THIS
INVESTMENT IN MAKING THAT A
REALITY WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY.
TO REALLY TRANSFORM THE SYSTEM
TO BE A BETTER SYSTEM FOR THE
LONG TERM AND US THIS
INVESTMENT TO GET COMMITMENTS
FROM SCHOOLS AND EMPLOYERS AND
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO REALLY
BUILD OUT AN ON GOING. HIGH ROAD
APPROACH TO- WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT HEALTH CARE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. I'M. FIFTY FIVE. MARY
YES PLEASE CONTINUE. ALL GREAT
SORRY ABOUT THAT- GETTING CHAIR
ARE ARAMBULA AND OTHER TO
REMEMBER THE HOPE IS THAT YOUR
NAME CORRECTLY MY NAME IS SHERRY
A LARGE AND I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF LABORATORY
PROFESSIONALS IN CALIFORNIA
REJECTING THREE ITEM. I
APPRECIATE THE NEED FOR THE
PERFORMANCE OF HEARING. AND
MURATSUCHI MAKAN CONSTITUENTS
AND PROFESSIONALS- SPEAKING WITH
DAMP. LET'S FACE IT CALIFORNIA'S
BEEN ON A DECLINE FOR YEARS.
WHEN AND NOW WITH AFFORDABILITY
AND SCHOOLING HAS THAT'S BEEN AN
ISSUE LACK OF FUNDING- THE LACK
OF INVESTING IN LONG TERM
WORKFORCE- ADDITION SERVICE. AND
I'M OF COURSE REFERRING ARE
HEALTHCARE WORKERS OR SOMETHING
ARE GETTING A VACCINATION. YOU
HAVE ALL BEEN USED PROBLEMS IN
CALIFORNIA IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN THE BUREAU OF LABOR
STATISTICS. UPDATED THERE IS
NEEDED TO BE GROWTH OF TWELVE
THOUSAND NEW MEDICAL LABORATORY
PROFESSIONALS PREPARE FURTHER
ACADEMIC PROGRAM ONLY FOR- TO DO
FIVE THOUSAND GRADUATES. I'M
GLAD TO HEAR THAT THIS PROBLEM
IS FAMILY BEING A THREAT AFTER
THAT. EVEN IF THE L. EIGHTY
THREE. A. R. B. O. R. HAS BEEN
SOUNDING THE ALARM. AND WITH
THAT SAID ALTHOUGH I DO NOT FEEL
THAT THE EDUCATION. I THINK THAT
WE SHOULD BE TAKING ANY CORNERS
. AT THE JUST THE BASIC OF
PREVIOUS I FELT SOMEONE SHOULD
BE IMPLEMENTED EMPIRE FIVE.
ENSURE THANK YOU AND TO THESE
EXCITING FEEL. NO WONDER
AMERICANS TAKE. WE NEED TO GROW. YOU MAY WE NEED TO GROW. WE
NEED TO PROVIDE. MORE COST
EFFECTIVE WAYS FIRST GOING. TO
GET YOU FOR OPPORTUNITY. TO GET
INTO THESE BILLS OF ALL YOU KNOW
ETHNICITY RACE CULTURE- AND I
FEEL THAT THAT IS. I WOULD BE
YOURS IF WE CAN DO THAT AND
THAT'S NOT INSTEAD OF HIRING
OVERSEAS AND BRINGING OUT M. L.
T. HERE THANKS FOR THE RESIDENTS
YOU. WE SHOULD BE INVESTING IN
OUR COMMUNITY. I KNOW THIS FOR A
FACT BECAUSE I'VE WORKED IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA FOR A
LABORATORY AND I WAS THE
MINORITY VERA THEY WERE HIRING
PEOPLE OVERSEAS TO FILL THE
POSITION BECAUSE THERE WAS NOT
ENOUGH BEFORE NONE OF MLT THE
HARDER. THIS IS A HUGE HUGE
PROBLEM THAT WE NEED WE NEED TO
FIX HERE IN CALIFORNIA- AND
WITHOUT SAID. J. A. YOU'RE
LISTENING AND LET'S LET'S HAVE
MORE DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THIS. ARE
A LOT MORE OUTLINED PLANS BEFORE
GOING FORWARD WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S PLAN. ARE WE REALLY
REALLY NEED TO HAVE MORE
DISCUSSION. I AM VERY
INTERESTING YOUR TIME THANK YOU
I KNOW THIS IS A VERY LONG
HEARING AND AGAIN I APPRECIATE
EVERYBODY HERE TODAY SPEAKING ON
THE TOPIC. ALL RIGHT AND LOOK
FORWARD TO YOU KNOW BE MORE
DISCUSSION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE
SEVENTY SIX. KELLY BURKE ON
BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTY THE
CALIFORNIA. COURT ABOUT THE
GOVERNOR ONE POINT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN THE
KERATOTOMY COUNTY GOVERNMENT
LIKE MANY OTHER EMPLOYERS A
CALIFORNIA BASED WORKFORCE
SHORTAGES COUNTY TROUBLING TO
COMPETE WITH PRIVATE SECTOR
EMPLOYERS TO IT ATTRACT AND
RETAIN WORKERS ESPECIALLY FOR
SOME OF THE MOST CRITICAL
SERVICES THE COUNTY PROVIDES.
HOSPITALS AND CLINICS ARE SOME
OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AGENCIES AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCIES THURMOND
HAS RECOGNIZED THAT WORKFORCE
SHORTAGES COULD HAVE A PROFOUND
IMPACT ON THE BOTTLE BILL
CHILDREN. FAMILIES AND SENIORS I
COUNTY. ALTHOUGH PART OF IT
DOCUMENTS IN THE PUBLIC HEALTH
WORK. AND BY THE TO GET A- IN
ALL FIVE. AND THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH WORK AS OUTLINED BY THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DOCTORS
ASSOCIATION. AND AFTER THE VOCAL
WORK PROGRAMS TO INCREASE COUNTY
CHILD WELFARE SERVICES AND ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR ATTENTION TO
WORK WITH- ISSUES THIS EVENING
<c.magenta>OOK. FORWARD TO WORKING WITH</c>
THE LEGISLATURE ON THE ISSUE.
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. I
IN SEVENTY SEVEN. GOOD EVENING
RONALD KOEMAN HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK C. PAN C. TEN STRONGLY
SUPPORTS ISSUE SEVEN THE
GOVERNOR'S THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION INVESTMENT OF ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR THE DEVELOPMENT A
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKER PROGRAM
WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE ACT AS
AN INFORMATION AS IT PREPARES TO
FURTHER DEVELOP THE GOVERNOR'S
AMBITIOUS POLICY PROPOSAL TO
PRIVATIZE THE FOLLOWING.
ESTABLISH A GOVERNING BOARD IN
WHICH AT LEAST HALF OF THE
MEMBERS ARE C. H. W.'S ARE FROM
A TAURUS IT SHOULD BE A BOARD
THAT HAS MINIMAL BARRIERS TO
PARTICIPATION AND ENSURE THE
REPRESENTATION OF C. H. W. THAN
PROMONTORIES THAT IS DIVERSE IN
TERMS OF LANGUAGE PREFERENCE
DISABILITY STATUS SOURCE OF
TRAINING AND ROLES AS
RECOMMENDED BY THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC HEALTH ASSOCIATION. I
SHORT DIVERSE ENTITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA CAN BECOME STATE
DESIGNATED TO PROVIDE
CERTIFICATES OF COMPLETION TO C.
H. W.'S INCREMENTAL THIS BILL
THE C. H. W. INCREMENTS FOR A
CAREER PATHWAY THAT PROVIDES
OPPORTUNITY BOTH FOR THOSE WHO
HAVE FOUND THEIR CALLING AND
THOSE WHO WISH TO SPECIALIZED
AND THOSE WHO ALSO WISH TO MOVE
INTO OTHER HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONS IN SHORT TRAINING
AND CERTIFICATES OF COMPLETION
PRIORITIZES WORKFORCE DIVERSITY
BY AVOIDING EXCLUSIONARY
BARRIERS TO PARTICIPATION LIKE
COSTLY CERTIFICATES OF
COMPLETION OR TRAININGS LANGUAGE
REQUIREMENTS IMMIGRATION STATUS
OR EDUCATION LEVEL ENSURE
FINANCIAL SUSTAINABILITY
PROCEEDS W. CENTRUM ATORES
THROUGH THE ESTABLISHMENT OF AN
ANNUAL SALARY ASSESSMENT. AND
GRANT PROGRAM FOR SMALLER
ENTITIES AND FINALLY
STRENGTHENED HEALTH SYSTEMS
INTEGRATION PROCEDURE W'S AND
CHROMODORIS ON TO HELP CARE
TEAMS AND THROUGHOUT THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM STONE ANNUAL
ASSESSMENT OF CHW INCREMENTS OR
UPTAKE BY PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
HEALTH CARE PURCHASERS AND STATE
AND LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU. ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE TANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER. NINE SEVENTY
FOUR. THANK YOU TERRY ARAMBULA
THERE BRIDGE ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT EEG IS
EXTREMELY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING REQUEST BY
EACH CARD FOR THE ADMINISTRATION
OF FUNDS COLLECTED UNDER THE SB
THREE NINETY FIVE EXCISE TAX TO
MINISTER BOTH A SMALL RURAL
CRITICAL ACCESS RELIEF FUND AND
THE HEALTH PROFESSIONS CAREER
OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAM DISTRICT
HOSPITAL OUR PUBLIC FACILITIES
THAT RELY ON THEIR COMMUNITY IT
SHOULD GENERATE THE FUNDING FOR
FIVE PROJECTS MANY OF WHICH
STILL NEEDS ME TO TWENTY THIRTY
DEADLINE THE ESTIMATED TWO
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
GENERATED BY THE FUND FOR
PURPOSES OF SEISMIC RETROFIT A
RESULT. WILL NOT BE SUFFICIENT
SMALL HOPITAL PROJECT COST
UPWARDS OF FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
OF LARGER PROJECTS IN THE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS AND WE
ENCOURAGE TE STATE TO MAKE
FURTHER INVESTMENT JUSTICE
PUBLIC DISTRICT HOSPITAL IN
MEETING THAT DEADLINE ECG IS
ALSO SUPPORTIVE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE
BUDGET PROPOSAL THAT THE AND THE
ONE POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT IN THE CARE ECONOMY
AND GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION
PROGRAM THESE INVESTMENTS ARE
NEEDED AS THEY WILL HAVE A
LASTING IMPACT ON THE ABILITY
FOR DISTRICTS TO GENERATE THE
FUTURE WORKFORCE. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
TO ENSURE HEALTH CARE DISTRICT
ABA INFRASTRUCTURE AND WORKFORCE
NECESSARY. TO SERVE THEIR
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ARE. NOT CALLER PLEASE. NINE
SEVENTY NINE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR BRENT SPENCE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TELEHEALTH
NETWORK AND- CAN SPEAK IN A
STRONG SUPPORTER OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS TO IMPROVE
AND EXPAND CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH
CARE WORKFORCE THE SERVICE
SPECIFICALLY- TENNESSEE CAN'T
SUPPORT RECRUITMENT TRAINING
APPRENTICESHIPS EMPLACEMENT OF A
FIRST AND REPRESENTATIVES HELP
I. T. WORK FORCE BETWEEN THE
HEALTH CLINICS A LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH AGENCIES IN OUR
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AND
ADVOCATING TO ENSURE PROPER
FUNDING IS ALLOCATED TO PROVIDE
FOR THIS IMPORTANT WORK FORCE.
MANY CLINICS ARE EXPERIENCING
PERSISTENT AND GROWING SHORTAGES
OF TRAIN OPERATIONAL AND SUPPORT
STAFF WHO KNOW HOW TO USE DATA
AND DATA SYSTEMS THAT PREDATED
THE PANDEMIC THESE PROGRAMS ARE
FOUNDATIONAL TO ACHIEVE THE DATA
IN INTER OPERABILITY GOALS OF
CAL AIMED AT VANCE THE STATE'S
HEALTH INFORMATION EXCHANGE
EFFORTS AND PROVIDE. A CLEAR
CAREER LATERAL LADDER. IN ON
RAMP TO IN. WITH G. EAZY. IN
HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA TO WELL PAID
CAREERS THAT OFFER WAGES AND
BENEFITS AND FUTURE
OPPORTUNITIES WE APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. I AM. EIGHTY TWO. CHAIR
NUMBER RG RETIRED CHECK-
CONCLUDES STRATEGIES ON BEHALF
OF SACRAMENTO COUNTY I'M CALLING
IN TO EXPRESS OUR CONTINUED
CONCERNED ABOUT THE TRANSITION
OF CARE OF KAISER MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES SPECIALTY MEN
MENTAL HEALTH BENEFIT TO
SACRAMENTO COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SPECIFICALLY THE COUNTY
HAS NOT RECEIVED CONFIRMATION
THAT SUFFICIENT FUNDS TO BE
PROVIDED TO FAT CAT. IN THE CARE
OF THESE INDIVIDUALS AND
INDIVIDUALS WITH SERIOUS MENTAL
ILLNESS AND REQUIRE HIGH QUALITY
INTENSIVE SERVICES TO FOR
BROADBAND AND AVOID ANY NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES TO THE TRANSITION
IN ORDER TO MEET THE STATE
SCHOOL TRANSITIONING
RESPONSIBILITY TO DEFEND THE
VIGILS SACRAMENTO COUNTY NEEDS
THE FUNDS IMMEDIATELY BEGAN
RAMPING UP SERVICES ONE TIME
ACCOUNTING NEED TWENTY FOUR TO
THIRTY SIX MONTHS TO RAMP UP
SERVICES FOR THE POPULATION. WE
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
. NINE SEVENTY. GOOD EVENING
CARE ARAMBULA MEMBERS ROB LANE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
COMMUNITY BEHAVIOR HEALTH
AGENCIES WE APPRECIATE YOU
INCLUDING OUR VOICE AND STATE
TERRAIN AND THE VARIOUS
PROPOSALS PRESENTED TODAY WE
KNOW YOU'RE NOT TAKING ACTION
BUT A FEW KEY INITIATIVES ONE
SUPPORT- THE INCLUDE ISSUE ONE
FOR THE GOVERNOR'S HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE BUDGET PROPOSAL ISSUE
FIVE THE EMPLOYMENT TRAINING
PANEL EXPANSION FOR HEALTH AND
SOCIAL WORK IF YOU TEND
WORKFORCE AUGMENTATION AND
BUDGET ALIGNMENT H. CHI BCP AND
PANEL LET THEM I ALSO WANT TO
UNDERSCORE THAT OUR PROVIDERS
ARE SUFFERING DUE TO WORK FORCE
SHORTAGES. AS YOU KNOW WE SIMPLY
CANNOT PROVIDE SERVICES WITHOUT
ARE ESSENTIAL STAFF IN CLOSING I
WANT TO SAY THAT I APPRECIATE
THE CONVERSATIONS AROUND
SPECIFIC LOCAL WORK FORCE AREA
ISSUES WE TALKED GENERALLY ABOUT
THIS AS AN ISSUE AND THAT
ACTUALLY UNINTENTIONALLY DE
PERSONALIZES THE PROBLEM WE HAVE
NUMBER AGENCIES IN ALL DISTRICTS
REPRESENTED HERE TODAY AND WE
HAVE WORKFORCE DEFICIENCIES IN
EVERY DISTRICT REPRESENTED HERE
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. I AM. EIGHTY SIX.
GOOD EVENING THIS IS REBECCA
GONZALEZ WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WE REPRESENT
SOCIAL WORKERS WHO HAVE
GRADUATED FROM ACCREDITED SCHOOL
OF SOCIAL WORK I WANT TO THANK
THAT THAT TOO MANY VENTURES
ARAMBULA AND- AND THAT COULD. BE
I GOT THEIR OWN PRODUCE HEARING
IMPAIRED RECOGNITION AS THE
DEMAND FOR MORE SOCIAL WORKERS
BOTH THOSE WHO ARE LICENSED AS A
LICENSED CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKERS
AND THOSE WITH THERE BE A PUBLIC
EVENT MSW PROFESSIONALLY
EDUCATED SOCIAL WORKERS WORK IN
MANY DIVERSE SETTINGS FROM
SCHOOL JUSTICE SYSTEM OUTPATIENT
CLINIC ACUTE CARE HOSPITALS
ELDER CARE SERVICES HOUSING
SUPPORT SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES AND DISASTER RELIEF
ONCE AGAIN WE APPRECIATE THE
FOCUS ON SCHOLARSHIPS AND
STIPENDS THROUGH THE TWO HUNDRED
AND TEN MILLION PORTION OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. AND WE
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION ON AND
REESTABLISHING THE MENTAL HEALTH
SITE AND WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE
WORK BEING DONE TO THAT MARK
pWORK WE LOOK FORWARD TO SHARING
OUR OWN ADVOCACY PROPOSAL BUT A
FUTURE HEARING THAT CENTER ON
INCREASING CAPACITY AT THE
SCHOOL OF SOCIAL WORK AND
INCREASING THE NUMBER. OF
LICENSED PROVIDERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. OPERATOR NEXT CALLER.
NINE SIXTY EIGHT. ANYTHING CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
CINCINNATI NOT LIKE HAS PUBLIC
AFFAIRS- CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA NURSE MIDWIVES
ASSOCIATION ON ISSUE ON A COUPLE
ISSUES ISSUE ONE WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE GOVERNOR'S ONE
POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO RECRUIT
AND TRAIN ADDITIONAL- WORKFORCE
CARE AND HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS-
ON ISSUE SEVEN OR SUPPORTERS OF
THE COMPREHENSIVE NURSING AND IT
SHOULD HAVE. ANY ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT IN EACH CAR- IN
ADDITION TO A BUDGET REQUEST TO
INCREASE FUNDING FOR THE SONG
BROWN ACT- AT THAT WE'RE WORKING
ON THIS YEAR IN PARALLEL WITH
LEGISLATION TO INCLUDE NURSE
MIDWIVES AND LYFT RIDES IN THE
SONG BROWN ACT TO BE ELIGIBLE
FOR THIS IMPORTANT FUNDING TO
SCALE UP TO RECRUIT AND TRAIN-
NURSE MIDWIVES OF PRIMARY CARE
NON PHYSICIAN PROVIDERS IS
CRITICAL TO MEETING THE NEEDS IN
OUR COMMUNITIES. AND LASTLY ON
ISSUE NINE- ON BEHALF OF THE
NURSE MIDWIVES AS WELL AS NAY
ROUTE PRO TREES CALIFORNIA BOTH
OF WHOM ARE MEMBERS OF THE STAFF
COUNSEL WITH MINERALOGIST DURING
COMMITTEE MEMBER JUST WANT TO
REITERATE OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO ENSURE
THAT. ALL CALIFORNIANS HAVE
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS
AND ARE ABLE TO MAKE THE CHOICES
THAT ARE RIGHT FOR THEM AND
THEIR FAMILIES I'M A BASIC
HEALTH CARE AND THANK. YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE TIME REALLY
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU
OPERATOR NEXT CALLER. I NINETY
TWO H. GOOD AFTERNOON SHARE-
CHAIRS AND MEMBERS THS IS
TERREL LUCIEN CALLING ON BEHALF
OF CHARLES R. DREW UNIVERSITY OF
MEDICINE MEDICINE AND SCIENCE I
WANT TO THANK YOU FIRST AND
FOREMOST FOR BOTH BOTH
COMMITTEES JOINTLY TACKLING THIS
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE ISSUE AND
ESPECIALLY YOUR MARKS THROUGHOUT
THE- THE HEARING ON DIVERSITY.
ONE THING DID THE SECRETARY'S
NAY INSISTED SECURE DELGADO FOR
THEIR COMMITMENT TO DIVERSITY AS
WELL- WHEN WE INITIALLY REVIEWED
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL-
WE WERE EXCITED ABOUT THE
HISTORIC INVESTMENTS THAT THE
GOVERNMENT RISKS MAKING AND
HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE
INVESTMENT- WE ARE STRONGLY
SUPPORTIVE OF ALL THOSE. BUT AS
WE INITIALLY READY WE WERE A
LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT WORKFORCE
DIVERSITY NOT BEING PROMINENTLY
EMPHASIZED- SINCE WE'VE HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH HHS AND THE
LABOR AND WORKFORCE AGENCY ALL
WE SEE THE INTENTIONS THERE- AND
SO WE'RE EXCITED ABOUT THAT WE
DO AGREE THOUGH WITH CHAIR
CARILLO- AND- CHEN ARAMBULA
THAT- AND I'M PARAPHRASING BUT
SOME SOME MORE MEAT NEEDS TO BE
PLACED ON THE BONES. IN A WAY
THAT DOESN'T VIOLATE PROPOSITION
TWO OH NINE HOW DO YOU DO THAT
WHAT WE'VE PROPOSED AND. WHAT
WE'VE COMMUNICATED WITH YOUR
STAFF. OUR TAKE STATUTORY
LANGUAGE UNDER THE SO BROWN
PROBE. AND LOOKING TO APPROACH
APPLY THAT LANGUAGE- TO SOME OF
THE OTHER PROGRAMS SEAN BROWN IS
VERY METICULOUSLY CRAFTED NOT TO
GENERATE TWO ONE NINE ISSUES BUT
TO REALLY GET AT- MEDICALLY
UNDERSERVED. AREAS AND TO PER
FOR INSTITUTIONS THAT HAVE.
TRACK RECORD OF WORKING IN
MEDICALLY UNDERSERVED AREAS AND
EDUCATING UNDER REPRESENTED OUR
POPULATIONS. PERHAPS THERE'S- I
NEED CANADIAN SURE THAT
EXPEDITED IT COULD BE BUT WE'RE
VERY VERY STRONGLY. PORTAGE OF
USING THAT LANGUAGE. AND
APPLYING THAT LANGUAGE TO MORE
THAN JUST A SONG BROWN PROGRAM
IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE- THOSE GOALS
AND HOPE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WON'T PLACE OVER RELIANCE ON CBO
TO DO WORK THAT- THEY MAY NOT
REALLY FULLY BE CAPABLE AND ABLE
TO. PERFORM AS FAR AS DIVERSITY
IS CONCERNED WE APPRECIATE THOSE
COMMENTS AND OUR OUR LETTERS IT
AND FORWARDED TO THE RESPECTIVE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU BYE. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. I.
NINETY THREE. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR ANY BLOMBERG ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL WE APPROVED
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
WE APPRECIATE THE THOUGHT FOR
HEARING TODAY FOCUSED ON
BUILDING CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH
CARE WORKFORCE THAT REFLECTS THE
DIVERSITY OF OUR STATE WITH
PARTICULAR ATTENTION ON
EXPANDING OUR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE ESPECIALLY DUE TO THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CRISIS
WORSENING AND ARGUE. FOR
CONTACTS- SIXTY NINE THAT FAMILY
MEDICINE RESIDENCY PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA AND FORTY FOUR
INTERNAL MEDICINE PROGRAMS AND
CONTRACTS ARE ONLY SEVENTEEN
PEDIATRIC RESIDENCY PROGRAMS IN
THE STATE OF THESE DATA PROVIDED
BY OR IN COLLABORATION WITH CCHA
MEMBER HOSPITALS. HOSPITALS
PROVIDED SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
TRAINING TO PRIMARY CARE AND
SPECIALTY PAEDIATRICIANS ALLIED
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CLINICIANS AND
STAFF THEY TRAIN 45% OF ALL OF
CALIFORNIA PEDIATRIC RESIDENTS.
AND 12% OF ALL. AND IF YOU TWO
GRADUATE AND- WE WILL BUY
CAROLINE ARE COMMON WITH THE OF
THE CAL HOUSE ASSOCIATION. HE'S
SAYING ABOUT THE ONE POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT OVER
THREE YEARS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET TO BUILD AND
SUPPORT THE HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE
. IN PART AND WE ARE CONCERNED
WITH APPROACH THAT SIDE IS
PROPOSING THE UTILIZED TO
DISTRIBUTE FONG. UNFORTUNATELY
DATA SHOWS THAT NOT A PROBLEM
PROFIT CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL THAT
IT'S SIGNIFICANT ADVANTAGE AND
DISADVANTAGE WHEN APPLYING FOR
EACH CRIED. WORKFORCE TRAINING
PROGRAMS FOR EXAMPLE OF THAT
TWENTY POINT EIGHT MILLION AND
FONG BROWN FUNDS THAT WERE
DISTRIBUTED. LAST YEAR THE
RESIDENCY PROGRAM LESS THAN ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION MILES AWARDED
TO PEDIATRIC RESIDENCY PROGRAMS
DUE TO SCORING CRITERIA WE THINK
THERE SHOULD BE- CRITERIA SHOULD
BE RE EVALUATED. ON THE ISSUE-
ON ISSUE NUMBER ELEVEN
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
ISSUES. SHE EXPLAINS THE COURT
WROTE THAT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE- AGAIN WE WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT AND LIMITATIONS THAT
AGE HAD PROGRAMS SUCH AS THE WEB
PROGRAM BEHAVIORAL HEALTH STAFF
BUT NOT THE PROBLEM. CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL BUT SERVER HAD MEDI CAL
POPULATION COULD NOT OBTAIN LOAN
FORGIVENESS BUT THEY AREN'T
REMAIN EMPLOYED AT A NOT FOR
PROFIT CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL AFTER
THEY'VE COMPLETED THEIR
TRAINING. CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
HAD THE NECESSARY EXPERTISE AND
CONSTRUCTION TECHNICALLY CAN'T
MIGHT CONTRIBUTE TO BUILDING OUR
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND H. HIGH AND
INCREASING CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
INVESTMENT AND CONTRIBUTIONS.
AND THAT THE AREA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OPERATOR NEXT CALL
PLEASE. LIGHT NINETY. THANK YOU
CHAIR ARAMBULA AND CHAIR CARILLO
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
AM CALLING IN TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE COMMUNITY CLINIC ASSOCIATION
OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY. A THREE
YOU REPRESENT FIFTY FIVE
NONPROFIT COMMUNITY CLINICS AND
HEALTH CENTERS THROUGHOUT LA
COUNTY WHICH THEIR MEDICAL HOME
FOR MORE THAN ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION PATIENTS EACH YEAR I
WOULD ECHO MY COLLEAGUES AND I
TO APPRECIATE THE ROBUST
DIALOGUE BETWEEN IF YOU BUDGET
COMMITTEE PURE SPANISH VERY
CRITICAL ISSUE IMPACTING OUR
STATE LOWER GREAT FALLS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED AT HISTORIC
INVESTMENT OF MORE THAN ONE
BILLION COULD TACKLE THESE
WORKFORCE ISSUES. HEALTH CENTERS
ARE REQUESTING TARGETED
INVESTMENTS CAN MEET THE URGENT
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION
CHALLENGES SPECIFICALLY UNIQUE
HEALTH CENTERS LIKE OTHER HEALTH
SYSTEMS ACROSS THE STATE A
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTER%
WORKFORCE IS EXPERIENCING A
MENTAL STRAIN YOUR THE CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC WORKFORCE
ATTRITION CHRONIC STAFFING
SHORTAGES AND GROWING SALARY CAP
THEIR EXACERBATING STAFFING
CHALLENGES THAT EXISTED PRIOR TO
THE PANDEMIC. WHICH MEANS HEALTH
CENTERS ARE REQUESTING A FIFTY
ONE MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET
INVESTMENT IN EDUCATIONAL THAT
RELIEF ADVANCED PRACTICE
CLINICIAN TRAINING AND RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS AND IMPORTANT TOOLS
ALREADY IN THE TO A CAT. HEALTH
CENTERS ABILITY TO RECRUIT
RETAIN AND TRAIN OUR WORKFORCE
YOU REALLY NEED TO GROWING
HEALTHCARE NEEDS OF THE
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY SERVE HI
WE RECOMMEND THE BOND BE
DISBURSED TO THE TARGETED
PROGRAMS UNDER THE NEW
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE ACCESS INFORMATION WHICH
REALLY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND THOROUGH
ATTENTION TO THE ISSUE AND
YOU'RE WELCOME TO CONTACT ME IF
YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
REQUIRE ADDITIONAL INFORMATION.
THANKS SO MUCH. THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER. NINE FIFTY. GOOD EVENING
THIS IS JENNIFER ALLEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION AMERICAN
FAMILY THERAPIST AND I LIKE TO
THANK THE CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY THIS
EVENING AND WE DO SUPPORT THE
PROPOSAL TO DEVELOP A DIVERSE
PAPER WORK FORCE INCREDIBLE
ADDERS FOR UNLICENSED
PROFESSIONALS AND URGE THE CHAIR
OF THE COMMITTEE TO CREATE A
DIVERSE WORKFORCE COMPRISED OF
LICENSED MARRIAGE AND FAMILY
THERAPIST PSYCHOLOGIST- PCC'S
AND LICENSED CLINICAL SOCIAL
WORKERS THROUGH LOAN FORGIVENESS
CLINICAL STIPENDS AND
SCHOLARSHIPS FOR THE
PROFESSIONAL WORKFORCE.
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS AT AGE HI
WE'VE SUBMITTED A REQUEST FOR-
MYSTICAL THE REQUEST FOR FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION FOR THESE
PROGRAMS ON THE CORE TO
CONTINUING THE CONVERSATIONS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LINE NINETY SIX. GOOD
EVENING THIS IS ANDREA SAN
MIGUEL CALLING ON BEHALF OF
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES
THE CALIFORNIA THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE EXTENSIVE HEARING ON ALL
ISSUES THAT- APPLY TO ALL THE
DIFFERENT PROVIDERS IN
CALIFORNIA STARTING TO SERVICE
THE MEDIC HOW POPULATION THIS IS
A GREAT DISCUSSION AND I JUST
WANTED VERY BRIEFLY COMMENT ON-
ARE VERY STRONG SUPPORT FOR
ISSUE NINE T. H. CAI ITEM COMING
FROM THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
RELATING TO- CLINICAL AND
DIGITAL PHYSICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
OF REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CENTERS.
AS WELL AS OF COURSE- THE TWENTY
MILLION RELATED TO WORKFORCE
SHORTAGES- WE ALL KNOW THAT
ABORTION IS ESSENTIAL HEALTHCARE
AND UNFORTUNATELY NATIONWIDE
INCLUDING IN THE STATE ON THE
WESTERN UNITED STATES SUCH AS
AYE IDAHO- JUST MORE RESENTMENT
ABORTION ACCESS IS BEING
DISMANTLED IN COURT AND MY STATE
LEGISLATURES SO WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S-
EFFORTS TO MAKE SURE THAT
CALIFORNIA IS- INVESTING AND-
BEING A REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM DAY
ADS AS IT HAS DECLARED IN RECENT
YEARS AND- APPRECIATE
OPPORTUNITY COMMENT TONIGHT.
ALSO VERY BRIEFLY WILL SAY THAT-
RELATED TO YOUR COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKER PROPOSAL- WE HAVE BEEN
BRINGING UP WITH THE DEPARTMENT
RECENTLY- THAT IS ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT TO NOT OVERLOOK THE
POPULATION FOR THE MEDICAL
PROGRAMS- RELATING TO THAT IF
YOU DO NOT HAVE FULL SCOPE AND
SO WE- LOOK TO CONTINUE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW TO MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE WHO BENEFIT FROM
THE FAMILY PRACTICE AROUND CAN
ALSO RECEIVE SERVICES. PROVIDED
BY COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER. BY EIGHTY SO. GOOD
EVENING LOU GRILLING KP PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF AND CAL PAID
THE STATEWIDE ASSOCIATION OF ALL
INCLUSIVE PROGRAMS FOR THE
ELDERLY CAL STATE CENTERS ARE
EXPERIENCING THE WORKFORCE
SHORTAGES AND THEY WANT TO
ENSURE THAT ALL INCLUSIVE MODELS
ARE ALSO INCLUDED IN THE NATION
AND IN PARTICULAR WOULD LIKE TO
SEE MORE PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS
AND SOCIAL WORKERS COMING TO
WORK IN OUR CENTERS AND BELIEVE
THAT COULD FIT INTO THE PROPOSAL
UNDER H. GUY AND I'VE HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT TO ELEVATE PAID NEEDS
WITHIN THE HEALTHCARE DELIVERY
SYSTEM. WE ALSO SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA HEALTH ADVOCATES
PROPOSAL TO ALLOCATE AN
ADDITIONAL FIFTY ONE MILLION DID
THE THING PROGRAMS ALSO ON
BEHALF OF NURSE FAMILY
PARTNERSHIP I'D LIKE TO VOICE
OUR SUPPORT OF THE COMPONENTS OF
THE CALIFORNIA CAN'T WAIT
COALITION PROPOSAL SPECIFICALLY
WAITING PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE
CERTIFICATION FEE AND SUPPORT
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH RECRUITMENT
RETENTION EFFORTS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK. YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. BLIND. OH TWO.
SORRY IS THAT ME AND MY ONE
WANTED TO HEAR YOU LOUDLY AND
CLEARLY- EXCELLENT- IT'S BEEN A
LONG HEARING- SO I BELIEVE I'M
CALLING IN FOR COMMENT A COUPLE
OF THINGS I THINK WAS THE ONE
WITH NUMBER NINE- RIGHT TO
REPRODUCTIVE- CHOICE AND ACCESS-
DEFINITELY SUPPORTING THAT AND-
WOMEN'S. RIGHTS TO CHOOSE- AND
THE OTHER THING I WANTED TO
COMMENT ON WAS. JUST THE SORT OF
REOCCURRING THEME- THAT TOOK
PLACE THROUGHOUT THIS HEARING
ABOUT THE STAFFING SHORTAGES IN
THE HEALTH CARE- AND MEDICAL
CARE INDUSTRY AND I DO FIND IT
FASCINATING THAT NO ONE HAS
OTHER THAN A COUPLE OF ASTUTE
COMMENTERS. HAVE BROACHED AT
THE- SUBJECT OF. THE FIRING AND
STRONG ARMING AND BASICALLY TEAR
ANALYZING OF HEALTH CARE WORKERS
WHO DON'T WANT THIS COLBERT SHOT
. YOU KNOW PEOPLE ARE FLEEING
CALIFORNIA AND MOVING TO A FREE
STATE FOR GETTING BONUSES IN
PLACES LIKE NEBRASKA AND FLORIDA
TO GO WORK BEAR IN THE
HEALTHCARE INDUSTRY SO. IT'S SO
STRANGE TO ME THAT YOU LAWMAKERS
AREN'T TALKING ABOUT THIS AND
YET YOU TALK ABOUT BEING PRO
CHOICE AND YOU'RE TRYING TO PUT
MONEY TOWARDS A WOMAN'S RIGHT TO
CHOOSE WHICH I'M FULLY IN
SUPPORT OF. IT IT SEEMS SO
STRANGE TO ME THAT WHAT I'M
SAYING IS THAT A RIGHT TO
CHOOSE- WHAT GOES ON IN ONE'S
BODY IF THE ARGUMENT IS ON THE
SIDE OF PRO CHOICERS THEN SURELY
SURELY THAT WOULD INCLUDE. THE
RIGHT TO SAY NO TO UNWANTED
INJECTIONS BUT INSTEAD YOU'RE
FIRING THESE PEOPLE IN THE
MEDICAL. COMMUNITY HEALTH CARE
WORKERS WHO DON'T WANT THE SHOT.
WHERE IS THE LOGIC CONSISTENCY
IN SAYING. SOMEONE IS PRO CHOICE
ABOUT VACCINES ARE AN ISSUE OF
LOW IMPORTANT. MY PET ISSUE IS
THAT GOVERNMENT KEEP YOUR HANDS
OFF MY BODY AND IT DEFINITELY
KEEP YOUR HANDS OFF MY CHILDREN
BODY. I NEED NO JUSTIFICATION I
NEED NO FIRE WELL I COULD GO
THERE BUT IT MIGHT GOVERNMENT
INSISTS ON INJECTING. AFTER THEM
AND THE DEFINITION IF YOU ARE
ARE YOU WHITE LAST COMMUNISM
FASCISM THEN WE REALLY HAVE TO
GET INTO ECONOMIC BECAUSE
COMMUNISM MEANS GOVERNMENT OWNED
BUSINESS. FASCISM MEANS
CORPORATIONS OWN GOVERNMENT WHAT
WE ARE GETTING HERE IN
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW IS ACTUALLY
A STRANGE MIXTURE BUT MANY IN
ARGUABLE WHEN GOVERNMENT FORCES
ON WANTED MEDICAL INTERVENTIONS
ON TO HELP PEOPLE. IF WE EVEN
ARGUE THAT MY BODILY SOVEREIGNTY
IS A FUNDAMENTAL MOST PRIMARY
IMPORTANCE THEN YOU A GOOD HAVE
YOUR THINKING. CAPS ON AND-
FINAL THOUGHTS WHAT CARILLO
SHOULD. STAY HERE CALL IN HER
OWN HEARING COULD A LATINA
ENACTED. COMMITTEE I KNOWS
THINKS SHE'S UNDERPAID BUT SHE
SHOULD STAY AND WITH THEM TO THE
PUBLIC GOOD EVENING. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE NINETY
FOUR. OURGREAT THANK YOU AND
GOOD EVENING FOR APPLIED LIKE
THE THING CARE GRANULAR AND
CAPIO AND ALL COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FOR CALLING ATTENTION TO THE
VERY EXPERIENCED WORK FORCE
SHORTAGE OF HEALTHCARE MY NAME
IS DEBBIE TELL AND IN ADDITION
TO SERVING ON THE MASTER PLAN
FOR AGING STAKEHOLDER ADVISORY
COMMITTEE I HAVE WORKED FOR THE
NONPROFIT COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION CHOICE IN AGING FOR
THE LAST TWENTY YEARS THE BANK.
WE PROVIDE A DOUBLE PLAY
HEALTHCARE STATE PROGRAMS WITH
SOCIAL AND HEALTH SERVICES
PROVIDED BY ITS SKILLED NURSING
STAFF BUT IN A DAY CENTER WE
ALSO PROVIDE THE MULTIPURPOSE
SENIOR SERVICES PROGRAM IT IS
THAT COMPLEX. IN A JOINT PROGRAM
THAT IS IN THEIR HOMES AND THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY TRANSITIONS
PROJECT WHERE WE GET. A RESIDENT
OUT OF SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES OPEN RESIDENT THERE
FOR YEARS. AND BACK INTO
COMMUNITY LIVING AND EACH OF
THESE PROGRAMS SAVE TAXPAYERS
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
AND YET THEY'VE BEEN SO
RADICALLY UNDERFUNDED WE DON'T
HAVE A SUFFICIENT WORKFORCE TO
MEET THE POPULATION'S NEEDS. SO
PEOPLE GET UNNECESSARILY
INSTITUTIONALIZED NOBODY WANTS
TO BE INSTITUTIONALIZED AND WE
NEED TO DO ALL WE CAN TO ENSURE
THEY AREN'T. JUST RECORDED
INVESTMENT AND I URGE YOU TO
FIND THE CATS ASK FOR SIXTY ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION IN ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR THE BRIDGE TO
RECOVERY FOR ADULT DAY SERVICES
GRANT PROGRAM. ADDITIONALLY I
ENCOURAGED YOU I ENCOURAGE YOU
TO EXPLICITLY PRIORITIZED
FUNDING FOR HOME AND COMMUNITY
BASED SERVICES FOR ELDERS. AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES WHO
RELY ON THESE PROGRAMS TO LIVE
DAILY. BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
WORKFORCE DOESN'T MEAN THAT THEY
STOP NEEDING TO GO TO THE
RESTROOM OR EATING THEIR MEALS
FOR GETTING TO AND FROM DOCTORS
APPOINTMENTS. IT'S NOT RIGHT. I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION TO
AND ATTENTION ALL AROUND THE
TODAY. AND I WANT TO THANK YOU
ALSO FOR YOUR PARTNERSHIP IN
ENSURING WE DO ALL WE CAN TO
PREVENT THE UNNECESSARY
INSTITUTIONALIZATION OF OUR
ELDERS. AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. OPERATOR CALLER PLEASE. I
IN ONE OH THREE GO AHEAD. WE'VE
LOST LINE ONE OF THREE WILL MOVE
TO LINE ONE OH SIX. GOOD EVENING
CHAIRS THANK YOU FOR PROVIDING
ME TIME TO SPEAK THIS EVENING MY
NAME IS TERRA CAN'T YOU AND I AM
THE CHIEF OF STAFF FOR TWENTY
MAKING- BY THE MULTITUDE OF
SERVICES FOR ADULTS WITH
DISABILITIES. AND FRAIL ELDERS
MANY OF THEM EXTREMELY LOW
INCOME. ONE OF THESE PROGRAMS IS
ADULT DAY HEALTH CARE. AT AMOUNT
PABLO CENTER WE SERVE PEOPLE
LIKE MARY. MARY THE MOTHER Q.
WITH EARLY ONSET ALZHEIMER'S HE
RELIES ON THE HELP OF HER ADULT
CHILDREN TO CONTINUE LIVING AT
HOME. SATURDAY PROGRAM. ABLE TO
SITTING ENGAGE WITH OTHER
PARTICIPANTS. AS WELL AS RECEIVE
NURSING CARE OCCUPATIONAL AND
PHYSICAL THERAPY EXERCISE. AND
GIVE YOU A SENSE OF COMMUNITY
AND BELONGING WITH HELP FROM HER
COGNITIVE DECLINE. AND KEEP HER
LIVING AT HOME. ADDITIONALLY FOR
CHILDREN RECEIVE MUCH NEEDED
RESPITE KNOWING THEIR MOTHER IS
TAKEN CARE FOR PEOPLE LIKE MARY
ATTENDING OUR ADULT DAY HEALTH
CARE STATE COSTS ONLY ONE THIRD
OF THE COST OF NURSING HOME. AND
ONLY 14% OF THE COST OF A
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY.
HOWEVER IN ORDER TO HELP KEEP
PEOPLE LIKE MARY ATTENDING OUR
PROGRAMS LIVING AT HOME AND OUT
OF INSTITUTIONS AND WE NEED MORE
STAFF TO MEET THE EVER
INCREASING DEMAND. I URGE YOU TO
PLEASE PRIORITIZE SPENDING. HOME
AND COMMUNITY BASED LONG TERM
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS WORKFORCE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OPERATOR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE. ONE
HUNDRED. HI GOOD AFTERNOON. MY
NAME'S KATIE CRUEL AND- I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIRMAN OF
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
CALLING ATTENTION TO THE VERY
SERIOUS WORKFORCE SHORTAGE IN
HEALTH CARE. I APPRECIATE THE
VERY INFORMATIVE HEARING AND
VERY VERY ESTIMATES THE RULE
QUESTIONS. SO WE ARE COMMUNITY
BASED ADULT DAY CENTER IN OXFORD
THANKS FOR COUNTY AND-
ESPECIALLY TO RURAL COUNTY SO
THEN WILL WE SERVE LOW INCOME
SENIORS AND DISABLED ADULTS IN
MILITARYVETERANS FOR NINETEEN
YEARS. SO AT THIS POINT WE ARE
FACING CRISIS ARGUE TO THE LACK
OF PONTIAC AND HIGH COURT. SO
WE'RE PULLING IN SUPPORT OF CABS
REQUEST FOR SIXTY ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION. IN ONE TIME FUNDING FOR
THE BRIDGE TO THE COMEDY FOR THE
ALL THE SERVICES GRANT PROGRAM.
THAT IS IN YOU CAN ONLY EXPORT
AND IMPORT AND FINDING BECAUSE
IT WILL HELP US. TO RECOUP
INDICATING PLOYS ARE DURING THE
OVERWHELMING STOCKING SHORTAGE-
LITTLE BIT OF SHE START WHEN THE
FUNDING IT COULD BE GONE TWO
YEARS THE GOAL AND ENTIRE CONTRA
COUNTRY WENT. TO SHUT DOWN SO
THE STOP OF OUR FOR HIM TO
APPROACH YOUR WEAK PEOPLE IT'S
NORTH SAYS NORTH THINK
ASSISTANCE THEY ARE GIVING
DRIVERS SOCIAL WORKERS. THE
TYPICALLY REDUCE THEIR LIVES A
KEYRING FOR HUNDREDS OF ISOLATED
WOMAN BOTH. SENIOR CENTER AND A
CARE GIVER. AND NOW MORE THAN
THAT. WE NEED FINDING TO
STABILIZE OUR OVERWORKED STAFF-
WHICH ACTUALLY- CONSIDER
THEMSELVES AND THEMSELVES. VERY
UNDERPAID. OR ANYTHING PEOPLE
AND THEY ARE THE LOYALIST
ADVOCATES FOR THEIR ELDERLY AT
CLIENTS AND THEY GIVE YOUR FOR
US HERE HE- SO WE URGE OU TO
SUPPORT CABS BUDGET REQUEST. FOR
GROUND SCHOOL DAHLE B. S.
SERVICES AND THAT'S THE BRIDGE
TO CONGRESS FOR DAHLE THEY
SERVICES GRANT PROGRAM THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE.
ONE ELEVEN. THE CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR DIFFICULTY
HEARING IS WANT TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS MADE BY MY COLLEAGUE
AND MENTOR STILL RESTING IN A
WORKFORCE WITHIN FINANCE AND
ESTABLISH WITH NO QUALITY%
CLEANERS. CORRECTIVE WORKERS
STATE AGENCIES. YEAH NEED TO
COME TOGETHER. OKAY RIGHT TO
ADDRESS I THINK WE CARE. ALL
JUST WANTED TO FIX OUR OF ECHO
THE COMMENTS IN THE NIKHOM
SOCIAL- AND CONTINUE TO ASK TO
ALLOW SOCIAL WORKERS TO PROVIDE
THE NECESSARY SERVICES AND NOT
BEING NECESSARY FOR INCREASED
WORKER. MUCH THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINE ONE TWELVE.
EVENING MISTER CHAIR BUT WILL BE
WITH YOU W. AT THE LOCAL DURING
A THIRTY THANK YOU FOR THE
HEARING TODAY HIGHLIGHTING
WORKFORCE SHORTAGES I'M
PROVIDERS REMAIN ON THE FRONT
LINE THE PANDEMIC BITING HERE TO
OUR MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
RISKING THEIR HEALTH AND WELL
BEING FOR THE CLIENTS TO KEEP
THEM SAFE AT HOME. BY THEIR
LIFESAVING WORK. AMERICANS NEED
TO BE PAYCHECK ABOUT THEM AWAY
TO HAVE EXTREMELY LIMITED ACCESS
TO TRADITIONAL WORKER
PROTECTIONS. LACK OF WAGES AND
BENEFITS THE HIGH TURNOVER RATE
AND WORK FOR SHORTAGE. ALL WHILE
KEEPING WILL DOUBLE WITHIN THE
NEXT DECADE. THE PROPOSAL FOR
HEALTHCARE WORKERS INCLUDING
SOCIAL WORKERS WERE INTEGRAL TO
AFFECTING THE NEED FOR CARE FOR
MY AGE THAT PROGRAM FOR OTHER
PROGRAMS. WHAT HOWEVER WE URGE
FOR ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT TO BE
MADE LEGALIZED THE GROWING I
SHOULD THE PROGRAM ABROAD AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ANIMAL SESSION.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. I
HAVE NO FOR THE LINES INTO IT
THIS TIME THANK YOU OPERATOR I
WILL TAKE THAT AS THE CONCLUSION
OF PUBLIC COMMENT FOR TODAY I
WILL TAKE A MOMENT TO START BY
THANKING ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND
CHAIR CARDIO FOR HOLDING THIS
JOINT HEARING WITH US TODAY I'D
LIKE TO THANK ALL OF THE STAFF
WHO HELPED TO PROVIDE FOR THE
AGENDA THAT ALLOWED FOR THE
ROBUST DISCUSSION FOR. TECH
BEING ABLE TO HELP US TO
DISTRIBUTE THIS ACROSS THE STATE
TO DGS HOPING TO KEEP THIS ROOM
CLEAN AND FOR THE SERGEANTS FOR
KEEPING US SAFE BUT AS ALWAYS
MOST OF ALL I WANT TO THANK THE
PUBLIC FOR PARTICIPATING AND
IMPROVING THIS PROCESS YOUR
VOICE IS BOTH NEEDED AND
WELCOMED HERE AND WITH THAT WE
WILL BE ADJOURNED. HAVE A GOOD
NIGHT.